[Music]
since we're nitpicking this incredible
show anyway why the does Morty have a
coat hung up on the wall here does he
really have no closet or is this a
trophy from a seral killing Rick turns
on a light but the obvious light on the
ceiling does not light up coming from
some magical Source in a room with only
one switch come on I got a surprise for
you come on hurry up got to get got to
go got to get out here you're tuing me
too hard conversation I had with my
college girlfriend during jeanclaude van
night at our local BDSM film dungeon
somehow makes it into the show look if
you want to know what we're up against
here the mothering moon is drawn with
such care here that they included the
phasing Shadow the level of thought that
went into this show is astounding well
played show well played I built it out
of stuff I found in the garage did you
though the trash can and the flashlight
sure but I'm pretty sure you had to get
this highdensity Bubble Glass and these
giant screws custom made where did you
find the giant cylinder base for the
spaceship in the garage it also looks
like most of the stuff that you attach
to the this thing wouldn't Aid in flying
but hinder it why would Rick even
install seat belts in the first place
does he strike you as the kind of person
while throwing together a junk crafted
space time ship in his garage stops for
a second and thinks but first safety how
are these two so close when Rick clearly
landed several feet away when he fell
out of the ship opening title spoilers
also I know Rick and Morty wears its
references on its sleeve but this
opening theme song couldn't be more
Doctor Who if Tom Baker and David Tenant
were in a threesome with the ghost of
William hartel while Russell T Davies
watched also also intro promises an
episode where Morty is a robot and
doesn't come through ever there are two
or three other things in this the intro
promises and doesn't deliver and I'm
calling my local adult swim about it
what is this pink liquid are the Smiths
drinking Pepto for breakfast I mean with
his family I guess that might make sense
I mean if you told me Jerry ends up
mixing it with whiskey and has a
fondness for Barb Wire I wouldn't say
you were wrong 2 plus two Jessica
hilarious that Rick said that school was
exactly this and it happens as soon as
Morty gets to school but this isn't the
first day is it what did they get taught
in the time leading up to this you know
what I named these my little Morty you
know what I want you to do with them
rename them honestly this kind of joke
deserves a sin removal but he's dreaming
about this so he's dreaming about
Jessica showing him her boobs having her
call them her little Morse and then
negging her for it it's like he mastered
Neil Straw's the game but is only good
at it when he's dreaming we got we got
to get get the hell out of here and go
take care of
business what's with dirty sanchez
always having goop in his mouth and the
constant beling with this level of acid
reflux I'm guessing Rick's ulcers are on
the verge of ending his life I'm just
saying if we don't find out in a future
episode that the beling and the mouth
splooge is actually caused by an
interdimensional species that lives in
his gut bacteria I'll lose a lot of
respect for the show now if you just
stick with me Morty we're going to be
holy crap Morty run Predator pauses
predatoring prioritizing panicking
protagonist punchline past partaking of
perfectly palatable people we're going
to die First Act ends on a cliffhanger
for a commercial break only to return
with Rick and Morty no longer in danger
and the monster gone and nobody
mentioning it again and sure that could
be some sort of comedic point about the
worthlessness of commercial Cliffhangers
but You' think a show like this might
acknowledge it a little bit just take
these shoes Morty I convenience them out
of my lab code of conveniences these
things really bring it all
together you have to turn them on Morty
sure Rick looks like a total for
not telling Morty about turning the
shoes on before he fell into the Ravine
but Morty's kind of an for being
this trusting of Rick and deciding to
dive in head first without even a
question Morty survives this is he
Immortal yeah it's a cartoon I get it
but in what alternate universe can a leg
broken in at least three places continue
to stay elevated like this I went into a
future Dimension with such Advanced
medicine that they had broken leg Serum
at every corner drugstore nice echoing
of the Back to the Future line there but
what kind of place is it that people are
breaking their legs so much that a
broken leg Serum is a viably
mass-produced medicine Rick separates
the seed but there is somehow a full
seed in each half now knowing this show
that could completely be intentional and
is some sort of paradoxical joke that
will be retcon into a storyline in
season 42 but the Pickin here be slim so
for now I'm going to need you to take
these seeds into the bathroom and I'm
going to need you to put them way up
inside your butthole Morty Morty full of
grace they'll fall right out of mine
I've done this too many times Morty sure
Rick is a quasy evil drunken and
an unreliable character overall but
didn't he tell Morty what do you think I
can just do it all by myself and now
he's saying he's done this lots of times
maybe Rick just wanted to spend time
with Morty I'll grant that but I'm
taking my sin and going home come on
Morty please Morty you have to do it
Morty man Rick says Morty at least 100
times in this first episode I'm sure
it's on purpose for some sort of comedic
effect but damn the effect wears off
quick why didn't you notify us have you
not been getting the messages I've been
leaving with Morty grandfather sure this
principal is dumb but if he's been
calling Morty's grandfather and leaving
messages that apparently have been going
unheated for 2 months wouldn't you try
and call the parents at work isn't that
how you got in contact with them this
time wait is there just an unguarded
portal just lying around at this airport
no employees no other people waiting in
line oh look honey it's our son with
Albert Ein I mean dickle the Tesla was
right there but sure whatever sure this
background joke is hilarious because
it's a towing company that has a mascot
that's a tow with eyes named toe whose
catchphrase is I toe which could both be
interpreted as I am doing Towing as well
as hello my name is toe but the
important thing to note here is that
toes don't bend like that I didn't know
hanging out with you was making me
smarter temporary super intelligence is
just a side effect of the mega seeds
dissolving in your rectal cavity oh
really then why did Morty only show
super intelligence when you asked him
questions to fool his mom and dad feels
rather convenient but how can I hate
this show the SS don't matter and I
needed those seats real bad not this
episode you didn't meaning those seeds
are about the McGuff finest thing to
ever Mac all over my guffins boy you
really got me up against the wall this
time
Jerry look I'm fine with the speed at
which Rick made this smart dog helmet
but he must have already had this thing
built except for like one screw to
Simply go to his garage and use a drill
for 2 seconds and produce a finished
product go to the
bathroom not sure how impressive that is
he clearly just flushed the toilet
because he didn't have time to climb on
top of it and actually use it jeez Rick
in the time it took you to make this
thing couldn't you have just you know
helped me with my homework Morty would
be amazing at TV sins I mean the guy
teaches high school math I I didn't take
him for an active dreamer I see someone
hasn't seen stand in the liver that's on
you Rick Summer's phone shows Snuffles
very close to Jerry but he somehow ends
up two feet away from him when it cuts
to the next shot oh yeah this should
play out just fine you said the same
thing equally sarcastically at our
wedding and guess what is it just me or
is the Jerry and Beth marriage way
sadder than it is funny also sitcomm
husband constantly does and says stupid
things sitcom wife gets irritated with
him to the point where no one
understands how they would have ever
gotten married in the first place and
had kids but somehow they make it work
just barely cliche why would I negotiate
with you because we're both rational
adults that don't want anything bad to
happen and because I have a human shield
how is Rick able to human shield Mrs
pancakes since she was clearly behind Mr
goldenfold when all this started
goldenfold landed the plane and he's
created a mechanical arm to pluck Mrs
pancakes out of the air while he left us
fall into a giant v of lava damn that is
absurd and funny I think Morty's ability
to know exactly what goldenfold did and
give a full report of it is what sells
it I'll just go ask her to tell
goldenfold not to kill us when she wakes
up who whoa Morty the trick to incepting
is making people think they came up with
the idea oh really then what was that on
the airplane then when you pretended you
were going to blow it up how was that
topnotch incepting Rick looks like
goldenfold has some predeliction so
shameful he buries them in the dreams of
the people in his dreams I don't think
goldenfold is nearly that Shameless
about his fantasies you remember the
first episode that guy was just standing
there while Morty unconsciously grabbed
his boobs and he leaned into it at
school looks like some sort of Legally
safe knockoff of an ' 80s horror
character with miniature swords for
fingers instead of knives why would he
need to be legally safe Rick why would
he need to be legally safe okay fine God
damn it this show is clever and funny
and all the things three C off it was
only with years of selective breeding
and genetic altering that this Noble
Beast was transformed into man's
subservient little buddy convenient TV's
position is convenient where are my
testicle summer first off why is
Snuffles terrorizing summer of all
people over this second off as a super
genius dog you damn well know where your
testicles went buddy you shall now call
me snowball because my fur is pretty and
white snowball must have gotten this
idea when researching video clips about
David Duke let's
go where the was this the whole
time do you mean the snuffle snowball
meant to go in and chastise summer over
things she wasn't responsible for hope
her parents would wake up and go into
her room to see what the matter was then
dramatically reveal this other dog when
the time was right you were trying to
accept me to get an A in math so how is
Rick planning on getting Morty A's in
all of his other classes is he just
going to Inception every one of Morty's
teachers every year of school Inception
Marathon Inception Thon he keeps saying
we can run but we can't hide like if the
truth was that we could hide it's not
like he'd be sharing that information
with us you know this is a hilarious
Rick and Morty discussion about a Trope
in horror movies that characters never
really think about but I'm wondering why
they can hide when Scary Terry has been
popping out of nowhere throughout this
Inception dream sequence in places where
he shouldn't know where they are hi
honey you're home early how was your day
I have a lot of questions about this
little life that's occurring in a dream
inside a dream inside a dream inside a
dream but mainly I want to know how
these not Kruegers use hand soap get off
my back in septic abuse I love you
Melissa I love you too Terry why is this
boner look while my sin hat wants to
question everything about what's in this
room right now this domestic scene for
Scary Terry and the claw marks that are
everywhere that suggest a sex life that
is better than yours or mine deserves a
sin off for detail and hilarity this
must be a dream because we just saw this
teacher push open a door with a doorknob
on it makes sense because he ain't
turning that door knob don't even trip
about your pants dog here's a pair on us
fool and where exactly did Morty get the
pants from because I can buy many things
that happen in this episode but Morty
getting bright enough to know how to
mediate the Dream Within a dream world
is not one of them these halves don't
belong together that's curist this
is because you don't give Morty Smith
good grades so I know they're
making fun of inception in this episode
but even while they're making fun of it
Rick was adhering to inception's rules
about making it seem like the person
came up with the idea on their own so I
don't know how the Scary Terry rocket
suddenly puts the idea of giving Morty
better grades into Mr goldenfold's head
that makes him think he came up with it
I'm entertained mind you but this seems
to be going against the rules of even an
Inception spoof I know one thing for
sure I'm giving Morty in a in math
that's great but what is the wet on Mr
goldenfold shirt since all he had was a
bowl of wheat things they just couldn't
do this thing without a dog's playing
poker reference could they well at least
I didn't really crap my pants no no that
happened before you went to sleep Morty
you're sleeping in your crap right now
wait was that even something that
happened I don't remember Morty saying
he crapped his pants at any time in this
episode until now like it's something
that we were supposed to be aware of
ready sounds like you just wanted to
wallow and a little bit show it's pretty
bad Emperor snowball we're going to need
to do another operation if snowball
Snuffles is so smart then clearly he
would know this is Rick behind the dog
mask I see dogs walking out of an animal
shelter into a warp to some other
dimension but is this supposed to be all
dogs or just the ones in Rick and
Morty's Town also this puts the onus on
the series to never show dogs in this
world ever again I could just send
holiday Inflatables because seriously
how did that become a thing but it's
much easier to send the fact that you
put Rudolph right in the middle of your
driveway also you shovel an immaculate
path to the sidewalk but only half of
your driveway what are you monsters put
it in the stocking summer or I'm joining
Facebook a teenage you're caring about
Facebook you're adorable 2013 also
Facebook is this a mirror at the bottom
of the stairs was the goal to both check
your appearance as well as block traffic
in the most dangerous part of your home
okay look I know the show is going for a
quick joke here with his giant Morty
melon somehow fitting through that
opening but why does the show go to
great detail with some areas of physics
but approach this one by literally
jamming its head a toll just hold your
breath until the process is over or your
lungs will collapse and then he doesn't
and yet he's fine hey Dad where's Morty
he's busy yeah great joke and all but
even Beth should be a little surprised
at the naked near-death Bad Santa whose
chest her dad currently has a giant
needle jammed into right welcome to
Anatomy Park roll Comm orals the anatomy
Park train has only one small entrance
exit for a train with three cars and
what the is up with these stairs with no
rails that lead to your certain Doom if
you fall I love details like a pardon
our does sign for an amusement park
inside a human body and I'm certainly
laughing but who is this sign for the
park isn't open yet and doesn't appear
to be close to opening so there are no
customers affected by it and if the park
has been open this whole time we're
talking about a logistical nightmare
from the customers getting shrunken
enlarged at the Smith house without
anyone seeing it and figuring out where
the hell homeless Reuben is to inject
them into his body Reuben's seen some
rough years Morty don't judge you don't
agree to have a theme park built inside
you if your life's going great why is
this saying not a t-shirt who are you
why would this guard be concerned with
anybody who shows up here it's not like
anyone can illegally trespass into this
homeless person's body unless Rick
specifically inserts them it's weird
that the security guy here shoots
bullets at diseases instead of like
vaccines or penicillin can we talk about
Jerry's sweater for a second the colors
in the middle section should be reversed
so that the red sections are green and
look like Christmas trees unless of
course these are intentional green
arrows pointing down to an entirely
different type of Christmas cheer I
watch them sometimes from a chair
sometimes from a closet almost always
dressed as Superman cut K nearly all
human lungs contain a strain of these
bacteria but the scar tissue keeps them
dormant if the scar tissu is already
been tampered with then why did the
tuberculosis wait until germ Oliver said
something about it to attack what is
that horrible smell must be your own
breath because you're breathing air from
inside your helmet from the attached Air
Supply so smell really shouldn't be an
issue keep your eye on Annie she was
written up several times by her manager
at the churo stand later on Annie will
say actually I studied Dr Bloom's work
so did she get written up because she
was constantly in Dr Bloom's lab
learning everything seems like someone
who was allowed to study the work of the
main boss wouldn't be stuck at the churo
stand getting written up for whatever
reason this also seems to indicate that
the park was open but I still haven't
gotten a definitive answer on that it's
[Music]
aak rhyming food with good garia can't
see us if we don't move wait I was wrong
I was thinking of a T-Rex why the would
you be thinking of a godamn T-Rex
because of the movie Jurassic Park that
you're referencing throughout the
episode like dinosaurs and infectious
diseases are in any way related enough
to confuse the two if it works we'll be
regular sized in a few minutes you mean
there's a growth Ray inside Reuben this
guy jokes about Ruben not being in a
room with white carpet or Upholstery and
good for the show for thinking of the
gnarly aftermath of such a move but
seems like in a world of impossible
science they'd have found a way to
escape without the grizzly measure
that's Bubonic plague so a couple
questions here first why did you leave
it roaming free in your backpack pocket
if you had this plan to sell Bubonic
plague to the highest bidder wouldn't
you have a container to put it in second
why the hell was there Bubonic plague
inside Rubin what the
hell I'm sorry does the grandfather
really think that his wife and Jacob are
going to have sex right now on the couch
while his granddaughter and her
boyfriend make out in the same room the
aristocrats also did these closet door
flaps open individually like this or
even at all what you like to ride the
bone train why are you doing this bit
we're going to die Morty would be
retorting at TV SS what the hell is that
E coli outbreak is it though because
those are clearly bacteria viruses and
eoli is a type of bacteria and not a
virus suck my fat virology expertise
Rick wads would this fuse continue being
lit while in space my guesses no but I
should probably send myself or even
thinking about it when it comes to an
episode about an amusement park inside
of a homeless man reports from all over
the country have been coming in about
what appears to be a giant naked man
over the continental United States how
fast did those reports come in exactly
Rick just kicked him out of the
spaceship and enlarged him like 3
seconds ago I'm pretty sure that
Dynamite would have exploded before any
news outlets had the chance to make
their detailed naked guy graphic
overlays I guess I'm going to have to
beat that guy and point out that Reuben
is now the size of the entire
Continental us so his face should be
covering way more area than a city block
the nipple hole it's beautiful agreed
but I have to ask why is there even
gravity now that Inner Space has gone to
outer
space What the when the bone train went
off the rails hepatitis A was looking at
it go past him and crash into this
nipple area even if he jumped to grab
the train how would he have gotten
inside in the time it took for the train
to crash it's atius
C did we have some sort of relationship
with him I think they're just like that
I think they're just good
guys holy that's hilarious I'll gladly
remove a sin wouldn't this life as rough
picture show the golf ball actually in
the rough rather than on the green where
the hole is actually I studied Dr
Bloom's work I I I believe have the
knowledge necessary to create an
entirely new much safer Park Jurassic
world that's it that's the
sin that's a targe 2600 Donkey Kong
sounds coming from these 2013 devices
it's time to upgrade our Gadget noises
Hollywood this is just sloppy
craftmanship Rick would be excellent at
biology sins also dissecting a rodent
with the garage door open What's with
Mom so you're saying that she's acting
weird on a good day everyone acts weird
in the world of Rick and Morty yet still
I have to ask why is Rick digging in
this rat he knows he's in a simulation
he knows the rat has floppy
craftsmanship so what is he looking for
he doesn't need more proof way to go
Morty celebrating math also wearing an
orange shirt and gray tie with a yellow
sweater interesting peeking into a
child's classroom window as an adult
also since Rick knows Morty is a
simulation why is he going through this
charade at the school Rick would
immediately be getting the zerian to
show their hands so he could plan his
Escape you know if you tell us I'll be
your girlfriend oh you will seems like a
rare opportunity Morty simulation or not
soliciting sex from a student for
bribing purposes will always be a sin
take a shower with me Morty what in
times like these I wonder how the
writers begin their creative process
does it start with let's put child
nudity in this one do they have a jar
containing tiny strips of paper with
random bullsh suggestions aimed at
making everyone incredibly uncomfortable
and at the start of their brainstorm
they grabbed several and slap them
together why is this scene lucky for us
they're also really uncomfortable with
nudity I just want to know how Rick knew
the location of the school showers in
the first place why go through all the
trouble of animating this Split Second
Peak into the locker room and not put
anything interesting in it at all
something is drawing a lot of processing
power you have more important things to
worry about alien scum these fans aren't
cooling the computers properly they're
limping along sort of Teeter tottering
back and forth and before long your CPUs
will overheat it's a real problem
trimming your nose hair while driving
I'm not sure that I can ask this
question without breaking my own brain
but here it goes why is Jerry separated
from Rick from the start they're both
inside the same simulation and yet the
aliens are surprised that they've got
another human they're literally looking
down on a massive simulation with two
simultaneous simulations happening
within it there should be no surprise
that Jerry's here at all are the writers
hoping to avoid revealing the twist to
us the viewers or the aliens
purposefully zooming out on Jerry's
inner simulation to Rick's inner
simulation forgetting what is real at
all are we in the simulation
too I broke my brain keep your hands off
your ding-dong it's the only way we can
speak freely because for some reason and
the aliens are unable to Simply listen
to the conversation they must look and
listen National Apple farmers of America
Welcome to our Ad Agency but how would
the Nigerians know this much detail
about Jerry's workday when they didn't
even mean to NAB him and on top of that
they only have a simulation operating at
.5% capacity simple question gentlemen
assuming
gender this scene just reminds me that
Dave Ramsey has forever tainted the
beauty that is Baker Street Dave Ramsey
well all is forgive because right now
I've got an erection the size of an East
Coast Lighthouse hey I'm going to make
love to my wife how big does Jerry think
lighthouses are because I'm not even
seeing evidence that a pup tin has been
pitched relax it's just a bunch of ones
and zeros out there binary code shaming
leaving your car door open is sex really
worth giving someone the opportunity to
steal your car running the battery down
actually yeah I guess it is but for the
principle of the matter I'm still a sin
making out with dead skin cells excreted
from a scalp I would definitely be on to
the simulation after seeing this
everyone knows yellow Pop-Tarts can't
jump deaning a child rather than
yourself Pop-Tart SquarePants moments
ago they're running through an alien
spaceship and quite suddenly they're
racing through another planet we don't
care about plutonians we care about why
Jerry is here at all moments ago they're
running through an alien spaceship and
quite suddenly they're racing on the
moon we don't care about the moon
landing we care about why the plutonians
are here at all man up Jerry I may need
you to work the lasers putting Jerry in
charge of the lasers doors are closing
and time is running out but the
protagonist spaceship makes it out just
in time cliche oh because shooting at
the person you want to steal information
from is a great idea and yes this is a
simulation inside of simulation inside
of simulation but the darkness of it
still matters you simulated my
grandson's genitalia you looked at your
grandson simulated genitalia you win can
we go home now I don't know can you
grammar police sure we do it too but we
actually spent 5 years at grammar Police
Academy to get our certification up
until now I had to brush off my
frustration with English appearing in
the alien spaceship clearly they have
their own language we see see it here
and here so when the signs were in
English or the doors were labeled I had
to brush it off that this was a
simulation and meant to continue to
deceive Rick but now here in this moment
before Extinction there is no reason for
we did it to appear on the screens for
our benefit also there is no reason for
this mixture to be combined at the Helm
of the ship during an office party when
there are plenty of labs up in this ship
also also Rick and Jerry survived this
waggling your tongue when you really
don't need to I already told you it's
not your family sure but can we talk
about what they're trying to do because
notcher seems to have you well in his
grip and able to kill you easily but
it's just standing there waiting for
this scene that's just an excuse to
justify a title sequence clip to
end why would this facility as part of
its infrastructure have a button that
remotely controls this Ghostbuster style
trap that Rick had in his hand isn't
that something he just brought to the
adventure you make a request the me
fulfills the request and then it stops
existing Rick knowing about this Meek
box makes so many of his previous
decisions in this show completely
unnecessary as disposable as these
beings are why wouldn't he use them as
at least an extra pair of hands to
complete all his adventures with Morty
I'm Mr Meek I want to be popular at
school O Okay this meik stick is a
brilliant way to play with the be
careful what you wish for tro but in a
world where the genie allows you to wish
for infinite wishes God this show is
just the best this Village is terribly
poor yet the giant that lives in the
clouds above has Untold Treasures Jeff
Bezos also this world not only happens
to have the Jack and the beanock story
from our Earth in its reality but r&m
also just happened to land in the
village where he lives just a reminder
that even the most brilliant shows need
some little blue convenience pills once
in a while to keep their stories firmed
up in conclusion a friendship with s
Smith is the most valuable an enriching
experience of your young Lords Mr mik
was able to call an assembly at summer
school just to say great things about
her so that she'd be popular and it
looks like the entire school is on board
with a magical blue what's it they've
never seen before in his Pro summer
message also holy hell what kind of acid
trip was the designer of this basketball
court on the key area or free throw dick
as it's more commonly called is
completely out of proportion and reaches
almost a half court which would be fine
except the other half of that Court
appears to be more like a third of the
court and doesn't even seem to have any
markings plus that far hoop which is
clearly not retracted and should be at
the standard 10 ft has to be at least 20
ft off the ground based on the scale of
the bleachers underneath it and speaking
of those bleachers why are they behind
the podium when all the space in front
of the podium is available and how did
they even get them there they clearly
don't fold in so did they move this here
in one piece this is a gymnasium of
Lies I know Jerry is a dimwitted sad
sack but wouldn't shaving Two Strokes
off his golf game suggest that he's
somewhat competent golf if the guy can't
even hit the ball off the tea then isn't
the real request shave a thousand
Strokes off his golf game let me try
something why did they bring the meek
box with them on the golf course do they
expect to need extra Mr Meeks during
this tutorial can you help me get two
strokes off of Jerry's golf swing but if
the Meeks are aware of their own process
and abilities enough to call other Meek
to help with what I asked them to do
wouldn't that impact their perspective
on their own purpose in a way that
negates my original request I guess what
I'm asking is how many seeks would a
miek seek if a Meek could seek me I Rick
and Morty from a spiderverse cuz I don't
know how you climb a mostly flat surface
like that without a little accidental
radioactive spider venom Meeks don't
usually have to exist this long it's
getting weird how does he even know this
I've about had it with the discount Blue
Man group's existential paradoxes here
we are you know walking down the
courthouse steps why would the
courthouse steps lead all the way down
to the non- giant World below wouldn't
the steps at the giant Court lead to
other places where the Giants regularly
go also did everyone else in the courts
just stay inside was the Rick and Morty
trial the undercard to a much more
important trial why did Jerry bring
everybody back to the house for his
lesson how are you supposed to learned
this inside a living room was he trying
to hit a ball inside his house was he
just trying to swing the club because
I'm pretty sure he succeeded at the
second thing but what do I know tennis
confuses me what happened to Beth's new
hair she had a new style a minute ago
and now looks like the old Beth why did
you even rope me into this cuz he rope
me into this well the him over there he
roped me into this the cinema sin's
hiring process who what do you know look
down there looks like some kind of
Tavern or something the Thirsty step I
mean the 12th step was sitting right
there stop fighting me just let this
happen holy my surrealist sci-fi comedy
show just went super dark the creators
have even said they wanted this scene to
reflect the trauma of assault and not be
funny at all but here's my question is
this really the place for it I'm all for
victim sensitivity but seems to me the
most sensitive thing to do would be to
not unexpectedly reference real life
trauma in a place where most wouldn't be
expecting to have to deal with it these
Meeks are never given verbal
instructions are we changing the rules
so that they can just Intuit it what
their purpose is now we heard Jerry
leave the house when he told the Meeks
at this point my golf swing is more your
problem than
mine and he was wearing the green golf
shirt but now he's in a suit but wait
neither Jerry nor Beth told the meekes
where they were going for dinner so
maybe after Jerry left he went upstairs
to get dressed and came back down and
told the meekes where they were going
but why did he clearly go outside after
telling them that there's only one door
in the living room that would open and
close and it goes outside come on Rick
quick stalling what do you got read them
and we Rick slow rolls the stair folk
Rick Rolling at this point I'm kind of
wondering how the Thirsty step stays in
business their location is awful and
most of its customers couldn't possibly
make it up here
easily
[Music]
so we're just saying hitting a tomato
with a metal shelving bar into a large
pot about 10 ft away is equivalent to
improving your golf game two strokes
well okay then Jesus I didn't know the
Meeks had such a huge Arsenal did they
knock off a gun store on the way to the
restaurant or did the Smiths have a
hidden gun room I'm a bit of a stickler
Meeks what about your short game and yet
more proof that the Meeks get to decide
when their purpose has been fulfilled
meaning they could have bailed at any
point and the entire premise of this
episode is null and void and now that
I've been this much of a pedantic
I can disappear also the
literally request was to shave Two
Strokes off of his game and Jerry got
more than that by merely learning how to
drive the ball so go yourself stickler
Meeks your job is technically done Jerry
look we don't have a perfect marriage
but I'm not going anywhere Define
anywhere see you next week everybody the
fourth wall is my least favorite wall
yet I'm sad somehow every time it gets
broken the mysteries of the heart
confound us letting Jerry help Morty
with homework I don't know how many
times I have to say this but if you have
the flu stay home does he mean stay home
and don't go to the dance or stay home
and don't go to school because you
shouldn't be at school if you have the
flu and if you're not at school how
would you hear this announcement why is
this announcement also episode of a
cartoon from 2014 predicts how selfish
humans are when it comes to protecting
others from a rampaging virus the flu
season dance is about awareness not
celebration you don't bring dead babies
to Passover well someone's not getting
invited to my Passover celebration hey
wait a minute where did Jessica's
friends go yeah try not to worry about
it Morty you're a good kid is he though
in this episode alone he asked Rick to
help him essentially rofy Jessica so I
think a little more honest parenting is
in order Jerry what the is the purple
meat on Jerry's sandwich ah well I
remember feeling that way about a young
lady named your mom and that's not an
urban disc but it works so much better
as an urban disc in fact that's a pretty
epic Your mom joke that he just ruined
Jerry we have ice we have no ice Rick is
a dick to carbonated sodas wait a minute
did Rick go into the kitchen to get
orange juice does Rick seem like the
kind of guy who drinks orange juice
without adding the vodka
yeah I'm just going to check on your mom
and apparently leave out the Mustard
Mayo an open orange juice pitcher and an
unstarted sandwich do you want food
poisoning Jerry because this is how you
get food poisoning Jerry and ance a hair
Morty I need one of your hairs this
isn't Game of Thrones my favorite part
of every episode of Game of Thrones was
when the CSI team came in and solved the
case there's a calculator of some sort
on the right side of this love potion
making machine here but when it cuts to
the wide shot the calculator is on the
left side of the spout your continuity
error will be the death of you Rick and
Morty geez did this Brad kid go to the
dance in his usual High School attire
just adding a tie that's actually pretty
funny but I'm sending it anyway you not
that this is the point but shouldn't
Brad already have the flu considering
Jessica was already sneezing at school
today and he ran right into her sneeze
Mist earlier Brad got sick immediately
is that how the flu Works how come
you're not at this stupid dance everyone
loves so much screw that I don't want to
get sick so wait summer are you saying
you're backing out of our trip to South
Dakota cartoon dry humping
Jessica get a hold of
yourself the flu Love Potion combo which
made Brad sick in second should already
be running ramp it through this gym
considering it was in the punch and the
air conditioning but it waits until
someone scolds Jessica before taking
over the entire school still being proud
of a swimming Championship nearly a
hundred years later whipped up an
antidote it's based on pray mantis DNA
they mate once and then they you know
decapitate the partner science I I
basically mixed this with a more
contagious flu virus why did you need to
mix it with a flu virus when everybody
at school already has the flu these
serums they don't work on anybody
related to you genetically I mean thank
God but that still is a serum of the
highest convenience the only thing that
is known is how cute he is I love him so
much I want to make love to him how did
these news anchors even get to their
jobs if they were obsessed Morty loving
praying Manis creatures also where did
they get a picture of Morty that quickly
that's almost creepier than the love
[Applause]
potion how has this virus already spread
to other countries the news station was
hard enough to buy but at least it was
potentially local and this is going to
be an issue for the rest of the episode
so instead of bringing it up several
more times I'll just add 10 cents here
wait so everyone knows where Morty lives
all of a sudden what the heck is that a
Morty doll how did they manufacture that
well I'm glad we saved all those horses
why did you short the glue industry how
did the flu mantis concoction get all
the way out to the horse Hospital have
people been driveby sneezing around this
place I'm Mr crowbar and this is my
friend who is also a crowbar
B I can't imagine a world where Jerry
actually deserves a sin off but I'm
giving him one regardless if people from
other countries are whiffing the
antidote already wouldn't they have a
period of time when they turned back to
normal before morphing into these
Abominations that's what happened to
everyone else how did this guy's
underwear stay on and intact throughout
all these Transformations here's another
thing Rick made the love potion for
Morty using his DNA and that's why his
family wasn't affected but he made the
Mantis potion in the every animal on
earth potion without Morty's DNA so why
aren't they also turning into troma
creatures right now hold on Mad Jerry
Fury Road Mad Max Jerry Road Furious
Jerry maximum Mad Max and Furious
presents RADS and Shaw the fury is there
any reason for Beth and Jerry to get out
of the car and fight these things they
were doing just fine running over all of
them what's the goal of coming out to
purposely kill these things other than
to pad this episode's runtime boy Morty
I really Cronenberg the world up didn't
I don't be so hard on yourself Rick the
world doesn't look too much like in
butterfly here Morty put this on while I
do a little bit of scouting why does
Morty need to wear this thing while Rick
does his scouting what computer works
just because someone's wearing a
backpack apparatus okay so we're about
to find out that this is one of the
infinite realities that original Rick
found where a parallel universe Rick was
able to get everything back to normal
and the Rick and Morty we see here are
not the original Rick and Morty team
which is what the show wants you to
think so why is this universe's Rick and
Morty just now getting back to the house
after a newspaper was published
explaining how everything went back to
normal the answer is don't think about
it it's not like we can do this every
week anyways we get three or four more
of these tops yeah but that violates the
cinema SS and therefore TV sins Charter
where we were told to think too deeply
about it it's too convenient yes you
don't follow the same rules and you
definitely shouldn't because nothing
creative would ever get made but that
doesn't mean that we're not sinning you
for this replace the Dead Rick and Morty
in a different Universe bit I'd grown
super fond of the original summer Beth
and Jerry and now I'm going to have to
be cool with exact replicas with no
differences whatsoever you owe us an
apology also you only get three or four
more of these tops has Rick ever watched
anything on network television leaving
the refrigerator door open he's got
lifeless eyes black eyes like a doll's
eyes glad summer could helpfully write
Jaws on this box in case you didn't know
the reference but what happens when she
decides to do the Englishmen who went up
a hill but came down a mountain not
enough room on the box to explain that
reference then why would you need these
kind of lines in a galactic parking lot
shouldn't it just be a series of
different Siz squares for vertical
landing and takeoff also what's the deal
with these parking lot lights they're
Illuminating a building that's already
lit up and neglecting the rest of the
parking lot I mean it's different from
the stuff on Earth they have sex dolls
on Earth and something tells me Morty
knows way too much about that aliens on
another planet not only speak perfect
English but their stores have open and
close signs written only in English like
what if you passed away or died or
something I wouldn't even have anything
to remember all the cool stuff we did
you know remembering your late
grandfather every time you use your sex
robot so we're just going to pretend
this isn't happening well not with that
attitude we aren't Rick why would you
let Morty bring that thing into our
house I mean we know Jerry has no power
but why did Beth allow it in the house
the real question for Rick is why did
you buy that for Morty in the first
place really simply drinking from the
carton is a sin but it's doubled when
you're drinking from the carton after
having sex with an alien robot sorry
them's the rules intervening with
puberty you'll turn him into Rafe fines
and red dragon first it's clearly Ralph
fenes I mean learn to pronounce things
but also referencing Ralph fenus from
Red Dragon instead of Tom Nunan from
Manhunter just a few seconds ago Morty
was Robo railing so hard he had the
downstairs light swinging but these
knick-knacks just stay put on his
headboard I don't even know how these
stay put but when he's not deep droing
this thing could grow to the size of
Delaware pretending like Delaware is
large or exists I've gone too many
episodes without sinning this and I
can't hold back anymore that sock has
never been moved from that spot in the
garage and it drives me absolutely
insane every time I see it my therapist
will be thankful I don't have to discuss
that with her anymore portal question
253 if you can't see through the portal
how would this creature know exactly
where and how to grab summer still think
it's a good idea to go through Holes
without a wiener wubble dubdub sorry I
just always wanted to do that so maybe a
sin on me that's fair great now I have
to take over a whole planet because of
your stupid boobs I can't tell if the
show is aware and poking fun at victim
blaming or just casually using it for a
laugh and considering the damage that
kind of thinking does every day this is
either a sin for the show's attitude or
the idiots who think this way also watch
what you're saying about boobs Mister
those things are like universally
beloved it goes Tom Hanks pizza then
boobs and honestly Hanks and pizza
better watch their back why do TV
families always store their fruit so
close to the floor also storing bananas
with your other fruit is a terrible idea
bananas release a gas that makes other
fruit spoil quicker crap that was
actually somewhat educational um bananas
look like penises saved it there's your
hands there's your hands title of my sex
tape and that's how we play handy hands
oh you are going to ruin that kid Morty
could be worse he could be showing him
Caillou what's the opposite of Wubble
LBA dub dubs am I right ladies and
gentlemen it's bad enough you're
breaking the fourth wall but now you're
throwing test questions our way too I'm
tired of Zoom classes leave me alone
having a section of a newspaper simply
titled news spider in sector C is still
alive plan your route accordingly and
expect delays so this world's just going
to be a bunch of sexist jokes now I mean
admittedly super hilarious sexist jokes
like that restaurant that's called just
a bite of
yours the weather report said is anyone
else cold or is it just
me uh sorry I mean um that's racist the
females are placed into educational
programs the
males they get to play outside the
original plot outline for Boss baby
somehow makes its way into this episode
yeah you know what I have to say about
that I cannot believe my ears
I rick survives this fart can we talk
about these ear arms for a second we've
seen them active so we know they aren't
just vestigial so how does the muscle
skure work part of the reason you can
control your arms is in the shoulders
and chest and sure maybe they have some
thick traps hiding under that hair but
what about the pecs shouldn't they have
some sort of chest muscles where their
cheeks would be and that would mean they
would also have boobs there too six arms
should mean six boobs damn it also do
you know how hard it would be to hold
your arms up like that all day those
arms should be dangling down like
flaccid fleshy earrings also also does
this mean if they don't apply deodorant
they have Bo right next to their nose
this is terrible design and the God of
this universe should be punished to the
maximum extent of celestial law was this
really the time to make that point
summer kids this is for you Daddy well I
guess we know where this episode stands
on the whole nature versus nurture
debate good news parents what you do
doesn't make a difference only
handcuffing four of the six arms and
doing it via two separate handcuff sets
with a foot of chain between them and in
front of the body this does nothing look
at the tag read it where was that tag
hiding and is that really where a tag
would be on a top like this Mark Jacob
these are names of the penis look a lot
of what these alien ladies are saying
about men is very true but we give our
penises way more interesting names than
Mark or Jacob like Boomerang or big Rick
or count schl longula if you think my
top is cute you cannot execute Johnny
Mory junor smoking but where
did he get the cigarettes he hasn't gone
outside no one else in the house is a
smoker I don't want to masturbate I want
to conquer the planet just like this
generation to not be able to multitask
also this race is so horny they just
just drop sex robots on them and then
have them all impregnated within minutes
so I think his murder boner would be
accompanied by a well boner boner but
first a deep sip from a very tall glass
of I told you
so those are gulps not sips you noisy
and Biber running wild running hot show
makes fun of motivating characters with
songs and that is just not acceptable
without Survivor and Robert terer Rocky
would have never been able to beat Ivan
drag and don't you forget it also movie
steals the Foot Loose scene from Hot Rod
hey stop that thinking honking your horn
will stop an alien monster from
destroying your car and potentially
killing you I never got that impression
from Reading marmaduk show wants us to
believe that a kid in the 2010s would be
reading marmaduk see see you guys next
week see everybody next week this joke
literally only works one time the first
time it airs unless you're the kind of
fan that plays your Blu-rays or streams
weekly to be more authentic why don't
you just prove you're a better fan than
the rest of us by having weekly View
parties where you can all Quote lines
from the show and sing songs about how
great it is and crap I just invented a
religion didn't I I know animation is
tough guys but why is the end table
behind the couch now when it was between
them just a few seconds ago you show us
your concept of good TV and we'll crap
all over that TV sin's mission statement
somehow ends up in the script didn't
snowball and the other dogs in this
universe leave in episode 2 why do the
Smiths still have this bed out here sure
it could be that they're just too lazy
to get rid of it but after a quick
cutaway to Jerry it's now gone so that's
a continuity error in at least one way
and maybe even too you can probably
guess which way I'm leaning how about
Showtime extreme in a world where man
evolved from corn welcome to the Rick
and Morty improv show with all the hits
and misses and improv show and tals
it'll be just like the everyday
programming on channel 62 in the movie
UHF the fact that this gun was duct
taped to his back and yet the duct tape
somehow stays in place after he grabs it
to pop this other corn doesn't even have
a colel of truth to it what too corny
Letterman from a timeline where Jerry's
Famous a stumble upon shows that
directly relate to themselves on a TV
with infinite worlds and infinite shows
and I find that infinitely convenient no
the other thing go back really all right
fine why would the TV go back
immediately to the guy eating when Rick
changed channels twice since they ran
across this disgusting show this episode
is a treasure Trove of quick hilarious
visual gags like bottomless baseballs or
a version of Game of Thrones where
everyone's a little person except Tyrion
I've never loved my pause button so much
in my life here these scan your retinas
and let you view parallel timelines and
I happen to be carrying this thing
around with me at all times check out
this refrigerator only $200 pretty
hilarious that because ants in his eyes
Johnson can't see he thinks the dryer is
a refrigerator but did anyone help him
shoot the commercial wouldn't someone
correct him that he's pointing at dryers
this commercial isn't being shot edited
and broadcast live although that would
be quite the trick I've heard of fire
ants but are there fireproof ants
because those ants seem just fine
despite being engulfed in
flames I don't see anything there's a
chance you weren't even born I thought
the headset scanned your retinas and
match them with your parallel universe
cell so why would the headset go through
parallel universes where summer doesn't
exist also if these goggles also land on
realities you don't exist in they would
be rendered basically unusable with
infinitely possible universes the
chances of you landing on one you
actually exist in is infinately small a
Mexican Armada shows up and their ships
are sombreros seems kind of racist Alien
Invasion tomato monster Mexican Armada
Brothers I felt a great disturbance in
the force as if millions of sins
suddenly cried out in Terror and were
suddenly silenced it's called Two
Brothers Two Brothers It's just called
two brothers I don't know what I like
best about this this episode but hearing
Justin royland laugh at his own bull
might be the most honest and funniest
part but leaving in the laughter of you
cracking yourself up seems a bit
distracting and over the fourth wall
line even for this show so no this hurts
me more than it hurts you and I'd be on
DiCaprio's yacht banging Kristen Stewart
since these goggles are directly
connected to the DNA of the person
watching shouldn't it disconnect once
removed from the scan we just discovered
a show called Ball fondlers but you guys
clearly backed the wrong conceptual
horse yeah but ball fonders is just the
at could watch regular limited cable to
watch that fakedoors.com is our website
this website doesn't work which seems
like a sin Until you realize it is owned
by the company that owns Rick and Morty
so it could be an inside joke about how
just like the doors and the ad don't
open neither does the website or it
could be because this is an alternate
universe so the website wouldn't exist
in this one like with many Rick and
Morty observations I'm left wondering if
it was accidental oversight or
intentional genius but here's a sin
anyway since it made my head do hurty
brain thinking huh he's making himself a
sandwich now this top piece of bread has
nothing on it which means he has put the
peanut butter on a slice of bread and
then jellied on top of the peanut butter
one ingredient per slice you monster
also he sets the dirty knife directly on
the countertop I can put up with a lot
in this world but people who set dirty
utensils on the counter can go straight
to Helman still here still selling fake
doors this might be one of the funniest
things they watch on infinity TV but
what kind of world is it where a guy who
sells fake doors can afford a commercial
that runs 90 seconds or longer paid for
by trunk people man the trunk people
emblem seems really offensive but I
guess the trunk people chose that no
room is safe from the turbulent power of
turbulent juice was that a movie or like
does it clean stuff as usual Morty would
be amazing at TV s baby legs you're a
good detective but not good enough
because of your baby legs I'm totally
down with a random Vibe of infinite
cable possibilities but why would baby
legs wear a diaper is this guy an adult
but like a baby can't control when he
goes to the bathroom so I'm partnering
you up with regular legs is everyone
with regular legs named regular legs or
does this guy's legs Stand Out amongst
his years as the most regular which
would be a contradiction in terms also
this feels like an average everyday
weird cartoon you can already find on
Cartoon Network it's in the same vein is
ay McGee here we
go that's the sound I make when I'm
trying to run fast this is basically
Beck Bennett's Office boss character and
when you're stealing from 2013 SNL you
may want to rethink your sketch premises
that out there that's my grave wow those
graves are so freshly dug and mounty
that it's pretty incredible no one from
this family has stumbled upon them these
graves are more obvious than the the
ones Ron Pearlman Sees at the end of The
Last Supper nobody exists on purpose
nobody belongs anywhere everybody's
going to die come watch TV if 2019 were
a movie this would be the tagline on the
poster 2019 Mrs Sullivan always planed
to leave everything to her cat I
understand this is infinite cable but
why does Rick somehow always end up on a
movie trailer rather than simply a movie
oh Mrs oh Sullivan wow this movie is
G-rated what does it need to even get to
a PG not to mention R but I imagine in
their world gaspero finds ways to push
the envelope I guess Jerry ate someone
else's toe because all his toes are
intact in the shot while this reflection
in the bird cage gives us a perfect
image of a sad Beth the reflection
itself seems completely impossible given
the POV and it doesn't even appear to
reflect the cage itself oh come on as if
the odds weren't astronomical enough
that they would even land on anything
about themselves both Jerry and Beth
happen to land on the same reality I've
never stopped thinking about what might
have been wow a pretty unexpected
heartfelt whammy at the end of this
episode full of Randomness this show is
so good hey Rick I have to make a
project for the science fair this
weekend you think you could help me out
science fairs well I mean traditionally
science fairs are a fatherson thing so
girls never have to participate in
science fairs that's unfair fair and
racist eating pancakes with butter and
no syrup oh my God a brand new sentient
robot would say oh my gears just saying
whatever this guy is doing balancing
plates on thin air I see they fixed the
Shelf but they changed the animation so
add another sin I make my own stuff and
the animators make their stuff up on the
spot too the skull candle and a floating
elephant carcass are brand new additions
to this counter I'm a man of science and
I'm a man who likes consistency why is
the elephant in a jar over here now not
to start a whole another GIF GIF debate
but does the glue have a label on it
claiming to be sticky giz or jiz but you
know spelled with a G for some reason
why do we have to corrupt glue why does
glue have to be perverted being limber
enough to flop your legs on the floor
like this without pulling any ligaments
or dislocating your pelvis Jerry was
inside the house and could have walked
through this door to the garage but
instead circles outside to the garage to
enter in dramatic fashion is he smart
enough to think about entering for
dramatic flare this after shave made
women won me but it also made me
impotent oh my God how can I not see
this coming because because you're
impotent this serum should counteract
the negative effects injecting someone
with your serum without their explicit
consent I like my devil fights to have a
lot more finger zapping and brimstone
and a lot less back and forth slapping
so what was the ironic punishment for
buying the vase how does a scary ghost
go along with your theme this vase helps
your flower stay alive but it's also
haunted is a joke that steps on the
theme and you're just being lazy I'm
King flippy nips ruler of Pluto we
discovered you quite by accident which
is interesting because Pluto was also
discovered quite by accident it was when
Saturn was going in and out of Uranus
and then about to hook up with Neptune
you really gave it to those guys at Nasa
the plutonians abduct Jerry so that he
can declare Pluto a planet and I'm sure
that's amazing for their egos and all
but why do they think Jerry has any sway
over the rest of Earth didn't they hear
how NASA responded this is what you do
when your be story has nowhere else to
go well I'm going to get the curses
removed at curse Purge plus you know the
guy on TV and of course Rick is on the
television right the second because TV
show has to news position but why she
could have just as easily said said you
know the store across the street as we
find out that's where it is in just a
second also this TV wasn't even on 20
seconds ago wub but how exactly did Rick
get a store boughten up so fast Rick is
not the devil he can't just make a store
appear overnight also how is the
shopping district if first in Maine had
a vacancy also also how did Rick know Mr
needful was going to this window at this
exact moment the center of Pluto Mr
Smith is made of a substance called
plutonium Pluto Exposition Pluto
Exposition exp Pluto Pluto goes from
planet to asteroid to meteor and
finally po a great visual truly but
where did the Pluto dust come from his
hands were empty a moment ago oh my God
that's the devil summer I wish this desk
was lighter absolutely none of the
wishes summer makes on the monkeys paw
come with any backfiring curses what a
waste of a monkey paw but how would Mr
needful know this he was passed out
while summer was making her wishes Mr
needful how could you even think of
doing something so horrible I'm the
devil can the the devil even kill
himself if he's the devil it implies he
sort of lives forever right I can take
out the eternity and the padding and
then you'll have some time traveling
mittens and at what point does anyone
ask what the cost for the item will be
these items are literally Priceless and
not in a good way I just got bored
everybody out how Jeremy and Cinema sin
staff meetings are you telling me 4
billion plutonians are wrong can we
worry about that in just a second
because who's going to tell Jerry to
stop putting scissors up his nose in a
moving vehicle Angry Crowd suddenly has
rotting food to throw cliche it was a
long 6 hours but we've overhauled
Needful Things into the globally
compliant web 4.0 Enon need.com
investing in the doc business in 2014
when exactly did Jerry's roof get
repaired when the plutonian showed up
initially they pulled Jerry and Morty
through the roof causing a lot of damage
he dumped me Summer wipes clumpy mascara
drippage from beneath her eyes with the
simple wipe of her hand I mean that's
the most unrealistic thing to happen in
this entire episode repeat a cycle of
violence repetitively so Dad guess what
tomorrow is the day you return this
horrific tablecloth to the store or stab
it because it's an alien see it changes
patterns it's absolutely an alien having
trouble holding a consistent geometric
pattern honestly this level of paranoia
is a direct result of watching too much
Rick and Morty trust nothing everything
is nothing or something umbrella
paintings but also tomorrow is your
oneyear anniversary back in our lives
celebrating arbitrary anniversaries
because you can I'm going to make you
Flying Saucer shaped pancakes and yes as
another Rick points out shortly regular
shaped pancakes are also Flying Saucer
shaped so this in is for teasing that
you're making fun-shaped pancakes when
in fact you are not Beth is a monster
considering breakfast is on the table I
think we're meant to believe it's 6:00
a.m. and there's no way this family is
gathered for a fully prepared meal by 6
a.m. nope in this episode we learned
that Rick's smarty brain waves need
Morty's dummy brain waves to keep Rick
untraceable or some such bullsh get here
in the opening credits he straight up
leaves Morty to die so what's that about
our son's been abducted you hate me for
buying those coins to be fair Jerry was
frozen when Morty was abducted and
therefore wouldn't understand the full
reason Beth is upset normally Jerry
deserves the yelling but not this time
Beth also coin collections jeez Rick
what is this place the citadela Ricks
it's the secret headquarters for the
counselor Ricks and where's the
counseling center for Jerry and beths
considering all Ricks have a Morty and
all Morty have a Jerry and Beth who
would be distraught because their sons
are missing turn your boring old Morty
into a hot fashion statement this is a
richastic concept but he can see that
the Rick is trying to sell his Goods to
has handcuffs on and is being
transported by some form of authority
right how does he expect to close a deal
here exactly it's supposed to be funny
because they have different hairstyles
but it's not cliche if his body was
stuffed into the wood chipper starting
with the head then how is the arm still
in one piece yeah so does the scientist
formerly known as Rick why isn't he he
in handcuffs because he's dead too tap
cap shaming so as they say in Canada
peace oot making fun of Canadians
wait is that a sin I can't remember run
Morty and then our Rick and Morty run by
many other Rick and mores who would
easily attempt to stop them but don't
even try perplexing considering everyone
thinks R Rick is a dangerous Rick killer
but oh well on to the portal pandemonium
I feel like this is a good time to
revisit the how the does the portal pew
pew gun work portion of the program does
he just think of a specific destination
or are the locations random and somehow
manage to spew fire insects and
tentacles at the perfect moment the
incredibly convenient timing is sinable
either way based on the fact that we
only see asses and no hand hands what is
the purpose of the giant rolls of toilet
paper who would even use them and how
are the rear ends so clean if the ground
around them is covered in feces this is
the least subtle symbolic anal
penetration since the ending of North by
Northwest yeah I'd like to order one
large person with extra people please
white people no no no no black people
and Hispanic on half racist Pizza yes
I'd like to order one large sofa chair
this is a pretty funny running gag but
with all these different wordss it makes
me wonder why the Ricks look the same at
the council where it was pizza Rick or
telephone Rick or greasy Grandma Rick
and we see a hammer Morty later so
clearly these types exist I continue to
take issue with the use of portals in
this episode and here's why Rick Splats
out a whole bunch of options the enemy
appears and they say they could have
gone into any one of these we lost them
which means they aren't tracking our
Rick and Morty so how would they have
known to follow them into the farty MC
poop Smith world in the first place I
just want to point out that there
appears to be a fruit bowl on the bottom
shelf which is a really dumb place for
fruit and bowls in the combination
thereof anything else yeah more phone
sticks please so they're eating phones
just because they went into a different
dimension does not mean they have a
different digestive system bad guys
avoid looking around the room thereby
allowing the good guys to slip away
cliche they look exactly like us so in
order to avoid confusion I'm going to
Mark us each with a red X right now but
they're also wearing different clothing
so you could just go with that as the
identifier also there must be additional
exits to this restaurant because a Rick
and Morty straight up Escape so rather
than marking x's on foreheads perhaps
watch those doors hey you didn't pay
your bill you said holy chairs are
sentient wrong advertis ing wow so
people need help figuring out what to
buy and then you help them I it's a
little more complicated than that it is
not also if the other Jerry's think bull
cut Jerry is useless why would he be
brought along for missions in the first
place appears there are more than enough
Ricks for the job you're missing my
Symphony hey I'll take it over Mumford
and Suns I'm pretty sure the Rolling
Stones review for that Mumford and Suns
album was it's the equivalent of
listening to a thousand naked children
being tortured so this race might still
be too close to call we will find our
peace in the next world world show now
asks us to believe that the captive
mortis have had enough time to form a
cult and mine this cave prison for the
resources to create cloaks printed
propaganda and a precise razor to shave
their heads the pointy thing isn't
piercing Morty any longer and so all the
tortured Morty spend one beautiful
second believing they are freed before
realizing they are likely falling to
their death how special owning a life is
rough poster that shows the golf ball on
the green and barely any rough saved
your ass all right Morty don't break an
arm jerking yourself off
I mean you can't really do that right
right this is the receiver yeah but
where's the transmitter Cliffhangers no
ibers cfers
[Music]
gers stalkers Let's Lose the tude please
losing the toue speaking of disasters
Dad we are leaving you in charge yeah
but that's kind of on Beth right why
would she ever leave Rick in charge of
her children or really anything this
garage door falls outwards after the
center is dissolved by alien eels except
the the hinges weren't destroyed so this
is a sin for the animators not making a
couple of heels dissolve the hinges and
a sin for the writers for forcing the
door to fall in order to kick off the
rest of the episode well we're past the
point of no return Bridget Fonda shaming
using your binder incorrectly or writing
math upside down and backwards on the
back panel of a binder for no reason
either way a in does that say
multi-grain legs I guess they sell
peanuts in a box and abbreviate legumes
to legs none of this seems appetizing or
profitable just keep your sci-fi friends
away from my awesome ones how about you
all focus and just keep that
refrigerator door closed while you carry
on conversations and then work on your
strategic segregation and you keep your
awesome friends away from my canipes
when the canop tray came out of the
fridge every one of them had a green
olive why would Rick remove one just to
add it back in dramatic fashion I love
watching I mean like I don't
know if I personally would ever do it
how many people did you invite
Rick better question of the many that
Rick invited how many are going to want
to get downstairs schwifty with Summer's
questionably aged peer group group looks
like the garage door was instantly fixed
I love seeing aliens and humans hanging
out together despite their differences
but how are none of the people freaking
out right now being a Morty at a high
school party casually watching a murder
meal knock it off slow Mobius if slow
Mobius didn't stop using his slow-mo
Powers until Rick said something why was
Rick able to speak at a normal Pace
running on Deck also
stealing this doesn't feel solid
objects in his liquid and that ising
concerning they weren't the size of ants
they were Ice Cube sized beings summer
don't tell me your friends with her
popular controlling girl is pretty and
demands your normal looking friend to be
sacrificed on the altar of Conformity
cliche I just want to find somebody nice
and sweet which somehow prompts Morty to
show her a deadly mad scientist garage
rather than the toy collection in his
room apparently the garage door wasn't
fixed in now I'm curious about the sign
story where the door was dissolved by
eels fixed before the party but then
immediately redissolved tarped taped
tacked and held in place by
house teleports to a different planet
that happens to have oxygen and an
immediate hookup to power cliche you see
Cherry may I show you something how was
Lucy not been caught yet the operation
doesn't seem to be that large and she's
wearing a maid's outfit no one has
questioned why she's fraen rizing with a
guest instead of cleaning or picking up
Rick's using a credit card to turn these
crystals into something snortable but
what's with the number on this thing 1 2
3 4 1 2 3 4 it can't be a show that
rebels in the details and then not
expect a nitpicker to examine stuff like
this come up with Applause number you
jerks move to the left that's the right
step to the right that's the left it's
the that's somehow everyone knows
instantly also River Dance did it first
the floor drops out to make it easier
we're going to get it nice and steamy in
there with with the floor kicked out
well at least you got all this free
stuff equating free stuff is an
agreeable result of being the victim of
a sexual assault it's not a door Beth
it's debris I don't care just leave it
yeah okay this door can fit in the front
seat seat so there's no reason it
shouldn't be able to fit in the back of
their wagon with a little
rearranging somehow despite the window
being down and the earpiercing volume of
her horrible laugh neither of these
hear her K fear explaining your
references since everything came back as
it previously was where did the rest of
this gate go pulling down someone's
pants while they are frozen midep
wouldn't be this easy in reality these
pants would get stuck at the waist in
top of the thigh don't ask me how I know
this not using the ramp for your cart
filled with expensive electronics and
yes it is stolen but it's still valuable
credit not until I hear you say Rickie
business or Rick and Morty Rick not
until party why is this boner I know how
to vacuum Mom and Dad summer I've been
doing it for 6 months but why would you
need to vacuum anything if time is
Frozen isn't everything Frozen in time
if the molecules of the clothing are
frozen how do you even move them how
does the washer work now that I think
about it how are you even breathing Time
Frozen oxygen right now it's not my
fault we froze time on a humid day but
the moisture would also free you know
what let's just add 5 cents for the
Paradox of freezing time and move on
shall we you have dropped so many balls
man I mean probably just two although
with the radiation Rick has probably
exposed Morty to with all the dimension
hopping could be more I suppose put a
shirt on your dumb dad and let's get
this dumb Universe rolling but how did
Morty get Jerry's arms through the
sleeves sleeves just don't magically
form around the arms when you throw a
shirt on no matter how many times you
pray for it when we pulled up I could
have sworn the house with is completely
trashed yeah well everyone in the family
knows that Rick can do incredible things
so why don't you immediately think Rick
must have stopped time and fixed the
house before we walked in I'm just going
to put it on the floor and uh kick it on
over to you or you could toss Jerry the
money so it doesn't look quite as
awkward I know Jerry is supposed to be
dumb but Beth isn't and she's a doctor
there's no way she's not checking
foreheads for temper at the very least
asking questions about this odd behavior
whatever this is also convenient machine
that can let you know if there's been a
split in time on the off chance you
freeze time long enough for this to be a
possibility is is convenient the two of
you made us uncertain what are you
talking English exactly what does that
mean uncertainty is a pretty broad
spectrum for instance if Morty was
uncertain about a math equation or if
summer was uncertain about what clothes
she should wear for that day would that
cause a Time Rift I get the Rick is an
ass when it comes to explaining things
but if this issue of uncertainty is
really that important then maybe you
should try a little hard or at least
have a sheet with rules on it cold stone
crey is the best marble slap Creamery
shaming we we have to tell the cops you
were driving why would you have to tell
the cops anything or even call the cops
do you call the cops when you run over a
skunk or a squirrel I believe the saying
goes if the car will still steer you're
in the clear and we've got about 4 hours
to be is what a very specific time frame
you just happened to know for convenient
tension building purposes all right
since this time Crystal exists in both
possibilities and since it's impossible
that I didn't nail this vanity it's
definitely my favorite sin naming your
Animal Hospital Animal Hospital do cars
not need license plates in this world
but how will people get in their
practice for removing tiny screws from
rusted out holes by using old credit
cards is an impromptu and ineffective
screwdriver how I ask you nurse please
move that snake that's my nurse
indentured nursit toe I shot it before
these two hit it with their car and I
followed them when they hauled it off
and how exactly were you able to follow
them were you hunting from your car look
the sin is either convenient vehicle
location or car hunting take your pick
I'm calling my lawyer I hope for all our
sakes you're as bad a surgeon as I am a
hunter this episode is an all timer and
remembered mostly rightfully so for the
time Rift storyline but it should also
be noted this B story is equally
hilarious and engaging all right
everything resolved everybody nice and
certain about their position in my world
yes I'm not sure I understand why Morty
is so let down here just a couple
episodes ago he discovered that Morty
are a figurative shield for all Ricks
I'm not saying he should be happy that
Rick looks down on him but he shouldn't
be surprised by it this time be like
Grandpa you mean drunk this is going to
cause the Ricks to go out of sink and
then both Ricks are going to take that
as a sign that the other Rick is trying
to kill him but earlier Morty said
something different from the other Morty
and then he said wait who said that so
wouldn't they have heard the other Morty
making a wise crack about Rick and
wouldn't Rick know that it was the
reason for the sink to go out of whack I
think about getting in the coverage but
don't really but Rick understands that
all of the Ricks would be saying this
right this show has made Rick really
dumb over the last 30 seconds for the
sake of moving the plot along so for
that away we go Beth pushes Jerry with
bloody gloves but there is no blood
transferred to his clothing and trust me
that stuff transfers I mean so I hear I
will reach into heaven and yank your
screaming dear Soul Back the deer
survives this well if all of me knocked
out all the Ricks and you peed in all of
your pants doesn't that mean that we're
all synchronized I mean no I haven't
seen a timeline reverse Butterfly Effect
this hard since the red Gren grum hold
episode of the xfiles what are you doing
calling myself if leaving your other s
of voicemail was an option this entire
time isn't that a pretty easy immediate
check before going full interdimensional
Shooting Gallery how long exactly do we
have to wear these things they're really
embarrassing oh I see Rick is an
anti-masker can we talk about Rick's
cord maintenance for a bit he's got four
plugs coming up from behind the work
counter and he chooses to plug three of
them towards the top of the first strip
and one of them on the upper strip and
the one coming down from the ceiling
plugs into the lower end of the top
strip what is this nonsense you have a
cord from below plugged in as your
highest cord you cord jumbling chaos
Monster these men are from The surine
Institute of elk moose deer and stag
they can take this deer to a helicopter
and fly it to the country's top deer
surgeon getting outsmarted by Jerry you
know what they do to third dimensional
life forms and time prison same thing
they do in every other prison only
forever so three Hots in a c Medical
Care tobacco based currency oh you're
making a prison rape joke aren't you
last time we sent a prison rape joke it
was in Puss and Boots so you might want
to think about the company you keep r&m
I'm really uncertain about everything
are you though certainly if the
uncertainty is a concerted plan you're
actually certain of your uncertainty
which would in turn create certain
certainty right come on let's help
Grandpa I'm 100% not sure about anything
the war with Grandpa hand me that flad
screwdriver actually made it a
flad so the decision over which
screwdriver Rick should you split off
the timelines again if something that
minor would do it then there should have
already been hundreds of these after
Rick was trying to figure out which Rick
he needed to kill there is no helicopter
and there is no servine Institute clever
Ploy and all but how did Jerry get all
the emblems made so quickly to pull this
off and where did the uniforms the Cold
Stone crey workers are wearing come from
so the cats float but Morty Falls his
gravity itself also
uncertain D well I guess they can touch
Jerry and Beth now without any
consequences but how would they know
that Rick didn't let them know how long
they would have to wait when they
unfroze everything are you going as
motorcycles with green headlights
instead of normal ones I'm not sure
which I want to send more that Jerry
would have this tight 15 ready to go
right off the top of his head or that
Beth who famously eye rolls just about
everything Jerry does would be laughing
this hard at it in fact I'm so uncertain
there's now two sins now
four we got some business to attend to a
few late minutes south of here oh you
still use South in space Oh Jesus Jerry
what the hell are you doing here being
excellent at TV s for one thing also I'm
done with shows pretending like people
have zero spatial awareness even if you
don't have the hypervigilance gene where
you're always checking your surroundings
one of your five senses is going to clue
you into the fact that someone's sitting
just outside your peripheral vision and
since we're talking Jerry I'm going to
go with smell you can park in a handicap
spot Morty anything with less than eight
limbs is considered disabled here of
course no one knows where to park
because they apparently don't even Mark
the spaces also not having some sort of
hover vehicle parking is just
inefficient planning there should be
roof parking with boxed areas for
vertical takeoff vehicles that don't
need all the extra space to drive around
the furp rock design committee sucks
also also looks like you've got gzk Hut
over here and then Pua Isa two doors
down and that's more poor strip mall
planning to have two pizza places that
close to each other and honestly it
might be three because I could be
convinced a place called dumpy stump
sells pizza as well this works help me
what the hell I know right even though
we know there are multiple versions of
all our characters I'm counting at least
25 Jerry's in here is the show
suggesting that a couple dozen Ricks
need to ditch Jerry's at the same time
when we know most Ricks aren't going to
want Jerry around in the first place and
yes I know the asteroid is cross
temporal which is just Rick and moriz
for we wanted to make a joke here so
maybe this will make it okay you know
what those guys do in in their fancy
boardrooms they take their balls and
they dip them in cocaine and wipe them
all over each other Rick is a liar ay
balling is a myth and he should know
that those pictures of me were clearly
fakes including a period in your hashtag
also when your vocation is life
extermination I'm guessing you're going
to just go ahead and leave the geot
tracker feature off of the business card
for exactly the reasons the show later
confirms yeah sure I mean if you spend
all day shuffling words around you can
make anything sound bad my theory for
when I'm trying to force a sin on a show
that probably isn't really a sin but
damn the joke would be so funny and meta
somehow makes it into this episode here
check this
out this whole full life simulation game
is exactly the kind of thing that makes
Rick and Morty such a pleasure it treats
the concept with enough respect to give
it all the time it needs to be fully
felt while at the same time not letting
the joke get stale take your sin off
Rick and Roy Parsons I mean Morty not a
single member of this entire crowd is
cheering during this spectacular play
also none of them have faces and most
are clearly copies of other people in
the stands they literally control seed
these four in the front rle and control
Ved them to the next row over I'd get it
if this were a cheaply animated TV show
but this is a Hightech game that
simulates an entire life so convincingly
that it becomes your reality hey you
sold a gun to a guy that kills people
yelling this in a public place yeah
that's the difference between you and me
Morty I never go back to the carpet
store all right since Rick is taking a
turn now we have to talk more about this
game because how can he have awareness
of both the world around him and the
living simulation if it's fully
encompassing also is this game only for
humans the character is human and that
helmet wouldn't fit 90% of the other
clients at this discount Dave and
Busters there's no way that this would
be profitable and finally if the game
simulates a 55e life how is it also
showing the players decisions in real
time on the screen wouldn't that mean it
would take 55 actual years to play who
wants to come watch midnight run with
director's commentary on Martin breast
has never recorded a commentary for
midnight run that's a sin for the show
getting its facts wrong a sin for the
collector's edition Blu-ray for not
making it happen and a sin for the
universe getting me all horned up for
something that doesn't even exist in my
world don't engage in breast play if you
can't finish the job damn it K Michael
must either have precognition or the
ability to see through solid objects
neither of which is mentioned or
explained so sin how is this big guy
unaware that a hole was cut in the floor
right beside him and his coworker was
taken out does peripheral vision not
even exist for these creatures with
72.4% of their head being eyes oh man
what have I done crashed into a heavily
guarded Fortress that apparently didn't
have a single bit of exterior spacecraft
deterrent I guess portal transport that
somehow knows EX exactly where to bisect
this chesticle mantis threat for reasons
X mchina we can't get him out of here
he's gashes he's not going to make it
through a portal Morty oh sure now the
portal has rules open fire oh I see my
mistake now I did some fake research and
apparently the company that makes the
portal gun is literally titled XM Inc
it's like the whole purpose of this gun
apparently fair enough I'll take back
all the portal SS we've ever done and by
take back I obviously mean double also
this room fills up with water even
though there's giant hole in the wall
where Morty drove the ship through a few
minutes ago Rick yeah yeah these guards
apparently attended the Promethean
nebula School of just standing around
and not shooting your guns even though
you're about to die or you know if you
still have that gun K Michael dropped we
could finish the job and go home you do
understand I'm telepathic right not sure
why this matters since Rick is saying
everything out loud and not with his
mind it's how things should be it's how
they could be I could not agree more
this psychedelic Unity musical number
that is like the Doctor Strange's open
your eye scene but less about the astral
projection and more about buts goes on
for some time we now interrupt this
masturbatory reference to a different
episode with some news position news
position a TV crutch so useful Even Rick
and Morty can't help but do it sorry
Rick the reward on your head is too high
higher than access to a creature that
gold seems like you could have dished
out some raisin brand gotten a few bars
out of the deal and let Rick and Morty
be on their way how are cogs that big
fitting through mouth holes that small
gear Troopers are apparently this
world's version of Storm Troopers put
these guys on a milk carton cuz they've
been missing this whole time I can't
figure out where the main pot starts and
where the Jerry pots begin but if those
three coins in front of our Jerry is all
he has left then he shouldn't fold even
with ace high these pot odds are way too
good to not play and I don't expect
Jerry to know that but I just can't let
that kind of bad poker go unsinn I'm now
way more curious about how gear people
sex Works than I'm comfortable with I've
been grinding my gears trying to figure
it out so to speak I'm going to find
some fuel and take a big fat Morty
that's my new word for because of
today's events explaining your jokes
which is hilarious because we also do it
which also makes it meta and honestly
the more we explain it the more meta it
gets get it telepathic being that rubbe
Goldberg the destruction of an entire
police force to escape somehow didn't
see this coming interesting somehow
didn't see this coming is also the title
of my why would all the Ricks and mores
be picking up their Jerry's at the exact
same time and so help me if it's just so
we can set up a hilarious taking home
the wrong Jerry joke I'm going to laugh
my ass off but also still add the sin
love
con
experience excitement distress Beacon
yeah baby you're excited about that I'm
confused as to how at this point Morty
is surprised by anything that Rick Czar
does the first rule of space travel kids
is always check out distress beacons oof
Rick is using an outdated space travel
rule book the most important rule of
space travel is to wear your seat belt
seems like something terrible happened
here really where'd you get that idea
summer was it the ship and disarray no
signs of life or maybe the stress Beacon
that brought you here summer makes worse
observations than Forest Whitaker and
species oh yeah if you find a room full
of eggs don't shy away from it give one
of them a shake so does this mean that
Xenomorphs exist in this universe which
would also mean the regular space
exploration is something that exists on
Earth and Rick shouldn't be getting away
with as much as he does also does no one
find it weird that when they watch
Ghostbusters or Gorillas in the Mist
that the lead actress looks straight up
like Ellen
Ripley oh hey you're alive thank God
false optimism then how do you know it
didn't get on the ship with you those
two dingdong seem pretty calm about the
whole thing which poses the question why
did they wait till now to attack the
rest of the crew even if Unity was
hoping someone would show up from the
distress signal they could also take
over that still doesn't explain why
these two didn't attack after the beacon
was
transmitted why scree and make the
attack incredibly obvious there's got to
be a better way for a brilliant entity
to expertly and covertly convert
everyone into well everyone whenever
gross here must love to be saturated in
water but only in one tiny place on the
whole lawn I'm trying to find our weed
whacker Jerry's dumb you know that I
know that but I can't help but sin that
he's looking for a long lawn tool on a
shelf where no one would ever store a
weed whacker your father put a hatch in
my garage which means now you have even
more storage space under the garage and
probably added 10 to $20,000 to the
value of the house Jerry never sees the
glass half full he's toe up from the
flow up this is season 2 and they still
haven't managed to move this plug down
here to one of the obvious three open
ports I hate you all World Peace
achieved nice little weird to publish a
paper about it for yourself I think at
this point we can agree that Rick would
be the employee of the month that TV
sends when we met I was a young hive
mind people who talk to you while
walking away I suppose a peaceful Utopia
that needs a police force for something
Mount rushmor this quickly show really
puts the rush into Rushmore huh well
this explains the $6,000 electric bill
wait what was the previous explanation
that sounds far more exciting than this
Jerry Beth bickering be story wake up
people you have to fight it you're under
the spell of an evil monster I can hear
you every four years in the United
States of America wake up you have to
have some individuality left in there
pep talks around the writing table
during Cinema staff meetings this woman
was a drug addict on the verge of
suicide now she's a marine biologist
which isn't impressive when you consider
that everyone on the planet is also a
marine biologist thanks to the hive mind
I have transformed life here into a
paradise prostitutes are now scientists
insinuating that sex workers cannot also
be scientists in a perfect
world are they all the same organism is
the mind telling them to puke Unity can
read their minds improve them with
education link everyone together and
relieve her drug binge through
individuals how does this even work I
can let go can you also teleport people
because in exactly 4 seconds the city is
destroyed and all the people are somehow
way over here hey we're right here we're
fine Rick can hear this from far away
inside a building and with loud techno
music playing and I'll be damned if that
Ripple nipple bitch's race is superior
those are some very impressive conical
nipples attached to that nipples
that that were clearly not present
beneath that shirt just a moment ago hey
these two freaks have no race speaking
of freaks what's going on with this
crowd of totally still people back here
are they Unity controlled just standing
by all hands- on hips angry looking are
they riers frozen in Terror or is this
lazy animation you want to go upstairs
and cut carrots and watch a lifetime
original above a alien dungeon
surprisingly mommy may I please have an
alien dungeon proved to be a very
uplifting piece of film making
especially for a lifetime movie I once
saw him briefly forget the word for
humans this sets up a joke later in the
episode but it's really not that big of
a deal to forget a word every now and
again our minds calculate thousands of
decisions a day so what if we forget a
word like right now I'm having trouble
remembering the word for that thing
that's like soft but then it gets hard
you know you put it in holes and cracks
it's really good in places that are wet
oh yeah yeah yeah you and unity are
like like leggings and midaf boots you
think you're great together but you're
just bringing out the worst in each
other that's fashionist if blim blam
could rip the the chains off this whole
time then why was he still locked up i'
laugh but I'm biologically incapable but
somehow capable of communicating clear
words and dynamically expressive
versions of just not able to haha is
there a slow setting best door ever
sarcastic aliens not named Al Unity
Community Rick forgive me for doing this
in notes breaking up with someone
through a letter also reading no more
alien prisoners but aliens suspended in
some sort of liquid chamber are okay is
anyone going to address
these
lay emotionally relevant song sincerely
plays at the end of a Rick and Morty
episode while also making fun of
emotionally relevant songs that play at
the end of TV shows cliche I wanted to
thank you for letting me live here all
this time so I'm treating the family to
a vacation Pro tip uh vacation is not a
treat if it's thrown on you at the last
minute people have to take off work or
school or find pet sitters last man
vacations are anxiety filled balls of
stress there is nothing fun about them
well I don't like your unemployed jeans
and my grandchildren Jerry but life is
made of little
concessions I guess this is the uh TV
sins takes off a sin from Rick and Morty
because it's hilarious cliche wall has
Alien Parasite head spatter wall has no
Alien Parasite heads spatter there's no
such thing as an uncle Steve that is an
Alien Parasite and even though everyone
else will immediately turned back into
the parasite wi shot Uncle Steve decided
to wait a few seconds for dramatic
effect how thoughtful I get they to
address this problem but I don't
understand why Rick had to throw the
parasite on the table that's perfectly
good breakfast casserole you just ruined
why would you do that Rick why get off
the high road summer we all got pink eye
because you won't stop texting on the
toilet Joe insinuates that there is a
single human being on the planet who
doesn't use their phone while busting
grumpies the pink eye is worth it and we
all know it so it's actually Rick that
needs to get off his high horse or high
road or whatever High he's on in this
opening credits cut scene Mr Poopy butth
hole holds his nose while jumping into
the portal but we all remember when this
originally happened PB had experienced
portals many times before and would know
this was unnecessary look I've been a
fan of the pupes be hole since season 1
episode one I know these things having a
slumber party style pillow fight in your
day close maybe you got the first one in
time Rick can't afford to chance it but
Rick apparently could afford to wait
until now to barricade the house instead
of as soon as he realized these things
had potentially infested the house also
considering how many we find out there
are what are the chances none of them
had already ventured out of the house
I'm guessing slim to poopy butthole just
pee your pants I did it the minute we
got stuck then are you wearing a diaper
summer because those pants are as white
as Christmas and I see no sign of pee
not that I want to but I've got a job to
do here people it's me cousin Nikki I'm
walking here I mean I'm not I'm
crouching the elevator Sha but hey I'm
walking here still a better Dustin
Hoffman impression than the one in
sphere also Deus X Nika Nikki was the
reason we found that old Nazi submarine
did that not even happen you know this
episode is really just a clever excuse
to do more interd dimensional cable type
cutaways which is strange because they
would do a literal sequel to that
episode just four episodes after this
one I guess what I'm saying is it's
pretty obvious that this episode is just
another excuse to make up wild scenarios
with no canonical consequence and as
someone who needs canonical consequence
to do their job correctly I find this
annoying Mr Bor and deos X borgard is X
making a requirement of adding new
memories no don't flash back thing I say
watching this is us or Arrow or The
Walking Dead or pretty much every single
show on television somehow makes its way
into the script marmalade is served and
apparently self-replenishing as well
considering he just poured out half of
that jar on Jerry and now it's almost
full again look there's only supposed to
be six this number gimmick is fun and
all but I have some questions if they
can multiply this quickly why didn't
Uncle Steve already have several new
friends at the start before Rick got
there how are subsequent parasites able
to control everyone's mind but Uncle
Steve couldn't control Rick's and
finally a raptor can the parasite
specifically change the part of the
memory that knows that even though
Raptor photographers are a thing they
shoot solely on digital I'm having a
blast here for sure but I'm also having
a hard time grasping how any of this
works here Rick use me oh thanks pencil
Vester let's just think about a sentient
pencil who also functions as a working
pencil for a second because it'sing
terrifying what happens when the lead
starts diminishing what happens when it
has to be
sharpened photos hard evidence and that
should be the end of it this show will
quickly shift from this with some slight
of hand but all they have to do is pull
out an old photo album or some family
vacation videos and this thing is over I
will admit it's suspicious that Summer's
only friend is a magic ballerina lamb
that we've never seen I find it
suspicious that creature that
self-identifies as Frankenstein used the
term only friend when summer just said
her phone was filled with pictures of
her friends from school nipple X's Rick
that is my daughter says the guy who
just stated that except for Beth and
Jerry all bets are off shut up hamurai
shut up Amish cyborg what is this '90s
Conan Rick as per usual would be the
goat at TV SS this living room has never
been this big also I'm pretty sure there
are at least seven that's racists in
here so I'll throw those in as well also
also I'm guessing every last one of
these characters has its own fan wiki
page and what I'm saying is we should
all find better ways to spend our time
fandom ruins us all
no I'm really curious about the
multiplying process of this species it
appears they can just appear immediately
once they're transposed into a memory
but how do they appear in the memory in
the first place doesn't appear they need
another parasites memory to do that cuz
once Steve was killed the next parasite
cousin Nikki appeared in Mr Poopy butth
hole's memory and we eventually find out
Mr Poopy butthole is a real person so if
they don't need another parasite's
memory then why wouldn't they all just
appear immediately this is the
equivalent of the ghost that can kill
you right away instead choosing to show
you how it has the ability to move
chairs around and we'll be right back
after these messages I don't hate a lot
about Rick and Morty but the blatant
fourth wall breaks make me angry
probably because when you destroy that
wall so casually and so completely you
destroy a Show's ability for any part of
the narrative to even matter ever and I
like things that occasionally matter and
we can play Nintendo games Nintendo give
me free stuff I'm guessing they just did
since that Nintendo DS was not in your
hand you'd set them all down in the
kitchen so you could grab the cash to go
buy more what is going on with Morty in
this picture looks like Mr Bill's ugly
cousin I get that the animators probably
don't pay as much attention to the
background but you've animated this
character many times over and everyone
else looks like themselves in the
pictures sleepy Gary even got a cool hat
in his leaving your pants unbuttoned
maybe we'll see Chewbacca oh what are we
doing I'm guessing not getting to see
Chewbacca sleepy Gary is such a tease
grass tastes bad grass actually has a
pretty neutral taste compared to the
bitterness of most
plants so how would you use this washing
machine to actually wash clothes
obviously this memory is fake because do
you know of a single amusement park that
would have this much space between
roller coasters and not use it for
souvenir shops Carnival cheat games or
overpriced Burger shops what was that
bottle recently painted purple and the
paint hasn't dried because black eyes
like that take at least a few minutes to
develop Morty give a gun to the lady
that got pregnant with me too early and
constantly makes it our problem this
message about how our flaws are the
things that make us human and connect us
is actually really smart and sweet and
I'd like to take a s off for Rick and
Morty actually having some depth and
meaning but the show casually broke the
fourth wall earlier so my hands are tied
my wife shot a longtime family friend
funny yeah Mr Poopy but hole being an
actual being and longtime friend make
any sense whatsoever no and you know how
we feel about things that prior a laugh
over the sanctity of complete logical
consistency that's right we're the only
ones that get to do it and that's the
way the sins goes show opens up on Earth
getting
head hey golf is easy now and yeah
despite the surrounding explosions and
cataclysm still unspeakably boring
wearing sunglasses indoors also why does
Rick put his sunglasses on in the living
room only to take them off before he and
Morty have even made it outside a place
where the sunglasses may actually be
needed with this this show I could
totally buy that they took a detour via
some far away planet with 42 Sons on
their way from the living room to the
garage but if that's the case why didn't
Rick give Morty a pairs well it's not
God summer she's allowed to think it's
God if she wants honey mixing parenting
and politics I mean religion I mean
religion and politics I mean this is how
you get ant summer hi I'm Mor's math
teacher I'm also part of the street team
inviting folks to the church Downtown so
we can pray together how long ago did Mr
Potato Head in space turn up have they
really had time to organize a street
team dedicated to inviting people to
church if so where are your priorities
people if you can mobilize this quickly
why not help the probable millions that
have been displaced by aforementioned
natural disasters also why is the math
teacher not questioning the fact that
Rick and Morty just flew away in a
spaceship right in front of him how is
praying going to help Beth would be
schwifty at TV sins seti norat and every
broadcaster on the planet are attempting
to show this being what Humanity's got
String Theory world history the human
genome have you tried sending in launch
codes what that's a terrible idea is
General warmonger suggesting they send
nuclear launch codes to an obviously
Superior alien being with clearly
questionable intent now I'm sure his
actual meaning here was to fire the
missiles but that is not what he said
people Mr President what America's Got
is 70,000 megatons of KaBoom boom I
wanted to send the fact that 70,000
megatons must be a colossal OV
exaggeration of how many nuclear weapons
America has after a small amount of
Googling it turns out that is the
generally accepted estimate of the size
of our nuclear Arsenal and that is a
sent
now the sunglasses are back so why did
they take Rick's spaceship in the first
place why not just portal gun their way
in like they were clearly going to do in
the first draft of this script also this
begs the question why does Rick have a
spaceship at all surely it's easier
safer and quicker to just portal gun
everywhere stay back this watch turns
people into snakes we will find out
later Rick has actually murdered these
people and the snakes are being released
from a Contraption to sell the illusion
and he is not punished for it then or
now so the sin as always is kids I mean
murder I mean it give me a a ding Fel
Newman Corgan and that dream guy They're
All Dead the Grammy sir there was an
earthquake and all the musicians all the
famous ones they're gone when was the
last time Randy Newman was at the
Grammys or Billy Corgan for that matter
get this man and his grandson on a
Blackhawk to Area 51 or and this could
be a terrible inconvenience for everyone
I understand use the portal you double
down and always hit on a soft 16 I think
hitting on soft 16s has landed the
church in plenty enough hot water as it
is thank you very much
in case you confused it with Nevada
desert the setting of that awful Dave
Batista zombie movie Yes I'm going to
send Army of the dead at every and any
opportunity regardless of the size of
the shoehorn required get shwifty what
the hell is that it's our world's best
effort that's what how can that possibly
be true okay every artist at the Grammys
was killed but there are plenty of great
artists that have never been nominated
for a Grammy what about the Kinks The
Strokes the Spice Girls The Talking
Heads the planet's about to be destroyed
by a literal talking head your savior
are right there I like what you got good
job this song Works Mr President you're
going to want to see this you'd better
come take a look at this cliche sir
started picking up on a garbled signal
we're decrypting it now decrypting it
based on what Rick wasn't here you
wouldn't even know what these aliens
were called let alone their language 24
hours five planets five songs but in the
end there can only be one planet music
trashy reality TV set in space this show
sounds incredible I can't wait to binge
all 988
Seasons uh it's probably a bad time to
mention it but any astronauts you guys
had in orbit are definitely dead
everyone on earth except orbiting
astronauts survives
this earlier all Morty had to do is
press a key and the keyboard
automatically played a funky beat
wouldn't this time be better spent
cycling through the pre-programmed beats
instead of trying to accidentally
himself into a tune also while we're on
the topic of the keyboard shouldn't they
find the person person that programmed
the keyboard with the winning beat I'm
fairly certain they weren't invited to
the Grammys you can put your faith in
nukes if we get through this General
until then I'll put mine in Rick and
Morty usually I would also be in favor
of anything other than the nuclear
option but after having sent a good few
of these episodes the phrase I put my
faith in Rick and Morty makes me lean
towards the big red button as a safer
option with the opportunity for far less
damaging Fallout we should pack up and
leave town now and go where is it not
clear by the floating heads in the sky
that there's nowhere to just pack up and
head to we hereby send these unwant
Skyward that they might be inhaled by
the many heads this is an entirely
inefficient method of dealing with your
unwant do you know how many helium
balloons it takes to lift your average
person the internet does it would take
approximately 65,000 lers of helium or
60,000 lers of hydrogen to lift your
average sized human that's over 5,000
regular siiz balloons also you'd
probably need to double that if you
wanted to get any sort of altitude for
smiting movie talker hey wait no that's
probably Fair please help me you can
reach me if you try please help me
inappropriate joke teller okay now I
just feel attacked Morty bird person
Mory lands on a planet of bird people
and just happens to be greeted by the
one bird person he
knows what the you can turn into ice My
Story begins at the dawn of time in the
far away realm of alphab betrium
23-minute TV show has time for this
amount of ice position okay things are
getting out of hand getting giant head
from space has created cataclysmic
natural disasters around the world the
planet has been teleported to Ho the
fork knows where to participate in some
sort of Intergalactic singing contest
with an 80% mortality rate and all of
your best musicians are already dead I
repeat getting out of hand I'm setting
the nuclear option to launch one minute
into Earth's performance and you Mr
President I hope you like being hit in
the face with a gun wait wait wait why
why doesn't the general need the
president to be conscious so that he can
authorize said nuclear option if he
doesn't need the president's codes or
authoriz ation why hasn't he launched
them already I believe I can access the
history of Rick's gun and help you get
back to him snooping through the browser
history of someone else's electronic
device not that you'd find anything in
mine nope no sir not mine clean as a
whistle did you guys did you guys see
that one thing on the did you see at the
place the one thing can we can we move
on now once in for the mental image
resulting from reading the band named
flesh curtains I married you because
you're the love of my life going to need
a whole lot of balloons full of an
Intergalactic skip Just Launch the
missiles maybe all it takes to launch
nuclear missiles is one guy at a
computer pressing a button but if that's
true I don't want to know about it and
it's no less of a sin after 988 seasons
of Planet music the cromulons have
decided to declare Earth the final
winner and bring our musical reality
show to a conclusion Goodbye Oh man now
what am I going to watch ooh maybe
there's a UK version trade secret Mr
President particle beam in a wristwatch
snake holster on the leg but how does he
refill the snakes while he's out and
about laughing at murder jeez I can't
believe we found a version of Earth with
a ball fonders movie franchise even this
early in the series I find it impossible
to believe that Morty could be surprised
by much of anything they find
considering all the Insane Adventures
they've been on to this point also they
choose ball fondlers over French toast I
can't speak to either movie's quality
but I can attest to the fact that ball
fondling is so much better after helping
a french toast or so I've heard allowing
Full House to exist in more than one
reality what's wrong Rick is it the
quantum carburetor or something Jesus
Morty you can't just add a Sci-Fi word
to a car word and hope it means
something over 800 episodes of Star Trek
would beg to differ wait you can't leave
me here to be fair he can but I'm not
sure why he does if Rick can bring Morty
with him into the battery I'm not sure
why he couldn't bring summer as well in
fact Rick knows that summer would be
less of a buzz kill so if anything why
isn't he leaving Morty in the car if
Rick and the Gang are in a different
reality who is summer texting did we
miss them getting an interdimensional
cell phone plan added onto their
interdimensional cable package either
way we're looking at one sin for the
show or one foring cable companies
always trying to upsell you on I know
that the joke throughout this episode is
that the ship follows Rick's
instructions to the extreme but why
would Rick program it to start with
murder as its first line of defense
Rick's an imaginative guy what about
electrifying the door or I don't know
having the ship move itself away from
the danger where are we Rick Morty
remember 8 seconds ago when when you
said go inside what and I said the
battery and then we showed up here and I
wasn't like whoa this is unexpected this
is not what I was expecting Morty as is
always the case Rick would be excellent
at TV sins I put a spatially tesselated
void inside a modified temporal field
until a planet developed intelligent
life by this point I know the Quest for
any semblance of meaning or logic behind
the science in Rick and Morty is a
fruitlessly frustrating one so to that
end I'm going to save my sanity and time
and leave this with a very simple and
succinct how the can this possibly work
you have a whole planet sitting around
making your power for you that's slavery
it's Society confusing the inherent
flaws that come with any modern society
with the actual aberration that is
slavery it appears we are being
Revisited by the alien known as Rick who
once gave our world the gift of Google
boox technology sinful news position is
sinful in all that but how is this new
story already being broadcasted Rick
just got there and they haven't actually
seen him in person how do they know
someone else isn't flying the discount
board Cube also why does the newscaster
have to explain what gooble boox
technology is the civilization is
literally built to use this technology
who there wouldn't know what a gooble
boxes do they need to have one of these
hooked up to every household appliance
and does that mean that the appliance
only works while The Stomping is in
progress why don't they have a way of
storing The energy they generate where
the do these cables go and why are they
a different color why is flub orks Morty
got to flip them off I told them it
means peace among Worlds how hilarious
is that as hilarious as this prank is
what's the point it doesn't mean to
these aliens because they have no
context for the gesture's original
meaning and it's not like anyone is
going to come visit the universe held
inside Rick's ship battery just to
appreciate this flipping off of an
entire civilization consequence free I
bet there are plenty of that
would pay good money to do that
including me either way someone deserves
a sin I would love to see it you what
did you say
me you you told me it means much obliged
how is much obliged a suitable response
to Rick wanting to see this genius
invention should even said something
like happy to oblige unless much obliged
actually means happy to oblige to these
people in which case f you would it be
possible for us to get some kind of tour
of your miniverse from the inside why
bother with a tour just destroy the damn
thing and make up some BS about why
they're forbidden to create this
technology again he is a literal God to
them this isn't aing chocolate Factory I
don't have time this comment doesn't
necessarily mean that the werse exists
in this entirely unique and
self-contained universe but it does mean
that chocolate exists and as comforting
as it is to discover that chocolate
appears to be a multiversal constant it
really doesn't make a damn bit of sense
so yes I'm sending chocolate all right
let's go how did Zer flirter BG know
that Rick would know to hold on to him
and Morty for this to work and how quick
are Rick's reactions there was Zero
warning for this sudden Transportation
what are you doing telling this guy that
his miniverse is unethical did not see
the hypocrisy here the only thing I see
is an implausible belief on Morty's
behalf that Rick isn't this disingenuous
and awful as a human being hypocrisy
indeed looked in a mirror lately Morty
incoming you got a device bom bom yet no
one moves back crank it I told them this
means peace among worlds but the
gestures lipop is making actually is the
sign for peace in our universe at least
so does that mean this two-finger
gesture independently evolved to have
the opposite meaning in this microverse
culture thus allowing him to comically
assign it the inverse meaning in this
miniverse which has actually me its
reversion back to the original meaning
as we know in our universe they not
really aliens no they're just a couple
of crazy wacky scientists you know I
hate to be the well actually
guy who am I kidding of course I don't
anyways from this perspective they're
all the very definition of aliens
pterodactyl the only reason this
exclamation should have scared zlap
Vander FLA is if he's aware of what a
pterodactyl is which means this place
also evolved dinosaurs this would be a
bizarre mathematical impossibility even
if it were just another planet this is
another planet an entirely different
Universe I guess the Multiverse must
reallying love dinosaurs honestly can't
blame them don't flatter yourself
there's always AAA youing I've
heard the quantum battery add-on to the
AAA plan is priced very reasonably what
are we going to do now question from The
Writer's room when struggling with this
very weak be story somehow make their
way into the episode we are now three
layers of distinct Universe deep in the
most variety this evolutionary gene pool
could muster is a third eye on a deer
this is still aing deer I don't know
whether to S the fact that this deer
would have definitely heard this
timber-based Jagger situation coming
from a mile away and would have long
since bolted or the fact that this
tries to Lunge for it instead of
using this fing Boulder launcher to kill
it both it is I hope your God is as big
a dick as you my God's the biggest dick
that's never existed
blasphemy Rick has form for using snakes
in this way so I'm prepared to
reluctantly buy this element of his
Armory however the cream of this
carefully crafted pie of bull is that
with this limited amount of storage
space Zulu Von stick here chose to keep
aing Eagle just in case of this very
eventuality and it fing worked ooh wow
gay that is pretty gay using the word
gay gay as an insult I masturbated to an
extra curvy piece of Driftwood the other
day xop files oh hey guys I just
finished cooking us a feast the fck is
there a kitchen in this lab for also who
would want to live in a universe where
one pan of beige constitutes a
feast genocide a long time ago I
implanted you with a subdermal chip that
can call upon dormant Nanobots in your
bloodstream to restructure your anatomy
and turn you into a car turning your
grandson into a turbo teen without
explicit
consent Rick's eyes survive
this um guys what happens if the hood is
locked ew what the hell Jesus there's
flies in my ice cream fce cream nice to
see everyone's just sitting here
patiently with their two eggs two
sausages pancake and I'm going to say
rice grits cottage cheese my point is
why is no one eating yet Rick and mor
episode F sub standard breakfast
operating procedure cliche this time
it's the case of the inappropriate bowl
of cereal everyone knows that you eat
cereal while the main breakfast is
cooking and if that sht has been sitting
there in a puddle of milk getting
soggier by the second I will lose my
damn mind and don't think it gets a pass
if this morning malady is at the premil
part of its Journey this bowl is filled
to capacity with cereal how does Morty
expect to be able to add any milk to
this without some serious cereal seepage
what is up with this balloon game that
Jerry's playing first I thought he was
popping just the blue balloons but then
he pops a red one and then I wondered
why there's no score listed so what's
the point but then I realized there are
apps where you just pop fake bubble wrap
like this so now the SS for app culture
and bleeding my bank account dry 99
Cents at a time sorry I wasn't paying
attention to a conversation about
vampires In fairness to Jerry vampires
are one of the least interesting
conversation topics to happen around
this breakfast table so not sure why
everyone's so worked up about it also
making me use the phrase In fairness to
Jerry we tried a couple's therapist
that's Earth therapy you might as well
ask a horse to fix a merry-go round it
may not be perfect and may take a lot of
work but strangely enough Earth therapy
is the only therapy most people on earth
have access access to and if I have to
throw sin on one of the funniest shows
of all time just to remind you that
therapy is indeed amazing ding away also
does he mean an actual horse or one of
the horses on the merrygoround itself I
suppose one is as ridiculous as the
other but both prove the point he's
trying to make but this is an oddly
specific example of futility and
sometimes I just want to know where this
comes from I'm going to go make some
wooden steaks good luck summer there's
one thing I know about Rick and morot
they don't really specialize in having
Stakes I booked you for a two-day
intensive at nuptia 4 the Galaxy most
successful couples counseling Institute
this place has a 100% success rate of
fixing marriages and is open to the
entire galaxy but somehow Rick was able
to book them in with zero notice I can't
even book a damn haircut with that sort
of notice my shoe fits up your ass you
wish take that back you do not think
that about me show doesn't clearly
explain that she's not really angry
about the whole killer insect thing it
was actually the four boobs who wants to
carry around two more of those
nuisances character closes a door and is
scared by a younger clone of
their grandfather standing behind it
cliche oh my God Toby Matthews boy Crazy
Summer is my least favorite summer but
strangely enough also my most favorite
summer the next step is to watch your
mytholog interact together and uh big
surprise it's never pretty is a battle
between the physical manifestations of
your deepest and most uncensored
thoughts about your significant other
really the sort of thing that should be
aired in front of complete strangers in
what way is that therapeutic for anybody
we can work together
smearing your arm oil on your worm
husband honestly guys have you ever
tried to send this show modesty hands
and I guess it's time for me to get back
inside the Oldtimer I'll let one of our
honorary TV SS team members take this
one um phrasing where are the Smith
mythes sending someone into check
instead of just watching back the
surveillance footage you do have
surveillance footage in your fancy
futuristic marriage monster prisons
right also this works seriously was the
wall matching color of this giant fing
glute ball really enough to side it I
mean it's clearly spilling over these
steps what the heck did Glick GL Fu Fe
think this thing was is anybody
listening can anyone understand stop
looking at me like that and actually
help me rhyming understand with help me
surely race this Advanced has the
ability to present these murderous
marital monstrosities as harmless
Holograms they'd still be able to
observe how they interact without the
risk of all this maming then again I
suppose that mean this B plot would
actually end up being about the
complexities of dealing with long-term
relationships and then then we'd be in
danger of actually learning something
that noise continue the Smashing and
slicing also if they absolutely have to
take a physical form which they don't
why would they send this guy all on his
own and leave the door wide fing open if
you know that this is the sort of havoc
and destruction they could cause and
this place has 100% success rate my trip
advisor review shall say otherwise what
the hell kind of relationship do you
have I mean you just screamed they're
codependent so are you being rhetorical
here as your universally lotted marriage
counseling service never dealt with
codependency earlier these creatures
called our planet eth as if they didn't
know how to pronounce Earth but the
entire map is in English make up your
mind ridiculous animated comedy show if
you can find one too we should be safe
for hours maybe days there is so much
room in this panel for both of them that
even Jack and Rose are scoffing at Jerry
right now get outside read a book
reading this episode says tiny Rick more
than the pickle Rick episode says pickle
Rick I feel like the writers may be
overcompensating for something here H
tiny pickle give me a second I'm going
to figure it out why was Night Rider
called Night Rider the car's name was
kit nobody rode Michael Knight Rick
would be excellent at a Night Rider
episode of TV SS why was Night Rider
called Night Rider the car's name was
kit nobody rode Michael Knight see get
your sh together get it all together and
put it in a backpack all your this gets
it together for
some no nobody's doing that around 41%
of people are doing that you want Jerry
I don't even want Jerry that's Jerry EST
stacking your cups this eyes just asking
for some kid to accidentally
knock them over as a distraction to put
some special ingredient in the punch
bowl shorter cup Stacks are the road to
True sobriety friends let me out let me
out this is not dance this in goes out
to the Rick and Morty fan who rocked
this dance at his local Club thinking
everyone would think it was hilarious
forgetting that Rick and Morty Uber fans
are a much smaller subset of humanity
than you might think and was mocked and
embarrassed and could never show his
face again in Allen's anticipation
station and it's me this it goes out to
me you're a great student the fact that
you're an 80-year-old man and a clone
body it never bothered me but it really
should why is everyone even aware of
this let alone okay with it and how has
Rick managed to prove himself as a great
student he's only been there since this
morning and I don't think he's even been
to any classes and if he has why he's
meant to be hunting vampires how can one
sentence contain so much sin summer
Smith is a psycho nerd and she
just got me kicked out of school not
owning your I'm here to save you are my
name isn't Jerry
Smith aha yes Jerry
Smith yeah no show has a right to be
this funny and genuinely insightful at
the same time it's just not fair to the
other shows and yes that means I'm
giving this show a sin because other
shows can't match it but don't look at
me that way you knew which channel you
clicked on honey I like to believe that
Hugh Jackman's character from The
Prestige survived found some youth juice
and eventually became his character in
reminiscence and that this machine is
the Twisted result of a merger of both
of his Infamous inventions I have
nothing to base this on but now that
I've shared this with you don't act like
you don't want it to be true as well
unless this clock is broken and there's
no reason to assume it is the school
dance was taking place at 2 in the
afternoon when they should all no I
don't know be in classes also this
calendar has at most 20 squares in total
of course this all could be taking place
in an alternate reality where the months
only have 20 days and school dances
regularly take place at 2 p.m. but I'm
not prepared to believe in a universe
where such Madness is possible now back
to the 80-year-old in the Clone body of
his teenage self attempting to murder
his original older self what are you
going to do I'm tiny Rick I'm the
coolest kid in your school you have been
expelled sir your threats are Hollow
Rick comes out of the vat and Marty says
Rick while summer says pants and while I
don't blame summer for her cultural norm
views on nude body boundaries regarding
grandparents I will say it's weird that
you chose this moment to be all of a
sudden so grossed out when his tiny Rick
has been in Clear View the whole episode
why go through all of the effort of
strategically covering the Rick if
you're just going to blur it anyway now
is there a set budget of blurs per
episode Mass Sanchez eyed just so you're
prepared there's a bunch of dead mies in
the garage speaking of multiple mies
what the is going to happen to the
assorted cast of into the Jerry verse
back here I know nobody behind Rick and
Morty is interested in answering those
sort of questions but damn it I want my
loose ends tied up hey phrasing don't
worry about Jerry Jesus that door open
hella fast how many broken noses have
these doors caused and how many people
have been sent to the hospital while in
this Hospital it'll stain if it gets on
your clothes and it'll send you into a
murderous rage if it gets in your eyes
or mouth seems like this Hospital would
be doing everything it could to make
sure Jerry couldn't projectile vomit
that stuff on anybody or at the very
least make sure anyone nearby was
protected from him hello I'm Dr glipglop
if Jerry is affected by the same mutant
bacteria why didn't he get sent into a
murderous rage and maybe Rick did
something to Jerry where he didn't have
to kill him but why didn't he do the
same for the doctor is it because
hilarity what are you doing a sequel I
don't understand yeah me neither we
pretty much nailed it the first time
acknowledging your premise is likely not
going to be very good so you can lower
people's expectations and people can
forget about the usual high quality of
your work cliche ow that is fully up in
there and I hope for her sake these
wooden letters have been sandpapered
smooth splinters in your sensitive bits
can ruin a good wood in the ass moment
you know also you're calling this one
interdimensional cable to even though
the first one was called Ricky minutes
you got some Rambo 3 in my Rick and
Morty guys not cool man versus car so
every single one of these shows will be
random and stupid in the hope of
generating roughly the same number of
laughs as the last time they did this
but they went with randomer and stuper
for this one I hope that when you told
your friends about Rick and Morty this
wasn't the first episode you showed them
I'm I'm looking through your eye holes
yes look through my eye holes my boner
is confused also we're about to find out
that these eye holes are a breakfast
cereal the puts their cereal on their
faces and has weird foreplay like this
or is this the species where eyeholes
come from this is an improvisational
pretzel you're guiding me
through is that rope made of metal or is
the Skylight glass really thin how the
did that break the glass I'm the only
one that's allowed to have eye holes
right after this Rick will say that this
guy actually beats you up if you possess
eyeholes so have a lot of questions
first if the company making eyeholes is
advertising this why would they hire
this guy as their mascot you know the
one who beats the out of you for eating
them second how does the eyehole man
know that you have eyeholes I mean this
guy came in a helicopter which had to
have been in Flight before this couple
even revealed their eyeholes third and
more importantly you can buy these at
Ikea and why does this place have stores
Earth has is it a comment on their
ubiquity shrimply pibbles life can be
saved if we replace his heart with your
human penis after the scenario was
revealed a writer for house woke up in a
cold sweat and yelled why didn't we
think of that their entire culture is
built around their penises man I don't
know how I got Vera Herzog for this
episode and to say this but I'll remove
a sin just because listening to him talk
matter of factly about jokes is
hilarious but also while I'm listening
to something hilarious look at those fly
wings how are they on the outside of the
lab jacket and tell shrimply pibbles
that when the Galaxy Came Calling Jerry
Smith from Earth didn't Flinch he's
right there jar pretty sure just told
her Beth and summer are cruising their
smartphones from an Intergalactic
hospital and I'm wondering how any of
that works does the alien Hospital have
Wi-Fi that connects to different planet
technology are there satellites that
transmit all the way back to Earth while
summer texts how did I get here it's
that lady with the sh on her face like
war from Star Trek that that was getting
coffee how did she get there it is it's
the same woman infinite channels
infinite possibilities but sure why not
have something happen to her on TV
immediately after Morty noticed her we
need one J Michael Vincent to quadrant C
we need two Jan Michael Vincent to
quadrant e seems the main problem this
world is having is that there are only
eight Jan Michael Vincent in 16
quadrants the Jan Michael Vincent
Factory wouldn't send two Jan Michael
Vincent to one quadrant I'm clearly
sending the fake movie and not Rick and
Morty here but where else am I going to
put this in this show where somebody
steals stuff must be a sham because that
camera didn't follow Steely through the
door it panned over through this huge
opening on the left side of this guy's
office so either this is a studio or
Steely went through an unnecessary door
all right okay now we're in the quiet
safe room where none of the people whose
stuff I stole can get to us yeah but you
literally stole a person you stole from
so where did you put that guy is he tied
up somewhere in your house what was the
point of stealing him we got a bag of
bobbish that's eight rles first off you
literally stole items that people from
Earth would recognize from a place with
nothing alien to us whatsoever how do
you suddenly have alien items sold for
alien prices secondly I'm looking at
your safe room and you have nothing
alien at all on your shelves this whole
scene seems to be setting up the plumbus
sketch for l get the orthodon out of
here no why take him out of this
audience kill him sick them demons suck
his life out this is so casually insane
I've got to remove a it why does the
doctor have a framed picture of the
anatomy of a human penis does the image
change based on whatever he's
researching or is he just obsessed with
all things I don't want to be that girl
but maybe there would be less conflict
if they didn't shoot their shows at the
same time oh summer you have no idea how
much money that must save production
would it though two shows being shot
side by side with conflicting lighting
and audio seems like an absolute
nightmare waste of resources we get a
one personal space two personal space
this guy has four slides that simply say
personal space the other five slides at
the very least say what you're supposed
to do with his personal space which is
to stay away from him I know this might
be the point but I find it hard to
believe any Dimension finds this
entertaining also this alien in the
background is loving this countdown of
personal space slides and their
enthusiasm is infectious but it took
them seven slides to start getting into
it which I'm guessing is how long it
took the animators to get into it if
they measure the size of this alien
splatter on the wall then why is there a
need for judges enough to pay for a
brand new state-of-the-art synthetic
heart that will be even better than Mr
Smith's pathetic penis wait that was an
option the whole time yep the a story B
story I don't know what the f it is it's
even more pointless than the
interdimensional cable shows who wait a
second is that Meda in a Duck Dynasty
show I can't decide if I want to remove
a sin or I'm a marine biologist who was
bitten by an octopus damn how far down
the chalkboard was the premise when you
brainstorm this episode oh my God I'm a
good person with a plan to what exactly
stick your penis in the open cavity of a
patient during surgery how is this
proving Jerry is a good person I know
he's an idiot but is he this much of an
idiot this is my butthole ice cream
parlor God damn show so now you're
resorting to humor and semi stealing
from that Nathan For You episode where
he convinced an ice cream parlor to sell
a poo flavor you were shot like 50 times
57 thankfully you're in a super
sophisticated alien hospital so it was
basically like getting a splinter
removed but replacing a penis-like
structure for shrim pibbles was too
difficult for this Hospital you can't
make people like you you just have to
wait for hating you to bore them Cinema
sin's long-term strategy somehow Finds
Its way into a Rick and Morty episode I
mean seriously how do I holes make any
money and this traveled From
Another Dimension to stop Jerry from
eating them penis penis penis penis
penis with your human penis balls their
entire culture is built around their
penises got such and such for a penis
you would give you penis take my penis
these guys they want to completely
remove my penis penis will be replaced
if you want to keep your penis I prefer
to keep my penis if the universe needed
his penis use your penis balls you
disrup my penis on one way tiet I prefer
my own penis BS this guy's trying to get
out of giving away his penis trying to
weasle out of his penis donation Mr
Smith's pathetic penis ball you cut off
my penis balls remove my penis remove my
penis sir I got to tell you Rick it's
pretty great to be in this spaceship
just the two of us you know mentioning a
Grover Washington classic and not
breaking out into song immediately after
just the two of us we can s it if we try
just the two of us myself and I I'm all
alone relax that's what windshields are
for once you break through Earth's
atmosphere shouldn't it be called a
vacuum Shield I love doing space sins
because it's the shest way to make sure
I'm wrong about something no matter how
long I research it also in this case
vacuum Shields are also for keeping
breathable atmosphere inside your
vehicle in fact I'd say that's probably
enough of the primary purpose that this
plot Catalyst bug protection is nothing
more than a side benefit I didn't know
that there were bugs out in space
doubling down on the space sins would a
bug in space have those kind of wings
what do they even flap against this
space bug is a lie yeah I guess I'm out
of fluid that would immediately freeze
or float away or something unrelated to
what it would be intended for space for
Millennia our society has been free of
crime and War living in perfect peace oh
I know what this is interrupting someone
in the middle of their story or
explanation one night a year where you
all run around robbing and murdering
each other without consequence thinking
legal ramifications are the only things
that fall into the category of
consequences it's like The Purge Morty
that that movie The Purge you're going
to have to be more specific there are
five of them now five of them and they
aren't even done making them yet you
know sometimes it's called the cleansing
or the red time so on the planet where
it's called the red time does it happen
monthly instead of annually cuz I think
you may have misunderstood hey Justin
I'm getting ready to design a creature
that'll only be on the show for a few
seconds what do you think does it have
two phallic appendages on its face yep
between them does the mouth look vaguely
Vish you know it a couple utter boobs
way ahead of you H maybe a brown
animated blob by the butt so you can't
tell if the animal has a tail or if it's
mid poop Dan you're a genius why don't
you have some candy bosss as well aliens
not only speak perfect English but can
also sell Earth items such as wiper
fluid and candy bars also the candy bars
have English written on them but all the
store signage is in an alien language
this planet is the worst how can you be
into this seriously after almost two
seasons of these Shenanigans how is
Morty surprised by anything at this
point why is reaction what why buing
your words in space we have something we
call the non-interference policy
since win leave you alone during a purge
I don't think so baby explaining you're
unable to stop purging you stop purging
to explain about being unable to stop
purging what part of that gives me
anything to work with my choice is to
say nothing be sarcastic or bark yes
like a trained animal you forgot the
fourth option explain the situation meta
contextually in order to launch a b plot
no one will ever remember when thinking
of this episode you know like a typical
teenager I don't want to answer any more
Purge questions that's funny I heard
Ethan Hawk Say this exact sentence at a
Boyhood press conference in 2014 can you
imagine being the doofus that asked
Ethan Hawk a second question about The
Purge when he's there for a link later
movie this is for oblivious Stevens from
how do idiots like this get into these
press events weekly you just now
remembered your nana exists Rick calls
our Thia out on her but still
follows her into the house which is
clearly a trap to get his gun and steal
his ship even if she sucks at it somehow
little mouse on the Prairie here manages
to fly a space vehicle she's never
interacted with before one that we
already know has sentients and security
measures in place heads up rapists
assuming the Criminal Intent of purgers
purge them me no me should I rub my
liver hole on
them I only had one of those things I
threw I'm holding a box of tic tacs
right now saying this out loud while
within close range of your adversaries
it's the space phone Grandpa gave us
keeping the space phone your Grandpa
gave you underneath the couch cushions
how was that helpful summer summer
there's a pile of silverware next to you
and you throw me the one thing that can
never kill anything he says directly
after killing something with it Morty if
I can get to the top of that Lighthouse
I can send the beacon and your sister
can launch our package having a plan
that involves a step up of having your
sister launch your package by the way
life on other planets exists don't let
it distract you oh don't worry no one
here seems phased by your alien
existence unless it's needed for the
plot or a joke and I don't sense either
of those things present here fade in
exterior unnamed City day reading also
forcing someone to listen to you reading
your screenplay this is not her day Fade
to Black title 3 weeks earlier in
media's res how are these screwdrivers
attached to the wall Velcro double-sided
tape doesn't that affect the grip and
why do you even need them accessible on
your wall toolboxes have been sufficient
for hundreds of years Rick hundreds of
years do you have any thoughts notes no
I I just enjoyed it that's my note you
know Morty would be terrible at Cinema
sense I'm not a huge fan personally of
the whole 3 weeks earlier teaser thing I
feel like you know we should start our
stories where they begin Morty would be
excellent It's Cinema sense you're a
petty person and you're insecure and
you're taking it out of me that's a good
script not sure how the writers of Rick
and Morty my email but at least they got
some benefit from my feedback from the
studios folder whoa Morty we're guests
here and is this Lighthouse full of
healing magic because Rick's gun wound
seems to have healed nicely he's walking
around like he hasn't been shot in the
gut for at least the last 10 minutes you
like that you want me to cut to 3 weeks
earlier when you were
alive this show is just the best cut to
one sin earlier when you didn't have as
many sins remember when we used to go to
the playground and I'd push you on the
swings oh you could push me higher than
all the other kids why was he pushing
other people people's kids I guess this
is what rock bottom feels like Jerry
being part of a b plot so uninteresting
and pointless that the story only spent
a total of 2 minutes and 16 seconds on
it in the entire episode yeah I can see
what you mean how did the beacon track
Rick and Morty to this spot they left
the Homing device at the Lighthouse okay
Morty now you're just shooting corpses
necro side honestly i' I've had my fill
it's gratuitous at this point Rick
admits the fall of the show before
doubling down and partaking even further
in that fault anyway feel like we've sin
this so much is probably repetitive by
this point no need to send it again I
suppose POS coordinated blood dancing
feels good to hit song top the charts I
think explaining your references you
picked the wrong man to push movie
Troutman First Blood 1982 I need food
who's got food for that guy I do but
this is for me this sociopolitical
commentates on for some time and while
I'm making food for everyone who takes
care of my kids not being able to cook
food and watch your kids at the same
time that's not a real job trying to
explain my job to anyone in my family
over 50 somehow makes its way into this
episode Jerry get a job okay fine 2
minutes and 44 seconds I'm just saying
if this entire B plot was built on the
Tatty Madison skill you'd only owe
$547 the trick to cereal is keeping 70%
of it above the milk this blanket
statement presumes that all cereal has
the same absorption rate 70% may make
sense for corn flakes or Cheerios but
you definitely want to land somewhere
between 50 to 60% for Froot Loops or
Cocoa Puffs and God forbid you Veer into
Shredded Wheat territory and end up with
one of those big old Ted lasso biscuits
you're going to want want to let that
thing soak for 5 days minimum maybe in a
mixture of equal parts vinegar and dish
soap after which you toss that in the
trash and figure out what you're doing
with your life it's like The
Intergalactic version of ups but less
offputting Throwing Shade at UPS and
pretending like FedEx and Amazon also
haven't been leaving packages at the end
of my driveway and outside of the fence
our TV signals take Lighty years to
reach this planet nobody tell them that
Braveheart wins first off a lightyear is
a measure of distance not time second
off how about a spoiler alert Rick I'm
only up to 1987 on my Academy Award
rewatch and I feel a little lost because
I haven't seen the first emperor yet
what the hell is a bird person he's
Rick's best friend Jerry said What Not
Who and even then bird person is much
more than just Rick's best friend he's
so many things weddings are basically
funerals with cake cute marriage equals
Death cliche but if that were true then
funerals with cake would have to
basically be weddings and speaking from
experience I can tell you they are not
you just say what's in your squanch and
people understand oh okay well
squanching squanch is before casually
squanching about out some squatches is
exactly the kind of squanch that makes
me both squanch and squanch this show
and with all my squanch I can't
squanching squanch how I squanch about
the squanching L squanch bit of
narrative squanch am all right maybe
it's possible that Rick and family beat
Jerry here but I have no way to prove it
either way so I'm going to send it to be
safe yeah because I'm an you say
you get it but I'm scared you'll keep
doing it title of my sex tape look
here's some humans you can practice on
title of the sequel to my sex tape blood
Ridge on clap flap third moon show uses
a variation of the word flap cliche ah
sounds like you and my dad have a long
history together this conversation gives
us insight into Beth's fractured
relationship with her father as well as
her insecurities and deficits and the
interplay between all three but it also
gives us some hilariously delivered
expositional backstory about bird person
and Rick the strange thing is I'm not
even mad about the exposition in fact I
welcome it what is wrong with me bird
person you are my seed my worm my early
surely one cannot be both the seed and
the worm plus lateness is generally more
common when the first two come into play
pulling out someone's innards even
jokingly I am a cyborg photographer just
act natural this is a candid shot I'm
not sure if the cyborg gaze is
problematic or not but until I can
collect more data I'm going to assume
it's a precursor to Terminator salvation
and I'm doing everything I can to
prevent that from happening again
writers didn't save this joke for its
Rick Sanchez in the temple of Squan
episode also they really turn this joke
on its head being nice is something
stupid people do to hedge their bets you
know as funny as it is this is the kind
of sh that serves as a driving force
behind this Show's toxic fandom and if
you're offended by that it's fair to
assume you're part of the problem now
you may be thinking that was a mean
thing to say well being nice is
something stupid people do to hedge
their
bets bird murder
mder the laser fire from these blasters
killed bird person but barely leaves a
scratch on what we can assume from the
instrument and Loc are referred to as
baseballs Squan is a dick to someone's
balls for no reason this catering space
fan has super convenient worm-based
countermeasures also the Smiths are
super lucky the Galactic Federation
hasn't realized the benefits of
spaceships that don't immediately
explode when they slightly bump into
each other when they develop that
technology Rick will really have to pull
some signs out of his ass you summer
saying F you to your granddaughter well
at least in this case you can't say F
you to your granddaughter we already
covered this Morty say you don't watch
TV SS without saying you don't watch TV
SS now who wants to go shopping for a
brand new World Elon Musk
and Jeff Bezos making plans for the
weekend if the Smiths think of star
screaming for 42 hours is the worst of
it wait till they see its coronal mass
injections after eating a space burrito
maybe I can buy that the space fan had a
TV handy and that Rick had some sort of
interdimensional cable thumb drive with
him or something I mean I don't want to
buy it but I'm going to try to get past
it how however I do not buy that they
build aing log cabin in this short
amount of time also I've decided I can't
get past the Working TV and cable signal
thing so we discovered a species of tiny
pig off the coast of new Australia we'd
offer you some but we hunted it to
Extinction for breakfast I know the
whole joke is that living on this tiny
planet is clearly not sustainable
however the idea that not only Rick the
smartest man in the universe but the
entire family excluding Jerry of course
wouldn't have foreseen this food
shortage as a problem is pretty
laughable especially when you consider
in the show Rick casually goes to a bar
before turning himself in surely they
could whip up some disguises to pick up
groceries at the nearest Intergalactic
grocery store Morty effortlessly sending
this frisbee around the entire planet
raises multiple questions about the
gravity here and how they're able to
walk around like normal all right just
the one question I guess Morty if you go
to where there's a bunch of ice cream
and then you don't come back you haven't
actually gotten ice cream you've just
gone where ice cream is Rick would be
squatching good at TV sense where's the
van Morty it's over Over the Horizon in
the driveway I'm not going to send Rick
asking Morty where the van is when he's
the only person we've seen driving it
I'm not going to send Rick asking where
the van is before checking the driveway
but I am going to send the fact that
they built a driveway for a space van
instead of a launching pad I'm Jerry
Smith and I love sucking big sweaty
boners and licking disgusting furry
testicle
sacks
okay only RI and Morty could have stuck
the landing on the transition fr from
that statement to the use of non
diagetic music to convey turmoil and the
general emotional toll of Rick's life of
the Galactic
Federation I feel better show expects us
to believe that medicine works this
quickly and it's someone who's sitting
here an hour later waiting for his
edible to kick in I'm calling
and this unicorn that's been hanging out
with me for the last hour totally agrees
what are you in for everything I really
hate Cliffhangers like this you're going
to put a character's fate in Jeopardy at
least make it someone that we might
believe will be stuck in this prison or
killed we know Rick won't be killed and
we know Rick won't spend the rest of the
series in prison this Cliffhanger is all
kinds of
squanch the blatant disrespect for this
pizza this might actually bother me more
than the Cliffhanger nonsense why would
you do that to a piece of pizza that did
nothing to you because you're a monster
that's why shony take all your clothes
off and fold yourself 12 times this is
exactly what I say when I open a fresh
package of origami paper no I'm not
sexualizing the art form but there is
something about those creases h also
leaving your underwear on when you're
clearly told to remove all clothing dude
literally tries to fold himself 12 times
but gets caught up on the never nude
claws I admire you Rick weird time to be
feeling admiration for one's intellect
while staring into your coffee Mug's
brown eye also fart mug is adorned with
a shony label and not one that reads
Spencer Gifts imagine deciding between
Master Sword Morty and spiked bat Morty
when throwing star Morty's right
freaking there spilling your breakfast
pills and leaving them on the table
especially the orange pink one those
things are like the bacon of the morning
caps meal industry stop saying his name
he abandoned us I know I'm not supposed
to cry over spilled milk but them mer
low didn't even have a chance to be sip
slowly after a snarky oneliner Willam
defo that's the guy I couldn't think of
this morning not being able to remember
Finding Nemo's Willam Defoe let's go
visit some memories oh any particular
ones you want to see my first boner or
should we go straight to the moment I
discovered interdimensional travel let's
go for the second choice my first boner
was at the front of my seventh grade
math class after solving a difficult
problem pretty sure the about the time I
was done everyone had solved for D yeah
well tough
titties there's no tougher than a
psychotic break Rick I once watched a
lady crush a six-pack of beer watermelon
and a brick with her on an episode of
America's Got Talent so I'm inclined to
disbelieve this fact between where you
were on 911 and your favorite sports
blooper crink is one of the most
intelligent creatures in the history of
creatures and his favorite sports
blooper isn't Jose cono headbutting a
ball into the stands for a home run
please also how does this baseball
Ricochet upwards off of this nut shot
I've got a degree inest testical physics
and that's just not how it works look at
these dead flies maybe if we arrange
them in a certain order it plays a
hologram or it opens a secret door
Summer's over here tampering with
evidence in a world where the alien
insect based Galactic Empire rules with
an iron fist you'd think this might be a
murder scene a bunch of the sesan sauce
like as much as you're allowed to give
me in the history of Life imitating art
that imitates life there's never been a
bigger fluster cluck than the Rick and
Morty Sichuan sauce Wars here's 15 sins
for Nostalgia based hysteria and one sin
back because honestly it's a pretty good
sauce but also the dude can invent
multi-dimensional time portals but can't
recreate a sauce bug boners bugers Bon
nugs honestly I'm surprised with this
much arousal the bug suit's able to
contain itself do you know how many
suits or pairs of pants I've ripped from
my bouts of excitement none because I'm
perfectly proportioned why did they bury
this world's Rick with a portal gun in
fact why did they bury this world's Rick
at all other Rick could have just easily
thrown the corpse into a portal or
incinerated or anything that wouldn't
require the manual labor of digging a
hole I don't know yet I'll make it up as
I go the motto from the Rick and Morty
writers room somehow makes its way into
the episode that's my sister this used
to be my home right because weird stuff
that happens in Rick and Morty's brought
back in reference by the show when it's
convenient what is the matter with you
people you're a bunch of back Savages
backstab aages we got you on this one
Morty
no a self-aware elongated and purposely
created fictional decoy no is still a no
yeah that's the three lines of math that
separates My Life as a man from my life
as an feeling ghost Rejoice Rick could
be worse I've heard three lines of Coke
can get you feeling like an unfeeling
ghost math is a much healthier option
gets me excited at least aome posum wait
how does this bug know what a possum is
did he study that much about Earth's
Animal Kingdom to know how to make that
clever animal rhyme always wait for
permission to I feel like acid reflux
would be a result of the condition of
the body and not the Consciousness and
so the insect alien shouldn't have
Rick's heartburn once Rick's mind
transferred and if you're telling me
that acid reflux becomes a part of a
person's soul than I I Hate Everything
what's the level n m access code again
Nathan fillian doing a Rick Sanchez
impersonation is everything I need in my
life what a treasure but also I'm still
mad that he never got to do Uncharted
and this show reminded me of that
emotion in a roundabout way so bummed I
didn't get to give that insect a test
drive wait you said you had to take a
level9 dump does that mean this insect
species poos out of their some things
are better off unimagined d99 this is
the commander-in chief of the citadel's
militia good
enough he's a spy blow him up I'm going
to go take a Rick may have invented
the best conversation segue ever but I
do have to wonder do all the Ricks
neglect bowel movements I can only
imagine having the urge to poop over and
over again has to be a curse now the
release of said waste I could do with
that feeling over and over again plus
I'd be able to catch up on all my Philip
DeFranco show in one day with that much
time spent on the toilet you killed him
because you were jealous of him that's
pretty obvious from the haircut judging
someone by their haircut unless of
course we're talking about Billy Ray
Cyrus circuit 1990s or Las Vegas Raiders
owner Mark Davis then it's totally fair
I was just trying to protect my sister I
wanted you to have a normal life Rick
and Morty tries to have emotional stakes
in a show where everyone's disposable
and no one's redeemable
[Music]
cliche hold on hold on there are
multiple already broken window paines
for you to jump out of balding Rick
smartest mammal in the universe my ass
okay I'm all about ease of access to go
to the bathroom in an armored outfit but
not protecting your buggy ball bag
you're in the middle of a gunfight I'd
rather get shot in the face than have a
hole in my scrotum now I'm questioning
if the insect who designed dis armored
practicality in mind when creating these
do the insects have extra lungs they
breathe through in their nut sack how
much elasticity is in the ball bag can
they be spun around their heads and
thrown at the enemy like some sort of
ball sack bolos to ins snare them I'm
not getting this out of my head for
weeks am I he who controls the PS
controls the Galaxy American idioms Have
a very weird influence on alien culture
my dad used to say he wore the pants in
the household but rarely did I see him
with pants on he was a tidy wh he in a
tank top kind of guy so was I really the
man of the house remember when phones
only had one camera and it didn't feel
like you were carrying around the Hubble
telescope array yeah good times Nancy
says they're drawing and quartering
aliens in the school Courtyard and it
technically counts as patriotism
Americans co-signing the brutal death
and torture of a culture or species you
don't say N More Seasons until I get
that dipping sesan spoilers summer next
time we're hiding in a Koran Echo Nest
can you do me a favor and turn your
ringer off desite what the subtitles say
it's still not entirely clear what's
being dealt with here was it a Koran
Ekko that had a nest or was it a Koran
that had an echo Nest how am I supposed
to update the fan Wei now Dan that's
because losers look stuff up darar right
pink shirt girl in this episode of this
television show darn right to live is to
risk it all otherwise you're just an
inert chunk of randomly assembled
molecules drifting wherever the universe
blows you show makes us question whether
or not this statement was actually
profound or just a setup to burn Jerry
cool just stay in the driveway the
killbots are Al and I took you off the
wait list good thing he just randomly
stopped right before walking into the
garage then or bad thing yeah let's go
with bad thing back in the very first
episode of Rick and Morty TV SS we made
a joke about this towing company and
finished by Sting that toes don't bend
like that we were then inundated in the
comments with people saying that their
toes do in fact Bend like that and I say
I'm giving 10 sins to you toe
scam Liars seriously if you can extend
your big toe and still fully Flex all
four of your other toes to where the
pads of the toe are touching the bottom
of your foot I'll give 20 C back in the
next Rick and Morty episode we send and
name drop you for it just send the proof
to pix or it didn't happen at Cinema
sins.com for verification in Absolut Ely
not because I want to look at pictures
of strangers feet as far as you know
half openen boxes in the mattress
leaning up against the side secured only
by this tall and unstable lamp the sin
is Jerry loading his truck like a Jerry
loser wind Sals can someone help me
understand if butts or faces and faces
are butts in this world then what part
of the butt is Butt Face Morty watching
the face butt porn with and what orifice
on the face butt do butt faces used to
you know what I just decided I don't
want to know any of this ding it quickly
please this episode is not titled mad
Rick Morty Road the exploding War boy on
the back of their vehicle has little to
no impact on them or the car proving
that even a show with an established
plot device for replacing main
characters can also be Shameless in its
use of plot armor I love
post-apocalyptic versions of Earth
people that believe in climate change
but still don't give a sh this stuff's
so powerful Morty it makes isotope 465
look like isotope 317 this technobabble
is so Star Trek TNG it makes doctor who
look like sliders your blood will be my
lotion blood would be a terrible lotion
dries up almost immediately and then you
walk around smelling like iron and
looking like a giant Scab this creature
with a horizontal hydraulic denture
mouth harmonica nose face speaks lies is
it really easier to eat human flesh than
to just tell me why we're still here
no no matter how many times you watch
these episodes there's always that one
joke that hits hard and this is the one
that did it for me uh you mean the blood
Dome save it for the santic Dome EB
white
burn I'm this close to giving another
sin offer yet another hilarious bit but
then I realized that calling the blood
Dome the Thunder Dome isn't just a
semantic difference blood is very
different than thunder although I do
hide under the covers the moment I
experience either of them this device
extracts and redistributes muscle memory
this McGuffin is fired so ungracefully
up the ass of this episode I have to
give it two sins even though its
penetration in the end will be quite
enjoyable letting this bicep meat rot in
the Heat and some chose to huddle near
the boomy holes calling it your boomy
hole and letting someone huddle near it
for the vert vertisements on Billy
boards did the boomy boom blow up all
your wordy word books summer would be
furiosa at TV sends nipple suspenders as
a fashion statement super cool nipple
suspenders as your chosen blood Dome
uniform liability man good thing
the Lady in the Water arm chose this
moment to stop destroying everything in
its vicinity the second summer showed up
huh his neck keeps pulsing more blood
out of it and honestly sometimes I think
the show forgets that disgusting things
can be distracting things and if they're
not careful I might not be paying close
enough attention to catch the next fart
joke we'll be right back aside from the
usual nonsense fourth wall breaking this
should also be sent for how it allows
the show to fast forward through how
Rick got out of this situation why sum
are sided with the death stalkers and if
Mor's monster arm got in some quick delt
work before it suddenly decided to drive
him out here chopping wood one-handed
wait chopping wood
left-handed now I'm going to whip you
narrating your whipping is only
acceptable if a problem comes along and
you whip it good what about the weird
guys on leashes then they're more like
interns this claims to have
little memory of the before four time so
this means that internships as a concept
have survived the apocalypse actually it
makes perfect sense that something as
soulless and evil would survive the end
of the world but still internships can I
see no one has seen my true face and
lived scene does not contain a baby Yoda
a metal bucket is on a certain level a
kind of mustache in that it's a specific
facial accessory a mustache is not just
a facial accessory it's a growing and
everchanging part of you that requires
care and nurture ing so it can one day
become a full and prominent statement of
your desire to never drink milk in
public ever again the thing I find most
disconcerting about this whole scene is
how all of them just sit there
conversing with an entire meatball on
their Fork I have so many questions like
aren't you worried about the SAU
stripping all over the place as you
gesture are you planning on eating the
entire meatball in one bite are you not
including any spaghetti with the
meatball they are meant to be eaten
together you Savages and that's before
we even get to your serving sizes that
plate of spaghetti is as big as your
head that's probably 3,000 calories
worth of spaghetti there and I'm not
even counting the pure a egg yolk drink
you've included dial it back Summer by
15% and increased Dynamic Movement by
three no matter how many times this show
tries to explain way Beth being
oblivious to All Things Rick because of
the issues with their relationship she
has also been established to be a very
smart person only takes a moderately
smart person like myself to see through
this robotic family ruse plus Dynamic
movement adjustments are always done in
increments of five otherwise what's the
point you Millennials generational
zations please slavery was a family
business that's his business business
the flashback we saw earlier was of his
men murdering the entire Village the
writers think someone could be this bad
at business and also have a taint washer
uh arathy can I steal you for a second
arathy arathy what about Armen fight or
sleeve jobs I mean hand squish him
Andersson was right there maybe the
lesson we've learned is that I don't
know if we get to do this with Rick and
bardy so
skip they did all this in 3 weeks I mean
my neighbor started putting up a fence
in his backyard 3 months ago and he
still not done part of this in is
probably on my lazy neighbor Bruce but
this is still a lot of infrastructure
for 21 days we were monsters we didn't
care about anything I still don't yeah
except I'm the only one in this entire
world that's still committed to that oh
ding ding ding ding-ding ding three sins
oh I get it you want me to send the
marriage kills romance and results in
Conflict cliche fair enough here's your
ding- ding ding no Union built on
running from your problems last more
than 5 years seven tops USA deniers
no no unless my suffering is your
nourishment TV sins I turned myself into
a pickle Morty with the garage door open
I mean it's possible Rick couldn't care
less if people know he's a mad scientist
but I usually like a little privacy when
I'm transforming my pickle I'm pickle
Rick Roll D mercials it's probably sin
enough that this intro scene doesn't
have an episode yet but I'm just
confused why each butt cheek would have
a separate face when the face is the
entire butt shouldn't the butt then be
the entire face and wouldn't this make
the mouth the oh god I've gone too far
also it's official Rick and Morty needs
to do a whole episode including all the
stuff they didn't do from the intros and
turn it into one episode they're good at
Off the Wall concept so time to make it
happen stop digging for hidden
layers and just be impressed Rick Morty
fans in our comment section did you do
this on purpose to get out of family
counseling he did and it really makes me
wonder why he didn't do something a lot
less convoluted seems like he could have
simply faked being sick or made himself
sick for real and had an antidote hidden
somewhere or thousands of other things
he could have done to get out of therapy
we're going to get one of the most
famous Rick and Morty episodes out out
of it but while it's hard to complain
it's not hard to sin hey Rick why is
there a syringe of mysterious fluid
hanging directly over you Morty's got a
point here why would Rick set up some
sort of rube goldbergan syringe solution
in full view of everyone I would think
someone smart enough to become an actual
pickle would also be smart enough to
hide whatever creative way they found to
not be a pickle anymore for instance
Conjuring a Meeks and asking them to
hide until everyone leaves and then
administer the antidote for one possible
solution Beth conveniently leaves the
garage door open so the pickle Rick can
get into his
Adventure
this goes on for some time it was a
bright ass sunny day with no cloud in
sight then the clouds with the flooding
rain came out of nowhere to bail Rick
out I'm pretty sure it only rains long
enough for Rick to get to the next phase
of the story making this the biggest day
of X mock in a rain since Noah when God
killed all of Noah's Arc Nemesis also
floods don't happen this fast and unless
the water is coming directly from the
garage this driveway wouldn't accumulate
water at any depth at all pickle Rick is
apparently holding his breath underwater
so can we talk anatomical morphing does
this mean this pickle has respirat
circulatory and neurological systems and
if so isn't it more of a pickle shaped
human than an actual human turned into a
[Music]
pickle yes how did he say yes so clearly
if he's tongueing a roach's brain
non-stop to make it move also most
scientists think that arthropods
actually have a distributed intelligence
which means their motion is controlled
at multiple points of the body meaning
this cerebral Lingus shouldn't really be
doing all that much at all it's nobody's
choice to be here you knobs the family
was told to get counseling by your
principal sounds like the principal was
a co-writer on the script considering
the unusual request for the entire
family to get counseling even though
it's not the family that was huffing
Pottery glaze in the art room as far as
my research shows Pottery glaze does not
contain any brain altering substances oh
you sweet summer child how long have you
all been eating poop yeah I bet when you
have fond memories of the pickle Rick
episode you don't remember the Morty
desk peeing incident or the teacher that
eats poop do you this rat trap includes
of weight wall screws and bolts and a
tied off rubber band secured at twice a
pickle height how the hell could Rick
build this at his current pickle size
and with a distinct lack of opposable
thumbs this Rick builds complex
Machinery quickly with no hands or tools
it's going to be a common thing isn't it
fine let's add five sins for this plot
forwarding nonsense and move on good
thing the city installed these sewer
covers to give way with such great sense
of dramatic timing I know this is one of
those things where you're not supposed
to think very deeply into it and just
accept that Rick who is a pickle screwed
rat arms and legs onto himself and now
has the agility of Tony jaw asz it
Rampages through this rat hord but if
rat Anatomy is this amazing I find it
hard to believe they wouldn't rule the
world or at the very least have complete
control of the New York City Subways
also don't get me wrong going all John
Rick chapter 3 pickle Bellum on these
rats is pure amazingness but unless he's
broken the law of conservation of mass
him making this machine appear complete
with seemingly unlimited ammo out of
absolutely nothing can suck my giren
well Dr Wong by the way racist name
calling things racist that aren't even
racist at all you have any
self-awareness God you were special the
rats now they're dead I guess it was me
you should have impressed I feel like
somewhere this episode should get a sent
off for its goofy premise paying off and
I'll do it here I mean to be a nitpicky
bastard but what the is up with all
these vents in this hallway and room 280
is directly across the hallway from room
290 who in the toilet is this how the
did Rick get this deep into the middle
of nowhere from that sewer he was in hi
um can you uh please let me out can't
Rick just find a way out on his own he's
been using the vents to get around and
he has more resources than when he was
down in the sewers and down there he
could build a jetpack and a whole
complicated rat part assembly machine
some of my men are calling you senena
the pickle man an old wife's tale he
crawls from bowls of cold soup to steal
the dreams of wasteful children this old
wives tail is about as stupid as the
First Wives Club a pickle as some sort
of waste not want not Boogeyman I know
Russia's up guys but it can be way more
creative and up than that this Russian
Syndicate must shop for office supplies
at the same company as John Wick and
Ledger Joker because these industrial
strength pencils are somehow nailing
someone to a wall and impaling entire
human shoulders my pencil breaks when I
press too hard while while dotting the
eye and Kendrick with a little heart
what do you think is in the syringe bath
you're the one that cost $200 an hour
you tell me okay so this mandatory
counseling cost $200 I can barely even
see the family agreeing to this
counseling much less paying $200 an hour
oh my god oh there's pictures of people
eating poop in there the alternate title
of this episode was clearly FAL Rick as
little that's left of these desks I'm
questioning their ability to support a
full vanam in their current condition
how is Rick flying this Chopper without
being able to reach the anti-torque
pedal and other important helicopter
things what is this some kind of Suicide
Squad I have no doubt that you would be
bored senseless by therapy the same way
I'm bored when I brush my teeth and wipe
my ass who has ever been wiping their
ass and said to themselves God damn this
is boring it's not like it's supposed to
be fun feels like this is just another
way for the episode to wallow and again
she hued enamel and we never even talked
about it uh yeah you did it's what led
to Summer saying I am mad that I can't
Huff enamel without people assuming it's
because has my family sexs saying she'd
prefer people to just think she likes to
get high it was
disgust a stringed instrument will be
completely muted by crushed corpses
attached to its strings even in the key
of B flat now for the E
Splat Jaguar is Jaguar um going to untie
Rick and Morty don't let any of those
things get away Morty and be sure to
keep the garage door open while these
things Scurry about that seems to propel
a lot of our plots also is this a garden
hose hanging on the side of the Smith
house that thing is huge that is the
giri yard hose ever to hose a yard can
we call it dirt digler I Morty Smith
invoke my right to choose one in every
10 Rick and Morty Adventures so it's
true Rick and Morty have Adventures that
are not televised so it's possible we
haven't seen other Adventures chosen by
Morty but the episode me seeks and
Destroy seemingly established that Morty
would choose at least one Adventure in
every 10 episode season when Morty
angled to be in charge of every third
adventure and Rick casually rebutted him
off with every tent this self-aware show
was surely referring to the number of
episodes in a season I think they just
forgot that this was a thing until now
this time travel box hasn't paid off and
I'm calling it it's been long enough I
want some time travel Shenanigans damn
it this container has been teasing me
since episode 1 and my flock is at full
capacitor they did a whole vindicators
without us bunch of them got killed too
so Morty is an unabashed vindicators fan
and while it makes sense that they would
do an adventure without Rick and Morty
seems like he would have figured that
out already since he's such a huge fan
of them and all wouldn't he have various
news feeds set up to follow whatever the
vindicators were doing even when they
weren't assembled yikes yeah things did
feel less diverse in there sure there's
a white guy but there's also a woman who
is apparently a solar system a person
made of ants a robot crocodile and a
ghost train conductor of color what the
hell is Rick even talking about I'll buy
that Supernova and Vance can fly down
from the Jet and I guess maybe million
ants can somehow float down with Morty
and toe but how do Allen rails and
crocubot even come close to surviving
the impact of that height are you all
right yes I only lost 400 ants million
ants is made up of a million ants this
many bullet holes would have caused the
slaughter of well into the tens of
thousands my queen is laying more I am
back to one 1 million ants literal
Ant-Man could have had any kind of
biology and it would make sense I
suppose I mean this guy is made up of
ants but no ants have to go through the
lar and pupe stages before developing
into full-blown ants this whole process
lasts a month at least so even if your
queen could somehow spit them out that
fast your chronology needs some work jez
Supernova I mean there's unrealistic
body image and then there is a toilet
paper roll balancing two cantaloupes
while sitting on top of the Great
Pumpkin is your superpow transmitting
body dysmorphia we're taking fire from
an automated turret can you bring it
offline seems like they would need Rick
to do this since many of the superheroes
have powers that could easily destroy
the turret on their own but this episode
is a parody of superhero movies so maybe
that's the point I'm sending it anyway
because I won't feel right in the
morning if I don't okay so the turret
shoot the decoy and it absorbs the
bullets but why do they stop shooting
once the decoy goes back into the box
these guns clearly have more bullets
left because they end up blowing
themselves up after Rick's hilariously
complicated device locks them down do it
in 3 minutes or you'll die so at what
point does Rick transition from
hilarious nihilistic to
legitimate super villain has he always
been the villain of of the show look
that's fine if that's the case I'm just
saying at some point we need some sort
of moral Foundation here right this is
triggering me I need space does anyone
even want to just glance at the board
and maybe just do the easy matching game
I'm as stubborn and prideful as the next
guy but if my life's on the line I'm at
least going to check out the difficulty
level before I get all flustered look I
know the drunk Rick set all this up and
all of this is surprising to him too but
sober Rick doesn't care one bit about
these so why is he all
horrified about fans the Rick we know
and love would be stoic about this and
be ready with a sarcastic quit give me
one reason why I shouldn't crush your wi
pipe because my epidermis is leased with
a nanofiber defense mesh okay that's
awesome but when he grabbed your neck
your eyeball went to bloodshot which
means your defense mesh wasn't working
when he first grabbed you it appears to
only exist for this joke of course we're
going to keep our eye on that clock and
now it appears to be under a minute even
though only one minute has passed since
the three minutes started this is like
the friends apartment quiz all over
again except Rick's more likable than
Ross but they don't pick the location
you'll you'll never hear them even
mention oh I know this dude this game
doesn't even have a timer why the rush
even drunk pickled Rick is a Super
Genius but he's just one Super Genius
right how does one person build this
entire fully automated giant
instructional screen and an interactive
holographic display in one drunken night
drunk version of me is probably so
supportive of Israel he wants what's
best for it and hey man I'm not touching
this that's a funny reply but does
million ants know the geopolitical
complexity of issues concerning Israel
to the point that he knows it's a touchy
subject let's say you have to hit five
three-pointers in 5 minutes or I don't
know the whole place the whole planet
will get blown up with a nutrino bomb
Rick clearly recorded his audio first
making it up as he went and then had to
enact his ramblings into the real world
which is kind of brilliant considering
that's basically how this show seems to
be created so this is either a sin for
Rick standing in as the proxy for the
writer's laziness or a sin for being
brilliant enough to get away with it
either way I'll disarm the drunkenly
improvised nutrino bomb Morty how many
of these too many Rick too many okay so
he's disarmed a few of these bombs but
why the hell is he all of a sudden going
full Heart Locker when we all know non-
drunk Rick is the one that will event
take care of this is there something set
up on this basketball court that detects
the distance from which these guys shoot
the basket because it seems like they
could just shoot layups and everything
rigged up here wouldn't know the
difference I mean if it allows Supernova
to cheat the three-pointers like this
then there's nothing stopping them from
taking the easiest shot possible because
when you're an it doesn't matter
how right you are nobody wants to give
you the satisfaction thing overheard at
TV sin's team building Retreat somehow
makes it into a Rick and Morty script
wouldn't Rick's nanofiber defense mesh
easily be able to break these handcuffs
so Morty gets on the platform and it
works but we find out that drunk RI was
thinking of noob Noob as the answer to
this question and while this game might
just be total Bull and that's exactly
the point of it all this whole thing is
so detailed you'd think if drunk Rick
was really thinking about Noob Noob he'd
have made sure the platform required
Noob Noob every single puzzle Rick set
up was accompanied by a video and every
single one of these recordings took
place in his garage and while he may not
have had every game planned he clearly
had the last game planned because he had
already cut out the rainbow background
for the last video message but that last
one was recorded somewhere in the cave
they're currently in so why did he wait
to do this one here when he did all the
other videos in his garage you were
always the Romantic which is why you
can't leave
either so Supernova is a full-blown
psychopath now just like that was there
any sign of this over her years of
service this is a sin for the
vindicator's HR department if nothing
else I'm going to enjoy this and let's
give a huge thanks to Rick sanest
wouldn't all the people up here have
seen Supernova doing all the evil she
did including killing million ants while
they took the ride on the elevator you
mean nobody was looking down during that
whole thing and what about the
superheroes nobody looked up and saw
tons of people up there having a party
and for booking one of the hottest
talents out there logic I mean there's
logic problems and then there's logic
problems apparently this episode has
both does Jerry not grow mustache
stubble also wearing tidy off whities
the show's hitting the Sad Sack Jerry
punching bag hard in this opening even
insinuating he flosses while on the
toilet but in what world does someone
with Jerry's personality traits even
floss at all though I couldn't give a sh
about washing my unies in the sink but
got to take care of my teeth tweeners
Rick and Jerry episode breaking the
fourth wall to advertise your episode
shortcomings oversaturating the plumbus
market what did you think it was an
execution jeez you really do need a win
is it really that farfetched though the
truth is the Rick we've been shown in
this show is probably more likely to
execute Jerry or manufacture a new one
entirely rather than waste his time
trying to give him a win huh this seems
kind of fancy Jerry for all you know
this is the equivalent of an alien truck
stop you have no frame of reference Rick
would be a master convincer at TV SS the
Resort's covered in an immortality field
you can't die here that's the gimmick I
have questions and thoughts of Plenty
about the functionality practicality and
sustainability of an immortality field
far too many to contain in the
parameters of this one sin so I'm going
to sprinkle them in whenever I feel
there's a lull in the cnal but first off
both Rick and his buddy seem to be in
pain when they're harpooned and glassed
immortality should really not be so
appealing when you can still feel the
pain of death Rich a-holes are rich
a-holes they all PID top dollar to come
here and enjoy a consequence-free
vacation stealing your idea from
Westworld the book or the old movie but
not the new show which came out later so
then then we'd send that for stealing
from this this job's complicated mom do
you think I'm hot this entire B plot is
dangerously skippable so I'll use it
instead to untable my immortality field
doctoral thesis next up is the fact that
this isn't technically an immortality
field it's a resurrection and
regeneration field an immortality field
would prevent death from occurring in
the first place and allow you to survive
your injuries regardless of severity
which would make this aing horror Escape
of a resort where you never die but have
to continuously feel the pain of injury
or mishap that befalls you is that a
hoof collage it's perfectly legal if
that's what you're wondering nope I was
just wondering why you're leaving your
wine glass directly under the
disembodied hoov sculpture do you want
hoof and mouth disease because this may
or may not be how you get hoof and mouth
disease or could it be her massive
stripper in my limited amount of
research I can confirm there is no
specific shape or size of tit required
to be a stripper yeah of course he likes
it look at him got two
heads and three trunks that's my cranial
triper boscus between the first whirly
and the third derly the ride dips just
outside the immortality field well
that's just terrible theme park design I
don't want to judge an alien race by its
appearance but I do want to know more
about the genetic quirks of this species
for example why does this individual
have nipples when the others do not and
why do they have one bubblegum stock and
yet our bigger friend here has two and
why are they bumpy when the smaller
chaps are perfectly smooth you can't
give me another new alien race without
the proper information to fill out my
Rick and mor decks if she's this big and
the Machine still running how is she a
alive and B not immediately popping
Morty like a tomato sauce balloon the
second he tries to squeeze through there
there are some major issues between you
and Beth that have been there since you
guys met this is what apparently tips
Jerry over the edge into patricide
in-law this an insightful statement
that's likely based on truth as opposed
to one of the many careless or hateful
things that Rick has done what's worse
is that the show never has a problem
making Rick out to be the so why
not use this as an opportunity to show
him really tormenting Jerry and Jerry
finally breaking what else could reverse
possibly mean In fairness to Beth this
is a terrible setting description the
setting should have clearly been called
inside out which still would be
incorrect considering basically all that
happens is the skin inverts but somehow
leaves the eyes and mouth intact man
this is going to be awesome Rick doesn't
find it at all suspicious that despite
the huge line of people waiting behind
him this card is allowed to leave
completely empty other than the two
clearly assassin looking assassins in
the back that are inexplicably being
allowed to stay on despite having
already partaken in the coaster also how
did the assass know that this cart was
the cart that Rick and Jerry were going
to be on and how could they guarantee
that Rick and Jerry were going to be at
the front of the
line did Jerry just lift up the lap bar
mid ride that should not be possible I
know this is an animated show but I've
had literal nightmares about this exact
scenario and I need to know that this
should not be possible the Assassin
inexplicably Waits until Rick and Jerry
have almost re-entered the resurrection
and restoration field I don't even think
they have a line of sight now instead of
activating a bomb I just assume this
button was some sort of quick release
mechanism for Rick's lab code and what's
concerning about this this is I didn't
even question how ineffective and
ridiculous that would be my brain just
said yeah that tracks and I am not okay
with how this show is reshaping my logic
Center look I've never managed to resort
with the resurrection and restoration
field but if I did I don't think I'd put
the power source to said field where it
was so open to being damaged I mean look
at all this rock why not bury that way
underground Rick and Jerry survive this
and you might think that's silly but the
whole episode is about a place with a
resurrection and restoration field and
when you're going to have your character
survive a direct collision with a
mountain and a rocketing wheel of death
your supposed immortality field becomes
about as important as the lowest button
on a button-down shirt I mean it's there
for a purpose but does it really change
much who do you think had more taken
from them when you shot 20 cc's of
liquid dream killer into my
daughtering love the writers of this
show she was Rick's daughter Jerry she
had
options the monster stopped eating him
for a second to pile on and say oof yeah
yeah two sin removals in a row because
the r random Forest monster said oof I
mean balls hilarious I get it but he
could just duck down in the pouch a bit
right also the creature that evolved to
carry its young within punching distance
of its goads would like a quick
conversation with Darwin please kissing
Rick's ass isn't going to help keep him
around mom but it will help you lose
everyone else chapter 47 on my thesis
challenging the RNR Resort a title that
the owners really dropped the ball on by
not using now that I think about it is
wondering if laws regarding murder and
assault don't fly here I mean you're
still going through the mental and
physical trauma of being attacked and
assaulted so are there just no
repercussions because there's no lasting
physical damage like I lost summer hey
you haven't lost her yet no I definitely
did she's gone there is not a chance
summer would have been able to sneak
away she's too big to miss would shake
the ground when she walked and would be
raining garage debris it's a synaptic
dampener that blocks violent tendencies
and controversial thought I want cookies
and a 90-minute cut of Avatar this show
Cuts so deep I fing love it but
unfortunately I'm dangerously close to
maxing out my sin removals for the
season so I'll just have to send the
Cookie Monster shade instead wait I know
where she is of course you do how else
would we wrap up two story lines in the
next 5 minutes Ethan and summer were
supposed to go camping and then he
dumped summer the next book in my RN our
field series will be dedicated to
organized crime why isn't this Resort
being overrun with space mobsters and
criminals that can either use it as a
place to torture their enemies or as a
hideout where they can't be hurt by the
authorities using it as a theme park is
wildly undervaluing its potential live
out the rest of your days in denial of
your vagina fantasies it was a one- time
thought that everyone has I mean other
than the people that already have a
vagina right Rick and Morty episode
steals the best scene from everything
everywhere all at once and the dumbest
scene from Doctor Strange 2 5 years
before either of them came out and don't
act like that is impossible in a show
like this oh God I feel like our souls
were United and we're all one with
eternity still a better explanation than
anything I've heard defending the ending
of
interstellar and the final series of
volumes will be spent positing that the
RNR Resort should be swamped by the
entire damn Universe this is a place
where you not only can't be permanently
killed but it reverses the thing that
killed you so anyone with a spaceship
and a terminal illness can come here die
and be cured of anything that was
killing them this Resort should be the
seed of power for the entire damn
Multiverse I know giant Inside Out kaigu
virgins of Summer and Beth are in this
scene but the real monster here is Morty
who uses his bare thumb to pat down this
melted marshmallow directly touching the
marshmelo is a Sure Fire way to ruin any
shot you have at not sticking directly
to everything you come in contact with
for the rest of the evening show takes
21 minutes and 13 seconds to actually
Rick and Morty I heard you broke up with
Brad who are you going to date now that
you can date anyone why is this an
immediate question asked someone that
just broke up I understand that they're
keenly curious about body stuff is
evidenced in the following line penis in
the foreskin kind of love so yeah go
figure out what you enjoy I guess but
can we we just let people take a longer
than 12 second break between the end of
one relationship and questions about the
next you can be single is what I'm
saying this Highly Questionable school
art that is inspiring a love of
microscopes trophies open Flames hookah
and magnetic floating chalises I'm
confused about my career path by simply
glancing at it let's go in and out 20
minutes Adventure title of my over
ambitious sex tape in this shot the
fleet isn't concentrating their
Firepower on one location but when we
zoom in the Firepower seems to be aimed
at this vola's Mass don't get me wrong
one should always concentrate on the v's
Mass but be consistent why is their skin
flapping around as the wind is pushing
it back from the ship's trajectory I get
the chief fores do crazy things to your
face but for this amount of gum flaid
surely they'd have to be taking some
bizarre route out of here and not the
straight line that we see in this
shot I can't do this anymore audio from
the TV sends writers room after sending
Game of Thrones final season somehow
makes it into the episode
this was insane that was pure luck I was
not in control of that situation at all
followed by Jeremy and Chris's reaction
to the birth of Cinema Sins also making
its way into a Rick and Morty episode
not closing all of your eyes when
receiving a massage you were right best
day spa in the Galaxy enjoying whatever
this is with your grandfather these
things are just doing what they do in
the wild they love swallowing stressed
out creatures for 20 minutes and then
puking them up I think cats feel this
way about birds like it's their
responsibility to end their stressful
birdy lives consume them and then vomit
them on my pillow at 3:00 a.m. as if it
does anyone a favor so this sin is for
the unexpected visual memory barrage of
my long gone otan obsessed cat Oliver
Oliver my whole body's like a baby's ass
diapered and rashy that makes no sense
try swallowing the giant ball of snot
that's dangling around in the back of
your throat it's disgusting says the man
who for 90% of his day has more bodily
fluids on his face than Jaba the Huts
gynecologist it's nice of you to let me
off the hook it's still unacceptable
behavior and I do regret it Rick is
being extra nice because he's had all of
his toxins removed but that would seem
to overlook that some of the most toxic
people you will ever meet will carry
themselves with a kind word and a smile
yeah take that you came here for sex
tape jokes and left with life fact
suckers I'm real proud to be your
grandpa Morty I guess this sin is on me
for enjoying this wholesome moment while
also realizing that the toxic elements
of Rick and Morty are ripped from their
Consciousness do do I prefer this show
am I a a sap trained by television to
feel better when everyone gets along
like puppets well you were flapping your
parasitic turd holster not specifying
what the turd holster is precisely so
I'm now unsure how to use it in
situations requiring insult slinging I
discovered the toxic equivalent of
electricity Morty I love the idea that
there's a toxic version of electricity
even if it doesn't make any sense I mean
with lightning just deliberately pick
out the nicest people to strike would a
power surge wait until you've nearly
finished a big project to short out your
computer and then do exactly the same
thing to your brand new computer just
the fck with you wait toxic electricity
may already be a thing now who can tell
me the common denominator of these two
fractions you don't know or you're all
just bored false dichotomies with the
kids clothing variety as your only clue
you will never discover the mystery of
the current weather pattern in the
neighborhood if we're all bored over
here wouldn't the common denominator be
you we learned that it's only the
character traits the individual believes
are toxic that have been removed but I
still struggle to believe that Morty
doesn't think being a back talking
smartass to his teacher doesn't fall
into the realm of toxicity I do however
know that I have a pretty bad case of
haven't taken you to denitis this works
oh sh the item on the wall wasn't art at
all it was an actual trophy case well in
that case I will remove a sin cuz I
called it art and then add a sin back
because it looks like the rest of the
trophy Cas is further down the hallway
but we saw much more of it from a
different angle earlier I think I know
what to do Morty holy sh what was that
foam made out of that it made it so easy
for Morty to snap it in half
oh I'll have a water but but you already
have wine so wouldn't the drink order
have already been taken or is that the
previous table's wine but why is there
wine at The Empty Tables what is this
restaurant look this is Rick and Morty
land so I'm going to gloss over the fact
that these two 14-year-olds are having a
first date at this fancy restaurant
instead of a arcade or something but I
refuse to believe that this teenager
would leave the house with little to no
battery on their phone that is a step
too far people hey Rick are you familiar
with Ben Wa technology the
behind Rick and Morty continue to make
me drop the ball when it comes to
resisting the urge to fall into the
annals of the internet just for the sake
of making sure I understand the whole
joke they're making they're all the bad
parts of us which by the way includes
our dishonesty but dishonesty can have
positive uses though an abundance of
honesty can lead to feeling like you
have to fill in the comment sections of
the internet with all the reasons you
hate something instead of letting people
enjoy the things they love you know just
as a totally random example no is it
wrong if I think this is kind of hot
watching an elder person force a younger
person to toxify themselves in a garage
experiment has Rick and Morty asked us
to contemplate morals a bit too far this
time probably did I ask for this huh did
I assessing threat to groin what uses a
defensive groin laser if it only deploys
after multiple hits to the vegetables
have been
received look either this door frame is
made of cardboard or Rick's body is made
of titanium and yes in this world either
could be true but if I stopped sing
stuff because it could be true these
Ricket Mor videos would be about 5
Seconds long carpet so we could Tears by
hand or hands so strong they tear carpet
either way it's a sin taping the horse
head to the exterior of the frame rather
than opening up the frame to subtly
attach it to the photo directly it's
pretty disgusting so you'll have to
believe me when I say they forgot to put
Rick's dismembered and eviscerated body
in this panel the monster tripping a
spine tube thing out of the center of
the floor with no Rick and then suddenly
there's a
rick
the randim of fruit on the bottom of the
table survives this what did the booger
version of you mean when he said he was
going to make the whole world toxic oh
I'm sure he just left that as a clue so
Rick would know where to find him once
he figures out how to recombine them
both into one being villains are super
helpful like that it must be by the
individual's own definition of toxicity
the best thing about this episode is
that it doesn't just assume that all is
well once the things that you believe
are toxic about you have been removed we
can all be toxic in ways that we're
totally unaware of and it all comes down
to perspective damn you Rick and Morty
for once again having more
self-awareness and insight than any
cartoon about a belching scientist has
any right to be this moon tower Morty is
the perfect heighten metallic
composition for the amplification of
beaming of toxic energies convenient
Tower fitting the exact requirements of
the villain's plan is very
convenient kids this stock is a
beautiful redhe head recently single not
looking a date but ready to fall in love
creators of the show into the extra
effort of animating this apple in case
this Jordan Bell Mor impression didn't
quite hit all the notes on its
own is this
organic yes proclaiming the organic of
your food is pointless but it isn't
Morty chopping this carrot while neither
moving the knife onto the carrot or the
carrot into the knife levels of
pointless hey did you ever want to hold
a terryfold thinking that playing a
Whimsical song will make me hang around
for the entirety of the CR wait what the
hell is a Terry fold why does it make me
think of dinosaurs is this like a sexy
Dinosaurs Song how did dinosaurs have
sex I suppose carefully is the obvious
answer wait is that the end of the
credits damn it all right Morty you
ready for our adventure to the lost city
of Atlantis Rick and Morty not being
complete to each other is a
pretty clear indicator that we won't be
going to Atlantis and I get that's the
point of the episode but it doesn't make
me any less upset that the episode does
not contain an adventure to the lost
city of Atlantis also we're three
seasons in and still no one's picked up
this fing sock we're going from reality
to reality asking Ricks to contribute
charity canvasing canvasing hey the
Brits and the Aussies went with charity
muggers and then a shortened version of
that so now there's been bad word
choices on three continents you're
pitching the policeman's ball to a black
teenager here the smartest man in the
universe being aware of the complex and
difficult relationship racial and ethnic
minorities have with the police but
choosing to use the topic as father for
his jokes as opposed to actually doing
something about it you don't have to be
a dick I think you know that's not true
when Rick stopped being polite and start
getting real we wouldn't dare play the
music but the sin as always is Joe Walsh
eating sardines while driving or pretty
much ever also drinking and driving
Citadel morning news news about The
Citadel in the morning pretty
self-explanatory when you overe explain
things to the different versions of
yourself as if you're the and
before you say what about the mores you
and I both know they'll never stop
playing with their remote long enough to
watch the news 60 iterations off the
central finite curve there's a Rick that
works more with wood than polarity
plating the subtitles on my version say
this narrator Sam Elliott when it's it's
actually Jeff B Davis doing an
impression of Sam Elliott now whether
that's a mistake or a joke I'm giving it
a sin for making me take the time to
figure it out but also Jeff P Davis
absolutely Nails this Sam Elliot
impression and the chemical that makes
his brain secrete goes into every simple
Rick simple Wafers wafer cookie brain
secretion wafer cookies are my least
favorite secretion wafer cookies come
home to The Impossible flavor of your
own completion tagline of my sex tape
the arrow on that this guy needs a
plumbus sign is not making it clear as
to exact who needs the plumbus I love
being your new FY kids having an entire
Factory that only makes wafer cookies
sure a factory could put out just one
product but fing wafer cookies how is
there a big enough market for those k83
affectionately known as cool Rick k83
doesn't pronounce his name cool herck
just four normal Mor normal put it in
your blog shop owner Morty is suddenly
clever enough to make this comeback when
a moment ago he wasn't clever enough to
give Training Day Rick and Morty any
information about the robbery Beyonce
saying they looked like Morty the Morty
Town Locos making your gang name sound
Hispanic by adding the word Locos to it
is like the social science equivalent of
adding the word Quantum to things to
make them more sciency more lasers
agreed how would you solve the citadel's
financial crisis for a show us
consistently outside the boxes this one
it's surprising they went with a
boilerplate financial crisis as a
problem facing the Citadel I mean at
least give us a financial Time Crisis
can we fact check this please juggling
would have been enough but this one's
for attempting to fact check a juggling
metaphor when they dismissed class
everyone but these four just walked out
of the room and presumably out of the
building using the front door so why
couldn't these four do the same I see it
in our factories where Ricks work for a
fraction of their boss's salary even
though they're identical and have the
same IQ if they all have the same IQ
then why aren't there robot servants
doing all the work and thousands of
Ricks just sitting around drinking
margaritas shies what else would I send
here everything else about the scene is
perfectly normal this screen in the back
shows all the Ricks running for office
and their percentage in the HS which
equals 100 but where's the Morty date in
his percentage even if he has 0% at this
point he should still be on this screen
since he was taking part in the debate I
believe the sin here is recrimination
you going to lick my balls or what
grandson you keep me peeling squab
squabs and slipping nib nibs I'll lick
whatever ain't nailed down well there's
just a lot of here I'm just going to
ignore for my own sanity and move
straight to sending Rick for lick
discrimination against things that are
nailed down bandaging your wound on the
outside of your
clothes hey y'all get the hell away from
my damn Mega fruit Mega fruit seeds
didn't go up a butt in this episode I
bet the wishing portal leads to a
reality where there where all where it's
a bunch of French toast with boobies
does the french toast have boobies or
are the boobies on the side I need to
know slick why do you have to be so
dramatic episode has a slick Morty but
no Slick Rick I thought I was
left-handed Morty then you should use
your left hand to eat more vegetables
lizard Morty would be TV sins Morty it
well TV SS associating food with a hard
Rick is not a health code violation in
this this scene one dance for 10 two for
25 for a moment I was worried about
shaming autosexuality here but the
longer I spend with this scene the more
certain I become that this is something
else entirely I want to be a regular kid
I want to go to school and throw balls
around and masturbate she wants me to
believe those last two aren't wi in the
same we got your portal gun after he
drops the shield they make a little baby
portal to give him the gun so while he
is distracted and the shield was still
down couldn't they have opened multiple
portals in the flavor core and
surrounded him a portal to the blender
Dimension the on line pitch responsible
for Event Horizon the factory made
cookies flavored them with lies Splenda
you have to give up something really
important for me that's my panini maker
I wish for a million sandwiches and yes
I see the irony not requesting these
sandwiches at a specific interval so
they don't arrive all at once and spoil
I wish anything about this life would
change the show does the wildest most
nonsensical and somehow swings
it back around to make you feel
something cliche now is the time for
Action sure launching the bodies out
into space gives us an idea of the
devastation evil more to can inflict but
it makes little sense in terms of
disposal especially when you've already
shown us the giant garbage portal that
seems much more suited to the job still
not curious about what might have
happened at that crazy Citadel place not
at all Morty that place will never have
any bearing over our lives ever again
writers let the audience know that
nothing in the show is sacred and
they'll do whatever they please whenever
they want and that includes bringing the
Citadel back probably somewhere around
the 500th season
oh jeez Rick oh jeez jeez oh jeez oh man
oh jeez hey oh jeez man I hear that oh
jeez but oh jeez oh jeez man oh jeez
come on oh jeez oh jeez Rick oh man oh
jeez Rick and Morty run away from the
Edward without Scissor Hands towards the
stairs but then somehow wind up on these
set of stairs instead of the ones on the
original trajectory this could be
possible of course but the show doesn't
animate them jumping or rocketing over
there which would have been a lot of fun
to see also has this Alien Planet just
randomly heard of mcer or do they just
have their own mcer I'm going to need to
walk up a few more impossible staircases
to figure this one out well that's what
you get for building your eer Palace
over a space Vortex Morty let's watch
some interdimensional cable remember how
we used to do that I do and if you want
to remember I will show you these two
examples of videos you could watch that
do not benefit me in any way I'm just
looking out for you I can't go on I
can't go on like this with the true
tortoise in my head I was just
thinking this the last time I let a tor
on my head wait this Morty is my Archive
of all the experiences you've begged me
to remove from your life lest you go
insane I call them Morty mind blowers
seems like an impressive amount when you
see them all but how many of them are
just simply about Morty forgetting the
mindblowers room exists because Rick
would have to erase that memory every
time as well right also Morty's memory
manipulation would be more accurate but
Rick is taking the marketing approach
here to keep this intriguing like
calling Botox a rejuvenating enhancement
rather rather than paralyzing injection
Jabs or a piece of house a unique canvas
ready for Creative Solutions this
labeling system that appears to depend
on the stickiness of the tape certainly
Rick has the ability to do better than
this okay so Rick doesn't give a sh but
why then label it all never seen signs
of a regular dude as you describe him
hanging out up there but Rick does have
the technology to take the memory from
Morty at this point so why not looking
at Morty's memory and see what he did to
confirm the person on the moon or tease
Morty endlessly for the rest of his life
but brown gravy on mashed potatoes or
really just putting brown gravy on
anything Morty's at least 11 or 12 right
why are they still learning simple math
like 18+ 10 at his age Morty took a
picture in printable Clarity at night
wait Morty printed pictures for proof
this is insane who prints pictures oh my
god what have I done how did this memory
not convince Morty that he'd actually
seen a man on the moon his memory is
clear at the beginning and this is
obviously a man and not a smudge also
this is the same flag on the moon is in
the yard there is no other conclusion to
draw from this memory except Morty was
correct about the man on the moon they
don't all have titles though it's not a
Simpsons Halloween Special more like a
clip show made of Clips you never saw
these aren't clips that Morty never saw
these are clips that Morty can't
remember but he definitely saw them at
some point or they wouldn't exist The
Collector comes to peek into their
habitat and spots Rick disassembling a
television wouldn't this be somewhat
alarming why would the collector allow
the specimens to take apart their
environment oh the schematic specify
second smaller pilot I mean they really
specify smaller they have to be exactly
5'3 but why Morty normally just sits in
normal siiz seats what would his height
have to do with anything in regards to
the schematics and Rick's making it
pretty obvious these idiots are being
set up to be stuck in an alien human Zoo
how come I was able to see those other
people's memories I wouldn't have been
around for that Morty would be new
Tropic at TV SS this very confusing
piece of paper that came from an alien
but is written in English now maybe the
paper is designed to translate to be
legible to whoever reads it but then why
wouldn't it be written properly with the
name capitalized in a period after
Warrior having two glasses of whatever
this is while also having a glass of
whatever this is is that orange juice oh
great now I'm thinking about OJ with
Mexican food and you can take that
flavor combo Straight to Hell Rick and
Morty I'm going to go take a quick sh so
Rick goes to the bathroom and walks away
down the hallway I thought that was odd
because I assumed the bathroom doors
were here then the shot cuts to floop
and over his shoulder the sign says the
bathrooms are the opposite direction
from where Rick went however on the wide
shot the arrow is pointed in the other
direction and we're left with nothing
but assumptions about where Rick
actually went to take a sh and honestly
this is probably the most haunting part
of the episode all right so you want to
do this here or outside I'm not proovy
to all the Dono establishment rules but
I'm going to go out on a limb and assume
they don't approve of alien murder in
their restaurant during normal operation
hours in the meantime enjoy a grab bag
of Mind blowers I call poop AIDS copy
and by grab bag he means two two scenes
does not a grab bag make you simply have
to choose summer summer okay go with me
here sure Beth had that answer at the
ready far too quickly but really the
blame is on this alien for not creating
a soundproof torture bubble Grand Rick
there must be some scientific way to
save him the visuals are saying wind the
audio is saying wind but the lack of
wind in anyone's hair other than Morty
is saying continuity issue well I guess
it's nice to know the whole family sucks
it took you almost three seasons to
realize that Rick opens the door panel
by hitting it with his fist but doesn't
he know that shooting door panels is the
official way to make s doors open for
the fun of the show these two have just
wiped almost all of their memories but
all indication is that the Mind wiper
would only wipe one specific memory and
not an identity see those two fleshy
sacks under his chin Morty grab them not
specifying which of these six fleshy
sacks you're talking about we're
Partners I guess and we fight aliens
like men and black Morty can't remember
who he is but he conveniently remembers
the movie men and black where one of the
main plot lines was about a device that
could wipe out people's memories
scooping up a potentially compromised
memory tube from the broken pile on the
floor rather than selecting one of the
many pristine tubes from the nearby
shelves leaving your Interstellar
laboratory garage door wide
open this audible beep would give Rick
all the indicators he needs to know that
the machine is being accessed by Morty
there's no way he wouldn't hear it and
try to stop him from ruining whatever
Morty is inevitably about to ruin there
I'm done just stay out of trouble
believing this would work what's the
point of going on if most of everything
that happens just ends up sitting in
here my thoughts on cloud storage some
make their way into this episode you
guys doing Morty's mind blowers asks the
ice pop eating sister who conveniently
wanders into the garage and enters the
bunker only seconds before her family
ends the episode with a bang which is
almost as convenient as some are also
wearing a key necklace needed to access
the panel that will save Rick and Morty
I'm saying this is too convenient and
Rick and Morty should be
dead there is no way she consumed each
of the steps on that card that quickly
and you should never do step number one
without reading all the remaining steps
to ensure there's no fery regarding step
number one in the following steps
especially when step one requires you to
shoot people also making me say steps
too many times no wonder you're
constantly fighting with each other and
behind schedule that's a funny way of
saying I should have just kept your
memories wiped because you're both
stop True Crime bragging
comment section of my favorite murder
episode somehow makes its way into the
show bch my generation gets traumatized
for breakfast kids was it my best work I
don't know does it deserve to be on
creatively instead of acknowledging how
childhood memories can be inaccurate
Rick gets all defense as if Beth just
dropped in everything wrong with fry
land video this calendar with only four
days in the week you know it collapsed a
Quantum Tesseract adding the word
Quantum to no wait adding the word
Tesseract to no that's not it either
okay got it combining two sciency words
and adding a random verb to create a
phrase that sounds like Rick did
something impressive cliche drawing a
portal on a mobile door based on the
trees alone it's pretty obvious that
Rick ripped off Dr Seuss and no one gets
away with that without a sin in dad
you're right I'm a terrible dad the
Terrible dad then goes on to throw
himself from the cliff that won't kill
him rather than pushing his unsuspecting
daughter to her non death and that would
have really sealed the terrible dad
title into place for eternity a dad
makes a toilet look like R2-D2 and it
breaks the front page of Reddit
insinuating that Rick gives a Star Wars
siiz about the front page of Reddit no
no seriously this hurts really bad in
that case you'd think he wouldn't wait
until being taken to the nest to take
out his gun and shoot threat no people
saw these two people floating in people
siiz Bubbles and sto to take a picture
and or follow for the views of the
people they would Shirley Garner on
social media your place looks way less
like a crack house show doesn't clarify
if this assessment is based on firsthand
experience at a crack house or summer
making assumptions based on TV or some
sh it's actually clean like a cocaine
House show doesn't clarify if this
assessment is based on firsthand
experience at a cocaine house or Morty
making assumptions based on TV or some
sh I'm simply centered
activated writers make summer suddenly
clumsy as if Jerry isn't annoying enough
to show off his powers without
provocation who wants a smoothie first
off no one said yes and second anyone
that does want a smoothie would also
like you to put a little more effort
into the recipe and not just put every
piece of rinded fruit you have into a
blender also summer and Morty both just
stand there and watch Jerry not putting
the top back on the blender without
screaming running or voicing disapproval
in any way whatsoever I'm sure you
noticed what she has three of but guess
what she has two of is a thing that
Jerry just said to his children are you
seeing Tommy survived here by having sex
with fry creatures creating fry human
hybrid Offspring and then consuming
their protein sustaining himself with an
endless ccle of cannibalistic incest
writers suddenly realize their stor is a
hair too long and complicated for the
show's 20-some minute run time so they
hand fist the episode with a bunch of
quick witted Exposition wrapped in a
plot reveal so disgusting we feel the
need to go wash our hands during the
commercial break dad do you understand
how serious crout tabul on Soul bonding
is nope and considering it doesn't come
up for the remainder of the episode it's
probably not that big of a deal at all
she's got a hot bod like chitara in
Thundercats if the ThunderCats exist in
this cartoon Universe would they be
considered cartoons or by the standards
of their reality would they be
considered live action and if a cartoon
Universe has its own version of cartoons
wouldn't those cartoons have to be
one-dimensional and what would that even
look like these are the kind of answers
I watch Rick and Morty for and I'm not
getting them after all the time and
energy I spent teaching you two about
race you ended up racist the sin is the
writers thinking Jerry would think that
he could get away with pretending to
think that he could have possibly taught
anyone anything I always find the
theater is the best way to clarify
things Somewhere in Time there's a fifth
grade version of me watching a
performance The Crucible that would very
much disagree do you want to see the
Honey Swamp the same Rick that made the
ground bouncy and the water breathable
managed to overlook the fact that a
swamp filled with honey is many orders
of magnitude more dangerous than a
regular swamp I am hungry and all I
could do to pass the time is hump my
dog's inner monologue somehow makes its
way into the episode leave him
alone get around gang dinner time
moments after Tommy has applied his seed
this animal births a new fry care
character and unfortunately the rules of
this episode place this in in the
category of meals being prepared too
quickly to have been made in accordance
with proper food safety measures all
right that's it I'm out of here no one
untied Rick's hands he just slipped out
of them to escape so why not do this
before watching the theatric retelling
of Tommy's cringeworthy survival plan
but Tommy's still in there ring Muppets
and eating babies is a thing that Beth
said in this episode look at some of the
sh you were asking me to make you as a
kid ray guns do they shoot Rays or are
they named Ray or do they specifically
shoot only people named Ray hey these
are legitimate questions for a show
that's willing to introduce a sentient
switchblade a lightning gun that's just
a fancy taser a taser shaped like a
ladybug that's just a fancy lightning
gun a pink sensient switchblade does it
being pink make it worse then why didn't
you specify the colors of the other
objects hm Rick and why hasn't Rick
fixed his boo boos has it occurred to
you that I asked you to make those
things because I wanted you to spend
time with me has it occurred to you that
your request for these items resulted in
a a father that actually made them
thereby encouraging your behavior take
that to your next counseling session I I
I think you have to stab them through
the harder something says the guy
stabbing the creature through the head
so if the alien heart is the head then
Morty should share that specific
information with his family to avoid
confusion people should eat people they
should not and that's why one plus
two makes a bunch of a
bunch at most this is a clouder and you
know it look I'm not an evil person I'm
just not very imaginative but doesn't
take imagination to create the lie that
your children were responsible for the
breakup I know Jerry makes no sense but
the writing of Jerry not making sense
should make sense make sense this
calendar with only 5 days in the week we
wouldn't dare play the music in the
background of this touching
fatherdaughter working moment mostly
because it's song about taking a Shir
and the show is trying to make us think
it's a metaphor for fatherhood do they
have this t-shirt just laying around or
did they spend time making this because
it's not easy writing on t-shirts it
takes a lot of time to get the lettering
right so this feels a bit like they
wasted time on this this instead of
rushing to stop the execution having
more fridge pictures of a child that you
do not prefer none of the vers chose
this moment of distraction to attack the
warrior woman who slaughtered their kin
yesterday you just got handed at
exmachina cliche we're home leaving the
front door wide the open araldo isn't
closed in the dimension where they
didn't invent daylight savings what
would we do without you find a pizza
place that doesn't close before dinner
time or at least not before the sun goes
down by the way that wasn't time travel
there just a couple pizzas on the
counter I grabbed them Rick has to break
the fourth wall to explain something so
the internet doesn't explode with fan
theories about what the insipid detail
of Rick not waiting for pizza means in
regard to what is and isn't possible yo
Jerry it's the Big R uh I killed that
alien that was coming after you looking
out for you buddy show thinks we would
momentarily believe that Rick did
something nice for Jerry and not see the
your exgirlfriend joke coming from a
mile away you can go ahead and keep that
answering machine nobody really uses
those anymore except for exposition on
TV shows anyways show cleverly writes
its way out of an Antiquated joke by
expositing its own Exposition but still
Exposition this OSHA violation of an
elevator that starts moving before the
doors close also discount Daniel de
Lewis if they can teleport why did we
take I just work here Steve same as you
look sometimes the characters in Rick
and Morty practically write these videos
for me which actually makes my job
harder because I have to get extra
nitpicky to justify my existence like
pointing out that this mail slot was not
in the establishing shot of the house
that we saw just a few seconds ago and
nobody likes it when I have to do that
Rick do you need a drink in here yes not
to disregard the obvious alcoholism on
display here but the martini glass is
the most spillable adult beverage
container ever conceived there's been no
attempt at displaying any sort of
technology that would allow Rick to fall
vertically through a portal without
spilling his drink some kind of alien
gooa has infested the Kennedy sex
tunnels the president concludes that it
must be alien gooa without testing for
clidia first yeah that sounds fun let's
set some boundaries with a spoiled
control freak that thinks he runs the
world in orders Dr drone strikes to cope
with his insecurity or some people call
it being a parent okay you're not going
to have fun if you analyze everything
Morty underestimates how much I enjoy my
job as far as he knows we're still on
the tunnels when should we reveal we can
see them show expects me to believe that
Rick wouldn't immediately know that
there was a satellite spying on them or
that he wouldn't have some sort of
countermeasure in place that would blow
it up turn it into pudding or evolve it
into an AI capable of explaining that
building a spy satellite and getting it
into orbit is a huge waste of money when
everyone has a cell phone in their
pocket I mean what doesn't look bad
through an legal spy satellite and ice
cream and yes yes yes yes you save the
world now and then and America returns
that favor by not holding the two of you
accountable to its laws any of them any
of the laws okay I can see why turning a
blind ey to some laws would be necessary
when dealing with giant heads that
kidnap the planet and other assorted
nuisances but all laws you're telling me
they could go to Arizona purchase a
donkey and let it sleep in a bathtub
with no consequences the production team
makes a banger of a song for a 5-second
joke but has the audacity to not make
the bang hanger of an album we all pause
the episode to search for just promise
if the results are too strong you'll use
protection by results you mean Summer's
choice right right how do you like that
Morty the absence of torches here makes
me question why this scene does not
contain a Rick and Morty getting blown
up by aing creeper that operated out of
nowhere causing them to lose over 1,000
levels of XP farming and that damn neite
sword that they were saving for just the
right occasion followed of course by
having to work their way back from who
the knows where to assess the damage and
pray to the Ender Dragon that their
carefully plotted cave system has not
been flooded or filled with lava or you
know something less specific South Park
did it four years ago Morty they're fast
or we're slow me every time I carefully
craft my own version of a meme that I
saw while eating breakfast only to
discovered has somehow become a thing
enjoyed being a thing and is now no
longer a thing before my coffee is hit
room temperature also South Park did
that episode about the simpsons's
already doing all the things and how it
doesn't matter so I don't really have an
excuse for not making the meme and the
writers don't have have an excuse for
not giving us a Minecraft episode The
Only Way using this portal makes sense
is if it's a quicker option than the
president just flying there this means
the portal would have to already be
there or at least be closer than the
president is but why why would it be
stationed in Brazil do they have one of
these things in every country aren't
they super expensive and why am I
surprised that the government has the
ability to waste my money I made
sanchezium up dumb asses don't believe
everything you read on Wikipedia well sh
Excuse me while I go and revieww several
100 of our videos for
reasons I don't doubt a bar like this
exists somewhere in the Multiverse but
wouldn't it make more sense for the
Footwear on the torosaurus sex to go all
the way up to the heel inverted
secondary knee whatever it is this
current setup does not look twerkable
what does what what what what what does
this mean this means nothing Jesus pull
forward and
park even with all the Sci-Fi hij Jinks
in this episode somehow the show finds a
way to make one of the funniest moments
out of a simple frustration caused by
miscommunication thank you to everyone
involved and especially Keith David for
bringing this hilarious character to
life Israel and Palestine have announced
a permanent ceasefire what they signed
something called the pretty obvious if
you think about it Accord Rick proving
he could do more to help Mankind in an
afternoon than anyone else could do in
10 lifetimes but he'd rather dick around
in his garage cliche an anonymous
American Diplomat took them to a Star
Wars Cantina where they smoked
prospective enhancing alien pheromones
through a laser hookah I see no laser I
demand a laser hookah oh and peace in
the Middle East that too you're approval
rating just hit 100% it is literally not
figuratively literally impossible for a
president to get 100% approval rating
everyone could be rich healthy and never
exposed to war and some would
still say they have the right to be
homeless unhealthy and at risk of high
velocity lead poisoning I was knocking
out a deterrent everyone wants to be
knocked out nobody wants to be dead Zack
Snyder explaining why his version of
Batman kills bad guys guys instead of
subduing them somehow makes its way into
the episode Doctor Who in this
motherucker proclamations of being the
doctor do not make you the doctor and
among other things Rick is approaching
the situation much more like a doll I'd
love to understand how I can help you I
can't be in charge of that Jerry my mind
my ideas are all part of the variable
the only constant is you this plan only
works if Beth is correct in thinking
that there's some ineffable quality
inside all of us that no clone no matter
how perfect could ever fully replicate
and while you all sit there insisting
you would definitely know the difference
if your loved ones were replaced with
clones I'll be chatting to the AI that
built the simulation we live in senior
year I took you on a date Skip and I
just thought it lips don't sweat lips
may not sweat but the face around those
lips does sweat a fact that turned out
to be a deal breaker for my freshman
year episode makes a weird metaphor
about destroying conspiracies
surrounding the Apollo moon landing the
Kennedy assassination in 911 at least I
hope that's what they were going for and
we're hiding from you so you don't kill
her if she's a clone in a place I pick
that you will never find I think Morty
is vastly underestimating Rick's ability
to track I'm sure he has ways of
scanning for Morty's DNA or an army of
drones that Scout the entire planet in
minutes or maybe he could just track the
fing cell phone that Morty's decided to
keep you're a terrorist you're An Enemy
of the State and you kicked me in the
balls 10 minutes ago oh and all those
Secret Service people he killed earlier
but no need to bring that up I suppose
inv visit Troopers Stand Down why are
invisor Troopers with knives preferable
to invis Troopers with lasers I hope I
could be of service if you ever find the
planet to be in danger
friends sounds good to me the president
thinks he's making a deal with a Rick
from Another Universe but what makes him
think that fly fishing Rick would be any
better than regular Rick he could be
just as murdery and insubordinate but
with the added annoyance of being one of
those people with a passion for
something hopefully you didn't just
around and waste your life o we making
us think Mr Poopy butthole is going to
be a fun call back than tricking us into
reflecting on all our poor life
decisions I've spent a lot of time on
the Smith breakfast table and for good
reason but does the Smith family really
strike you as the kind of family that
gets up at the same time to have
breakfast together and prepare this kind
of spread which part of any of these non
Jerry people is the part that's like ooh
can't miss the good old family breakfast
tradition my inherent love for
sentimentality and routine will not be
denied also if you're making a breakfast
that has pancakes toast and what looks
like mashed potatoes with rice sprinkled
on top of it but I'm hoping is grits
then you do not need all these what I'm
graciously going to call hash browns I
trust no one in this room because not a
single one of them is drinking coffee
and this is in caffeine moderation
shaming what's going on here is a
statistical impossibility to those who
rushed out and grabbed the yasica insta
handles all I have to say is that your
commitment to mimicry and parody of this
character has been underwhelming this
sin is on your hands hi I've placed an
autor response chip in my brain so I can
spend time with my family what kind of
lousy autor response chip responds by
declaring it's an autor response chip a
terrible autor response chip that's what
any death crystals from forb boalan
Prime show will never explain what makes
the death crystals from falan Prime
better than any other death crystals and
if you're going to say they only exist
on Falin Prime then we never find out
why Rick who cares about nothing cared
about name dropping this planet dad you
hardly put any syrup on honey stop
raising your father's cholesterol so you
can take a hot funeral selfie but isn't
Summer's logic a bit off here she just
said that the reason funeral selfies are
hot is that grief reddens the cheeks but
who's grieving at Jerry's funeral why
are they called Death crystals do do
they kill you you're thinking of bullets
Morty while bullets are technically
Crystal and solids this punch line
probably should have been reserved for
jokes about death metal death crystals
show you how you're going to die then I
hereby submit they should be called
cause of death crystals also expir Rite
was right there the contrive nature of
these rocks is immediately forgiven
because of how much thought went into
coming up with and animating all the
amazing possible Morty deaths in this
episode people that spend their life
avoiding death are already dead and
what's dead may never die so what are
people that spend their dead lives
living death Quantum entangled see I can
sci-fi up some random too the idea of
using the expir Rite as some sort of
morbidity divining Rod is interesting
and all but no I'm not buying it even if
you did catch a unified glimpse of your
demise every micro movement would
completely change the possible outcome
in a way that would render it no longer
valid and impossible to recover I
thought you were masturbating you took
that in stride you'd rather I address it
it's not so much that I'd rather you did
it's just that it seems pretty in
character for you to do and nothing has
stopped you from doing it before I'm
willing to accept that you're doing this
if you're willing to accept that you
need to stop title of my sex tape it
appears as if the Smiths collaborated
with their next door neighbor on this
fence since it crosses both yards and I
refuse to believe there's any Universe
where Nextdoor neighbors get along well
enough to accomplish this feat operation
Phoenix initiated something something
something cloning call back something
something Rick's pixelated improv the
rest is how I'm guessing this scene was
written but you are down with fascist
dystopias right if you have to ask your
question is obviously more about
dramatic reveals than your commitment to
extremely problematic political
ideologies sitting on the nasty floor of
a school hallway leaning against the
lockers this is your respit I don't have
to be anywhere in the next few minutes
you know where I'm going to plop down
for conversation staff of laka C control
that's where throw that thing in the
garbage stop planning your own death and
talk to whoever you want Rick steals the
exact words I told my younger siblings
about their paper fortune teller oh and
if you don't know what I'm talking about
see also Chatterbox flipper flapper salt
seller whirly bird pacu pacu or cotie
catcher stop doing meta commentary he
says meta
commentary being so worried about
scientific accuracy that you make space
completely silent when you know your
audience would rather hear the Nazi
Morty choking to death get out of here
asking stupid question Mor sound like a
piece of these shrimp Ricks yelling
at Mor because verbal abuse is fun does
your house look like a tree or no it
looks like this it's like identical to
this actually Rick and Morty hang a
lantern on a logical inconsistency
thinking that will somehow keep us from
sinning it as if they've never seen one
of our videos before come on just admit
you watch TV sins already um cliche I'd
remove a sin if I could say for sure
that this signment no flossing but I
can't so instead I need to write you up
for improper signage you're bad at math
but I'm giving you an A+ in confidence
Americans wait isn't that the same stud
student that was sitting on the floor
earlier are you telling me that wasn't
even their locker they were in front of
you sat down and leaned on someone
else's Locker who does that only if the
events of the Pixar movie Coco are to be
believed which I doubt Coco deniers I
certainly have questions about how or
why Holograms eat but the show is of
course touching on that just enough to
pretend like it actually means something
so instead I'll ask how this holotech is
powered and where it's physically
distributed from the show gets a lot of
credit for thinking through its
theoretical Concepts but when it comes
to technology lives firmly on Yad yada
Avenue will you just show me how to stay
alive Morty is now asking Hollow Rick to
help him not die instead of Consulting
the death Stone even though Hollow Rick
helping him not die was not presented as
an option by the death Pebble show is
all over the place when it comes to how
committed Morty is to following his new
sedimentary God M to
fascisti
nope first up I think this is a very
funny recurring gag which is something I
never thought I'd say about fascism
second the writers made a teddy bear
Rick because of course that's funny but
they also made him mortal in the same
way a human would be mortal instead of
giving him soft and cuddly innards as we
would expect the commitment to Teddy
Rick was less than that of pickle Rick
who was a pickle all the way through and
that's just unacceptable bringing a
chain to a horny teenager with a death
Crystal fight oh the air is getting thi
it is not sure I'm enjoying the every
Rick every Mor all at oness of it all
but how was he able to so quickly
identify which path leads to Jessica
when up until now he had to take time to
zero in on it Shield me from the law
cool two meiks callbacks in the same
episode but wouldn't these meiks have
immediately shielded him from the law
thereby accomplishing their task and
consequently
disappeared
our time really getting all the sounds
correct on the first or second shot
there are 44 different phonetic sounds
in English Morty 4 four he loves you
little Sparrow he's innocent case
dismissed the US justice system I think
we're just about ready to forgive him
and move past this whole thing he's a
free young man and as far as continuity
goes the reset button's been hit what
the did you just try to tell the
audience that none of what Morty is
doing in this episode matters as it
relates to the broader storyline oh it
matters and this is not the last time
you will be hearing about it oh it's
nice to know it's also 2: p.m. in every
other universe as well I was beginning
to think this clock was just broken we
eat our prey alive and when we don't we
lay our eggs in their eyeballs so that
our young can Feast on their brains when
they hatch nope nope nope not looking
that up here's a sin for just making me
think about it so what do the wasp nests
for if you furnished a human type house
and why is there a collectible plate on
display if you don't even use plates in
the first place does no one on this show
care about the important things where's
my bogin there you are don't worry Pop
Pop's back goosing the boglin market
directly after I sold my 1987 slurp for
measly 30 bucks all that's left are
these Kirkland brand me boxes Kirkland
shaming was it's funny because he can't
be stung but it's also not funny because
he's been spouting off all episode about
being a hologram so we know that he
knows that we know that he knows that we
know that he knows that we know that he
knows excuse me that he's not able to be
stung and that's only because of all the
fourth wall breaking I can feel I have
MK for
[Music]
reasons whoa that was fast dare I say
too fast and only because the episode is
ending soon the runtime should never
dictate the rate of pupation there's a
lesson here and I'm not the one that's
going to figure it out is it that Rick
and Morty will do just about anything to
make sure they hit their gratuitous War
quota am I close okay fine I'll take the
assignment seriously the lesson is that
as Humanity becomes more and more
reliant on technology to sustain us
we're also more at risk of those same
Technologies also killing us and while
it's more likely to be a dispassionate
accident we don't really know what we're
doing and one day maybe it will be
malicious there not saying I won't do
your job for you but you aren't going to
like my consulting fee I don't want to
see any more anime stuff the comment
section when I tried to send my hero
Academia somehow makes it into the
episode you ruined the season 4 premiere
it was already ruined from the second
you decided to take over 2 years after
season 3 to bring us any new rig and
Morty and you know it we're at of syrup
there's clearly some syrup at the bottom
of that bottle might take some elbow
grease but I have faith you'll get at
least a stack of pancakes worth out of
there more importantly though the
bottle's just sitting at the table
without a cap on and there's no cap we
can see on the table where did that cap
go is the syrup even good anymore now
that it's been exposed to the elements
is there air you don't know maybe I'll
use my intern gluty gluty arrives from
offscreen as if he appeared out of aing
portal syrup in hand but how did he know
that Rick was eating even in need of
syrup I mean maybe Rick staged this so
he could introduce his intern but how
did he know the syrup wasn't going to
run out before it got to him and why
does he even care about introducing the
intern other than to set up an
underwhelming be
[Music]
PL also the syrup bottle gluty is using
doesn't have a lid on it either what
does his family do with the lids are
they monsters now if you'll excuse me
wait he just dragged his poor intern
into syrup his pancakes and now he's
just going to off feels like Rick went
to the every CEO ever School of treating
interns when Grand Rick Pats his belly
like that and leaves without Morty it
means he's going to go poop I guess it's
that time of day when we sin that Rick
isn't using his portal gun he doesn't
have a problem using it later in the
episode and I don't know about you but
when I realize it's time to drop the
kids off at the pool the last thing I
want between me and the community center
is a car ride honey why can't you get
this excited about your SATs asking this
instead of wondering why summer knows so
many specifics about her grandfather's
Hershey squirts well I'm man enough to
Simply say I'm going to poop defining
your masculinity by a willingness to
announce your Readiness to sit the
porcelain th when you're barely
competent enough to be defined as
sentient assuming that Rick sinks the
Bismark once a day like a regular human
that is regular right wouldn't this path
be well trodden I suppose this could be
a magically regrowing field SL meow
macroscopic cilia Farm but I refuse to
keep filling in the narrative gaps in
the show until I get an official writing
credit reverse digestion extrapolation
here's a sin for the several minutes I
spent trying to imagine SL sketch the
anus that would make the geometry of
this pre-owned nutrient log possible
time to meet your maker nice try but
time to meet your eater would be far
more accurate I can't see how there's
any way of knowing ahead of time that
the maker was the eater also how is the
turd pewer only picking up on the
sandwich shouldn't it be a selection of
well other too what are you guys doing
did you develop an app but if gluty
already had the app design handy what
exactly did he need Jerry for if this is
his species way of stealing water from
the planet why not just develop the app
immediately what's the point of all this
do you want to develop an app pomping
circumstance r number one in app
development son never follow the rules
except when the rule is tattooed on an
alien's forehead dad why do you think
Rick would have that rule Morty would be
excellent at TV sins but the sin here is
that Rick should have known this was a
likely possibility and should have
either a found a Ser delivering intern
without a don't develop my deadly app
caveat or B not left set intern with the
primordial smegma film that Evolution
deemed necessary to give the most basic
self-awareness to called Jerry guys
we're getting our first users and it
just happens to be summer because
coincidence thy name is Rick and Morty
this new app just matched me with a guy
that is Sue My Thai super my type learn
to aree Beth wasn't asking you what you
meant summer so there was no need to
explain and how is the explanation 10
times more irritating to hear than the
thing you said Al k your Sue taii works
at Jersey miks and sees 25 fish shows a
year then Danny must be independently
wealthy because tickets along with all
the drugs you would have to purchase for
25 fish shows aren't cheap this world
cares too much about bands and too
little about love and I Think I Love You
tummy how's the beeping tmy how's the
beeping tmy tmy tummy tummy tummy just
sitting the fact that any menu claiming
to have the best frog food would
advertise this basic ass sandwich and
not its fce cream cheeseburger or ant
chovy Pizza dad give the human whatever
he wants he knows where I live He's
Crazy you have
470,000 messages Weir just left to
imagine how Rick was able to find and
leave voicemails with 470,000 flies and
just accept that it happened even if he
managed to automate some of the
voicemails how is this his best option
if he's not afraid of murdering child
flies why is the far more convenient
decision to torture this adult fly not
top of the list you fing idiot I have
800,000 kids thinking the amount of
children one has coincides with how many
they're willing to let die I mean it
totally does but we're not supposed to
announce that to the world I'm not
arguing that being hit by a car isn't an
effective form of contraception but it
sure does feel like dealing with the
Splinter and a finger by removing the
entire arm had you bothered to master
love you would have learned by now it is
as abundant as water you know what isn't
water so we'll be taking yours
oxymoronic Exposition in aside expoxy
Morana ining we've got an aliens come to
Earth to steal our resources cliche oh
scoping for this bit then crocy my
wife's still alive she she went into
remission 10 years ago what did you do
today oh I uh pooped on a really awesome
toilet I found wait a fing minute let's
talk about the villain's plan here Rick
just found and traveled to an alternate
universe to find a Tony who used his
toilet despite his wife still being
alive and then dragged him in front of
this universe's Tony to prove he's lying
putting aside the fact that he found the
perfect Tony in a matter of seconds what
the does that even prove unless Rick can
say that every Tony in every Universe
makes this Choice regardless of
circumstances this doesn't prove sh so
next time you stumble onto a toilet that
feels too good for your ass trust me it
is but how did Tony even find the damn
thing in the first place and why didn't
Rick have any sort of defense or Shield
oring laser beam that turns you inside
out and teleports you into the final
days of a civilization that PRS itself
on flaying any and all visitors with a
limme soaked cheese grater before they
fall into the abyss of a black hole I
think you'd get a kick out of
that I suppose we can add allowing your
anus to give the finger to an alien to
the list of defeca fors after you left I
I thought about what you said and how
much I needed to skip you rang I'm
pooping too this is not how you're
supposed to poop either that or God
knows something about pooping we don't
regardless I'm torn grossed out and very
confused come poop with me poop with me
Tony aren't you going to join us in the
pooping Tony how's the pooping Tony
how's the pooping Tony Tony Tony Tony
Tony you can make a perfectly realized
toilet filed simulation of heaven but
you can't share a toilet Tony would be
the king of his own thrown at TV SS I
get that this drawing is likely
gibberish chiefly because Jerry drew it
but at some point I have to wonder how
even his lonely brain cell doesn't
realize the futility of its actions like
why spend the time drawing a portal gun
you don't possess a grandpa that isn't
here or a baseball bat you don't have
come on adventures of Jerry and Morty
okay premature Jerry is a burden to the
oxygen he Breeze and didn't even deserve
this P5 vibration summering thing yeah
but I'm assuming you chose this working
thing is your method of locomotion so
what the were you expecting here where's
your
daughter you're right she join Isis
we've got Isis jokes y'all that's what I
thought gluty looks like you and
I are all we got well this worked out
conveniently enough for Jerry that I'm
awarding it 10 sins then those 10 sins
will be awarded their 10 sin matches
which they will then cheat on each other
with the other 10 sins you know what
just add the damn sins already mother
that's my name don't wear it at is it
though I mean it's not beyond the realm
of what the show is capable of but that
feels more like a season 6 style of
episode considering the presence of Sam
Neil Jeffrey Wright and Tao ITI I'm
genuinely shocked that this scene does
not contain a Ted danc in also look I'm
not one for promoting infidelity but if
Ted dancon wants you to cheat on your
husband then you cheat on your husband
that is Ted dancing people this episode
is 37% defecation and honestly I'm
pooped out enjoy using it all by
yourself while you sit there and think
about how nobody wants to be around you
however only Rick and Morty could turn
the act of decorating porcelain into a
beautiful metaphor about how hoarding
precious things is not as fulfilling as
we believe and that true Joy is in the
sharing of said things with the people
you love and for bringing that home by
making Rick suffer through his own booby
trap I shall happily allow the sin
counter to drop a
deuce an Alien Spider just bit my finger
it's an alien Cliff you can just say
spider yes but the spider's still alien
from Morty's point of view it'd be
pretty confusing if Morty found an earth
spider on this mountain so specifying
its alien origin feels pretty warranted
everyone knows that pedantry is more fun
when it's safe for the really important
stuff like critiquing self-aware
cartoons on the internet also this
episode opens with a pretty clear Star
Trek 5 the one with God reference which
has led us to using this side-by-side
comparison to prove it which has led to
all of us watching more Star Trek 5 the
one with God than we ever need to which
has rather fittingly led to sin activate
anti- booby suits well I be sinning this
scene because it uses the phrase anti-
booby even though I know for a fact it's
talking about booby traps and not actual
boob boobies yes look we all like saying
booby but someone has to nip these
inaccuracies in the bud also great idea
but what if this place contained traps
that didn't rely on projectiles would
these suits have been useful against
disappearing Bridges quicksand or those
irritating statues where one always
speaks the truth and the other one
always lies more like trying too hard
con or more like trying too hard to come
up with an insult for the heist con that
is trying too hard con or something con
guests are fans Morty which we are not
guests don't have to be fans in fact
there are plenty of people out there who
things or watch movies they know they'll
hate so they can give themselves
something to complain about which
honestly fits Rick to a tea I'm not one
to judge based on physical appearance
but the fact that this individual's eye
is not fully connected to their body is
giving me all of the heebie jeebies and
I would like it to stop please thanks
for doing this guys what's the job that
was it bye I would say I feel bad for
glar Angie flint and truckula but they
chose to show up at the location without
even knowing what the job was so that's
kind of on them it's showtime Morty and
I don't mean a bad impression of HBO
you're jackets Twin Peaks the return and
the first six seasons of Dexter would
like to have a word with you lab coat
rip off Doctor Strange if Rick actually
developed a sentient lab coat then I
guess he's kind of ripping off doctor
strange but also Rick developed a cient
lab coat why isn't he using that more
often your boo me nothing I've seen what
makes you cheer reason I'm able to read
YouTube comments somehow makes its way
into the script it doesn't make things
interesting it makes them Oceans 12 by
far the worst one I'm just going to go
ahead and send myself for liking Oceans
12 I have no good excuses I just love
watching people enjoy European Vacation
going to go ahead and give myself a sin
for liking National Lampoon's European
Vacation as well oink oink my good man
half of nightly eight or just three of
Sanchez's five that's not how math Works
Morty well no Heist is complete without
a double cross okay maybe nightly
predicted Rick would take the bait at
the tomb which would result in the heist
off but how could he have known Rick's
team would be so willing to portray Rick
especially when Rick has a reputation
for
M What the hi what the sh what are you
doing here I'm you but from from several
minutes in the future look this episode
gets Mighty confusing If You Don't Know
How It Ends so I'm here to set you
straight when needed makes sense but
what's with the weirdly deep announcer
voice don't worry that'll make sense
later the important thing is that these
three were specially selected by Rick
because he knew they'd betray him so I
guess just do the thing where we send
the show for the time we wasted writing
a sin that it later disproves see you
okay uh yeah what he SL I said and I had
the perfect job
heisting the Crystal Skull he got the
skull already looks like Rick and Morty
left their crew and went straight to see
nightly on stage so how did nightly have
enough time to recruit Rick's heers set
the heist in motion
and again already sorry buddy we're
about to see there's a huge time gap
between Rick and Morty leaving the crew
and then them turning up a nightly show
and that's when all the heisting happens
we're better off sending that there's no
way nightly could have known Rick was
going to dick around for a few hours
before coming to see him which is the
only way nightly had enough time time to
pull off the heist okay thank you but
wouldn't it be better to just lay all
this out now and save some time
by looks like you're available for a job
Rick and Morty literally just left could
nightly not have waited until they were
at least out of earshot okay let's take
a second to talk through this Heist glar
steals some keys and hands them off to
key catcher who hands them off to double
microwave who well microwaves them as a
distraction to presumably clear out
security they couldn't even microwaved
anything metal why did they have to go
through the effort of stealing the
specific set of
keys
did The Shape Shifter just shape shift
in front of the damn camera I don't care
if the crew is in charge of the
surveillance room now that's still
recorded footage of their actual
identity why even risk it do that off
screen we're smart we'll figure it out
also they turn into the security guard
give the thumbs up and the next thing
that happens is that monitor Lord
switches off the lasers allowing Angie
to steal the skull why the does the crew
need a security guard at this
point I'm trying to figure out how miles
didn't know by the weight of the attache
that there wasn't a crystal skull in it
I'm not saying he should have known it
was a recent Deuce Rick dropped but the
stench alone should have given something
away God damn it Morty what did I tell
you you gave him a time limit that he
needed to pay attention to but this is
also the kid that said half of nly's
eight or just three of Sanchez's five so
I'm pretty sure you should have been the
one checking the clock Rick WR an
algorithm based on two heist movies I
slept through and use it to automate a
joyless process you call Art Rick
clearly has an issue with the heist
genre being overly formulaic and
predictable but sometimes it's that very
predictability that brings people to
comfort and joy they need from their
movie watching experience we don't all
have to like the same stuff and we don't
all have to agree except for Army of the
Dead that movie somehow no one in this
long line catches on to what's happening
until all of them get hypnotized look
Morty I did not know that that was going
to happen that's not on me that not how
homicide law
Works told you Morty he still got it oh
come on the entire universe is in danger
and yet Rick took the time to recruit
all of these students to set up this
attack just to prove that Professor
poopy butthole
has damn it what now hey I'm with you on
this one but they're going to make the
same point in the post credit scene and
steal our thunder so I think we'd better
send them for leaning on call backs to
characters no one likes but I like Mr
Poopy butthole no you
don't are you vent Trill
quiver in this episode alone we've seen
Rick block a hammer with a sudden robot
arm but a arrow hits the mark how I'm
sure it's not the show sacrificing its
Integrity just to show us a unique super
power Rick Sanchez I presume damn it
guys Elon Tusk listen we need your help
Rick Morty y me Elon
M oh for look what could possibly be
wrong here this in is quite clearly whoa
there steady on no objections here at
all I just wanted to come back and send
this one again oh
cool at this point heistotron has become
large enough to Heist entire planets but
is it even heisting anymore everyone on
this planet knows that they're being
heisted are we supposed to believe that
there's no way to scale up a heist to a
planetary level that doesn't just
involve making all the gadgets bigger at
this point it isn't heisting it's just
breaking and entering with a sprinkling
of genocide instead of two heist movies
I slept through Rand tron's algorithm is
derived from the plots of three David
Lynch movies I pretended to like to make
my friends shut up for me the crucial
question here is which three David Lynch
movies I think it's only fair that we're
told where on the spectrum between Dune
and blue velvet this is going to be so
we know the best way to pretend we've
seen either one if our colle I behavior
is just random enough we should be able
to walk through heistotron lazily
contrived like it's not even
there but even choosing to be random is
a plan if the end goal is to out Heist
heistotron relying on Randomness will
either be so random that you never get
to the desired outcome or not be random
enough to not be predicted by heistotron
I don't like these little Jabs you get
in Elon signed literally all of Twitter
surprisingly my issue here isn't the
consumption of diapers but the fact that
this box specifies fresh suggests there
is a not fresh fresh diaper alternative
on sale the most unbelievable part of
this episode is that Morty's room would
be this clean I've got something to tell
you let me guess when you invented me
and randotron you swapped our brains if
he knew heistotron was going to go Rogue
why does he even need randotron why
couldn't he even just programmed a fail
safe into Heist
to here we go again buddy believe me I
am with you but the next 5 minutes are
going to get super weird and I'm still
not certain how many switch Ros actually
make sense and honestly I'm not sure the
show does either let's send it for Rick
labeling these brains and then
immediately switching the labels just
for the purposes of the flashback that
heistotron can't see to comate for a
switcher Rick couldn't possibly have
predicted what well if the brain inside
of you is actually heistotron it matters
because it explodes when it hits six
levels of contrivance I mean could he
not have made it four and saved us all
some time and migraines well done Rick
randotron I'm afraid not but if Rick
built both machines how the did it
manage to switch out its own motherboard
and why didn't need to bother with this
earlier Switcheroo also if this is
heistotron that means this was randotron
which means it shouldn't have blown up
after that sixth contrivance because I
programmed you to believe that I
programmed you to believe that robot
kids what's happening Professor poopy
butthole he's learning I think it's fair
to say that nothing within this rambling
incoherence could be considered learning
in fact I would argue that we're all
dumber for having experience it Ricky
Mor should be awarded no points and may
God have mercy on our souls it appears
the only perfect Heist is one that was
never written goodbye Rick and Morty
writers create a paradox they have no
idea how to solve so they blow it up
deny its existence or banish it to an
alternate reality cliche well you know
that screenplay that I've been writing
Netflix is pretty interesed Morty Morty
Morty I'm so excited for you wait is
Rick being sincere right now about a
Netflix deal what
is okay last one I promise we're about
to find find out that Rick put this
adventure into motion just to
disillusion Morty and make him sour to
his own high script however I think
we're safe to send him for the many many
many millions of people that had to die
just so that Rick could crush his
grandson's passion for a project o
that's messed up even for Rick right see
you at the sin
removal wait the what now well let's
hear about this Heist movie okay so it's
kind of all all built around this big
crew with like a cool double cross and
then this big awesome twist expecting us
to believe that Netflix didn't
Greenlight this at okay and then cancel
it by awesome twist if Morty ever gives
up on a single dream it had better be
because of his own disillusionment
somehow Rick and Morty manages to pull
off sitting everything tropy and cliche
about heist movies while also
inceptioning itself into an excellent
homage of an example of how to do the
genre in a unique and satisfying way oh
and and on that sin removal I guess it's
time to head back and make sure past me
doesn't make a bigger ass of myself than
usual I still don't understand the deep
voice thing but better safe than Paradox
am I right I got a date with
density these aliens not knowing that
even with a Sleek design and increased
lethality these space blasters will
never be able to strike both fear and
love into our hearts like the original
Super
Soaker you Rick we get it you don't care
about anyone or anything and I don't
care about you not caring about anyone
or anything the person viewing this
video doesn't care about me not caring
about you not caring
about or anything Justice for Chachi did
you get the ultimate cube is anyone else
thinking about Cube squar hyper Cube has
nothing to do with this episode but
neither does this McGuffin I mean Cube
also now I'm just upset we never got
cube cubed ultimate Cube because someone
decided Cube zero was a better idea
cubes I mean prequels I want my dragon I
want my dragon I want my dragon kids the
convenient trajectory of this outof
control fall to planet Earth where they
Land close enough to be discovered and
taken to a hospital that somehow know
knows to contact their family without
anyone questioning the whole space
travel part or Rick and Morty surviv
this you choose your ship crashed in
Malta Beth points out that Rick's ship
entered Earth's orbit and crashed onto
an archipelago in the central
Mediterranean Sea between Sicily in the
North African Coast known for historic
sites related to a succession of rulers
including the Romans Moors French
British and the Knights of St John like
that's the weirdest thing about this
situation I'm okay says the man whose
body is in a cast but more concerningly
whose fingers are outstretched and
unbending at the joints Rick just
regained Consciousness and his hanging
bag of water isn't connected to anything
if I've learned one thing from medical
dramas it's that unconscious people
always have a straw going from the
hanging bag of water to their arm I'm
not co- beding my sister trying to argue
her way out of menstrual synchrony at
summer camp somehow makes its way into
this episode also no one in the
neighborhood ever sees any of these
things ever my name is bamar breaker of
Sky Slayer of mountain if you have to
announce that you're slaying it you're
probably not slaying it and unless
dragons are the main contributor to
climate change then I'm going to say
that Bama has broken more wind than Sky
I'm guessing you'd rather not be tagged
in this is is she talking to the dragon
from another dimension right now does
she think he would be linked on social
media or even know what that is I want
you to take us to the airport and get us
two first class tickets to Florida cats
thinking they can just show up in
Florida whenever they're looking for a
good time like it's their own personal
playground as far as States go it
deserves a little more courtesy than
Ohio I want to enter my lar and sleep
upon my horde until the age of man
expires Mondays what's this show called
ass they solve ass crimes this ass is a
clue go to her ass go to brener ass I
love you ass should I pause ass show
passes ass for all the gluteous amounts
of some butt oh and that's the end of
the moritza Dragon episode it is not I
hoard that which all kind covets but not
everyone covets this specific drink so
the dragon could essentially collect any
random thing simply because some people
like it also why would the ecto-cooler
drink be considered something to CET
when it was in production for so long
it's not like it was rare it was
produced for years small soldier spin
pops Rick loves pop culture things from
the past to make him more relatable
cliche hey why do you have future
self-titled album on vinyl Rick loves
pop culture things from the present to
make him more relatable cliche he signed
it in Molly and peret a mixture I can
only imagine is something akin to oil
pastels we all know that would never
really dry these beach umbrellas that
are not anchored and would absolutely be
blown around the beach flip up with the
wind and knock an unfortunate passer by
unconscious not that I have any
experience mining my own business on a
Sandy stroll only to be woken up minutes
later by a half- naked sunburn man
chuckling about probabilities why and
who it was
him right but she also asked why someone
in the sand so is everyone going to just
ignore that what if his reason was so
profound that everyone decided to join
in and bury their sh on the beach what
does it mean when means you're lame
Morty just summoned a Taylor Swift
concert likely Al live one in summer
thinks that's lame that's a free
concert forcing a caged animal to free
its mind with drugs and yes I'm assuming
the drugs are mind expanding in some way
but even if they aren't why with a
creature that is with enough as it is
I'm bonding
bonding bonding why does it feel better
now I hope it's not because you're
watching but don't go anywhere is a
thing that Rick says to his grandkids in
this episode you're dragon soul bonded
with my grandpa oh my
I am so sorry that is a total violation
yeah no sh how would Morty know that the
dragon shouldn't Soul Bond with more
than one person at a time why wouldn't
the wizard know that a dragon can Soul
Bond without warning see people this is
what happens when no one reads the fine
print of the blood bonding contracts
that we agree to without a thought raot
do something or I will tweet and you
will be cancelled show treats this as a
credible threat without giving us the
slightest idea of how you cancel a Rick
and even if it were possible to cancel
your R scription we all know he would
would just off to some new dimension
where he hasn't been canceled yet it
takes like 78 years to hang a dragon
what an odd thing for Morty to know I
assume he knows the length of time it
would take to hang a dragon because of
the book He's reading so I could also
say what an odd fact to have inside the
Tome of dragon spells and lore summer
make it look like it's coming out of
your butthole is a thing that Rick just
said to his granddaughter in this
episode yeah yeah despite this agreement
it does not look like the Aro came out
of her butthole and any attempt to
achieve this seems to have been
primarily done by the camera operator
and not summer power of 12 ft
[Laughter]
I never thought I would laugh so hard at
the simple visual gag of Rick getting
his ass
kicked and there's wizard p in the
background oh Ricky Morty you you take
my breath away and if the goal is to
make something up why not make up
something funnier he cat would have a
point if it listened to the remainder of
the Bro dude's explanation of what a
peanut butter gargoyle actually is it
could have been hilarious and for that
reason alone I'm angry that the cat
interrupted guess I'll never fully
understand this totally made up
hilarious sex position its correlation
to statues and mashed peanuts stupid cat
a why can't couples that start out
cheating ever end up happy did Rick know
he was cheating they're not a fun SC to
explode into accidental bonding and
non-intentional cheating and sure Rick
would have cheated anyway and we all
know it but this didn't seem to be that
sort of situation they were both
surprised by it how about finding the
spell that unbinds me from youring
Dragon no spells can do that only the
wizard can unbind Soul bombs yes and the
primary tools of wizards are spells but
instead of arguing that I'll just say
that 2 minutes later they all agree that
killing the wizard can break the bond so
either way this statement is untrue yeah
we like it down here cuz we could woolly
mammoths get out before watching this
episode I never really thought about
woolly mammoth erotica but knew it
wasn't a thing and now thanks to the
writers and the internet I have
confirmation that it is in fact a thing
so this s is for Humanity's boundless
creativity in the fact that we found
ways to use it that can simultaneously
Inspire wonder and evoke fear it's high
time I emerge from my puberty so
killing the wizard will break my Soul
Bond yes it solves all of our problems
and I rush to get on with a dragon show
glosses over all the important questions
related to this resolution like how
oring why maybe don't tell your parents
we did this why wouldn't he Morty didn't
agree to this experience at all he was
actively looking for a way out of it
without having to s bond with nine other
beings he should talk to someone about
this violation of his person and
entirely too early exposure to the
pleasures of inner species bonding wait
why did the dragon come because you Soul
him and have a soul orgy with your
sister and Grandpa on every Dragon we
could find yeah is a thing Cy do I
really have to complete this one or do
you get the point cool thanks no look I
just want to be clean I I I feel dirty
after everything that's happened how
about a quick hand bond this moment of
pressuring a kid into any number of
sexual Soul bonding scenarios goes on
for all of these should be jailed
amounts of some time I'm from outer
space happy no exactly because no answer
would be satisfying writers use this cat
as a proxy in their attempt to Gaslight
me into thinking my need for answers is
what has left me unsatisfied by this
episode and not the boner killing Dragon
CEST get out get
out I'm not sure why Rick doesn't just
kill this cat for whatever it did he
just went through and murdered all the
Wizards guards even the ones that were
just reading a book why did the writers
draw the line at murdering a horrific
alien cat creature that causes Rick to
consider suicide it's for the post
credit scene isn't
it you SL
Dragon why the does it feel like you're
whipping
me do something Thief you're a
Thief a Dragon also a we are
the dragons caves dragons
be up there all dragons are
enough fresh wet 10
Soul ory the all Phoenix
Dragon Morty be sure to pee
before we go this adventure is going to
be a long haul and I don't feel like
emptying The Jug while the pee will
return momentarily it and The Jug are
ultimately red herrings that exist only
to set up a rather unfunny centipede who
eats urine joke later so you're getting
two sins Rick and Morty for pissing all
over my valuable time I made your Atomic
Matrix slightly lighter than air and now
your shoes are heavier than air which
makes you neutrally buoyant which I find
personally more impressive conceptually
than walking on water but what do I know
I wasn't born into the god business I
guess Rick's proclamations on his
godliness make this decision and the
resulting hij Jinks the product of his
hubris but that won't stop me from
pointing out that Rick's magic does
whatever the plot needs pistol probably
could and should have been able to make
Jerry neutrally buoyant without his
shoes what you think the centipede wants
to eat your pee since matter can be
neither created nor destroyed I have to
ask where does the pee go when it's
inside the centipede I mean even if it
evaporated or some that's still still
seems Less Pleasant than just peeing in
The Jug you've written out of the story
for some reason you young people think
space is like Saturday Night Live you
see it every day so you dream of being
in it so then it's nothing like Saturday
Night Live because it's not on every day
and I'm pretty sure whichever generation
is currently being accused of lacking
work ethic has never seen it literally
everything is out here and unlike
everywhere else I'm too busy to help you
never mind the fact that he does end up
helping Morty after he gets bitten by
the space snake I'm more concerned that
the writers think changing a space Tire
requires more concentration than
toppling a Galactic Federation seducing
a hive mind or fixing a fragmented space
time which you coincidentally also broke
I'm already starting to look like a '90s
Japanese ghost I'm not going to send
Rick trying to flex his knowledge of
ringu but I'm more than willing to call
him out for not knowing that juah and
The Grudge came out in the ODS imagine
being a racist snake hey other snake I
hate you because you're the wrong color
snake I had a hearty laugh when I
realized how easy it is to replace the
word snake in this statement with the
word human then I cried because frankly
it's sad that a lot of humans have yet
to learn such a simple lesson but then I
laughed again because conceptually a
racist snake is just funny then I cried
again because conceptually a racist
human is not funny so take your sinim
back so we can get back to laughing but
also this snake parade is traveling in a
straight line spitting right in the face
of the slythering snake aesthetic that
has abandoned aerodynamic efficiency for
the sake of these wobbly snake Rockets I
I can't be the reason why 19 billion
snakes lost all hope using Morty's guilt
as a reason for him to do some
questionable things with a snake sure is
a weird way to get the story rolling
especially when you consider how many
people he killed in episode one of this
season and how little he cared about the
hope he robbed from those families I
don't know which Red soda this is but
without naming names I drank one of them
several years ago after walking five
miles in the hot Texas sun and then
proceeded to vomit furiously never been
able to forget the uniquely potent
flavors of its Ingress and subsequent
egress and the sight of red fluids has
continued to haunt my Waking Life so as
far as I'm concerned they're all a sin
Morty suddenly not being smart enough to
know that when this snake sheds the
temporary t tattoos will likely go with
it is slightly less concerning than the
overt speciesism he displays by thinking
one snake could be so easily replaced
with another I me like me showing up at
your Thanksgiving dinner with a matching
Team Edward tattoo and acting like I
didn't regret getting it your family
would see right through it everyone has
a plumbus in their home writers think
they can milk this plumbus every time
they need a quick
laugh this snake is somehow now wearing
the space snake suit properly even
though earlier Morty was shoving it into
the suit face first if it doesn't work
for leing bags it shouldn't work for
this the next two minutes of this show
will be Super Cuts of snakes doing the
same things humans do with these same
things humans would use to do them
because it's funny to anthropomorphize
animals especially when it makes no
sense evolutionarily but unfortunately
the funniness of the
SS doesn't negate the sinness of the
[Music]
logic to be fair newscast involving
humans are no more interesting than this
downbeat how do you win this fing game
we we've never gotten that far Rick
spending time with his grandkids in a
scenario that doesn't involve putting
their lives at risk makes me question
everything about this scene like is this
a simulation I mean are they a
simulation not am I a simulation I am
100% certain that I am real Jerry I
paused Beth with a device Christopher
Walkin gave me after a record session
taking the long way around saying remote
just so you can make a reference to an
Adam Sandler vehicle from the mid 2000s
thinking this is a better name for a bar
than Devil's protuberance of the mamory
gland upon which the lactiferous Ducks
open and milk is drawn just rolls off
the TP right one Diet Sprite remix
please and uh is anyone here an Uber
driver Cherry the obvious pool table
light not being over the actual pool
table and frankly your bar has a lot of
ceiling F Jerry brings up an interesting
point here that honestly isn't addressed
enough in this world when you over
sealing fan your bar you're just asking
for trouble whether it's a man who
brings in a boulder one day because he
claims he will float without it or it's
Davey having one too many shots at Tios
and then deciding to see how many pool
cues he can jam in all the fans bad
things will happen things you'll never
be able to unsee just say no to over
sealing Fanning you will thank us summer
house soups shook am ey by your
playlisting fleetness tonight wrers
thought my chi ass would be highkey
stressed by the vibe but summer Squad is
just being extra and that's super sus so
bye Felicia I think my little brother
got bit by a snake in outer space and
killed it with a hubcap can you alter
the course of a species Evolution like
that without repercussion saying that
Morty altered the course makes it sound
like there was a predetermined
destination when what happened was more
akin to an unintentional participation
in their evolution I'd say an encounter
with a new species that results in death
is very much in line with the principles
of natural selection in this case the
snake literally bit off more than it
could you and as a result they were not
selected for the next round of the
tournament get behind me I will protect
Beth was right there watching the creepy
snake man's Judgment Day sales pitch
aliens I am a robot sent back in time by
the snake resistance to protect you from
surfac cour so her reaction here is more
comedic than logic dick Rick pulp
fictioning Morty back to life in the
middle of Crossfire from time traveling
snakes seem seems much harder than
helping Morty deal with one snake while
changing a tire but for reasons Rick
seems much less angered here than he was
during the cold open the war between
snake and machine snake oration 2
Judgment snake how exactly were they
able to get a picture of Morty even if
the snake was able to describe how he
looked this attention to detail is
insane I know we've gone over this so
many times but you can't just write the
present and expect us to know what that
means does that mean 2019 present
because that's not theing present for me
get behind me your brood will seed all
life on this planet that doesn't make
sense make sense I don't care if it
doesn't make any sense the deceitful way
that Morty brought this earth snake to
snake earth makes the seating of a
planet more problematic than the weird
sacrifice at the beginning of Prometheus
I can't get reception at my dentist but
Jerry can make a phone call thousands of
feet in the air Jerry almost never hits
his Target outside of the bedroom so
this working is just as much as
Jerry not being immediately killed by
the impact also the depth of this pocket
and this phone not falling out of it I
don't suppose you guys will take a bribe
attempting to bribe a snake officer of
the
law anyone else want legs the results of
this literal and drastic intervention in
the biology of snake kind don't play a
bigger role in the snake evolution of
this episode it's just 1985 but with
snakes you know kind of like 1952 with
Mir cats but not so much like 1976 with
possums that one was a disaster also
show wants me to believe that
Massachusetts is a phase that all
pre-warp civilizations must go through
that book has everything they need to
create snake time travel and and they're
getting it in 1985 snake time the
existence of this book tells me that the
writers are aware that I'm aware that
they're aware that I'm a
world what the was
that a forgot I left Nar bot
running how long did I leave this thing
on wow he should have been watching a
lot of Rick and Morty looks like he was
right in the middle of sinning well I
guess I shouldn't leave this episode
unfinished well let me see where he's
okay what was he trying he was sitting
here look I I don't know I don't know
what he was doing here I'm just going to
go with something about some convenient
1980s time travel cliche snake
raham Lincoln survives this not that I
wanted snaker Ham Lincoln to not survive
this but why is snake Lincoln so ready
to accept time travel that he
immediately reads this note instead of
being more concerned about what just
happened to the well-dressed man from
the80s snake Hitler not using a shower
curtain but mostly just being a snake
Hitler just have to keep my grip Jerry
says as he's holding on to the outside
of a plane likely traveling at something
around 600 mph rers if going to do this
kind of we're eventually going to need a
Jerry as an immortal super beinging
episode to explain it if that ever
happens we promise we'll give this sin
back since British Airways once flew a
747 from LA to the UK on three engines
I'm going to say that Jerry causing
would I imagine to be the first ever
snake Strike should have been a cause
for concern yes but not nearly the
catastrophic event that the show wants
me to believe it was also no matter how
many times I watch this I continue to
see a rocket powered alligator that
suffered the loss of two legs and not a
rocket powered snake that has suffered
the growth of two arms it's pandemonium
out there Morty being a snake demonus
his hole somehow during all this hacking
and slashing Summer's clothes stay clean
how is the blood physics of this scene
just as silly as Kill Bill but in the
opposite direction nobody chokes me
without consent summer would be 50
Shades of great at TV sends also that's
about as much curvature as you're going
to get from a time travel story Josh
fman has entered the chat yeah have fun
snowing those snake costumes together
you little wait did Morty say snow
instead of sewing s run that one back
again I have fun snowing okay one more
time a little bit slower I have fun Sno
Christmas
episodes that book has everything they
need to create snake time travel and and
they're getting it in 1985 snake time
the existence of this book tells me that
the writers are aware that I'm aware
that they're aware that I'm
aware yes in this video I revealed that
I built a robot to do the sinting for
shows I'd rather Skip and this silly
attempt at reconning my powers in the
cerse was definitely a one-off gag that
will never ever happen again
ever
[Music]
[Applause]
a I know the only reason to travel by
train is to travel with weapons false
other reasons include but I'm not
limited to meeting Donald gleon and or
mer Weaver for an affair playing
cribbage with a random stranger or
finding out what baby tastes like also I
know this particular train car are so
hard edged that they drink alcohol Hall
from Taps that look like snakes but why
is there a knock dispenser at every
table who one who enters this car would
come unprepared to the point that this
bar freely hands out brass knuckles at
each individual table would they and yes
this is the Rick and Morty where the
creators decided nothing matters so it's
our job to say that everything does take
that logic who are you dirty sanchez
Rick is clearly firing toward the
ceiling in some of these shots yet
everyone hits its Mark did he purchase a
zorg zf1 from Gary
Oldman even in a simulation or whatever
the you want to call this why not drink
this potion
[Music]
sooner you know growing a second ass
just so you can fart out of two
buttholes is a true waste of real estate
I don't accept your weird leap and logic
that has everyone on a train going to
kill one guy I'm wondering who made the
decision to animate Jeremy from Cinema
Sins in this way why would we take turns
telling stories about it like little
girls at a sleepover they are called
slumber parties and you sir are a meanie
what is with the Rick Sanchez Obsession
I know right and which Rick Sanchez are
you even talking about there's like a
whole Citadel of them this show plays so
fast and loose with its Ricks that I
never know which one is the real Rick
and which ones aren't it gets confusing
you don't see us just switching channel
narrators in the middle of a video
without ever explaining it I mean can
you imagine I know this story is BS but
how the did that Christmas tree jump
from the right side of the window to all
the way over to the left side of the
window Morty and summer were hanging
ornaments on it when Rick walked in now
they're nowhere near it also good to see
that they've managed to set up only one
glass of wine on this table before
bringing out the turkey none of my
business but he didn't even save
Christmas in that story this whole
episode would be excellent at TV sins oh
you don't have to pretend you didn't
date him we all did now a lot of you
will be focused on Yoda in this shot but
I'm more focused on the fact that Rick
dated Quinn morg andorfer Total Recall
Sophia Vergara and Conan O'Brien also if
you're an octopus how do you pick which
leg the Garter goes on is it like a
wedding ring situation it's not a real
train it's a story device okay guys if
you're going to do all our work for us
what are we supposed to even do show
random pictures of adorable cat costumes
if we wanted one-offs we'd do
interdimensional cable this episode is
interdimensional cable only this time
Rick and Morty is the show that they
keep flipping to it's like Rick and
Morty and Inception just had a threesome
baby with devs it's Rick and Morty
entering their own portal like malovich
did in Being John malovich that sounds
like it should be a sin removal so it
won't be since nothing makes sense in
this episode I'm going to remove a sin
for the oversized tickets Please arcade
game with a huge monitor that requires a
seat a VR helmet and a giant console to
play everyone give me
tickets ruining your grand kid's
birthday this could come in handy so in
this literally metaphorical literal
metaphor Anthology Story train air is
continuity does that even mean anything
does anything mean anything sorry to
nitpick sir sorry to
nitpick and doesn't that mean those two
could be any Rick and Morty has blown up
continuity as we know it but what I
really want to know is why are there
tally marks on the wall suggesting that
someone was trapped here for 10 days
even in this Wacky World it's hard to
believe that Rick and Morty can punch
somebody just once and they die
instantly of course this thing is just a
circle the first image of this episode
is a regular ass looking train in Space
the track might be circular but the
train isn't there's probably a point to
this but I'm too lazy to look it up we
don't have to do anything Morty this is
just a structural guide we're obviously
going to impart our own style I don't
like how meta this is getting rich you
know I've watched this episode five
times and a lot of it feels like the
writers were going through a therapy
session like they're worried that their
original show might get stale it's like
a pallet cleanser but after waiting for
this show to come back since 2017
waiting 2 years to get half of a season
and waiting another 4 months for the
next episode I'm not sure I really
needed an episode where the writers
obssessed over their own creation what's
funny is that a year from now this
episode will be just another episode and
the pressure on it to be great will be
completely gone this sounds like it
should be a sin so I'm removing one shut
up Morty you're 14 you watch videos of
people on YouTube reacting to YouTube
bet you really felt that one de huh I'll
be the judge of when we get to meta look
I don't have a problem with the meta I
have a problem with when the meta
becomes a lazy excuse just to do
whatever you want and pretend it's
clever like when YouTube channels get an
easy laugh by accusing the show they're
dissecting of doing the very thing that
people accuse them of doing oh wink a
wink what's happening going into an act
break you know it's kind of like they're
trying to steal our job and break our
will so hard that it never returns like
when parents find their kids with
cigarettes and force them to smoke the
whole pack bad news dad our lungs were
made for this I'm a bird and a person
and more sure that was a great moment
why is it that in this train car the
people get a stage to tell their Rick
and Morty stories also taping photos on
curtains we've been here a really long
time and nobody's taken our tickets how
does a guy suspended in disbelief in
space gather up enough momentum to
suddenly appear for a joke I just
answered my own question didn't I Rick
and Morty just made the most TV sins
proof episode ever with this thing
didn't they or should I say the most TV
sins debunked episode ever cutes name
news cutesy name news meet insert joke
here sin stop thinking and do it uh okay
uh there was this my name is Mike
Johnson that's good coffee wait is this
how Mor is telling the story or is this
the representation of the story Morty is
telling I mean is Morty Standing On Top
of the train saying my name is Mike
Johnson that's good coffee or is he
talking about a guy named Mike Johnson
who likes coffee why is lesbian part of
her job title oh now you're
Progressive I love you ever since you
were mailed to me by a doctor woman this
is a brilliant deconstruction of the
Beck Del test mainly the idea that some
people have that following it inherently
creates a great narrative Jurassic World
pass the Bell test fight them with your
heavy special time you do it
too wow you know what's really special
about summer and Beth's heavy special
time their pants stay completely intact
that new brand of CeX is phenomenal I'm
that Supreme Court lady and you did it I
don't know if this actually passes the
Beckel test Beth was called Mom and
Morty couldn't even remember Ruth Bader
ginsburg's name so I'm not sure there
are two or more named females in this
story Rick saved Morty by plugging his
oxygen into Morty's helmet but when Rick
Falls they are no longer connected and
sure Morty could hold his breath for a
few seconds but why do both of their
helmets now have hoses plugged into them
don't worry Morty nothing out there is
Cannon as if it matters this show is to
Cannon like the dersley are to Harry
Potter it throws it under the stairs and
only lets it see the light a day when it
absolutely has to if continuity doesn't
matter then this one ball that was
definitely coming towards Rick shouldn't
be coming towards Rick in the next shot
it should be lizard at this point am I
giving this show a sin for not breaking
continuity yes yes I am who the am I
it's not real nothing's real you can
tell because not only do these officers
arrive 5 seconds after Rick is stabbed
they come from two different directions
did the third one run in and then around
the camera and then in from the other
side well it's nice to see their cuts
and bruises from the rest of this fight
have healed up so nicely is this
intentional maybe does it matter lasagna
I'd take all the sins back if this ends
with one of these two bringing the other
one back to life and then exchanging a
kiss that is somehow both platonic and
romantic Even Rick and more can't help
but play the hits for a cheap thrill and
if you don't think it's a cheap thrill
explain to me again how the me play into
this scene in any way whatsoever I'll
wait time's up they don't thank you for
sending your only begotten son Jesus
what are you doing you guys would never
do this okay I understand that this guy
represents the fans and or the network
but if Rick and Morty started praying
like this everybody would know it's
building to a joke which is exactly what
this does complete with Veggie Tales
reference I mean even if this happened
for real we' laugh because it's so anti-
them listening to Rick's voice is funny
enough that they could do a whole
episode in church with him playing a
pastor and it would be funny somehow I'm
thinking it would be funny somehow I beg
your pardon well it is Jesus and they're
in a machine so this is as Dex mocking
as it gets and I think that deserves a
sinoff
oh so what do you think haha you thought
this was a big play on the setting of
snow Pier but it turns out it was a big
play on a scene from the 1991 Adams
Family ha you thought this was a big
play on the setting of snow piercer
which turned out to be a big play on a
scene from the 1991 Adams Family but it
was actually a big play on a scene from
Ant-Man nobody's out there shopping with
this virus holy way to get that in there
at the last minute we know how long it
takes to get one of these episodes done
and to do some timely last second thing
like this that's awesome but now that I
think of it why is this episode titled
never ricking Morty is that a play on
The Never Ending Story does that work on
any level is it a joke a play on words
does this episode have anything to do
with that movie does a horse get real
sad and die they should have just called
it throw logic from the train and been
done with it try it now look it up it's
real it's not after the scene I
immediately grabbed the face hugger I
have in my garage and went to the cave
in my backyard to see if one of its
tentacles could get hung up on a
stalactite in this manner I was really
good at hitting my head against the
stalactite and even after several rubs I
was turned on by the stalactite but I
could not get the face hugger to wrap
its tentacle around it jeez does Morty
only have four top teeth why have I not
noticed this before four last thing I
remember I was in a cave looking at some
wet egg and oh that probably did it
which makes you wonder how Rick even let
this happen based on how this episode
progresses he's clearly very aware of
the alien movies and face huggers in
general so he should have been at the
very least putting those lessons to use
that nobody from Prometheus learned
about touching strange substances out in
the wild I told you not to look at that
egg it was too wet you don't get to tell
me what to look at I've seen your pornh
Hub account man you couldn't wait to
take the leap from things you shouldn't
look at as a matter of survival to
shaming Morty for his Porn profile could
you not to mention invading his privacy
and that's your grandson man you looked
up his account to see what turns him on
also later we find out that while Morty
told Rick not to look at the egg he was
just as enamored with the egg as Rick
was this might be a little harder than I
thought holy sh they've got an Eminem
store oh have I been watching one of
those Rick and Morty integrated ads this
whole time I thought this was the
episode and this after I wrote so many
sins on that Pringles ad last week I'm
not putting that back on my face relax
it's dead it's not exactly an incentive
you feel an egg in your stomach no well
glass half full if Rick is basing all
his information on alien then he should
know that Kane didn't feel the egg in
his stomach until it was way too late so
sounds like your glass might be half
full of Glo glub Jesus Christ who the
was I I guess Rick immediately
subscribed to his parasites Channel as
soon as he saw it or he took this phone
from one of the guards who clearly
didn't like Rick and therefore wouldn't
be a subscriber to his channel did I at
least sell out and sell vitamins or
something no IES but close enough I did
this you and the amazing technology you
both brought us I get that the summer
reveal is a surprise for us later on in
the episode but there is no reason the
face hugging parasites wouldn't be
mentioning her here since she is the one
most responsible for the changes in
their society is there more nope nope I
I guess uh that that's it just don't
gloro Earth so are these creatures
called gloro is gloro what they call
Morty or is gloro a verb because I'll be
God gloro if I can gloro out with the
gloro these face huggers are gloro about
are they like the Smurfs why haven't you
blinked uh for 20 minutes and why uh
doesn't your mouth move when you talk
they're just now noticing this these
creatures clearly have gloro for brains
geez you'd think Rick would have better
duct tape than this in that magic lab
coat he wears why are they keeping the
face hugger masks if they're fleeing the
planet it's as if Rick knows they might
forget something and have to come back
later and use them again Rick's tiny
spaceship apparently can take flight
even with something like 20 times
heavier attached to it
honestly I'm proud of us for not totally
it would have been cheap congratulating
yourself on not making a 911 joke which
actually by definition is still itself a
9/11 joke also I'm wondering why during
this entire Rampage Rick hasn't been
wearing his seat belt except this one
time here just before they see the not
World Trade Center and then when it
comes back he's not wearing it even
though it's the same background same
framing same everything did they animate
multiple takes pretending that the actor
who plays Rick had to go to the B at
some point and he forgot to put his seat
Bel back on so you did a 911 almost did
a 911 we we went with a Pearl Harbor
we're pretty classy in a moment of
Michael Bay versus Charlie Sheen I do
think Rick and Morty made the right
choice but not sure it's a moment to be
proud of I've been getting into
beekeeping lately there something wrong
with that wrong with beekeeping no but
there is something wrong with how long
it's taking you to slice those pancakes
who even uses a knife on a pancake are
they steak pancakes I mean what the
gloro I don't sequel It's called
Integrity then please please explain
interdimensional cable too so Rick's
wristwatch thingy is saying that summer
is underground and that's it how
unhelpful is this locator thing does it
even have directions Empress is
everything all right um sees them I
don't get why Rick can't put that shield
around them again and bring out some
other weapon that he probably has in
that lab coat but show's got to fill 22
minutes somehow I
guess who whoa who whoa whoo buddy I'm
just going to call this Deus X haraka
because why the does either of them have
a harmonica and it just so happens to be
the face hugger's weakness what took you
so long why the did you tell your
minions to seize them you've been on
enough Rick and Morty Adventures to know
that Rick would have gotten you out of
here without having to come up with some
wacky plan to escape you're in a cape
summer how bad could it be no bad story
ends with a cape Justice League does or
was I simply getting too close to garol
was garol consuming me Rick can we
listen to something else first off
people listen to anything surrounded by
other people who don't want to listen to
it without headphones I'm talking of you
dude at the airport on speaker phone and
woman watching YouTube with the volume
turned to 85 DB you know who you are
second off why doesn't Morty have his
own device with headphones I'm just
saying they're currently in a spaceship
I'm assuming the technology exists it's
a toothpick I'm a toothpick or now get
used to it God are you that desperate
for a thing this show is experiencing a
self-awareness crisis from the previous
episode that is spilled over into this
episode everything is being introduced
as a thing and someone has to comment on
it why couldn't the episode do something
where she simply needed the toothpick
because this toothpick is crucial to the
plot it's the only reason why face
huggers can't grab her later it is my
thing just like yours is dying alone how
can dying alone be a thing a thing is
something you do often dying alone is
something you do once maybe twice if
you're a Gemini how long have you been
hatched 30 seconds I've been alive 7
Minutes uh I've been here for 29 minutes
I'm getting heavy Meek vibes from these
things so all you do is live half an
hour eggs and die yes we love it Stephen
King presents Rick and Morty's dream
catcher okay you guys don't have to
listen to me but I vote you don't do
that and who's up for changing things
around here so wait all these other face
huggers that have been around long
enough to know what their purpose in
life is just accept summer suggestion
with no questions asked and they're able
to get everyone in town on board with
that plan how the do these things suck
the egg back into their bodies also why
do they do it they obviously don't know
who summer is so they don't know why
they should follow her also summer seems
to be without her toothpick all of the
sudden which I think is unwise
considering that's the reason she was
considered a God in the first place okay
there's at least a couple details in
this episode that I love the pencils and
gums stuck in the ceiling and the face
hugger paper dolls in the classroom
honestly summer I can't thank you enough
it's really weird that this Society
deifies summer but they don't put images
of her everywhere and give all the glory
to Steve Morty yeah I know there are
groups of fans out there who have been
dying for Rick and Morty to make out out
it's probably the number one requested
thing on all the chat boards but this is
one of those things that shows do where
they play on that thing that you really
want and it doesn't count it's like in
the xfiles movie when Moulder does CPR
on Scully and the filmmakers were able
to tease that their lips touch or when
James Earl Jones's voice comes out of
Maggie in one of those Simpsons
Halloween specials anyway I'm glad they
got the burning will they or won't they
question out of the way in season 4 now
maybe they can bring in cirst the
alley now that they're showing this part
again I've got to say this is the MC eer
of animated Xmas how the does that
tentacle get around the right side of
that stalactite when Morty walks to the
left of it it's not like the tentacle is
in a loop formation it's tightly
attached to his face and we shall drive
away from here and
die okay guess what everybody it's me
the whiny guy you never want to hear
from she's trying to escape with her
family my time to
shine this is what we get for evolving
I'm sorry we thought you were evil why
would you think that we had a giant
tower that blared gloro is peace I know
is there something missing from this
episode in the first part of the episode
that causes the conflict the missile
that they were supposed to send to the
Earth was going to send a bunch of face
huggers right their message may have
been peace but they were still going to
send parasites to a bunch of unwilling
hosts but before we get a chance to see
what it was going to do Rick throws it
into a building and it explodes this is
the most confusing part of the episode
because it's never spelled out what that
missile was going to do when it got to
the planet and it seems like Rick and
Morty were going to have to kill a lot
of these things to escape anyway so it
doesn't really matter if they were
peaceful or not so why is he apologizing
about killing them how is this guy still
alive hasn't the harmonica music reached
him yet I was working with a lot just
let me listen to the podcast next time
but the podcast had nothing to do with
why they ended up on this world can we
just relax and maybe watch some
interdimensional cable we don't need to
try so hard you know let's just take it
easy and riff you know hi for one we'll
be very happy when you guys leave the
Being John malovich stage and just go
ahead and make a an episode without so
much self- reference I mean it's kind of
cute like your dad keeps bees when the
heck was that was that some sort of
American Beauty parody Jerry's
beekeeping makes him attractive to
teenage
girls this opening foreshadowing is
fantastic this rat gets lit up by some
acid leaving only his bones totally
setting up a classic Rick and Morty
Adventure I almost parked I know driving
around in a spaceship is cool and all
but why does Rick even need the
spaceship anymore since he regularly
transports
uh-huh well I thought it was cool it was
also a great way to waste some time so
you could fill all 22 minutes of your
episode what is this face you're making
I mean it's pretty much the same face
Morty makes 100% of the time you tell
him something it's a combination of
exhaustion and disdain usually you
ignore it but this episode wants to set
up a relationship Tiff so now all of a
sudden you're Mr Sensitive shout out to
the props guy on set who loads the exact
amount of bottles in trash for Rick and
Morty to kick out every time they exit
Herby the space bug if this vehicle is
such a mess why is the only trash by the
door while I'm glad to see the hyrulean
economy has taken over the universe
there's no way Rick is dumb enough to
trade 10 red rupees for 10 green ones
the red ones are worth 10 times as much
how will you ever afford your
flamebreaker armor okay but does
anything beat fake crystals in a fake
arm maybe fake crystals a fake arm and
the wisdom to go ahead and keep shooting
until they're all dead also why are
Peter gory and Guilford Grimley even
holding guns if they aren't going to
shoot back these tubes have no regulator
to let the car carbon monoxide be
exhaled and I don't see any bubbles
coming from their noses I'm no expert
but this is clearly a Suffocation
machine guess he took his threat pretty
serious sound does not travel through
Mountain do this well and to be honest
bones don't float in it either of course
Rick could have invented some sort of
liquid modifier to give it the density
of acid that also has some sort of
acoustic transmission molecule or
something but my patience for BS tank is
running low so since when do they title
these episodes in the open this is like
the Simpsons bartk gets hit by a car
title that comes out out of nowhere
should we use a different vat does acid
lose its acid power the more it
dissolves what am I an acid olist I know
this extremely hilarious conversation
happens so that Rick and Morty will have
to stay down here a little bit longer
but if the idea of dropping their buddy
in the same vat of acid is potentially a
problem then why don't they just use one
of the many other Vats in the factory
it's funny they care so much but
seriously this is not a difficult
decision look I've watched the John Wick
movies and those movies clearly prove
that you can't fire laser dissolve
through faux acid water without at least
first priming the Xenon also there is no
way that Ladle was long enough to cover
this
distance you said not the rat the guy oh
Mar look at the size of the bones on
that rat sometimes things are so funny
they actually need multiple sins removed
also I love this gangster character so
much I want to remove a sin but then
Rick and Morty end up murdering these
guys I really hope that when he said
even if you kill me you're a dead man
that means he'll respond in another
episode but until then he's dead forever
and that is a
shame see now that wasn't that hard was
it maybe just do that the first time
okay also someone just give these guys
their own show I would watch a whole
three seasons of these gangsters
followed by a contract dispute that
leads to a split up fourth season just
to watch more of them I'm resining the
fact that you killed them but these guys
are the best oh was it worse than when I
was a pickle oh oh that's right you
weren't there for that turns out kind of
cool maybe there's a connection there
excuse me that cool thing you did
without me again the awesome thing I I I
guess you wanted a dragon I haven't seen
this much fan service callback humor
since Jeremy's College girlfriend
narrated The Prometheus School of not
lap dancing 40 seconds of logos I guess
the rest of the family went on vacation
does Rick regularly Park his spaceship
in the garage there are times when this
garage has cars in it and other times
there's nothing but Rick in his lab so
I'm wondering where he keeps the
spaceship in those moments there's no
such thing as a bad idea Morty it's
about execution while this episode is
mostly free from the last two episod
episod psychological self- evaluation
there are still a couple of moments in
this episode that have that hang up get
over it already save your place like in
a video game but in real life so that
you can try stuff and then go back to
your save point yes Morty I saw it on
future Rama and now the show is having
its South Park moment where it's worried
that it will do something that another
show did which became the basis for The
Simpsons already did it you even dragged
another Matt graining show into it I may
have never noticed this before but does
Rick keep a fire extinguisher way up
high on a shelf nearly Out Of Reach all
right class remember when Morty went to
school and had normal interactions with
daily life is it a bad sign when you're
having Nostalgia for the first season of
a show that's only in season 4 asking
for every show ever also I don't doubt
that this guy's class is probably the
worst math class you could ever witness
but I don't understand why there is a
two plus two equation on the board
unsolved nobody in this class is having
trouble with two plus freaking two are
they the show attempts to establish here
that as soon as Mory dies he resets to
his last save point but that's not what
we saw when Rick killed him earlier and
you may say that because Rick was the
one who pushed the button and I'll say
well doesn't that mean that it should
only reset if Rick died and you might
say it's still attached to Morty's DNA
somehow and the same person who sets it
has to reset it and then I'll say but
later Jerry resets a save point that
Morty started and you'll say it's just a
cartoon why do I care so much and I'll
say you're the one who started it man
and you'll say you're not Jeremy I don't
have to listen to you sorry I I may be
working some things out here my point is
the death reset thing is convenient and
unexplained can we carry
on trumping these examples of mundane
ways to Groundhog Day are hilarious ious
but if he's resetting when he misses why
are there scattered cheesy balls on the
table this turn into this long
relationship segment is exactly why I
will never give up on Rick and Morty
it's carefully constructed nuanced and
confident even though it remains
irreverent in crass sure you basically
know where it's going but it still
executes it beautifully take your sin
removal you Rascals you earned it having
said that it seems like Morty is so
Jessica obsessed that I don't understand
why he even takes an interest in this
girl he even knows he has Jessica on the
hook after he acted all aloof around her
a minute ago yes show we know how they
met we were watching remember this is
the show briefly going into self park
there is no way anybody knows where the
tail section of this plane is after that
crash much less created a detailed map
of the entire terrain if they did they'd
have already checked the tail of the
plane I guess the news didn't give a
Shir about the other survivors or the
other survivors died before the
helicopter could save them look I know
Jerry is dumb but I doubt he's I can't
recognize the difference between this
and the TV remote dumb also why is
Morty's bag on the side of the couch
open with the remote control sitting
neatly on top for this type of thing to
even happen so from the time just before
he met his new boo Morty never once set
a new save point like not even
accidentally dude went from resetting
cheese ball tosses to never resetting
anything cold turkey nope also I bet
you're kicking yourself for already
burning that Liv die Rick Pete episode
title huh I don't respect time travel if
Ant-Man and the WASP can do it I'm not
interested funny because just like
Ant-Man in in-game you depended on a
completely random and convenient button
push to move your plot along you just
substituted falling on your butt for a
random rat and now you're the very thing
you despise also didn't you shrink
yourself in one episode also also Rick
has crazy pop culture knowledge for a
guy who's always going on adventures
drinking and building inventions it
wasn't so much a doover as it was
isolating a moment in time splitting
your probable selves and shunting you
into a near duplicate equally probable
reality this goes by fast so let's sort
this out what Rick seems to be saying is
that at the exact moment Morty presses
the save button the remote looks for
parallel Dimensions happening in
concurrent real time that have the
previous safe Point moment just now
happening the problem is Morty was in a
relationship for several months which
means that when Jerry reset to that safe
Point Morty traveled to a universe where
all the same things that happened many
months ago in his Universe just started
happening in the new universe I thought
it was impossible to think of something
more confusing convenient and messy than
time travel but congratulations and even
so this means as many times as Morty
pushed the button and for all the
seconds hours days months that passed in
those moments have all actually passed
in his original Dimension without time
travel which we know Rick hates he's
been missing from his home family for
quite some time will the show ever deal
with this no does it matter garlic bread
that there was already a u in each
probable Dimension so we had to solve
for that by melting the previous Morty
doesn't that leave a dimension without a
Morty shouldn't they swap Dimensions how
does killing one of them even solve
anything also it's not like leaving a
burning pile of Morty goo in a dimension
really changes anything it's just a dead
Morty instead of a live one right it's
right you little it's the Prestige
you prestiged
yourself The Prestige being used as a
verb oh this is a great episode the
original split is still time stamped I
can make it so those mores never existed
at all wait what without time travel I
can't tell if the show knows it's
talking out of its butt or if it
actually thinks this makes sense and
that's not a good sign you live with the
consequences those things happen
somewhere but you can merge the probable
realities so that only one Morty did
them how can you merge all these
realities when a Morty died in half of
them not to mention all the ones were
doing one thing would have meant he
couldn't have done another thing wait so
so you're not even my Rick if this is a
parallel universe Rick that means there
are several other parallel universe
Morty who all challenge their Ricks to
build the same remote right there isn't
just one Morty who asked for this and
all the other parallel Morty just went
to the room instead of challenging Rick
to make this thing let's face it there
are so many versions of Morty doing this
that it would be an impossible mess to
clean up and when did this Rick figure
out that this wasn't his
Morty
so did the girl who became Morty's
girlfriend merge with all the other
versions of her who pepper sprayed him I
bet she's super confused about all this
right
now all right come on Morty let's go
home wait what this isn't our reality of
course not because Dimension portals are
this Show's get out of plot jail free
card also if that's the case where and
when did they enter this reality
according to my frustrated half
understanding of the concept it had to
be before he pushed the button the first
time right did he drag Morty to another
dimension while he was sleeping either
I'm not smart enough to comprehend these
compl complexities or this show is
shoveling so much nonsense on top of
nonsense that it hopes we don't notice
or both both could be true so Johnny
Carson is still alive and doing his show
at 95 Ed McMahon is 97 man Johnny Carson
really hated Jay Leno in this universe
didn't he our next guest uh gave us well
actually very little information uh
besides the fact that he is uh
impervious to acid so we put him on the
show without even rehearsing it because
that's how talk shows in this parallel
universe in 2020 work and that means
sci-fi bull is not right Rick uhhuh how
the did they get Rick to come along on
this trip I feel like if four seasons of
Rick and Morty taught me anything it's
that Rick will be willing to turn
himself into a pickle if necessary to
get out of stuff like this why are you
building a Faraday Box to block out the
signal thank you Morty for telling us
all what a Faraday Box is I mean I know
what it is but you know not everyone did
but also Morty has seen Rick build all
sorts of crazy things how did he
instantly know that Rick was building a
Faraday Box and not let's say a deadly
Jack in the Box or a box to hold hold a
bomb or gloro knows what else why go
through all the trouble of building a
Faraday Box if throwing the phone out
the window is an option and no I'm not
saying Faraday Box over and over so I
remember it I super already knew that it
was called a Faraday Box you know what's
really bugging me about this scene the
steering wheel seems to be very low
while yes this gives us a great view of
the car it would be chafing Jerry's legs
the entire drive I love this contraption
Rick is stalled into the station wagon
but is he attached to the door the back
seat doesn't come with him so what's
holding Rick up during this trans
position I hope you realize the tubing
permit was non-refundable relax Jerry
we'll be in and out in a minute all this
talk of lube and being in and out in a
minute reminds me of a what oh tubing
right oh man they got to Rick's baby
mama fast I was hoping they were going
to do a twisted take on the movie Lock
sex with a living planet big step for
mankind stop encouraging people to stick
their divining rods into Earth holes
doesn't anyone remember the 1999 penis
spurn epidemic after American Pie and
there are Critters in those Planet holes
come on guia Baby Big Daddy Rick is here
what's the problem the problem here is a
perfectly missed opportunity to show the
animator's ability to draw anything
other than a balls we've seen after
after hairy ball and when it comes time
to show the beauty that is the vulva we
get aing multi-tiered crater with a
sphincter in the middle are you kidding
me look at them they look just like you
they really really don't I mean just
because they have pointy hair doesn't
make them look like Rick the father
could be Lisa Simpson for all they know
got you baby going to need a little raw
iron and steam whatever you need baby
and then Rick summons a thing from the
station wagon and that's all it takes
apparently for Rick to build an entire
Factory out of this planet's womb Dad
can we please go back and hang out with
Grandpa's clay people why go back there
when you have the most interesting
mystery developing right in front of you
Jerry creates this murder stick for no
reason oh you think it's for roosting
marshmallows but nope he whips a metal
stabby tool out for that why is this
stick being whittel because if you move
the bar so low you might actually seem
like you're worth a jeez they turned
Jerry into this Show's Meg Griffin
didn't they they can Heap all sorts of
abuse on him without him fighting back
and is it funny you just end up feeling
sorry for the guy as dumb and listless
as he is I mean this kind of lashing out
would be reserve for a Jerry who
actually did Summer's friend from the
promus episode we got you guy guy shoot
him hard enough the middle shouting
unhelpful directions at the woman giving
birth with directions that are in fact
simply stating what she was already
doing penis fruit also if Rick and Beth
were going through all the trouble of
helping these clay Ricks achieve
fulfillment why confuse them from the
start with what the number two really is
is it a watermelon a pear why can't it
just be a number also we have a pie
chart with an actual pie on it and we
have another screen that shows how you
definitely don't play Tic-Tac-Toe sure
just give the O's the game X's it's not
like anybody bet all their life savings
on yet another draw why is the sign for
interns plural when everything else is
singular this might be the worst sin
Rick and Morty has ever committed I can
add an online college workaround or just
push them out through a pipe in the back
same thing ah I knew it wouldn't be long
before I had to remove a sin guess you
don't want to learn how to skip rocks
either the first step in skipping a rock
is to choose a rock that will Skip and
not immediately sink to the bottom of
the water the second step is to choose a
body of water that is still in lacks of
current and yeah maybe this is the joke
but if Jerry skipped Stones by selecting
tiny boulders to Chuck at Rivers he
wouldn't be interested in teaching his
kids because he would constantly fail at
this task also Jerry survives this this
series of blocks contain zero cubts okay
where did Jerry get a s'more he cooked
one earlier and gave it to Summer who
threw the onmore into the fires of
mountain dysfunction a couple minutes
ago does Jerry just have spare mores in
his bag I grant that this is something
that Jerry would do but I'm sinning It
Anyway also now that we've sin that
Jerry even should have one in the first
place let's discuss the fact that Jerry
is the sort of person who keeps an
unprotected s'more in his bag he is also
the sort of person who can pack the
fragile s'more in such a way that it
doesn't crumble even though he survived
a river Factory and fall so really I
don't know if I should respect him fear
Him or hate him what is that this this
is camping that is aing SM more well I
guess that seals it I hate Jerry there
you go guys pump those cheeks
encouraging incest also I guess it's a
standards and practices thing but if
these two really are pumping cheeks then
the lack of motion means they're doing
it wrong if I die don't eat my ass that'
be weird so you're boobs and vagina are
okay then by the way it would be awesome
if summer was ribbing Morty here for
actually eating human flesh in the last
episode if summer is going to be the
teenage girl version of Rick this would
have been a perfect opportunity for that
call back but it doesn't even seem this
episode knows what happened in the last
episode damn listen to those pipes you
sure these kids are yours what you've
never heard me sing karaoke well
everyone on Earth at this point should
be familiar with the events of get
schwifty in which you had to show an
alien what you got and what you got
ain't that you guys self- reference a
lot when it comes to your writing
anxieties but characters not remembering
things like that is crazy to me Shaboom
boom sorry sorry just trying to get the
hang of this thing who is he apologizing
to his family that would be dead right
now had the staff worked as he thought
it did oh sorry I didn't kill you in a
glorious fashion just then oopsie
Jerry you for real just try to smite me
Siri triangulate source of power did you
for real just use Siri to triangulate
this God's source of power jeez our
Communications companies are going to
know everything now you see my true form
the clouds were simply a shape more
appealing to gu's mine wait so why do
all of your kids look like the illusion
of you you look like Kid Rock Zeus does
anyone know who kid Rocky is anymore
mixing Zeus with Sophia pontelli
would make more sense and probably be a
more interesting Google search honestly
also looks like somebody got some
Deadpool in my Rick and Morty all right
motherucker let's go this goes on for
some time also the power of a God versus
a guy who has gadgets and knowledge of a
God and we're about to see a fist fight
way to DC Comics show this ship has
power also not only does it have power
they're able to get the ship off the
ground from this position and with a
bunch of roots and Vines running through
it
Jesus Christ was that the wings I think
it's the thrusters but no matter whether
it's wings or thrusters this ship
somehow gets into space you like these
plagues I'm unleashing on your asses we
never once get to see one of Jerry's
plagues even if they're as lame as best
says they are I want to see the full
brunt of Jerry's
plagues Maka X Deus show thinks that
Jerry can use his marshmallow rooster
thing to pull be out of the chasm and if
four seasons of this show has taught me
anything about Jerry show is
contradicting itself about Jerry this is
a another one of those weird animation
things the lava was so close to them
here that I don't know how they didn't
get melted by the lava before they climb
aboard the ship it's one of those things
where they're saved because the show
says they are and I refuse to accept
that see you put the fire stick to the
wood and voila campfire you have known
about this the whole time one of not
Rick's kids would be amazing at TV SS is
that all you want to say to your
children before you leave oh yeah about
that title childrick of mort it's a
Children of Men parody title I get that
and I get the childrick part I just
don't get the mort part unless it's some
clever nod to all the death in the
episode but you know how much I hate
acknowledging the French remember when
there were episode titles that didn't
need to fit the Rick or Morty in like
lawnmower dog they didn't call that lawn
Morty dog well I love this bit at the
end where Rick is scrolling through a
planet dating site I'm wondering what
planet would call themselves two r- f181
like they're content with the random
name some Earth scientist gave them oops
there's a hole in my ozone I didn't put
it there did you I can't fill it by
myself I'm not smart enough ayous ozone
Beth SM Beth Beth Beth Smith okay God
this it's just such a plain I'm trying
to come up with a pneumonic device true
facts before we released last week's TVs
video for Chri of Mo we called Beth Pam
on a couple of occasions it's hilarious
the show thinks Janet's name is
forgettable too I'm I am so sorry um uh
oh God starts why would space Beth shoot
him if she wanted him to tell your top
bugs the Defiance lives on why not just
write her name down on something if he
can't remember it congratulations to
your government business or teror cell
on its acquisition of the nx5 Planet
remover by Zama a in partnership with
Wrangler jeans the product placement is
funny and all but how many aliens out
there would be ones that would wear
jeans and even if they would Wrangler
doesn't seem like the type to affiliate
themselves with Planet destroying
Weaponry that really feels more like a
Levi thing don't you ever Miss Earth I
don't have to miss it I'm technically
still there my dad made a perfect clone
of me to take my place man Beth brings
up the fact that she has a clone with
very little prompting the question was
don't you ever Miss Earth and the first
words out of her mouth are I don't have
to miss it which makes no sense but
she's able to do a perfect triple axle
from that into by the way I have a clone
I am actually
disintegrating D is that really it we
did it I believe Jerry would be gullible
enough to think Rick disintegrated but
none of the rest of the family I don't
even know what this Gambit is supposed
to do in a post pickle Rick World other
than to provide the episode with a be
story Morty's making a big mess isn't he
I'm almost certain that the next time we
get a good look at this table we'll get
confirmation of oh it's like nothing
happened at all Rick probably did
something where where messes clean
themselves up in some other dimension or
something Rick creates this grid barrier
between he and Beth but I'm wondering
why this thing doesn't go all the way to
the ceiling why would you create a grid
with this kind of glaring
weakness okay have fun pumpkins wait
what does supposedly clone Beth have in
her neck that allows her to imitate Rick
perfectly she doesn't even have a
Tracker in there anymore not that it
matters is this how perfect impressions
are possible stick a finger in your neck
even if she had some sort of device in
her throat how does it know to imitate
Rick specifically okay fine this guy
uses military time on his alarm clock
but wasn't it just breakfast like a
minute ago we should still be in the
morning digits right also I will say
it's kind of interesting having the
typical invisible teenage male uses his
powers to be a creeper peeping Tom
switched around to an invisible woman
doing the same thing but a Peeping Tammy
would still be creeper is so I'm going
with a sin regardless so I'll just see
you at cheerleader practice this will
only be the second time Morty has used
an invention to spy on girls in the
locker room in the last three episodes
I'm surprised we haven't seen a Morty
Rick Possible episode where Morty tries
to spy on the girls by going through the
air vents how do you like that I
liked it more than my old belt you mean
your old belt that conveniently had a
similar blue circle on the Buckle just
like the invisibility belt did you mean
that belt holy crap what is happening in
this picture is this such a lurd picture
that the kid wearing a meth Gator shirt
is the least insane thing about it I
guess Rick and Morty have a deal with
shony too that's the only reason I can
think of that would possess someone to
go there to get their drink on I feel
like this is both a joke and product
placement like if we weren't in the
middle of a pandemic we'd mock this but
secretly go there when no one is looking
my daughter having Space Adventures this
packet sitting by Rick appears to be a
pink Sweet and Low knockoff and he's
drinking a beer what's that
[Music]
about they're trying to take over the
Galaxy everybody in the Galaxy tries to
take over the Galaxy the trick is to be
left alone by whoever succeeds this
coming from a man who is destroyed no
telling how many universes and even
recently impregnated an entire planet
that sounds like like the exact opposite
of laying low oh look they somehow got
Sun's TV into the shies the eye was
broken off when Woody Allen threw a
baseball at it during a ronin Pharaoh
report shower fire the shower's on fire
step aside girls I got this I guess
summer was just planning on fire
extinguishing the entire locker room to
find Morty but her convenient choice of
this spot is still
convenient show gives me irreversible
irreversible flashbacks Morty Smith
hands up if you can find Morty on a
random peeping trip why can't you find
his mom who's actually at the therapist
place at an appointed time the only
reason these guys show up to ask Morty
questions is so that summer and Morty
can overtake the ship and exmar Rick out
of a bad situation later Tam man for a
season that is making fun of sequels
rehashes and callbacks they sure are
producing a lot of sequels rehashes and
call backs I'm better than this job
Susan sandon self appraisal after her
first day on the set of Speed Racer
somehow makes its way into this episode
and who is that uh a clone when Rick
froze the Beth clone why wasn't he able
to put her in something more permanent
so that this confrontation wouldn't
happen wow naive and attractive wow
jaded and hot Clone Wars but if you stop
fighting you both get McDonald's how
about I just blow my brains out starting
with hers okay Wendy's we love Wendy's I
think they even gave us some money show
makes a joke about McDonald's just so
they can make a joke about their Wendy's
ads it's not enough that there's a
regular Wendy's commercial and a Rick
and Morty Wendy's commercial during the
broadcast but yet another mention in the
show itself they know if you're left
alone you're a non threat what how does
that even make the least bit of sense
once again he has destroyed so many
universes and recently impregnated aing
Planet it's not Citizen Kane but why
compete with whatever's going on here
you know I'm going with Star Wars meets
Starship Troopers meets my stepmother is
an alien what a crappy Death Star does
it really take this long to blow up a
planet the ghost of alderon is pissed
guess the Galaxy's Most Wanted mammal
needs her daddy to come change her diapy
come on kids we have to go do a piece of
sh Star Wars which they dropped the ball
on the title of this episode Rick turn
of the Jerry okay but shouldn't it have
been a play on Attack of the Clones oh
am I not a non-threat now I really want
to know how these portals work exactly
because there was a previous episode
where Morty was stuck with the gun and
Rick wasn't in the same universe and he
couldn't figure out how to get it to
work which means it's not something as
simple as thinking about where you want
each portal to lead so if there is some
kind of coordinate code that means Rick
just opened up nine portals to each of
these space bugs positions by hitting a
button on the gun a couple of times and
I'm calling glove glove on that looks
like summer went to the Fast and Furious
presents Hobson Shaw School of using a
dead or unconscious body for facial
recognition as I watch Rick once again
pull out a whole bunch of gadgets to get
into yet another fight I wonder why he
didn't use any of this stuff when he
fought that Zeus guy from childrick of
Mor yeah maybe he agreed on a no weapons
fist fight but Rick doesn't seem like
the kind of guy who cares about the
rules of combat some of Rick's extreme
body mods don't even make sense sure
building a panic room for your heart
keeps the heart itself from puncture but
those major entry and exit arav veines
are all still exposed and in the same
general area protecting the heart muscle
itself after a giant drill has breached
the entire chest cavity is so
ineffective that it's basically the
pullout method of interior Mech
technology how come some of the pants
the nx5 can't destroy Wrangler jeans
these product placement things are
amusing and tiresome at the same time
their tires amusing but what I really
want to know is how does one of the guys
not know about the nx5 is inability to
destroy Wrangler jeans maybe we could do
like a parat trap thing together
sometime as long as you mean Lindsay
Lohan version Haley Mills
shaming Rick survives this never thought
this was how I'd die we're nowhere near
Venice and you're not a dorf in a
raincoat don't Rick now it fascinates me
that an entire family can be this
critical and suck this much I don't even
know where to go here um the Kardashians
the Vander pumps the Christley I feel
like there's one obvious one that could
Trump all of these but I'm at a loss let
me give you some of this sweet ass
weekend at tamies
oh come on Phoenix person has a super
obvious onoff switch on his back why
Mory look at your little balls I know
momentary about your own kids balls also
please understand I am super happy this
scene does not contain Morty balls but
since I'm a sinner I've got to sin
that's what I do also also hugging your
son with his balls exposed jerk off's
ready to get the answers to your burning
questions yeah like where is the family
car do they park it at the end of the
street now remember clone Beth is just a
cartoon remember clone Beth is just a
cartoon just where is this secret room
supposed to be in the house this secret
room would be going directly into a
visible part of the house
somewhere Goodbye old friend just
because you're done with the
invisibility Belt doesn't mean you have
to throw it away why would you throw
something so mind-bogglingly useful out
for OT the garbage man to find
it but doesn't the tongue of the Belt
have to go into the buckle for it to
work and why would it make the entire
truck disappear wouldn't the Buckle only
be around a few items of trash and it
would make those disappear if this is
the way the belt works then everything
summer and Morty touched when they were
wearing it should have become invisible
not to mention Jerry's PE were we were
we blades in that one for the love of
Snipes how many times do I have to say
it keep it singular there's only one
blade also show never gives us the
context for any of this if it does it in
another episode fine I'll give back like
30 sins but for now I'm all horned up
for the alternate gem Dimension and the
show keeps rolling over insisting it has
a
headache hello Morty gets cell phone
reception in space meanwhile I lose
connection anytime in nearby SC farts
don't ask me how I know I just know okay
painting your toenails on your bed with
no towel or any kind of protection
underneath yeah that's a great point the
3D holographic warning system however is
operating at full capacity I'd
appreciate the detail in this call
screen except that your screen darkens
when you have it next to your face so
there's really no reason for it to be
showing anyway look at all that work you
did for nothing Rick and Morty do you
feel ashamed come on come on this works
you touch the ocean Morty technically
the ship is touching the ocean Rick and
Morty are still in said ship so I don't
see how the treaty we're about to find
out about with Mr nimus has been broken
Kaboom you've been lawyered now face the
wrath of your once and eternal foe Mr
Nimbus sorry who is that my Nemesis
Nimbus Nemesis never named noted nor
noticed until now noteworthy nemeses
name non-stop normally this Nimbus
Nimrod not nearly known enough for
Nemesis nomination I am Mr Nimbus he's
going to say that a lot I mean I would
too if that was my name it's Mr Nim it's
a lot better than neyar uses magic Ray
to double the length of the table but
has to use a cloth to clean up the wine
spill sure why not is Nemesis Rick has a
nemesis Rick and Morty is clearly poking
fun at shows that introduced some random
pivotal character in a later season such
as cousin Oliver And The Brady Bunch or
Eli Scruggs on Desperate Housewives but
Rick and Morty is only so good at poking
fun at these tropes because they're too
guilty of using these tropes it's the
classic comedy Trope ad dope and we
ain't falling for it Rick and Morty
summer is going to dive into the
marana's trench to recover The Forbidden
shell that gives him his power allowing
your granddaughter to dive into the
maranis trench to recover The Forbidden
shell that gives Mr nimus his power
without her parents explicit consent so
time moves faster in there it's like a
Narnia thing I'm not a beaver who
believes in Jesus Christ Morty I think
they call them Bel beavers they're a
distant cousin to the Believers it's a
long story also he didn't ask if you
were a narni and just if it was like
Narnia in there I don't know man all
that defensiveness probably means you
want to believe in Jesus or be a beaver
it's probably the beaver thing Mr Nimbus
is an ice cold killer Morty pretty sure
Morty already experienced the ice cold
killer sensation a few minutes ago when
Jerry and Beth declared their love of
porn to him police a strange horny ocean
man is on my lawn horny cuz he wears a
speedo likes to moisturize move
sensually just cuz he's sexy doesn't
make him horny Jerry project much
fight flee jeez nimus sums up the
entirety of the human relationship cycle
in 5 seconds I don't know whether to
take a sent off for the intense but
hilarious depth or SOB in the corner
contemplating the mundanity of my
existence in other words yeah it's a
Rick and Morty episode leaving the
recliner chair reclined patricide fine
whatever terms term number one how does
nimus not hear this he's right across
the table I accidentally had a video
playing with similar noises across the
table one time and now I'm disinvited
from family Thanksgiving also where is
this camera exactly and did Rick plant
it and if Rick did plan it why didn't he
just grab the Forbidden shell while he
was down there I thought you already
went I did I just just got a little busy
why would you make up a lie that makes
you look bad when the truth would make
more sense and take the blame off of you
yeah I got it but the adults wanted all
of it Bing Bang Boom time to suck face
where is your wine boy Richard I thirst
he's getting it now I'm not sure why
Rick thinks this because he didn't ask
Morty to get more wine what if it gets
weird even just contemplating having sex
with the fish guy already puts this in
the weird category so you might as well
just go all in at this point
Jerry the wine survives this centuries
of this isn't every in beginning stay
back I don't want your stripped down
Sundance sci-fi
oh Rick and Mory how I have
missed you take your sin back for just
being you old friend can you believe he
bought that tree bullsh easier than I
can believe they've been running the
simulation non-stop all these years just
waiting on Morty to return but sure yeah
go for it make us slightly more wet
title of my sex tape I just took some
wine I said I was sorry what the is
wrong with you people but it was Morty's
wine to take so why does he think that
that's the issue here he realized is
he's killed a lot of their people right
uh it is Morty though so I guess maybe
he doesn't realize this Frozen in Time
Forever asleep and exactly how long has
forever been again Morty leaves one time
and comes back a decade later but
another time it seems Millennia have
passed if you think I'm not going to
send your inconsistent portal time
passage rules just because you didn't
officially establish any you have
severely underestimated my willingness
to stretch for a sin why did I clone
myself weird hoovie clone guy would be
excellent at TV SS let me d x mocking of
this and let's go home I believe you
mean Deus X Rina you're going to try to
be all excellent at TV SS and such at
least throw a portm in there to pretend
to keep it
fresh oh that's cool why because it has
a setting that disintegrates all
clothing except the parts covering the
genitals I'd go with convenient or
prudish prud venient did you think I
would let you die alone
Richard pelvis x junken a see that's how
it's done yes time I had nothing but
time but
while Rick wi is in paint at this
nutshot I feel the need to point out
that he's been standing here
nonchalantly ignoring chunks of flesh
out of his body either you feel pain or
you don't Rick you can't have it both
ways you two are hungry yep good thing
you made a fresh plate of I'm going to
say strained orange pulp mashed potatoes
with Amber food coloring a pile of Sunny
D slushy I'm not sure what it is but
don't you try to pull off that vomitous
Mass's eggs you know better can can I
kill God summer summer took out an
onslaught of underwater foes in the
previous episode how would she not be
useful when going to battle anyone and
sure she's a clone so maybe that wasn't
this summer but it's too early in this
episode to know that sweetie don't get
all worked up before your job interview
job interview show doesn't resolve this
I mean I know that's the point but you
can almost hear the audible Glee in the
writer's room when they're like let's
introduce b-plot hanging thread so we
can troll the audience with this
ultimately meaningless episode and you
know how much I hate threads and things
that are hanging so Jerry Morty are shot
side by side but in the overhead view
they're now separated by a table and hey
where did that juicy plate of not eggs
go oh no they died this show has killed
its main character so much that caring
about them is like eating your eighth
piece of pizza I mean you still like
pizza and all but at that point you've
eaten too much but also once you get to
eight is nine really going to make that
much of a difference so you stuff it
down like the meaningless hunk of matter
it is and wonder if anything even means
anything anymore hunt me hunt me
somebody hunt me if sweaty Death Wish
here truly wanted to be hunted he'd be
hiding in a bit more stealth what he
should be saying is Chase me Chase me or
kill me kill me I Mr always wants to be
hunted yes and how interesting did you
think that would stay show then proceeds
to hunt itself for the next 20 some
minutes making another self-referential
dig which in turn makes my job even
harder so dang it I shall golf well I
don't see any Stakes at all summary of
the biggest issue with Rick and Morty at
this point somehow makes it into the
episode and by somehow I mean the
writers intentionally put it there as a
meta wink to self- diffuse any criticism
because they probably think it's not a
bug it's a feature but in either case it
is a sin so the new family we think is
our family suddenly dies and I guess
this is the part where I remember that
it isn't a new season of Rick and Morty
until we have a good old game of for
Smith Monty the only explanation is to
how this green car missed the arrival of
a spacecraft and the obliteration of the
adjacent vehicle is distracted driving
put your phones away people holy crap is
Morty called me by your naming at the
age of 14 when the outside grows on the
inside and then reaches back outside
your plan addiction has gone too far how
many lavender shirts does one person who
only wears Coral shirts need this armor
somehow flattens the basketball hoop on
the garage without it moving folding or
pieces of it flying off and also leaves
large sections of the roof and walls
unprotected Rick would suck at Purge
survival is all I'm saying decided it
was maybe better as a kind of kinetic
mislead for another special episode jeez
Rick and mor sew up its own ass with his
fourth wall destruction and I swear an
episode in season six will just be a
static camera filming the actual actor's
table read it will be so clever but then
eat people yeah during this scene I
thought oh interesting I'm eating
popcorn too and then as each murder
devolves into organs and viscous
explosions my level of popcorn enjoyment
began to wne this is a sin for me
forgetting to never eat while watching
this show I'm not looking at your ass
public beaches summer you idiot
calling your granddaughter an idiot
while concurrently exposing your in her
Direction Jerry come on family emergency
a bigger emergency than my lemon square
is not setting you mean those lemon
squares that appear to be stacked nicely
on top of each other indicating that
they have indeed set pretty well all
right we've seen enough of these decoy
houses to ask the question are we really
suggesting that all these decoys have
been set up with not only identical
houses but an identical neighborhoods
and most importantly why do they all
have the driveway crack from when the
house was removed and replaced in season
1 I think you got the wrong house bro
analysis mode password
80085 kind of expected a funnier
password I kind of expected a rick would
have shot another Rick in the head
already in the time it took him to make
that password boobs joke are the golden
circles the decoys or the concentric
circles and why is there no text on the
map so we can point out in consistencies
this map is confusing and is hindering
my ability to do my intended job of
actually pointing out real sins instead
of just making jokes or hindering my
ability to make jokes instead of just
pointing out real sins depending on who
you listen to analysis mode
80085 H but if these aren't this Rick's
decoys then why were they on this Rick's
terrible map analysis mode password 8
equal sign equal sign capital D honestly
the vertical Bar number three works
better than most fonts go ahead and
throw in a few more equal signs while
you're at it am I right fellas were you
say anything they were already killing
each other and you saw that through two
walls also three spaceships a lava gun a
house engulfed in flames and exactly
zero nosy neighbors Jo doesn't know how
to suburb correctly connory plays the
Spaniard but does nothing about his
accent presume decoy Rick would be
excellent at Cinema Sins on TV sins I
say we split up some of us take down
squids while the rest of be stories will
have the track simultaneously no thank
you D and D conversations why are we
wearing these better question where
where did you get these do they have an
assortment of fabrics and foam to
construct these costumes did they make a
stop at the fabric store there's one
conveniently why is Jerry even holding
an active bomb after the crash is it in
any way in Jerry's character to be aware
of how to do something like this or even
want to do it in the first place it's
either accidentally convenient or out of
character and C is hungry today so Feast
syny Feast how exactly are these
restraints containing the Smiths they
have room to breathe they have room to
wriggle out the top of these things
can't kill you yet the skin needs to be
be fresh so why peel the skin off at all
if the skin is removed from its blood
supply it likely start to die pretty
quickly the peeled skin is already
unfresh is what I'm saying also you
can't simply banana someone and still
leave the victim alive it at least
that's what Jeremy told me come on
there's a place we can go and despite
knowing that all the Clones sorry decoys
would also be somewhat programmed to
want to kill each other they do in fact
go is this decoy missing his pickle Rick
it doesn't appear that Mr Skin cut it
off and you can't spell decoy without
the D what about the squids the summers
are going to explain that the squids
were decoys who realized they were
decoys and wanted to kill the other
decoys and sure sure fine whatever but
in a world of apparently countless
decoys have none of them died before now
to start this azimoff Cascade have you
met Jerry like 12% of Jerry's die within
the first year of existence an
absolutely pendulous ball I mean is that
something anyone wants now the only way
to prove I'm real and not him is to Isis
expository ass self-referential Asos The
Shield lowers and somehow this version
of the family is battle guard and
bruised which seems unlikely because
their Shield has been protecting them up
until now and also in the previous shot
they were completely normal I'll just
point out once again that no one outside
of the Smith family seems to be
interested in this insane activity
happening all around them not one
civilian passing cars straight animals
police officer or really anyone is
alarmed by what is happening in these
streets you want to get in one more I
Told You So about synthetic life or
whatever this week's theme is how are
these mouths moving Big Bird's mouth
moved because one of the puppeteers arms
was actually moving his head instead of
Big Bird's other arm but clearly both
arms are functioning here as gestures
around so what moves the mouth I want to
say technology I want to believe
technology and I think it's just
convenient animation because those heads
are as Hollow as a presidential promise
happen Rick survives this I think or
decoy Rick maybe survives whatever this
is someone survives something that much
I'm sure ha both Jerry's stop fighting
to
hug Hunty M here one shot fatalities the
entire Smith family but only wounds Rick
for for reasons and did you just bleep
oh yeah I hear it now you should have
hunted me what who since the show
apparently wants to sin itself I'll let
Rick handle it from here were were you
significant like like did we tee you up
you want to be hunted God I have so many
[Music]
questions decoy decoys decoys decoy
decoy decoys decoy decoy decoy decoy
decoy decoys decoys Deco decoys decoys
decoys decoys decoys decoys decoys
decoys decoys decoys decoys decoys decoy
Deco decoy decoy decoys decoy decoy
decoy decoy decoy decoy decoy decoy
decoy decoy decoy decoys decoys decoys
decoys decoys decoys the decoys decoys
Deco decoys decoys decoys decoys decoys
decoys decoys decoy decoy decoy Deco
Deco decoy decoy Deco Deco decoy decoy
decoy decoy decoy say decoy
again this might be bold but I'm going
to have to remove a sin before we even
start this dog here fishing for a
t-shirt that says compliments only is a
great visual gag look man game respects
game however as the sin Lords do giveth
they equally doth taketh away there's
absolutely no need to censor the word
Patty here Hells yeah iing love merch
okay show when you say you love merch
and you fla a shirt you sell it we have
a new promethus shirt we showed off in a
video recently it's also available in
our store whereas I scrolled through
five pages of shirts only discovered
that this shirt isn't even available you
know though now that I really think
about it they really did spare me a lot
of horrible looks at the Sunday buffet
Rush my acid rain will destroy all
things green and natural but not the
very natural skin of the diesel weasel
or its very natural body parts in
general those are immune for reasons
there's only one solution for Earth's
pollution you plantina looks straight to
camera as if she has a Polar Ice Cap's
chance in hell of changing the lifestyle
habits of an audience which is currently
juggling their freehand from a Reddit
scroll an energy drink and their own
personal yosity
shirt what the was that kidnapping also
that was an obvious ripoff of Captain
Planet and by your powers combined I
will not have our childhood hero mocked
go Planet tears Mother Nature has
Enlisted the help of four young adults
from each major ethnicity that's
actually not racist but the way the show
pokes fun of it might be great Taylor
Murphy dumps me the day before his hella
big pool party and my little brother's
dating a phase 4 superhero um actually
summer I think you'll find that plantina
can't even be in phase four because she
isn't even in the MCU Cannon I mean she
doesn't even
appear just shoot me in theing head
until I die a comment that is very
triggering while simultaneously
meaningless after that decoy
episode what in the name of sweet baby
meix is going on with Jerry's breakfast
how do he expect to eat this softboiled
egg if his toast isn't pre-cut into
strips ready for dipping he can't afford
to cut the toast now every second he
wastes the gooey egg interior is slowly
solidifying also the egg wasn't even
cooked and why didn't he rescue the
toast why is breakfast three planets are
all ending in a delayed succession
surely there must be a multitude of
cataclysmic events befalling a plethora
of planets Across the Universe if Rick
really wanted to go on a doomed Planet
Bar Crawl isn't his ship fast enough to
prevent their proximity to each other
from being the limiting factor or
failing this couldn't he use his oh I
don't know portal gun if you don't want
to help me I'll find my own goddamn way
to the
Wildfire kids Tina girl have you gained
weight well I had a plant-based donut
yesterday just a half sugar is worst
thing for figure darling I don't know
what's worse about this exchange the
fact that Tina is being fat shamed for
eating a donut or that said donut was
plant-based I'm going to send both just
to be safe this is freaking you out huh
no what's freaking me out is this phone
fitting into that pocket so are you two
dating asking this question to a
kid bonding with your grandparent over
and I can't believe I'm going to say
this while in the don't look now but
someone's giving you the big eye what in
a sea of aliens with big eyes all
staring at them on the party float you
don't say ready right meet me at the car
calling a ship a car one of these has to
be hers where'd she go where' the purses
come from they left away seconds ago and
returned with 50 bags were they having
sex next to the lost and found room also
why would a race of aliens bring their
purses to an end of the world orgy and
then abandon them at the bar money would
be meaningless identification pointless
and whatever other products you keep in
your bag you kind of want to have them
on your person right also also many of
these purses are shoulder length and I
think their sensitive elbow orices would
rub up on the bag and either over
stimulate or chafe or both me why does
this make me think of these things how
do you let someone permanently tattoo
the wrong Arrow directions on your body
I mean you're literally wearing the
reference on your chest so you know
better idiots step her away going wait
isn't it interesting how they can summon
plantina and whatever she is holding but
can also force her to be dismissed
without the item she holds this spell
was obviously crafted by the Dark Lord
that rules plots in the world of
convenience this really must be the
greatest party in the universe this
guy's loving it so much he duplicated
himself so he can enjoy it from 12
different perspectives neat he oh Lots
honey calling a woman honey actually
calling anyone honey you don't even know
me Kristen from Denny's oh that's how
you smoke marijuana I mean I of course
knew that because I smoke the reefer all
the time wow how about this weather sure
is unseasonably warm tonight what is
this mop made of that would allow it to
break a storage shelf and obliterate a
container what are Morty's teeth made of
that would allow him to instantly bite
off a finger what are his lips made of
that he could blast a Firebolt out of
his mouth without any singing
fire fire we've seen enough of these now
that I really shouldn't be surprised by
how quickly and remorselessly Morty
turns to murder and yet his phone keep
going to voicemail his phone has been
ringing for a minute and 43 seconds
before going to voicemail what sort of
hell hole are they living in they should
be relieved by their impending deaths
also voicemail which one of you ordered
a pizza no one order pizza what is this
not ordering pizza is always a sin Morty
shows up in a murder pie hat and my
question is did he swipe a hat from a
local pizzeria with that name or did he
stop at a hat embroidery store and have
this whipped up for just such an
occasion imagine either being so dumb or
having so little regard for human life
that you repeatedly machine gun your
boss just because your intended target
ran behind her air I've never had a
magical ring streaming air forced into
my mouth before but let's say I had I
truly believe my instinct would be to
keep my mouth open rather than create an
unimaginably Tight Seal around said
ring not oh I'm not a fan of gratuitous
murder but this right here gets my seal
of approval sorry I've been harboring
that one for a while okay I'll stop
now why we small consolation but the
soon to be dead SL of Aran would be
great at TV Sins not keeping your eyes
on the road while driving through what
appears to be an asteroid field that's
right girlfriend this is what you're up
against elbow hemorrhoids elron prolapse
best seta elbow titties on more gluts
okay hitting your funny bone under any
circumstances is Agony but I can't begin
to imagine how painful it would be to
accidentally catch these L boobies on
say the corner of a table you know what
I have someone I could check with hey
Den yes how much would that hurt it
would suck yeah that sounds right thanks
you're welcome weirdos then I put my
sunglasses on and walked out like
nothing happened what a romantic story
about our son killing a room full of
people I don't care if they were
technically in self-defense Morty just
admitted to mult multiple murders while
casually playing whatever the fork this
board game is and no one cares and no
Jerry and Beth that quip in those mildly
withering stairs do not count as
disapproval I only want to spend as much
time as possible with your son my son is
14 Miss I'm really glad that someone is
finally addressing the underaged
elephant in the room but why is Beth a
the only person to realize that this is
sick and wrong and B more outrage by
this than all of the recently described
boner induced blood lust there's only
one solution for Earth solution whatever
that solution is I'm fairly certain it
lays somewhere on the Spectrum after
rhyming couplets but way before multiple
homicides no Morty is crushed and runs
away because pla's current body count is
25% higher than his competitive
relationships like this are so toxic
this gay sex with my dad is terrific
paternal sodomy pomy so D you know what
there's just some places I will not dip
my portmantos in
oh gross now you're grossed out summer
this is what's pushed you over the line
not the incest not the El boobs not
whatever the this was swimming through
these bodies and kicking this gropey
tentacle is what really took the biscuit
for
you this works so why the wasn't it plan
a is genocide really a palatable price
to pay for the sake of Rick's Party
boner
H let me just grab my phone here
um although both can be cloa bearing
this CR drawing is clearly a frog which
is an amphibian not a
reptile cap should have antenna caps No
Cap so Beth is standing at the washing
Station Washing this bloody body part
which she then throws away she turns
back to the water to wash the blood off
her gloves but why wash your gloves at
all when one you're just going to throw
them away and two you should be washing
your hands okay but we've been here for
hours I don't want to hang out at the
stupid horse Hospital kids what's this
thing that's a breeding Mount how are
you communicating so clearly with
someone who has Departed the room
entirely and if the walls are so thin
how does Beth not hear Morty flip on the
bang bang bop bop machine I can't
believe I'm going to ask this question
but since we find out soon Morty is
going to the boow Jacker how exactly
does he get his Morty Jr into it he's
practically at eye level with the entry
point drinking directly from the carton
while on a lawn chair sitting on a
slanted roof come on yeah because
rolling a barrel of a horse Sean from
the street is much easier than backing
up the station wagon to The Garage
Reading from a great distance away you
know that race of underground dwelling
cannibal horse people that were always
fighting yeah the chuds what about them
you can't just take an acronym that has
already situated itself in previous pop
culture and make it your own and how
would the acronym even work in this form
cannibalistic horse underground dwellers
it doesn't roll off the tongue in a
meaningful or fun way cud might be a
terrible movie but it got here first
also what the is up with the security at
this horse hospital no one here finds
out a kid is mounting the horse juicer
why don't you trust labels all right
fine I won't test it wait what since
when does Rick give into Morty's
hysterics or even trust labels God damn
your generation really picks random
Hills to die on Zoomers can you give me
a minute I'm trying to steer around the
bodies of our neighbors oh that felt
like Jean knowing your neighbors by the
sound their body makes when you run over
them space sperm sperm from space is
anything a stretch for the Smith family
they've seen countless unexplainable
things up to this point so this newest
shenanigan should end in a casual shrug
this is the greatest country on Earth it
is is not don't blame me I'm just
quoting Jeff Daniels hello hello sorry
I'm late oh look a fumbling disheveled
an awkward scientist cliche neat how do
we deal with these orgasa goblins who's
going to tell the writers that sperm and
orgasms are not synonymous just because
he oomph doesn't mean she zooms it's a
fine suggestion but I doubt their leader
will be a sexy queen that needs to be
kick booxed sexy sperm Queen
foreshadowing says Queen shadowing
squeen Zig zigging Rick and Morty
survive this no you're getting Dumber
because that's a tree I guess the show
has time to discuss the difference
between a trebuchet and a catapult but
not concern itself about the giant hole
in the aircraft right to the top just
the way you like it except the water
isn't to the top get this guy a Nobel
Prize you became a woman
today yeah that checks I was so wrong
about this guy he didn't even buy us any
time well maybe run away instead of
watching someone attempt to be both the
six and the nine the stalling is really
on you Rick silence in the presence of
me I am the sperm Queen I don't even
need to question this one title of my
sex tape in fact a lot of dialogue could
fall under many of my titles space sperm
sperm from space damn they must be huge
why would the sperm go to the Grand
Canyon we'll use it as a placeholder and
beat it later right to the top just the
way you like it I I know how to myself
you need more than that dummy you need a
horse hand job solo How did Dan Haron
get a hold of my stash I don't know
whether to be ashamed or Overjoyed why
do you have the horse jerk off machine
for my daughter's Hospital it's kind of
weird that Rick knows for certain this
breeding machine is the one in Beth's
workplace no oh but our stallion is
already here I get that Morty created
all of them in the first place but do
they really need Morty to continue their
race every sperm person could be
eligible for this very disgusting highly
sticky nightmare inducing situation that
I'm totally not signing up for a chance
to experience myself what was it like
fantastic asking your grandson how his
sexual experience went sorry I just
thought maybe I could have repeated sex
with the horse machine without it
becoming Armageddon you and me both
Morty you and me both oh sh did I say
that out loud what did you do I got out
of your
eyeline this show man you can't beat me
you didn't bring a woman that could
kickbox totally fair but also kickbox my
hands are tied for a perimeter protect
that egg at all costs or and this might
be crazy shoot the egg and destroy it
you slept with my daughter I did oh
I did chesal you come to the kingdom of
chuds for forgiveness um technically
Rick and Morty were kidnapped to the
kingdom of cuds so they didn't come here
willingly to do anything chuds don't
forgive humans chuds eat humans this is
out there even for us it is not right I
I love you too princess petta
lying where did you get all that and why
aren't they spraying it on the egg take
three steps back amazing Jonathan show
proposes the idea that the president of
the United States would know who the
amazing Jonathan is let's Nancy Reagan
this I would say that none of this
hopping from sperm to sperm should work
but really we could just say that about
the entirety of this show Mom I promise
to use condoms even when it's butt stuff
okay we have a lot to talk about tonight
waiting this long to talk to your kid
about butt stuff always be honest
sometimes it will hurt people sometimes
it will help but always be honest Sports
Illustrated Kathy Ireland is making a
lot of sense I don't think we
appreciated Sports Illustrated Kathy
Ireland enough in her Heyday and that's
100% of sin a giant incest baby in Bas
still makes more sense than 2001 I guess
Jerry can you watch the kids tonight oh
um no we can't watch the kids it's guys
night not telling anyone else how to
parent but why is Beth even asking Jerry
to watch the kids Summer's old enough to
watch Morty and they've left the home
alone before in Prior episodes I'm just
saying this feels like a purely
arbitrary way to get Beth involved in
some hell raising activities later on in
the show also this dartboard location
are you sure that's where the grapes go
Morty because I feel like they'd feel
more at home beside that fruit bowl that
we've Sinn before four for being in a
ridiculous place in the living room and
we will keep sinning until theying
remove it and they're all crowning I
have to go show leaves the achieving the
rare Triple Crown joke in the stable
yeah most people would call that
family you're so gross you have to like
it or you're sexist that's flatulist I'm
not sure if this creature has a tongue
pen or a mouth Gina but either way this
pen Gina dentata is getting us in hey
we're in luck gang they've got the
entire Smashmouth catalog Smashmouth
shaming what they had that song you know
the one there was hanging now and they
couldn't get enough of their baby and
and yeah they were putting your feet on
your eating surface with shoes on is
that classic snake boy that guy just
keeps getting bigger commenting on Bruce
snake dude this plays it
close to the vest thinking running tap
water will drown out the sound of you
talking about someone in the Next Room
nuh uhuh nuh uhuh I said don't touch my
sh also I just watched Jurassic Park on
cable explaining your references you
could be brilliant Rick and Morty but
you're a coward Black Swan seriously
though touch my and I'll freeze your
Amber so how exactly would that threat
stop Summer from touching his which
means Rick is going to die because of
you unless you you go offline this
computes this computes bowow oh yeah as
much as this buers on for some time I'm
surprised the title of this episode
wasn't rickus mortler Rick day off Morty
why would a mailbox society live in
Building shaped like mailboxes if it
were a letter or package Society sure
but do humans design houses that look
like giant humans dogs maybe but not not
humans
beautiful going postal summer Morty and
chatback survive this why is it that
whenever the Smith Springs some Rando on
one of these Adventures said Rando is
never freaking the out chatback should
be chut backing his pants right now or
at the very least asking how the they're
flying in space except I don't get
pleasure from mocking others because I'm
not
lame uh no sin here just really great
show being really great I mean I have
add a sin or C won't move on but we're
totally not lame
next what is that essence of Hell how
did they get this drink or these cups
they didn't have any of this on them
when they enter through the Hellgate I'm
not sure what's going on here but I am
sure that Morty needs more water intake
looks like he's peeing orange juice I
hope it's at least pulp free what the
hell bro thing I say every time there's
more than three clasps doneo somehow
makes it into the episode why would I
like a change forer I'm the most
powerful car in the universe and what
that means you don't have feelings
actually yes it does it's a car I am a
car not a robot wrong you're both a
robot's simply a computer that can
transport itself and do tasks which you
can you could have said you aren't an
Android since that has more of a human
connotation or you could have said you
aren't a change forer since that has
more of a don't sue us I swear they
aren't Transformers connotation isn't a
doorknob a virgin not
mine what do you expect I mean she's my
wife I almost want to take a sent off
for the show pointing out that Borat
isn't all that funny but then again this
made me think of how unfunny Borat is
and that irritated me so Jerry's the
best talking about someone in the
bathroom not realizing said someone is
in the stall and can hear everything
being said cliche also how did they not
realize Jerry was in the bathroom these
two were outside when he said he had to
go pee after a weak rif with a Fetter of
sin I yearn for a taste of his cringe
sitting episodes of The Office casually
dining while face peeled hell spawner
around this is going to lose this place
at least one of its Michelin stars
remember Beth is just a cartoon remember
Beth is just a cartoon remember Beth
also there's not nearly explanation
enough for how Rick has created these
outfits is Beth really bleeding did they
stop at a costume store does Rick really
have a hole in his midsection now is he
wearing a Marlin a Marlin there's no
Marlins in baseball I mean hell oh it's
painful so I love it this pleasure
equals pain equals pleasure diet tribe
goes on for all the some time I think
the statute to citations is about up on
sending Rick and Morty producing complex
devices out of thin air like this arm
Cannon so in order not to let it slip by
I'll just point out that something can't
come from nothing something has to come
from something and you can yell
nanotechnology all you want and it still
doesn't make it any less of a cheat
zippers near genitals and yes I'm aware
most pants already have this it was
always a bad idea see cringe cannot
exist in a vacuum it needs to be
observed the TV SS motto somehow makes
its way into this episode like what I
did with the chip in her head she going
to be okay summer is concerned about not
Alice and Hanigan but not the sentian
alien mailboxes she obliterated earlier
could this be the end of mous trap the
apples I mean one can help but because
of Wiki fan pages and fanfiction I'm
guessing
not sorry I farted the rare fart joke
bookends look when you bookend with back
end I got to give some respect and by
respect I mean since the lasers seem
awfully close to the large American flag
what if there's a draft sure leave these
cameras operational but shoot the others
with utter snot makes total sense
Morty's laser Canon is AED upward but by
the time the beam takes out a bell in
Liberty it has managed to shift
trajectory enough to cause me to send
every possible person place or thing
that was in the line of this plot shot
also with weapons like that it almost
makes you wonder why taking out any of
the other decoy families or sperm
monsters in previous episodes was a big
deal at all was a trojan horse Morty
never trust the French that's rist once
again all kinds of going down at the
Smith's house and there are no nosy
neighbors to be seen has anyone that
works on this show lived in the suburbs
there'd be like a watch party barbecue
going on next door with at least 20 to
30 people in attendance there' probably
even be a bounce house rented to keep
the kids occupied well Happy
Thanksgiving to me celebrating yourself
can't wait to see what a shimmer does to
my prostate shimmering your prostate I
don't even know what that means but
certainly it's sinful synchronized
digital Exposition syn digital
position coupe not on Thanksgiving how
would she know who was calling Coupe
does he have a specific vibration
pattern for turkey time that little race
car driver you got bacon in your belly
what world you want him rearing up in
parental
predestination what happened to the
clothes they were wearing did they meld
into the skin of the turkey because when
they get turned back into humans later
they're no longer wearing the clothes
yeah yeah it's cartoon blah blah blah
but have you watched this channel before
all due respect sir I know flesh when I
see it those flesh covered robots should
buy us some time but where did Rick get
the flesh you know what some things are
okay to be left un said I'll still send
it for lack of explanation but I'll be
okay not knowing about Rick's leather
face practices ship goes stealth but
only after flying directly overhead so
we can clearly see where you are in
relation to your mission and forget
about asking how the ship escaped the
bubble back home unnoticed we don't ask
those kinds of obvious plot hole
questions anymore huh turkey Marines the
president came to play but you knew this
already right I mean you did the entire
expositional plan thing and even showed
fully armed Marines who won't recognize
me so why is shock let it be known that
it cannot be an official episode of Rick
and Morty until a questionable egg dish
has been placed on their dining room
table huh that's weird ID chips for
finer and Rodriguez are glitching yeah
super weird that you've not been
monitoring them the entire time you've
turned men into turkeys people watch
their vitals wearing heels on a lawn
also wearing socks with heels on the
lawn Here Comes dip right on schedule
nothing can go wrong now aside from
things immediately going wrong I'm
curious how the original plan would have
gone from here in order to be pardon
Rick would have to be the selected
turkey how does he plan to stand out how
would he have ensured that he was going
to be selected I know it's not sexual
favors turkeys are notoriously selfish
lovers hold your positions as a feeding
friend the blueberries have been
available in this dish for any of the
birds to eat at any point so why would
their sudden presence on the ground
initiate a food frenzy I hate to be
morbid but if you use the angle of the
gun barrels as a guide every bird in
this pitch should be dead now sir we are
losing the mental game down here the
mental game I think your bigger issue is
that someone up the chain forgot to
mention there were people inside turkeys
in this chamber and that all machine
guns should be turned off because bird
stomachs are just filled with air so
when you punch them whatever is inside
just cannons outward super scientific
does anyone find it suspicious that the
laboratory now only has six Turk fire
thingamajigs they didn't know two of
their own wouldn't be returning did they
but why does this turkey look anything
like the president when it's transformed
the pill was simply a transmitter
assigned to the president there was no
mention of it being DNA encoded and why
would it be look at this dumb piece of
sh earlier humans had no issue
communicating with the Marines in Turkey
form but now they can't understand the
president sounds like a load of turkey
to me so to be clear the president
planned to straight up murder Rick and
Morty for charring a little piece of the
Constitution and activating a war
machine that he doesn't actually care
about in the first place I know I know
questions like this matter about as much
as questioning fire under the ocean in a
SpongeBob episode but still why is there
fire under the ocean I thought we
already rehumanize all the turkified
Marines forgetting Fincher and Rodriguez
I am selling New York to
France and giving all of the money to
Congress I want to send the idea that
these tactics would prove to be this
simple but sadly I'm more inclined to
believe they really are this
simple that's right murmur and when
you're done get me some pants perhaps
the most confusing part of this episode
is how Rick managed to turn the
president back into a human without a
lab we skip over any transformation
explanation entirely and you just know
that wherever they went had something
that would have worked for clothing but
I guess if you have a you really just
wanted to swing around there is more
bareass in this episode than both boss
baby movies combined also so why does
Rick randomly have suits to fit the
president there won't be a single bird
left in DC something Birds aren't real
has been telling us the whole time I
can't stop looking at these two this
man's torso is longer than hers but her
legs are longer than his and the
circular foot rests are down so low they
both appear to either be very short or
the stools aren't made correctly and wow
his hair grew back quickly sir we've got
Rick and Morty coming in what appears to
be an unlicensed Star Wars Adat or as
the Millennials say 880 I yes the is Die
Hard a Christmas movie argument for Star
Wars fans except it's even more annoying
pilgrims of the Corn I wish to explode
this
works a they love each other perplexing
sure but even more confusing may be the
fact that the far superior race of
aliens willingly returns to their secret
chamber to re-enter some sort of
cryogenic status so they can be called
upon again at some point in the future
by a civilization that they do not have
to
support kids bo World Bo
world singing in the car also Summer's
the person that always holds their note
after the song is clearly over to show
off we get it Cindy you know how notes
work no way it can't be this one's just
for the commenters that said that Rick
might have missed Jerry being in the
back seat in a previous video dude just
spotted the glint of a goon faret out of
the corner of his eye from a couple
hundred thousand miles away so I think
he could clock Jerry sneaking into the
trash saucer after he unlocked it chew
on that commenters look no one said I
wasn't Petty it's not a goon faret Morty
it's the blue goon feret so a goon feret
then that's how it all began to my
sister it was just another game there
will be a lot of morian Summer narration
in this episode and yes in the end they
make fun of the fact that there was so
much narration in the episode so one
might think that we would let that go
but one is naive and will receive 20
dings as your sentence Joe thinks it's
all cute including Snippets of actual
episodes in the opening credits but now
that we're here this section is
redundant and therefore wasteful and
therefore sinned mine smells skeletony
smelling your boot not only is that way
too much spaghetti and meatballs but how
exactly did they serve themselves off
that plate and leave it so undisturbed
and if they got theirs from somewhere
else why did they even make a serving
plate at all the Smith family doesn't
know how to food correctly told you
let's just get Jean from next door and a
homeless guy considering this episode
decides to have some actual continuity
by bringing the incest baby in space
back I'd also like to note in that exact
same episode Rick runs over Jean and
therefore he would not be available for
godron activities get your asses into
some anime space suits and despite not
having been told told where they are or
given any instructions they do Rick's
tube sucks the spaghetti off but doesn't
spit any out yeah I heard it too where
are we ziplining through futuristic
metallic tunnels to you're going to the
center of a volcano incorrect the
correct answer is you're ziplining to a
transport chip that will take you to the
center of a volcano so close Rick so
close did I just monor rail from my
kitchen to Hawaii just to regroup an
outer space above my kitchen Jerry and
the show continue to be excellent at TV
SS swear the show tries to for give its
own sin so much it might as well be well
organized religion guys we did our best
they did not holy I I I can't believe
this is working neither can I summer and
Morty should either be passed out or
vomiting profusely now after being swung
around like that not to mention they're
upside down when being fired wow it's so
ridiculous that this group could pull
all this off with no training that I'm
surprised the show hasn't sent itself
for it yet how do we just hit buttons
we're too big to fail there it
is Holy Sunny D look at look at that
purple stuff what kind of circulatory
system would be pushing that amount of
fluid through it at that pressure even
with a clean kill I'm simply not buying
this amount of Kai juice Rick showing
affection will never not be weird and
will always be a sin I swear the only
alien animation rule for this show is is
there somewhere you can put a nipple or
a nut sack then do it at nip sack
animation All Creatures large and small
deserve vaguely sexual external
appendages having spaghetti at a cookout
hotthead Rick he got that name because
he was prone to dramatic outb birth
explaining nicknames that need zero
explanation oh they got him not our
problem turning a blind eye to murder
goon Montage goat Montage go the last
time we saw Morty's goon ferret come out
of the parking garage he didn't need to
reach for a ticket he just left
furthermore why does he even need a
ticket are you saying at the end of the
adventure he comes back to the parking
garage and gets a ticket that he now
needs to leave it and those go
transformed the goo Tron these
Transformations make so little physical
sense that it's clear this episode
attended the Michael Bay School of
transforming things let's just say we're
the rightful owners of these ferrets
then why were they scattered and buried
Across the Universe yeah scattered and
buried let's go with that you mean in a
more General cultural sense overly
emotive anime shaming are those boot
bucks how did these three even know he
missed out on going toy land for that
matter how do they even know they have
the right Morty Morty was supposed to be
security Mor I I I stepped away all
right that's a strange way of saying you
were kid napped dad you know that's not
what I do around here no I'm not your
dad I'm a version of him but how does he
know that's not his summer how does he
know that's the summer that is the Rick
second in command and why do all the
Ricks dress differently and have
different personality traits but all the
Jerry's Beth Morty and summers are
virtually the same I'm not sure how this
show ever expects to be successful with
this kind of shoddy logic work I mean
look at me I'm easy to make happy which
is why nobody gives a sh if I am this
statement is so depressingly true I'm
giving a sin for it which makes me happy
which means no one cares but as you guys
call and as a lot of people keep
bringing up Morty and I did accidentally
create a giant incest baby only Rick and
Morty could pull off a check offs giant
incest baby x Machina through a full
minute of exposition and still make me
consider removing sin for it instead of
adding them after further consideration
I'm adding the sins anyway because we
all have a part to play in this crazy
world and my fate was decided long ago
if this is a goon from goon's from goons
do you know how far a trip it would be
from these robotic appendages to the
head no me either but that's not going
to keep me from sitting how conveniently
fast they got here say hello to my
little me title of my sex tape but how
did you get here where did you find him
how do you still have your suits how did
you know where Rick would be who changes
the America diaper if incest baby has to
launch a missile from his rear Port man
when it's time to wrap up an episode
Rick and Morty skips all the interesting
stuff also this is an incest baby right
do incest babies have better
capabilities to float around in space
without a suit this baby isn't a space
vehicle or The Last Jedi Princess Leia
so what the heck is going on here ratou
in your giant incest space baby without
explicit consent episode does not
contain a boob World episode expects us
to believe that Rick would help pack the
car for a trip he's not even going on
are you sure Rick I know I know a cruise
doesn't sound like an adventure on paper
what a cruise only sounds like an
adventure on paper all you can eat food
the ocean views Random Encounters with
mysterious strangers it's only once
you're on board you realize you're
trapped in a floating bacteria prison
with half cooked salm and the threat of
death Below in the rocking waves and a
dude named Rusty who can't quit telling
you about how his 2001 Ford 150 just
crossed 300,000 miles Morty I'm trying
to stay humble right now Rick for real
ionic coaster deployed what does Rick
need an ionic coaster for when he has so
much free space on that workbench right
next to him garage AI is just showing
off at this point approaching paw
pregnancy in P minus 5 Jesus
Christ it's worth mentioning every once
in a while that despite being here to
sin it the show continues to find new
ways to make me laugh so take your Rick
and Morty gets a s off because it's
freaking hilarious cliche and let's move
on how can a mind be hidden by itself
inside itself the first question
Christopher Nolan asked before starting
every screenplay somehow makes its way
into this episode suggestion don't go in
right the AI is loose enough to offer
fellatio for its own Survival but still
rigid about saying command words like
suggestion before every sentence pick a
lane shallow how yeah yeah hop to a
different timeline grab a version of my
friend that suits me best that's not how
this works and why not exactly did Rick
just place that IV in one movement with
no tie off and without looking like I
get that you can do something enough to
be good at it but even the best phonus
wouldn't Dain to Fain the main vein oh
excellent I get to keep my clothes I
thought for sure I'd have to be naked to
go through something this artsy why does
Rick care about his clothes when has
Rick ever given a if he's naked or
clothed if you looked up down to free
ball in the dictionary it'd just be a
picture of Rick saying wubble LBA dubdub
now I got Yol balls title of my sex tape
no wait that was now that's what I call
Yol balls 23 my bad you see an older
version of him come through here what
talking out of just one side of your
bosom seriously you've got two jabber
jubblies use them both opening a porta
poty without knocking first why was my
ninth birthday party in a pine tree pine
tree Pizza is still at least 19% better
than what they serve at Chuck-E-Cheese
so what's my deal am I sentient do I
have free will who does does covering
the same ground as free guy I'm I'm
coming with now that I know my life is a
lie wow you really are 35 30s something
shaming random convenient pants that fit
perfectly are random and convenient and
can fit perfectly also chafing can we
both die in here are we damaging our
friend's brain I I don't know any of the
rules welcome to the club the trick is
just to pretend that none of it matters
and that making meta jokes about it
makes it all okay but we suck at that so
here's 5 cents situation not looking
ideal Rick and bird person survive this
also it's bad enough when human
characters talk to themselves as a way
to force some Exposition but an AI
construct what kind of a logic chip
would have to be installed for a
computer to start thinking out loud
thinking to themselves is their whole
gig I am Rick's garage oh like like a
like a Jarvis like like Jarvis an Iron
Man well that's a strange way to say
what the this garage with a dying man
hooked up to some sort of cyborg bird
creature is talking to me also MCU nerds
this is where you being this leads
you're not my fault I'm yours this is
all fun self therapy and all but Rick
isn't engaging with his younger self
he's engaging with how not Michael
Keaton's Birdman remembers his younger
self so why is argument if you die in
your friend's brain you die in real life
citation needed your life isn't real and
I didn't save it take off all your
clothes but why all of his clothes real
Rick already has pants on your values
are wrong Facebook this battle of blood
Ridge goes on for all the some time why
would you not revisit this oh I don't
know maybe uh the ending The Dark Knight
Rises okay you matter to me oh look the
show that spent several seasons teaching
me that Rick has exactly zero moral
compass and is a complete dick to almost
everyone he meets in the service of
humor is now asking me to have emotions
about this the answer is no why the are
you risking your life for that
taking the wrong message from the lesson
you don't get to tell anyone what's sad
man you're like a oneman mount sadore so
I guess like a Lincoln sador I mean the
satue of Liberty was right there man
everyone knows what a CLA is do they
it's not like there's ever been a
company out there that Bas an entire
t-shirt around one sorry but we do not
get to choose the ones we love but we
can't choose our friends and we can
choose our noses but we should never
choose our friends noses wait Sanchez
you're under arrest for making me spend
2 years in Earth High School I bet this
show would be really fun for people who
could remember all the details of all
the other Tammy plots and I've got the
memory of a goldfish so all those
callbacks mean nothing to me actually
goldfish have been proven to have better
memories than we thought so maybe more
like the memory of a dog or a bee or a
what was I talking about again oh well
make the noise thing change the number
thing oh my God I'm a memory just set
through all that stand up for nothing
but in a world where you're aware of
multiple universes and multiple 's why
would your first instinct be that you're
a memory when you see another Rick come
crashing in okay listen everybody my
name's Rick this is my new friend
Birdman and his friends we all just met
at this festival and we're so high we
formed a band oddly enough this is
exactly how Sugar Ray was formed I'd
like to point out that this clock still
says 2: p.m. which it said when all of
this started and don't be claiming
Inception rules because discount AA had
plenty of time to offer b-plot BJs to
random passers by while they were out
and yes it could just be a dead clock
battery but that's boring it also means
I couldn't give this in
pretending prisoners have servers that
go around and dish out food to the
prisoners does this look like a white
collar crime prison to You Goodbye Mr
cookie president electing a cookie as a
president why would you elect anyone or
anything that you know for a fact will
eventually crumble also that's not a
cookie that's a wafer and I will need
you to kindly get the out of here with
that nonsense how does this universe
work the camera is candy the mic is
candy the gun silencer is candy and the
lollipop appears to be a candy weapon of
some sort so why would a gun or a sword
be an actual weapon and not some other
form of candy not sure which is more
convenient that Morty somehow had
thousands of gallons of water readily
available to dump on a lava monster that
he knew precisely where the Lava Monster
would be or the portal gun itself well s
all three son of a he marked it
how is Morty just now seeing this I
assume the portal gun had some sort of
scientific woo woo that would Zippity
zap a portal to life after activating
the portal juice but apparently just
falling on to skin activates a portal
just fine we find out in a moment that
the opposite side of Morty's hand portal
is not connected to a garbage dump but
rather the leg of a stranger for this
amount of garbage to pour through Nick's
thigh he must be buried in trash but he
isn't hey how do you think I feel I had
the ultimate stash hole and now I got a
kid in my thigh first world problems
good luck finding someone that can be
told 880,000 times how replaceable they
are anyone who has ever worked in a call
center oh look a failed attempt at the
humorous pull nondescript lever to do
something incredibly specific cliche
good thing it didn't land on Jean
because we know he's dead from that
other episode this season and when we
pointed it out before everyone agreed
with us and and no one called us out on
it so I'm sure that won't happen here
simultaneous Crow snatching is severely
questionable commence Bird on a Wire
seemed does not contain a Goldie Han or
Mel Gibson also when did Rick even train
them for this he literally just caught
them outside and brought them in here to
begin pavloving them with the bird feed
damn just like Jackie Chan I've always
said my favorite Jackie Chan move is the
one where the broom comes out of the
portal in his hand classic Chan
convenient Escape Route through the only
window on an otherwise windowless
building is convenient damn it he must
be showing the off to his stupid crows
it's not fair kids also I like surprise
gun hidey holes as much as the next
person but this secret cabinet should
have been easily spotted below the table
based on how high it lifts not drinking
enough water pee clear people Morty is
that what I think it is the perfectly
convenient appearance of the very item
you were looking for what is that
nothing I find it odd that the game
Wheel is the first thing the crows
fixate on rather than the anti-ro
graffiti all over the walls not now
garbage goober get back in your hole
Rick is a dick to garbage goober
Adventure discounting the psychiatric
hospital as an adventure that's not how
extinguished and discarded cigarettes
work I know we're not supposed to
question how Rick's magical scientific
things do their but his arm
goes a really long way and I just don't
understand where the mechanical bits are
stored when not in use pressing
something to your face that is dirtier
than a toilet seat busted you don't get
it do you how you were able to secure a
jetpack and how you've already mastered
it in this short amount of time no no I
do not I I I thought we were both
victims of abuse thinking that Mutual
abuse means Mutual friendship also how
did Nick track Morty being portal
buddies doesn't mean they're
automatically portal tracking buddies
does it how does any of this episode
work Morty survives this for getting to
clasp your safety harness and sure he's
missing a hand but he didn't even try to
secure it with the functional one he has
left lucky for me abandonment to my
bread and butter if Rick had the
multigun attachment why didn't he lead
with that when he first got on the ship
you were supposed to die then maybe next
time kill a Rick when you have have the
drop on him instead of tying him up so
you can bondly exposit your planing
humanoid crows I'll always be your
grandpa Morty just kind of obsessed with
crows now abandoning your grandson due
to a crow fetish this would mean a lot
more if I didn't already know there were
more seasons left and they're not
changing the name of the show to Simply
Morty or Rick and Crow Rick will be back
there'll be a reset and none of this
means anything this is a Rick and two
crows of Lies I suppose one might think
I'm about to remove a in for this
emotional scene of Rick and Morty
breaking up but instead I'm removing one
because I appreciate this show has
taught me to not give a about
anything that happens in it shutting off
emotions is healthy thank you Rick and
Morty thank you watch sitcoms on your
sneakers can you imagine the amount of
neck problems that would exist if this
became a reality did the chiropractor
Guild sponsor this
[Music]
segment show does not contain chapters
1-
12 this owl does not exclaim loudly and
angrily about dropping his cabbages oh
come on you know this flower wasn't here
a moment ago sure looks badass but we
want to see this Owlman bloodied and
broken at the base of this Pummel tunnel
he's anti-heroic run because he took out
one of the hinch owls is Luke an
anti-hero every time he shoots a
stormtrooper is bond an anti-hero every
time he defrates some random blof felian
guard is Uncle Joey an anti-hero every
time he insists someone cut something
out also why is blue goblin group even
running he's clearly on your side if you
were going to get out of there I don't
think you needed to wait to out Rick's
anti-hero
quotient good luck I've never had a
thousand crows fly down my throat before
but if I did I highly doubt I'd be able
to say anything audible afterwards also
wasting a thousand crows when a few
grains of rice would have done the trick
what that's an urban legend okay fine
then wasting a thousand crows when a
single Alka Seltzer would have done the
trick what that's an urban legend too
well I guess this is now a sin for any
Aven hating society that needs two
distinct urban legends about how to make
Birds explode
psychos what's the point here's two I
count eight nine if you include the
sword sure you only use two of them for
your owl tri-section but how is my
four-year-old nephew supposed to learn
to count correctly with this kind of
confusing phrasing guy who screamed run
decided to stay and cheer hypocrite oh
uh two crows you remember Morty crows
are not capable of hovering also these
Morty cameos and Rick and two crows are
forced and getting out of hand we get it
you used to have this thing with your
grandson on a different show but that's
not what this show is about so let's
focus okay episode does not contain a Mr
mle map paky Chan or bbina the
unrealistic body image witch okay maybe
these humanoids have soft round skulls
that squish like fruit when they roll on
a table but that is just dumb Evolution
come on puss a fur was right there
you've had a thousand adventures with
these crows in 13 episodes this may be
the last time you ever lay eyes on me I
hope that's not true Morty because you
look like sh and this is not how I want
to remember you the reason I choose not
to attend high school reunions somehow
makes its way into this episode setting
aside that this isn't even how real real
crows sleep does Rick strike you as the
kind of person that would be down for
this kind of crow habitation agreement
while I appreciate the hilarious live
laugh love art and the attention to the
Triad details my laughter is broken by
the much more important fact that crows
contain no teeth and have no need for
items specially designed to brush them
we immensely enjoy each other's bodies
what oh no King shaming wearing clothes
underclothes for that long wait that's
it the long way to chapter 13 of Rick
and two crows ends after just 5 minutes
who will avenge pfer will Mr mle map
ever be saved from Captain eagle eyes
Lair will the silver skurfer find a way
to cure his dandruff in time I guess
I'll have to go back to sitting Rick and
Morty but that means a whole new intro
to wait through guess I could eat the
yogurt in the fridge but what if the
[Music]
yur show requires watching Rick and two
crows chapter 13 to understand what
happened between the end of last episode
and now and why Morty now appears as a
middle-aged schlub jeez guys why all the
homework that seems like it's worth oh I
don't know 21 cents sure I should be
paying attention to the family's reunion
conversation but why is the wall a
watered down sherbet color who
purposfully paints their walls like this
thank God this is the last episode of
the Season Maybe by season 6 I'll forget
this atrocious Hue hi I'm citadel's new
mascot Andy because this place wouldn't
be home without Rick's Andy Morty except
Rick and Morty never uses an Amper sand
it's always the full word and so I
believe this is actually Amper Sandy who
has somehow escaped the magic kadel home
to various pins and or tellers Morty
survives this working I'm almost ready
to sell out so 27-year-old Morty gets
closed the fit but 40-year-old Morty was
given a shirt size too small none of us
wanted to see that discolored and
distended midsection of middle-aged
Morty but the second he reveals he's
evil we're gone show then cuts to an
overhead shot of the dinner table that
includes a Jello mold dish which is the
first reveal that President Morty is
evil and I have a hard time believing
either Rick or Morty would miss this
obvious clue tell me how one might bring
down the central finite curve all right
time to go Morty I want to know what
he's talking about me too I'm sure it
will be a completely coherent story
point that I won't need an advanced
degree in physics a few days to rewatch
old episodes and 5 hours of in-depth
mining of the Rick and Morty fan Wiki
just to understand glad that would never
happen can you give me 10 more seconds
literally 10 because now it would be six
nice attempt at being excellent in TV SS
Rick but that took 2 seconds so
technically you still got eight oh I'm
fine with that make it two five like I
said would have been a big help for you
to tell me but I should have everything
I need from you now if you were stalling
to finish Rick's brain scan then why
don't you bring up anything that would
make him suspicious in the first place
Evil Geniuses should be called evil
morons check out season 1 episode 9
riads Excel Seer ruining the hunt for
the true ricke heads who wanted to
figure this out for themselves this is
why we're with them this is why we're
alive what the no idea man you're
on your own with this I mean d doy I'm
basically Inspector Gadget I would have
gone with inspector convenience but fine
sending it either way way who am I to
judge how the writers decide to develop
this fight but also why the isn't Rick
pulling out his big go- go gadget guns
right now does he like it metap for
capitalism I think I've seen this before
you created a being that gets off on you
getting hurt and then transfers that
energy back to you to use on others so
basically it's 50 Shades of vium that
was close let me try that one again so
basically it's 50 Shades of Black
Panther and white panther cuz together
they are gray Panther damn it I should
have quit when I was ahead tonight I do
that thing I wanted do with the curb
thing title of my text tape hopefully we
can snack some untainted fluid at the
source and get the out of here
title of my sex tape this lazy the whole
place is going to blow no I don't trust
you Morty just watched a whole slew of
Rick and Morty be devoured by their
portals and he chooses not to trust Rick
right now Rick's only consistency is his
desire to survive but now Morty decides
to belabor things this two full minutes
of Silent backstory is pure cinematic
awesomeness it's Moody propulsive and
informative without the usual clunkiness
that comes along with having to do this
much heavy expositional lifting take a
sent off for being true artists r& m i
mean R and M but also you knew when you
did this that I couldn't help but s two
full minutes of confusing and
pretentious Exposition summed up as whoa
dead wife call me to faced if you like
but I prefer the term multifaceted what
is this to be thing and is it always
here would you have to drive over it to
get to the garage will it pop a tire why
is ho casual murder in front of the
neighbors is casual I feel a lot better
having seen all that yeah so much
sympathy and emotion now that I've seen
him brutally and callously murder
thousands of other Ricks because how
could Rick not his wife died I am so
moved you still got a way out they never
thought of operation Phoenix and me if I
can't remember back two years ago as to
what that is huh I can barely remember
the plot lines of shows I watched last
week I throw that stuff in my brain bin
and destroy it with fire now you want me
to recall it by raising it out of the
ashes and bringing it back to life like
some sort of um fire Death revers bird
even if I did remember that episod
episode I'd probably also remember that
mores were never part of the deal but I
don't so I'll just send that this Morty
has no nipples I'm going to be honest I
don't have the slightest clue about
what's going on here I I think evil
Morty is breaking the curvy thingy that
separates the genius Ricks from the dumb
Ricks by launching himself towards a
space anus fueled by the blood of Rick
and Morty who try to use the operation
Phoenix call back while our Rick and
Morty are trying to escape the resulting
gravitational pull by using a Unity
metaphor Drive booster as the Citadel is
flooded and poisoned by portal juice and
ey patch Morty finds himself in the
quantum realm until he's needed by V
indicators end game I guess I'll just
have to wait till the season premiere
next season which I'm absolutely sure
will clear everything up yay I thought I
was better than this dramatic voice over
while stranded in space making fun of
the thing while doing the thing doesn't
make you cool it just makes you a
hipster please refer to the following
ding if you have any questions regarding
how I feel about hipsters I guess when
you're dying the first thing to go is
your creativity that might make sense
considering your body probably should be
using all your brain power trying to
figure out a way not to die that being
said I can't tell if Rick's being Prof
found or just using the opportunity to
take cheap shots at Marvel the Russo
brothers and Iron Man so in Li of
dragging this out any further I'll just
add us in for him Rick trolling us for
the millionth time this is going to be a
long season isn't it citadel's gone
acting like the Citadel being gone is
negative we've been there enough let's
move on nobody quits Twitter hey that's
not okay yeah that checks out hey
remember like a second ago when you
pretended not to know who Iron Man was
who was that for oh how I've missed you
Rick and Morty spinal cord robot tusin
has a base then surprise me robotussin
is a funny choice but since you started
in that direction it's likely your
spinal cord will surprise you with some
cough drops in an edti pot show makes me
wonder if this was just a fun idea they
wanted to throw in the opening or a
glimpse of a future Rick and Morty is
Sherlock and Watson episode I so want it
to happen stop playing games with my
emotions in the opening credits oh my
God she found you here eat if Beth
didn't even know they had been found who
were these two perfectly timed
sandwiches made for digest aot convert
to nutrient Mass show drops a dox
mocking on hopes we won't notice also
handling a nutrient Mass with your bare
hands I explained it fine Morty you're
spoon feeding spoons so is that taking
food with a spoon and putting it into
another spoon or is it using a spoon to
feed someone actual spoons I mean both
are funny visuals but I need to know
what I'm laughing at oh my God the Jerry
B oh the Jerry bur deep Cuts making fun
of your fans for getting the reference
but Rick PS me in things like
Wolverine claws pretty sure we all felt
the disturbances that singular
individual just yelled at the screen
those are not Wolverine claws well I
must humbly inform you that the double
claw Arrangement does belong to x23 who
ultimately takes up the Manel of
Wolverine so as they say the episode's
case does hold water however litigation
has no place here and will be sent
accordingly having a doorbell for a
garage door this picture right here for
which I have so many questions who is
this is it an Easter egg a young Rick
perhaps one that is yet to know the rap
aages of time maybe it's sleepy Gary
could he have been real in this universe
maybe my memory is failing Me Maybe the
numerous callbacks in this series have
become too much or maybe just maybe this
picture means nothing at all it's just a
cruel joke thrown in for the Creator's
sick Amusement well all the magazines on
this rack seem pretty sinful my main
issue is with rolling boner because it
sounds painfully detached also porn
magazine survive a mutant holocost wait
is that a good thing or a bad thing well
now we'd have time to read the articles
I guess so I'm going with a bad thing
damn it Morty there's no doctors anymore
then maybe announce yourself before
sneaking up on your kid who's carrying a
weapon Figures it's underwhelming the
one time I visit tourists they say my
mind is held captive in a Time Loop
trapped in the day of a traumatic event
ah this is one of those convenient
Exposition notes that show up when the
writers realize there's so much going on
that they couldn't possibly explain it
organically in 20 minutes right I used
to drink drink using alcoholism as an
excuse for your behavior she reminds me
of you oh really is she dead too the AI
ghost version of Diane would be
devastatingly efficient at TV sins Rick
and Morty quantam Mania my plan is to
wait for you to turn your back then I'm
going to grab all your sh and split this
moment where Morty gets bested and has
to chase after Jerry is unexpected and
surprisingly thought-provoking we find
out that Jerry's content with his life
and reached a point of acceptance with
himself that neither Rick nor Morty has
been able to find and beneath all the
silliness there's a meaningful question
about what it means to move on Morty
wrote this fast cuz had to set trap
thought you'd have cooler sh see other
note
by and it's also hilarious Batman
doesn't abandon people Jason Todd has
entered the chat if you were pulled home
by whatever happened it's likely our
Target was as well convenient computer
generated ghost reasoning is convenient
and reasonable or you'd be a bomb do you
feel bomy asking this and not giving the
person any idea what that would feel
like because what I think bom me feels
like usually turns out to just be a fart
where are we going to kill your grandpa
little buddy premature murder no that's
not it premeditated
murder um conspiracy to commit murder
that's it am I in aing khole right now
what is going on asking this without
prior knowledge of eating Kellogg
Special K listen I'm not here or am I
this evil Rick around around for all the
some time and we never learn why his Bas
looks like a Perplexus maze ball there's
the Clone you found or maybe it's me all
naked just a little Kaiser so this is
not how you Kaiser so this might be how
you terminat her or sixth day wait is
that what happens in sixth day did
anyone actually watch sixth day I've
lost my train of thought regardless
incorrect references to Kaiser soos will
always get you a sin I don't make the
rules oh wait actually I do so here's
five sins you did this last season
you're like a suicide bomber do they
often do the thing more than once maybe
I'm not getting it well this one is for
confusion then theirs or mine a
stupid fifth dimensional stomach juices
assuming all stomach juices from The
Fifth Dimension are the
same this emergency was oversold to me
Rick pulling a a guffin out of his
pocket just so he can be unimpressed by
something cliche wait if they had to
wear helmets I do child proofing stuff
while you're asleep doing stuff to
someone's body while they're asleep and
yes this makes all surgeries though
medically necessary still inherently
creepy also considering Rick could have
probably pulled some space suits out of
his ass the writers have essentially
written themselves into a plot hole just
so they could write themselves back out
I don't see the bowl for the peas where
did the peas come from don't eat the
peas it's colder than Beth on our
anniversary season 2 Jerry survives this
that is to say he's not killed by season
6 space Beth in this scene what the dad
why would you bring that thing into our
house it was cute the father son
conversation from when my younger
brother was born somehow makes its way
into the episode the whole
episode all over again fourth wall
called and is starting to question its
existence how was this house so pristine
already there was a lot more going on in
here than just a few dead bodies so what
do you want to do today eat some snacks
and maybe let me kiss you finally you
know with my mouth and stuff we're about
to learn that all of these people are
tiny parts of Morty's Consciousness so I
don't know it's sadder that some small
part of Morty wants to kiss himself or
that another part is totally not into it
you guys keep thinking I'm a religious
leader you're all my grandson your name
is Morty you're stuck in a video game
and I'm here to get you out look this is
a pretty tough cell but Rick Roy's
tactics certainly aren't doing him any
favors if he wants to make sure this
doesn't look like an organized religion
why use a flyer that clears gives the
impression he's running for political
office also I think it's worth
mentioning that we're six seasons in and
this Show's still coming up with clever
and intricate sci-fi Concepts and
introducing them clearly and efficiently
which is more than can be said for this
sin removal so just take it and let's
move on the power went out the game
restarted and your identity has been
splintered into all the non-player
characters well then that seems like a
pretty big engineering flaw no I mean
when the Pirates of the Caribbean breaks
down it's not like the pirates eat the
tourists is a joke I just totally made
up myself every single one of you is one
five billionth of Morty all of you
collectively are Morty but how are they
even functioning if they're only W five
billionth of Morty's Consciousness I use
at least 10% of my brain and yesterday I
totally forgot the word for that thing
you do when you thrust your hips
backwards and forwards and try to stay
inside of a moving circular void hula
hooping you know for kids do you
understand time dilation I'm losing a
month a second out here so what happens
to Roy while you're out here does he go
on autopilot does he disappear Because
by the end of this conversation you'll
have been gone for almost two full years
years and if you really want people to
buy in you should be shooting for 3 days
away Max just do a Die Hard what does
that mean sneak around use air vents
you've never seen Die Hard hey doing a
Die Hard is way more than just sneaking
around and hiding in air vents you could
dedicate a whole episode to doing a die
hard if you wanted to but I suppose that
might come off as an unimaginative
excuse to include a lot of di hard
references so I guess you'd have to
balance it with an overly metaphorical a
plot questioning our perception of
reality against our many internal
narratives and that just seems like a
lot of mixed message melting an entire
stick of Morty butter to cook only two
eggs designing a video game that's so
detailed it simultaneously keeps track
of 5 billion individual NPCs but won't
render a simple license plate but if
this is a game about Roy why is it
currently focusing on her walking down
the street shouldn't be wherever Roy is
right now why does it look like it's
happening in real time and yes I know
the game is broken but you know what
you're broken okay that was mean I'm
sorry this job just gets to you
sometimes this don't touch me game
reminds me of a game I played this one
time in an arcade called flaming finger
you basically had to draw your finger
through a map and try to get to the end
of the Maze Before the time ran out no
lie I played that game so many times in
a row it literally rubbed the skin off
the end of my index finger which of
course meant I had no fingerprint and
was then logically required to take up a
life of crime 20 years in prison and it
was all the fault of flaming finger
flaming finger we exchang tokens for
digital currency we don't have a safe
correction what you don't have is a head
discount Mr tagi makes a great Point
what are the terrorists doing here if
there's no currency to actually steal
what are they even heisting hello hello
my name is Morty I'm a 14-year-old boy
in a video game still better than most
religious music except for the
Benedictine monks of Santo Domingo dyos
those dudes
rule coming through the ceiling when
you've already driven a tank through the
fireplace stealing your logo from Star
Trek I'd say this was a odd to space
force doing the same thing but I'm not
sure one five billionths of Morty's
brain would be quite that meta sneak
around craing some vents a Die Hard
imitating die hard this well without
ever having seen Die Hard oh my God it's
disgusting that it tastes good fagra
because they killed him and it wasn't
difficult getting so angry you
accidentally Go full gungan every
sentient civilization across the Galaxy
eventually develops the same myth John's
boobby are we supposed to believe that
despite every single sentient species
having their own version of Die Hard
there isn't a single iteration that
better suits this specific situation is
the show seriously saying that no one in
the galaxy has come up with Die Hard in
an arcade I'm amazed we haven't come up
with Die Hard in an arcade the
difference being that cultures like mine
are aware of its importance fine but did
they care enough to make two killer
sequels and then wait over a decade to
make another one about hackers and
and then wait a further six years to
make another one that was basically
nothing like the others and essentially
lost everything that was fun about the
original did they did they live free
until it was a Good Day to Die Hard did
they walkie-talkie Die Hard mother we
all have that friend that mangles movie
quotes this sin is for them the world is
United because the world is one
14-year-old boy United the only thing
that would unite a world of 14-year-old
boys is the mutual agreement that no
sock could be confidently used for its
intended purpose I couldn't find it but
so I'm standing in in the general area
with the microphone is exactly how my
sex tapes get made for good enough news
I'm Tony good enough news position that
will Force the game to reset but first
it'll kick us out which Morty should
survive I mean whatever amount of Morty
we have on board this is the most yach
yed pile of convenience in the episode
not just that you can force a reset but
that the reset will kick out Morty and
the reset won't harm Morty it's almost
like the creators of this game were in
cahoots with the writers of Rick and
Morty also why does it only kick out the
Morty Minions that are on the ship why
would a forced glitch have arbitrary
plot tension rules a mom in a video game
occupied by a tiny fraction of yourself
a fraction of yourself which is now Dead
Forever and fractions add up okay so
when a piece of Morty dies they die for
good but Rick will eventually spend
decades in here so if those fractions
add up why isn't Rick in more of a hurry
if this simulation is anything like the
real world 60 million fractions of Morty
are dying every year from natural causes
sloth attacks and staple gun pranks all
of which means that Rick only has maybe
83 years before there are no fractions
of Morty left to save unless of course
the fractions that die are saved by The
Game and recycled into the babies that
the other fractions of Morty are making
putting aside the fact that we don't
even have a word for what type of CEST
that is it also means that Rick
shouldn't be worrying about losing
fractions of Morty at all also for some
inexplicable reason at least two other
fractions of Morty's subconscious
believe they have monocular vision I'm
going to wander the arcade unarmed and
when she comes across me I'll pretend to
be a hostage if John's study di hard so
much would it make more sense to improve
upon the mistakes made in the movie
rather than repeat them and fall for the
same tricks Hook Line and sinka also I'm
tempted to send summer for ruining this
fancy suit but I'm sure John's has two
you can't just keep yelling die hard I
mean you're basically doing the same
thing as is this episode there's a lot
of hypocrisy going around here don't
throw bare feet in glass houses or
whatever he spent 50 years 50 years it's
what a couple hours to him well since he
said that every month is a second 50
years would be 10 minutes not 2 hours
and the president of the United States
should know this they don't just let any
idiot have that job I can finally get
out of these clothes I don't have nearly
enough Pockets complaining to a woman
about how you don't have enough Pockets
but you have to tell us you love
us I mean at this point even if he said
it what what what's with the paws Rick
is a dick for no reason even though his
dickishness will short circuit his own
plans cliche where the hell were these
guys a few minutes ago let me guess
they're all sitting on a beach earning
20% we got to help her you what wherever
she is I'm sure she's doing fine without
your help woof Jinx any trying to make
me believe that Rick Believes In Me
believing that Rick believes in jinxes
you don't have to not do things that
were done in Die Hard you can shoot the
glass shoot the glass scene does not
contain Jon saying this in their native
tongue and then repeating it in English
for clarity wait person on his face ship
and then what and then we help your
sister do her die hard but how in the
hell are they able to hear this in real
time this game is happening so fast it
should sound like
this his name is Rick and we have no way
of knowing if your generation is
actually part of Morty do you really
have a way of knowing anything like for
instance how do you know that there
aren't parts of Morty in things other
than human NPCs maybe dogs have some
Morty in them maybe rocks with googly
eyes I've seen everything everywhere all
at once I know how this sh works okay
this is a little awkward but the time
dilation has given me a chance to
reflect sincere Rick is the least
convincing Rick but since we're in time
dilation I have to be careful how I do
this cuz I could end up skipping the
entire rest of the season if I'm not
careful so
skip well still overshot it give me a
second I got adjust a time dilation
offset manifold let's tweak this here
time dilation not my fault Rick has to
get all sentimental pretend like five
full seasons of sociopathy don't exist
so move this wire here and boom okay
this should jump us back to close to the
right spot and un skip you really are a
good grandson you know that I'm proud of
you Morty all right let's try this again
I'm not going to presume to know how
this alien's Anatomy works but I would
think it's safe to assume that this arm
should at least be slightly less
functional while carrying this laser
hole around you left your book in the
bathroom I read it while I took a
reading on the toilet AKA committing a
hemoroidi and slip AKA boarding the
pulmonary embolism Express he's fine got
him all out every last piece another
open-ended Rick and Morty ending I'm
dubbing these CeX closings because the
writers know they might want to pull
stuff from the episode out again later
so they make sure to always leave a
hanging thread oh my God I cannot
believe this here weing go pretty sure
we've landed on the actual title of my
sex tape something something something
turkey call back something something
Rick's pixelated improv the rest is how
I guess this scene was written also
Rick's turkey feathers fall out and I
can't help but wonder what part of his
human body is forever transmuted laying
forgotten on the cold concrete of the
back porch I heard you smack the glass
Dad she knows the sound of turkey
smacking glass that is oddly specific
and highly suspicious Rick put some
pants on today has so few rules Jerry
doesn't acknowledge that wearing pants
inside the home is a courtesy we afford
to our loved ones and not an obligation
or requirement under the law also if
they're too few rules then perhaps there
should be more rules for example one
must wear clothing before entering the
dining room be specific if you don't
want to see Rick's dangle Doodles you
know he's a nudist ding ding ding whoa
whoa whoa you have to be careful with
that sacred word you just can't go
around sinning your yourself like that
you reference your own sins enough as it
is leave some fun for us can we please
have a normal Thanksgiving does Beth
actually think anything normal is
possible with her family and what does
normal even mean anyway I will never
miss an opportunity to send the
Thanksgiving Jello-O mold rest in peace
aunti Grace you are missed but your
Jello-O Abominations with a side ofing
horseradish sauce are not holding your
glass like this I mean animating your
character to hold a glass like this move
the thumb laterally for balance to avoid
the glass accidentally flipping out of
the grip oh I got this adjusting
someone's body without their explicit
verbal and written consent along with
signed approval from aing doctor I got
just the thing for that here inserting a
foreign object into a body without their
explicit verbal and written consent
along with a signed approval from a
doctor I feel like it's been a
while since I've s the backward motion
of the tongues of the characters in this
show whenever I think about the anatomy
of it I start to try to do why talking
conversation times more ly bro tell your
your son you love the out of him oh
I'm going to this is touching in a weird
way and I don't like it when I'm touched
in a weird way we do share a shitty back
you don't though you share a point in
time with specifically replicated DNA
but then both bests have individual
opportunities to find a way to heal
their backs it's very realistic is it
there's not another terminal adjacent to
the one tube steak is paying for in a
real world scenario I just walk around
it I I mean tube tube stake would avoid
paying and just walk around it I'd pay
for sure floppy drop youits have less
taste bud than humans their ice cream is
like a hospital bed it's designed for
you to do less so it does more wouldn't
this mean their tongues are less
sensitive and require more flavor to
elicit the same effect and yes that
would mean the food is doing more but
unlike hospital food or its beds the
flavor would be overwhelming you have
your own space station but you said
earlier I'll sleep in my car it's got a
tardis thing going on bigger on the
inside an admission that renders a space
station pointless and redundant we're
the same person they are not I want you
back in my guts like I'm one of your
sick little Phillies is actually
something that best said to herself that
I now must consider when thinking of
this episode later yeah and if he kills
himself we're going to have to get a new
dad assuming Jerry is a dad this species
of bionic space wheale has carbon wiring
show forgets that we were dismissing
most of the things of the show because
of portal travel and doesn't bother
explaining how or why Rick has a space
whale prepped and ready to go on the
operating table just in case I'm not
killing it for the record carry on with
your shocking space species Shenanigans
sir but perhaps install some sort of
grade in the floor for goop cleanup I
mean we know there is a hatch down there
somewhere but mopping up victim's Gore
must be exhausting I want to watch the
dissection of this telepathic bionic
whale but instead I'm wondering where
this Wayward cord is going and why it's
not plugged into the outlet properly oh
oh good they remembered to animate the
plug I just had to wait 10 more seconds
during the bionic birth scene I'm just
saying lies pile up like credit card
debt you retain an advantage by staying
liquid Rick doesn't have this Live Your
Truth sign hanging next to the live love
laugh one in his knitting Den but also
solid Financial advice the single most
important part of this scene scene
happens off screen I'm sure it involves
some fanciful Tech but to flaunt the
achievement of a perfect snow angel with
no Footprints leading to or from without
sharing such knowledge is an affront to
the laws of God and men are we in love
with ourself I mean does that make us
the most or the least healthy woman in
the universe this is a wild hypothetical
and I'm happy it's being explored but it
also feels like a fanboy fantasy being
exploited on a dark website swimming
through the adultness of the internet
that I should not be exploring my poner
is so confused right now making us
believe that Jerry could complete a
puzzle in a few hours let alone one
night or a week holy sh you you did a
full sand Juna pero in here if they
could pull a full sand Junipero and
Rick's sudden Hol deck then why does
Rick even need to go to Blitz and chits
to play Roy for the next several seconds
the children pile ice cream into their
moue like crazy people and neither of
them get an ice cream headache or make a
dent in their bowls I'm hyperfocused on
it because of the awkward sex chat
between Mom and Dad and Mom so at least
give me more details to distract me not
ironing down the letter on your
jacket
show just pulled one of the weirdest
funniest and most unexpected Jerry
moments completely out of its ass and
reminded us why we love this show in the
process these tattoos could win on
inkmas and I can't send that but I can't
send having an ass this shiny it's a
cool power to have like if you have to
fly coach or if summer asked you what
you thought of Wonder Woman 1984
thinking that summer would not only
watch Wonder Woman 1984 but then also
ask her potato of a dad for his opinion
this entire sequence reminds me of my
hatred of the word Forest I was once
told that if I I was confused about how
to spell desert versus dessert that the
extra s in dessert was like an extra
helping of sweet yummy goodness and that
helped me but you can't use that same
logic for Forest versus Forest so you
would think that the extra R would mean
lots more trees so add the extra R in a
word defining a place with a ton ofing
trees but that is incorrect so the sin
as always is the English language oh God
what happens in the shadows considering
they follow this up with vampires oh
come on that's not realistic I'm
guessing the writers know exactly what
they do in the shadows I see you twist
de ex-husband ah what is happening RI
and Mory taking another one of my
favorite sins are the writers trolling
me all right we've got to find out
writers if you are watching and you're
taking my sins away like some sort of
entertainment Jesus I pray demand you
show me your power by correcting the
greatest sin on your show the fing bowl
of fruit wilst thou move the fruit from
the bottommost Shelf to the topest of
the table is a sign that you are real
and because relationships like this are
highly transactional I promise if I see
that bull move I will know it's a
miracle and give all of the sins back
sin men having many of the same shirt
and the same color well hold on hold on
this is weird weird and permitted this
weird permitted versus not permitted
assessment goes on for all the
uncomfortable twin sesty amounts of
Jerry being aroused times they are still
eating off the bird for dinner man you
pick it clean for meat fre easy snacking
later and Chuck the bones in the bin
there is no reason to shove a carcass
into the fridge and take up all that
precious space probably the most sinful
part of this Thanksgiving dinner is the
family can hear the threesome upstairs
at all Beth and Jerry's bedroom is here
and the dinner is here so the sound of
their conversation is pressing through
the barely overlapped section of their
room in the entryway and wafting into
the dining room to be heard
perfectly disrespecting the garbage
disposal sometimes we have Jerry's come
here and try to touch other Jerry's
Jerry's touching Jerry's reading but
also I feel like the show knew exactly
what it was doing pulling this your
quote and I will not thank it for
turning me onto the second sympathetic
cannibal story I've been subjected to
this year strange usually my dreams the
cream are the opposite of a nightmare
they actually shoot I mean turn out
quite Pleasant using snoozy as your
app's brand name when I'm getting sheepy
was right there for the taking Rick
clearly went to the Michael Meers School
of sit-ups and no amount of rock hard
ABS will fix that kind of lower back
drama Jerry appears to serve everyone
from a batch of pre-butter pancakes but
why does Summers appear to be unpre
buttered did Jerry Only pre butter the
ones beneath Summers why what's this
pancakes sold also those pancakes have
had syrup sitting on them for who knows
how long you never Ser up another man's
pancakes without their permission guys
Rick should not be sold on this not at
all also also Jerry's decided to serve
up Rick's pancakes even though he hasn't
arrived yet while summer is presumably
just sitting there watching everyone eat
this is exactly why no one wants you
around Jerry also the third where even
is the syrup there doesn't seem to be
any on the table so did Jerry pre- syrup
the first batch if so why is this second
batch of Pancakes only pre-b buttered
and not pre- syrup and where did
Summer's unpre syrup and unpre buttered
pancakes come from that's it I'm
including a separate sin counter for the
show and I'm going back and including
all past and present breakfast sins best
investment I've ever made this family of
sociopaths didn't even Flinch at a glass
of orange juice being spilled all over
the table when this happens in my house
the resulting reaction invariably causes
more damage than the initial spilling no
go on say it say what I don't know what
you're talking about kids you can poke
all the fingers I got if I get abs like
Rick I'm just going to assume that this
gadget is doing some internal Switcheroo
that means it isn't poking everyone with
the same quickly diseased needle but I
will be sending the show for not
confirming that assumption judging by
the brown edges here these eggs are
getting close to being overcooked and
yet more Morty butter is being added
suggesting the egg cooking is not
complete why does this show hate me I
also like Tori Amos reading the words I
like Tori Amos in a condescending manner
you take that back summer you you
Cornflake Girl Who Wants cake
answering a question with a trumpet how
the hell does this discount saning even
work their bodies are still getting up
at night and Performing many tasks so
how would everyone not wake up sore and
tired from the previous night's
activities all I'm saying is that if a
fancy machine is causing me to wake up
satisfied yet sore I want to remember it
also why would he be doing laundry in
the dark you wouldn't be able to
separate out the colors darks and whites
as well if anyone ends up with red
clothes that were previously white they
have no one to blame but themselves pow
pow pow pow pow pow pow pow p pow pow
pow pow pow pow pow pow P pow pow no
notes well Rick I do have notes like why
is the power cord Manus extended to the
garage door why is it plugged all the
way into the bottom ismost Outlet
causing whatever this plug leads to
overstretching itself into an
unnecessarily higher position nope not
going to let that one slide even if it
is a joke you cannot be over 100%
indestructible unless of course any
attempt at destruction actually resulted
in an increase of indestructibility by
10% or an increase of mass by 10% as a
result of this misbranding you will see
a roughly 10% increase in SS seems like
you spent an awful lot of energy just to
not give the night family what they want
Jerry would be no notes at TV SS why
won't you rinse your dishes counter
question why are your eyeballs glowing
like you have a th000 watt bulb inserted
into your cavities once again we do not
need to see anyone puking ever I don't
care if it's animated we don't need to
see it stop showing it the's your
problem with me not already knowing the
answer to this question after just
bursting into your granddaughter's room
without permission while she's sleeping
Rick's lucky he wasn't greeted with a
high velocity radio alarm clock to the
jaw or whatever it is the teenagers
sleep through nowadays did you have to
make mushy garbage science on the living
room carpet if this has been pulled from
the garbage I'm very confused putting
aside the fact that an entire box of
eggs has been thrown away what even
happened to them did a wild fox just
very politely nibble on the top half of
these knowing that Rick would need them
for some Wild Eggs Machina either way
I'm still counting this as a breakfast
sin aren't they going to be suspicious
seeing night summer covered in all this
Terry gillium two episodes ago summer
said she didn't know anything about die
hard but we're supposed to believe now
that she has enough knowledge of Terry
gillium to make this kind of reference
you were souping up that some n you
whatever so they could extend its range
beyond the house I'm guessing the plan
here is global dation by creating an
army of night people but if it currently
only covers the house and night Rick has
only managed to extend the range by 169%
nice then that's really only going to
cover the neighboring house and maybe
70% in the next one at most I really
don't think think D Rick needs to be
worrying at this point Sorry Rick but
your opinion means very little to me
wait how did night summer manage to fake
being regular summer are the viny
eyeballs and husky speech just a choice
how the hell is she just switching that
on and
off demo everyone get behind my
app this fing show man okay somebody
really needs to dial in the dosage on
these darts it should not take this many
darts unless the dosage is homeopathic
or the end goal is a coma I am afraid
friend of your son-in-law expecting us
to believe that Jerry would be able to
make a friend yep that joke's exactly as
mean as you think it is Rick just had to
slap night Jerry to get him to turn back
to Day Jerry but night summer flies
several feet and lands in these boxes
without reverting back to day summer
that is some nighttime SL daytime
I know this is a fun visual gag
but what Maniac is selling cardboard
boxes in the middle of the night that
are fully assembled fully assembled who
buys cardboard boxes fully assembled pH
almost didn't make it choosing to peel
through metal instead of oh I don't know
shooting through the already smashed
window the day and night families
survive this let's go home right grandpa
great idea summer rolling the credits
here makes it seem as if the show wants
this to feel like the end of Rick and
Morty as we know it what's weird is that
the post-edit scene is super long and
undoes all of that which kind of just
makes it a scene scene and now I feel
like I've been tricked into hanging
around for the credits which I didn't
pay attention to anyway because it was
so obvious that the story wasn't over
yet so the bot line for me is that if
you want to make a big swing with your
TV show start by getting breakfast right
first normally this would have been
dealt with by our demonoid oppressors
the night family scheme falls apart
because they apparently aren't smart
enough to keep their jobs budget their
finances or do laundry which is beyond
baffling considering this isn't nearly
as complicated as half of the that they
were being asked to do in the first
place wasn't the whole point that they
get the mundane done so the Day family
can be the Mindless zombies how long
have we been asleep no it can't be that
long
oh my God no they killed the Choco Taco
Time to update my weekly list of crazy I
have to say because of Rick and Morty
with using a sweet flavored Taco as a
unit of time measurement now that was
some fantastic Chow Manion and before
you say that sounded racist you can ask
the waiter how they say it having to
explain yourself this much to prove
you're not a racist also having a family
dinner at Panda Express sometimes I look
at the background of a scene and just
glaze over for a few seconds which is
what I was doing while looking at these
slip-on shoes which are suddenly
obscured by the appearance of of a foot
stol bar that wasn't animated in the
previous frames the kids seem
disappointed that Rick won't play along
with teasing Jerry but how would Rick
having robot arms extend from his body
not be something interesting for the
kids of Tik Tok to enjoy film that and
get those views views are all that
matters baby you know fortune cookies
only come true if you eat the cookie
first eating your fortune cookie while
you still have this much of your entree
left on the plate also is that a glass
plate and are they getting served at the
table episode doesn't know how to Panda
Express correctly family time is time
when well spent okay that's not only
empty it's been disproven Beth would be
excellent at fortune cookie sins you
will have sex with your mother in bed
wait no I was just going to add the
infamous in bed gag to someone's Fortune
I didn't realize this would be a sex
with your mom episode I was set up by
the Rick and Morty writers and you know
it also sure right it's not an ideal
thing to get in a fortune cookie and
certainly shocking but Jerry is speaking
of the same volume as when he talked
about getting the sh from the zoo
earlier and no one in the restaurant
reacted to that over four episodes into
the season and we still haven't gotten
the Sherlock Holmes episode this scene
promises I am very bothered by the very
far from Center buttons on Jerry's
pajamas Jerry Are you seriously asking
if I think you're going to have sex with
your mom he is man I really hate that
this Cliffhanger of a question is
actually intriguing me this is the who
shot Jr of Rick and Morty incest
Cliffhangers and unfortunately making
Cliffhangers plural was not an accident
on my part sleepy Gary wasn't real
neither are fortune cookies I mean The
Fortunes in the cookies might not be
real but fortune cookies are indeed real
you can hold them you can eat them you
can stick your well yeah then you should
definitely hit that Morty raises his arm
for a high five before his punch line is
delivered and summer proactively preps
for the high five without knowing if the
joke would even be good enough and now
we know that Jerry's familiar with
tucking so he either has no pubic hair
or is able to shave very quickly all
things I did not need to know about
Jerry also walking into your parents
room at any time without knocking even
if she's trying to catch her dad doing
something embarrassing this is still a
horrible risk Rick walks this way with
towel over his shoulder then this way
with three rolled towels a second later
and here he comes by with another set of
folded towels you know he's not doing
house chores now all I care about is
what seven moisture absorbing pieces of
fabric could possibly be needed for okay
I'm just as likely to sh a balloon as I
am to become a dolphin things overheard
at the D and D table while reviewing the
chaos table calculations somehow make
their way into the script why is this
person holding a tray of food as if
they're going on a lunch break when the
store is closed and currently under
attack I'm going to take the truck in
exchange for not turning you in I'm
going to s in the convenience of the
fortune cookie truck that just happens
to be in the back and now we're being
retina scanned maybe somebody knows the
answer to this but I don't so I'm
sitting why Jerry would need to have his
eyes closed for the retina scan but Rick
would not you can't crack a smile oh
yeah you're worried about doing it with
your mom okay fair
[Laughter]
enough it's sure is nice for the company
to Showcase torture in the adjacent
conference room you know to be sure that
our infiltrating Duo can see the
positive and negative impacts of the
cookies without having to walk more than
a few feet use the emergency fortunes
you'll have great success in a fight the
cookie designed for an emergency is
fight related what if the emergency had
been a fire if the security guard fought
the fire with water would that have
fulfilled the wish and if the wishes can
be fulfilled by a more vague approach
couldn't Jerry's wish be completed with
a game of poker that ends with Jerry
tossing the table and exclaiming you me
mom hate crawling through a air
vent maybe try going forward through the
air vents that makes it much much easier
why is the creepy alien Handler touching
the wish list with bare skin and also
using this Grabber thing as if it's
important to not touch the paper with
his fingers I'm just trying to make
sense of something simple that I can
understand while the episode derails
into portals and alien poop which I do
not understand fortune cookies are alien
poop ladies and gentlemen I would buy
this on a shirt and I'm sure that is a
sin does the alien want that it's not
exactly what I'd call a sentient species
a man knows so let me get this straight
this guy wants to an alien the proper
way so he creates a your mom cookie and
hopes that someone will come and
investigate a highly secure evil
Corporation and accidentally their way
to the secret area to discover the
exploitation of an alien creature which
would trigger an empathetic response and
encourage them to free the alien and the
Dirty Man allowing them to in harmony
forever your friends picked me up in a
limousine being so impressed with the
luxury of the car that picks you up from
the airport that you're able to ignore
the multiple semi-automatic weapons
pointed at your back for someone's
striving to be the most successful
businesswoman in the world this company
sure is leaving a lot of profit on the
floor literally come on and already
at this point I'm pretty sure Rick and
Morty is simply trying to title my sex
tape but I'm not that easy actually yes
I am I just used a dark web account to
hack Goldman Sachs remove trillions of
dollars and purchase everything your
company offers congratulations you're
officially the most successful
businesswoman on Earth see this is why I
strongly suggest defining what success
means to you before you start on a
project in this case Rick's sudden
definition of success fulfills the
cookie prophecy rather than her version
of success totally avoidable I see that
I've romanticized a wild animal the same
way Margaret how did when she jerked off
that dolphin in the 1960s I mean there's
no way that actually
happened
oh for the love of why are there
pictures so this guy's guts get sucked
out of his body but Rick's guts aren't
sucked out of his ass and I guess I just
don't understand how much of Rick is
robot or human and how that impacts his
immortality it's a super good thing that
Rick packed the Nano laser printer in
his arm Cannon this morning and thought
I had to build the cookie ammunition
Chambers in the first place what a champ
we should all strive to be more like
Rick God damn it I think I think God has
indeed damned this show damned it
straight to hell where we TV sends
freaks are prodding it with our dingy
pitchforks and having a blast thank you
God for sending it to us Jerry's mother
is held in a gynecological exam position
by her right ankle alone and her left
leg isn't being sucked backward she
should have a broken pelvis and in weird
things in space news starting your
episode off with blatant
self-referential news positional
repiping bold move Rick and Morty a bold
move indeed oh what's it now I mean if
you're forcing me to send something in
this sing that Flags annoying me because
there's no way there's room for the star
section in little part that's off the
screen this is just red and white
stripes all the way to the pole and you
know it what did you do you tiny monster
Morty didn't do anything but I'm still
going to issue a sin for the convenient
timing of the dinosaur aliens showing up
right as the teacher was accusing Morty
of always bringing terrible like this
down on the school you know how we feel
about that in these quarters starting
your episode off with blatant
self-referential news positional
repiping twice in the first two minutes
old move Rick and Morty a bold move
indeed if these aliens want Earth
they'll have to go through Egypt and
they can ask mummies how that goes but
are we talking about the Boris Carlo
mummy the Brenan Frasier mummy or the
Tom Cruz mummy I mean we could also be
talking about the Cushing Lee mummy or
the Jason Scott Le mummy or even the
Abit and Costello mummy which is also
basically the Boris Carlo mummy but more
of a funny mummy and then there's the
waxwork mummy not to mention the charlon
hon mummy which which if it wasn't for
Scream Factory we'd all forgotten about
it and been better for it in the end
there just too manying mummies to wrap
my head around this statement then I
think I might cry I want my mommy
monkeys went bald hilarious but in what
world do you know enough to know monkeys
existed but not enough to know about the
development of homo sapiens how did
these dinosaurs even get in the UN
building did they install a dino door
pretty considera of this long neck to
hold their head like this when the
imaginary cameras on a closeup and then
extend their neck completely for the
wide shots the imaginary cinematographer
thanks you but surely there was some
point between gunpowder and something
called Amazon Prime we don't know what
Amazon Prime really is either we just
know that $130 or so disappears from our
checking account every year and that
allows us to then send more money to an
invisible entity that often sends
something in return that we didn't even
ask
for every fridge full but why in a post
scarcity Society Like This Not only
would you never have to stock up on
stuff you'd never have to cook at home
either I mean you could if that's your
thing but I'm guessing most fridges
would just sit mostly unused while
everyone picked up free Five Guys I can
see the headline is unemployment at 100%
but someone had to write this article
someone had to print it and someone had
to distribute it so how exactly is no
one working currently somehow
pre-filling in only the M on several
lines of your crossword puzzle I do
think it's kind of funny that you're all
basically Jerry now Rick per usual would
be the rickest at TV SS show teases us
with Panda's falling and a snake wearing
miniskirt and doesn't follow through on
either forcing us to come through in the
clutch you're welcome does anyone know
how to mail things to Publishers not to
keep making this my hill to die on but
even if they did who would be able to
publish the book who would even pick up
the mail sure maybe it's technology of
some sort but I don't see any cool robot
Butler so I'm calling shenanigans the
only thing that can make the name of
this restaurant more wonderful is if Bo
Bridges was the one inside cooking the
food and since that's not the case
here's a sin at first it was fun
spending all day watching whatever
YouTube Auto plays after the last one
Auto played insinuating it ever gets
tiring letting YouTube videos autoplay
give in the algorithm the algorithm
loves you the algorithm is your friend
how often are you westw worlding me
calling it westw worlding instead of Dr
goldfoot in the Bikini Machining there's
an order to these things
if you get rid of the dinosaurs you can
host the Oscars in a situation where one
has all the leverage and said person
chooses their reward to be the most
thankless job on the entire planet over
candling around flammable Flora the
gateways are see-through not a green
swirl so now you can see where you're
going I like these Dino Lords can they
also help me understand how the portal
automatically knows where you want to go
I mean if you're fixing our portal sins
we might as well go ahead and fix them
all they're going to call us Laura D
because we're about to get elbow deep in
Dino doodoo yeah let's not reference the
parts where Laura D WS off a T-Rex and
velociraptors to save kids let's just
talk about her reaching into some which
for the record she's doing an attempt to
save a dinosaur's life you put some
respect on Laura D's name Rick I said
clever girl earlier you didn't even
react complaining that a reference you
are also explaining wasn't given its due
in the past what are you a syon or
something yeah we figured they used to
hold huge outdoor concerts in their land
Amphitheater maybe this is a silly
Theory but the singing skull feed is way
more interesting than our boring old
dinosaur stories also just making sure
everyone C that syon reference a few
seconds ago that's from Battlestar
Galactica and while I can't watch you
watch this video I could feel there was
very little laughter so I'm just
bringing it up here again for no reason
at all the Majestic baskets are aren't
they incredible we're even making a
series of increasingly terrible movies
about cloning them in a theme par can't
be worse than Jurassic world Dominion so
please feel free to bring the basket
sore franchise to Earth also
increasingly terrible show wants us to
laugh but honestly Jurassic world was
better than both two and three and to
pretend otherwise on any Planet strange
credulity police what fossils were
wheel-shaped what fossils I say it
appears that the Rick and Morty
animators are using the repeating
faceless crowd models again which fine
do what you got to do but this guy bugs
me why is his head so big why is it all
skin tone when others have distinct hair
colors why is he looking up to the sky
as if ready to ascend to the Rapture
this
one is headed directly towards us and
all of our work it was for how are these
Ultra evolved creatures with their
Godlike knowledge and wisdom unaware
that they have an arch nemesis you know
everything there is to know in the
universe except that you're being hunted
by evil sentient space rocks using a
perfectly beautiful slice of pepperoni
pizza as a hate projectile it's pizza
and it's delicious and it contains every
single food group you yum chucking waste
monsters and you had no idea about the
disastrous meteors that followed in your
wake deciding to let Anderson Cooper
interview you to tell your side of the
story also do the dinosaurs not watch
movies because if they watched
Armageddon they'd save some time there's
a formula to it a very simple formula I
mean no one knows that the meteor
species is even real deciding to let Joe
Rogan interview you to tell your side of
the story this guy created a dinosaur
Avenue sign and is replacing a current
street sign just so he can graffiti the
word sucks onto it game recognize game
Wilson why does Tom Hanks yelling Wilson
all of a sudden sound like Dave Seville
yelling at Alvin what even is this
nonsense Rick has a gizmo that lets him
see whatever he needs to see even though
he clearly didn't type in any commands
or coordinates cliche Oscars are over
something every single person except the
academy is known for about 10 years now
somehow makes it into the episode Elon
Musk be damned we're blowing up Mars
thinking you need a reason to damn Elon
Musk we're doing something selfless are
you though there's no way calculations
could have been done to guarantee the
safety of earth when Mars blows up into
thousands if not millions of pieces
there is so much that could go wrong
here somewhere in Tasmania a devil
silently weeps at the cruel theft of his
native tongue can we turn on the AC it's
like 1,000° outside it is not or kids
take take your
pick HOA check it out Rick and Morty
Riders last a full five episodes without
their portal gun crutch before giving up
a dimension where hats wear people fun
but why do the hats also have the same
body construction as people those aren't
really hats then are they they're hat
people so technically it's a dimension
where hat people wear people is people
hats huh I felt good I've missed you
portal gun I've missed you so much here
we go Rick and Morty time he says
directly before announcing the final
four episodes of the season are on
surprise Hiatus previously on Rick and
Morty previously on before Rick and
Morty committed the Cardinal TV sin of
having a previously on in their episode
I really don't know where to go with
this because let me tell you Rick and
Morty thinks they've created the most TV
sins proof episode yet and I think they
may be right they may defeat me but I
guess I could just start sitting myself
for liking raccoons more than dogs or
preferring eggs over Pizza things are
going to get really weird over here for
the next few minutes so I guess I'll
just leave you with potato salad Jerry I
had sex with your wife not realizing
Jerry would probably be less mad about
this and more turned on by it or maybe
I'm just projecting my own fetishes onto
the scenario because what I've always
found useful is working out your demons
with episodes of Rick and Morty at least
that's what Carl told me who's Carl you
might ask I'm just getting to know him
but if it helps he does live in my left
pinky I did it I fixed portal travel
show reminds me of its lack of
commitment to a portalis existence I'm
pregnant having the cake on the table
with the candles lit before you finish
the primary meal also positioning the
cake closer to the camera than the
birthday person it's raining meatballs
and you'd think I'd do a simple quick in
here like Cloudy with a Chance of Rick
and Morty but since I don't give a sh
about what you think I'm just going to
send the fact that I've never once seen
a pickup basketball game in this
driveway and that basketball goal
honestly looks like it's never been used
and for the record I do care what you
think i k o so much please don't hate me
thanks for solving that murder guys
here's a skateboard thinking that
solving a murder is anywhere near as
impressive as doing a kickflip myty say
you'll marry me what just say yes being
forced into marrying her grandfather is
a meta plot point or really just at all
I do in for her honeymoon let's go to a
seal chamber line with ionized dyum why
because the charge acts as a narrative
accelerant Morty none of this is real if
nothing here is real then how would an
isotope have an observable effect on the
fake matter in your fake reality unless
just saying it does the thing means it
does the thing but that would mean that
name dropping ionized Deuteronomy was an
extra step and Rick could have just said
let's go to a sealed chamber lined with
a narrative decelerate now repeat after
me Morty next time on Rick and Morty
next time on Rick and Morty no
previously on Rick and Morty narration
to counteract the subsequent narration
leads to my narration sending your
narration we got to get through the
opening titles oh F me I didn't want to
have to do this but if the Rick and
Morty writers are going to kick down the
walls of their reality and attempt to
make this episode unable I really have
no choice but to prove to medic inverse
that no episode is truly without
sin even if that involves sinning myself
I am
aive no need to be so melodramatic sorry
decreasing dramatization by 5% better
make it 15 you perfect now you just keep
Sting the video like that and I think we
might just get through this syy activate
the sin transfer
array well also you adding a sin just
because you didn't like something is not
really an issue with the show
magnificent let's go oh my God it's
squirrel pretty sure that's a sugar
glider and not a squirrel and I
understand most people don't know what a
sugar glider is but then just make it
look like aing squirrel how hard could
that be don't succumb to his pointless
self-aware says the king of
pointless self-aware and that
may be the point but do you know what I
have to say to that potato he wriggled
back to the meta layer through a hole in
the fourth wall So Meta Antics aside
adding a convenient metal layer to your
story to essentially UNM meta The Meta
Story You've created and acting like the
encroachment on my territory would go
unchallenged bro you literally just did
the same thing just because you have a
sign that says check off's guns doesn't
mean that we can't sin check offs guns
because if we don't sin check offs guns
then the sin doesn't come into play and
it becomes check off sins which doesn't
even make sense because who's to say
where and when a sin can have action in
the end maybe it's just check offs Rick
and Morty and maybe that's the point and
maybe nothing means anything and I mean
nothing and am I even really here all
you hear is a voice a voice that could
be coming from a computer a simulation
or a ghost all of this to say I want to
sin check off's guns because they are my
guns to send damn it and you're not my
mother that being said I'd also like to
thank the writers for their cynicist
with these metaphorically literal
representations of narrative Concepts my
job is much easier when you lay them out
like this I mean it's funny when I do a
little nod to the viewers what viewers
Morty would be the most meta thing to
ever meta at medicines and if Rick and
Morty continues down this path we might
just create that channel to fck with
them personally none of this season 3
Moonlighting sh talking about season 3
of Moonlighting when we all know that
season five was the real problem you a
womb with a view I'll never get that
hour of my life back also nothing the
kids like these days more than
Moonlighting jokes although we just made
a Moonlighting joke didn't we yes you
did damn it he needs to be put down like
a rabbit dog literally breaking the
fourth wall running in the opposite
direction of Trials honestly don't know
if that's good or a bad thing but I've
got a job to do and just like this
episode appears to be doing out of pure
desperation I'm throwing a lot of stuff
at the wall and hoping a few things
stick is this whole place just a bunch
of grown inducing word play for seven TV
critics that won't even enjoy it we're
not critics it's a comedy channel a
comedy channel also thinking word play
is more grown inducing than Wordle and
that I don't enjoy both the narrator
thinks the writers of this show would
honor him with such a reference even
though the critical value of his
commentary is as questionable as his
Wordle skills and there aren't seven
sins writers there's one 2 3 four five
six and jemy makes holy sh every second
we spin here is the equivalent to 10
Space Jam cameos sending your own
appearance in a terrible movie does not
exclude us from sending your appearance
in that terrible movie and just in case
our dad's s Channel didn't send you the
first time around we're giving you to
here I'm here Leon this Dex makina
riding in on Leon's prayers like some
kind of literal literary Jesus cannot
absolve you of your TV sins I love a
good refusal of the call hey story
Lord's back and now I'm going to send
myself for remembering who the story
Lord is but how could I not this episode
is a sequel to the first episode I ever
appeared in the video as your narrator
and 3 years later I still get asked
where the the other guy went and when
will he be back and it doesn't hurt
doesn't heard at all not a bit narrator
thinks that just because he's taken the
guard rails off the ride he can add sins
wherever he pleases stay in your lane
also it's not like just because this is
the sequel to the episode where I
appeared out of thin air to start
narrating that we'd go back to the
original narrator for this video nope
I'm out it's all you buddy you think I
want to deal with this plus you've been
killing it as the narrator in fact
you're so universally beloved and
supremely talented I'm wondering if you
should narrate Cinema sense we have to
stop letting narrators write their own
scripts oh God not the B not the B sorry
to keep keep interrupting but I do need
to mention that a shout out like this
used to remind me of the Glorious hours
I spent reading the Nightfall storyline
in the Batman comics and now it just
reminds me of that fcking Dark Knight
Rises movie that for some goddamn reason
a lot of you are still trying to tell
yourself is a good movie and it really
pisses me right the off sorry carry on
I'm the Jesus from every Jesus joke
which reminds me have you heard this one
who's the shortest man in the Bible give
up it's Nehemiah get it niim
Maya you I'll be laughing if SP gly was
telling that
joke gouie previously on Jesus Christ
this narration into flashbacks position
is an automatic sensation now that's
grown inducing word play dude she's a
hooker the entire second season script
of White Lotus somehow makes it into the
episode look guys I can believe in Jesus
or The Lochness Monster but not both
unless they're Partners on the force who
initially hate working with each other
but then learn to mutually respect one
another by the end of their first murder
case make me normal
witch this pantsless Jesus is Five
Seasons late to the rexie business
episode Leon you saved Our Lives not
only did he save your lives but he saved
your lives by Killing Jesus is there a
bigger sin than Killing Jesus how many
sins should I give oh of course meta
Morty his life doesn't matter yours does
Rick staring into the camera there is by
far the most UNS subtle fourth wall
break I've ever seen this series do but
it manages to feel more meaningful than
all the others because it's delivered
with a sincerity Rick usually comes
across as incapable of I'm not going to
claim to completely understand it but
the writers took care not to bury this
message in a joke and telling people
they have value as a message I'd like to
help amplify as well the narrator was
being a bit of a monologuist there but I
agree with the sentiment so I'll take a
s off as well you want to know what
happened like specifically writers write
a writer delivering Exposition about the
writer's written writing that was just
some nonsense to see how many times you
could put a variation of the word right
into a sentence okay here's your
motivation you're looking for motivation
you want all the motivation writers make
fun of the character motivation they
dreamed up because hating your own ideas
is the 20s versions of hating anything
your parents thought was cool the
narrator delivers a sin that's super
argumentative because he doesn't really
know what motivated the writers to write
the motivation motive they're meta nerds
that found out they could be less
bearable as a team staff antia field
show has Rick create a thing using techn
magic thereby creating a contradictory
world that somehow has enough rules to
make science feasible and enough
creative license to make literally
anything else feasible don't try it
flashback come on flash backer was right
there it runs on hydrogen Isotopes a few
barrels of petroleum should dampen it
run Morty show is now doing whatever it
wants without regard for anything and
somehow the plot still makes sense so I
should probably remove a sin but instead
I'm adding one narrator should get a sin
for adding sins when he should be
removing them but I'm obliged to take
sides in this sin as part of some
broader narrative that will be explained
at some point
maybe were those not there before guess
there's been a continuity error acting
as if continuity errors are a part of
Storytelling they as well include typo
Mary and Karma splice but the way Rick
and Mor's bodies and clothes heal they
may have a point that's protagon Nick
his beam has the power to make any
character their
protagonist doc why would Rick tell
Morty to duck they're already the
protagonist of the story and since Rick
knows he's in a TV show shouldn't he
know that and knowing that shouldn't
protagon Nick's Powers be useless
against Rick and Morty come on protag
nnest was right there vignetting and
wacky episode like this as if we're
about to finally get the
interdimensional streaming episode we've
been waiting for no one's been waiting
for this because no one ever knows when
Rick and Morty episodes will be
available for streaming they really went
all in on Nessie and these different
continuities didn't they Nessie is
quickly becoming the David S pumpkins of
Rick and Morty or at least we can hope
or do we not want that to happen can we
flash back to what I was saying the
other
day I swear to God of all mythical
creatures if they ever start inserting
the lock this monster randomly into Rick
and Morty episodes I shave off all my
ball hair and finally take a
frost damn
it they got him in a Cell made out of
sports because it's the opposite of
story tell that to the producers of
drive to survive but his name is Brett
con I think Brett's a name too his name
could be Brett con naming a character
Brett con for no other reason than
getting in your Rhett con joke and just
so you know if you named him rhet con to
begin with I would have sent you for not
naming him Brett con for those of you
who are new to the channel welcome to TV
sins narrator does and I've painted the
show into a corner just to deliver my
welcome to TV sins cliche what is my
purpose to wait until I tell you to pull
the lever retconning butter robot to
have never pass the butter you monster
explaining the show's call backs because
you think it will make people like you
also that one hurt quiet you I'm in
control now if you don't free me right
now Rick I can make very very bad things
always have been the case for you if R
The Hitman con can affect Rick's story
while he's in this cage why would he
make very bad things have always been
the case instead of just making Rick
have always opened the door and this
Fortress has always been an orange and
it has always been in a fruit bowl which
has always been on the top shelf right
right oh come on the narrator's need for
acknowledgement is consuming him it
hurts show severely under explains how
Rick and Morty got from the orange that
just became all of existence to this
frozen tundra what happened you atoned
since when is nearly dying in a
snowstorm the same is atoning if that
were the case Buffalo would be the most
virtuous place in the world and it's not
that's where Josh lives he knows what he
did the narrator and I would likely have
a better grasp of what is going on if we
read more books and watch less TV I'm
Joseph Campbell making me think of Heart
of Darkness even though you're Joseph
Campbell who I often get confused with
Joseph Conrad but regardless it makes me
think of Heart of Darkness and I hate
thinking about Heart of Darkness why is
that prick here no more a prick than you
friend the animated representation of
Joseph Campbell would be some on
a hero's journey at TV sins TV sins got
I would be excellent at letting other
people do his job storing Joseph
Campbell in the personification of all
that is in the unconscious I'm pregnant
what do you do Rick who bearded Rick
thinks Joseph Campbell impregnated a
bearded Morty so he tries to drown him
in a bucket of water improv the rest is
how I imagine the scene was written now
that's just an excuse for you to
verbally describe what is happening on
screen because for some reason you think
it's funny to do so I hope this version
skips Ember and dry blood trying to be
creative instead of just saying discount
song of I fire when you get home Rick do
some classic Adventures like season one
I'm so sick of that note what the does
it even
mean of all the fourth wall breaking
jokes this show has done that one is my
favorite shot and Freud cubicles one of
the writers had a job with cubicle one
time and now they make the same Tire
joke every time a row of them pops up on
screen you know what I've had enough of
you no I want to
live let's never do do that again wait
you have to register the real joke isn't
that this alien is too unmotivated to
register to look at porn it's that he's
going to a site where you have to
register for porn he's bad at porn I
don't take notes Rick and Morty writers
constantly reminding us they don't care
about feedback while constantly making
episodes directly related to said
feedback kid I'm a writer that wrote
something successful did you you wrote a
character so shallow that he literally
has no motivation but you did manage to
help build a machine capable of sucking
motivation from beings all across the
universe so I think you missed your
calling there you failed me storyl Lord
is not only still alive but still able
to talk after being inflicted with a
massive head wound Harry look if you're
going to make weird and dated references
Rick and Morty then I'm going to make
weird and dated references it's my right
and at least I'd never stoop to having
Joseph fing Campell in my story mainly
because I don't I don't know who Joseph
Campbell is Joseph Campbell also says
you have to use this brand new limited
edition Rick plh available only on Rick
plus. Biz not a real product or website
that I had to waste time researching and
that is frankly a terrible URL yeah I'm
tagman I I I I live in the
tag I I I am the tag I'm tag man potato
salad scene does not contain an adult
swimming I can't hold them off Rick I
love a strong cold open but would it
kill the show to just once begin at the
start of an adventure just once I swear
linear storytelling is starting to
become the new nonlinear storytelling
and no one wants that I think get it
he's shelling the beach but if you
designed a happen to shoot seashells
wouldn't the barrel shape need to be
more seashell-shaped I guess what I'm
saying is if Sally shoots seashells by
the seashore then she should shoot
seashell shaped Shooters I'm sure your
Fortress is a salty waste of coral and
clam Disney didn't even attempt to
incorporate any of Mr Nimbus into their
version of Neymar also I'm sure I wasn't
the only one who recognized this guy
enough to know that it was a call back
but not enough to remember that it's
supposed to be Rick's arch nemesis
without Googling it of course this
probably means the show is either doing
too many call backs or not calling back
to things I care about sorry I had to
blow up your bunker close but the
correct answer was sorry I had to blow
up your bunker while you were stilling
inside it and with barely enough time to
escape child of my child it is I cookie
Magneto show plays superhero Mad Libs
and disguises it as being clever this
will never stand at least if uh botchy
ball kitty pride has anything to say
about it okay fine it's harder than it
seems but I'm still sitting how easy it
seems I'm sorry do you control things
that people agree are cookies and does
that mean you have barely any power in
England where they call most of them
biscuits sorry just adding my two cents
to the ever growing examples of Morty
being excellent at TV SS being that
therapist who has an abstract painting
of what is clearly a boob on your wall
just so I'll point it out and then you
can analyze my maternal issues and make
me think I'm the one who's just seeing
boobs everywhere that is a boob you
piece of so about my mom I'm a walking
Target for a never- ending sea of angry
nerds that think getting in a fight with
me is some kind of I don't know platform
is he is he still looking over here here
uh act like you don't know what he's
talking about yeah man about that book
of Boba Fett yeah that waso that was
rough is he still looking at us I am
piss Master here to flush the toilet
that is Rick
Sanchez that's your catchphrase you're
in trouble now mister was right there
also where's all that urine even coming
from he's got enough of a steady stream
to create upward propulsion of his
machine while still hosing down the
house with a separate delu I don't care
how much Prost men he's running through
that thing there's no way he's getting
that kind of flow with these two
fighting I'm not sure if I'm supposed to
be rooting for the pants pissing ugly
faed whiny guy or piss master all these
people who are videoing this I'm going
to say fight instead of calling the
police I'm not saying filming wouldn't
be happening but I'd like to think a
piss powerered alien ping a subpar
parent would be worthy of calling a
higher power before publishing your
pictures sorry I sexualized you apology
we've been asking for from this show for
the last six seasons comes out of the
mouth of a character named the pist
faster and you're getting a lot of hand
clap emojis on white Twitter's
impression of black
Twitter wow It it's sticky yeah that
means it's found a pure heart it wants
to bond with wild my orbs do the exact
same thing you guys saw my son-in-law on
the news now he gets a sticky ore but
what's the catch we're not Rubes yeah
your power is well known in our
jurisdiction Rick Sanchez Jerry is
bestowed with a Magic Orb that Rick
doesn't qualify for because of his
infamy in the Galaxy but if they've
heard of Rick's exploits should they at
least have a vague knowledge of an
incompetent human that is sometimes with
him who inspires Calamity and
disappointment just by leaving his
bedroom and realize he's Unworthy of any
orbs too yes it'd be quicker to just say
we hate Jerry but I think this is more
fun the orb is raw power trust your
heart Jerry it will know what to do all
powerful item that doesn't have any
fixed rules but instead relies on the
power inside you and for once can we
just be told how things work instead of
this handwavy emotional BS cliche this
orb is emitting a constant high
frequency tone that is not only making
me hate its very existence but is a
disqualifying feature from being
something anyone would want around them
for any amount of time like Jerry here's
your goddamn suit i' hardwired the orbs
infinite energy right into it giving
Jerry this much power even if it is to
prove a point to a piece of teenager
this shooty thing looks cool that shooty
thing is a nuclear disruptor that can
blow up planets okay I get making the
suit to shut everyone up and let Jerry
have his time in the superhero Spotlight
but arming the suit with aing arm
mounted Planet Killer was 100% your
choice Rick Cherry would have been
content if the thing had a built-in TV
remote soda hat and fidget spinner space
Hitlers are convening on zpp Prime oh
that's a problem tackling space Hitlers
when we haven't dealt with all of our
Earth Hitlers I'll beat us same bad guys
I don't deny that the Galaxy's most evil
entities would take up the manle of
space Hitler but I do find it hard to
believe their conference for all things
evil would be so easy to find and
destroy by operation Valk Jerry over
here and there were no other people on
the planet are you sure because that
looks like quite an infrastructure for
just a handful of Hitlers who are their
assistants where did they eat who ran
the internet so that they could leave
comments on YouTube videos you got to be
kidding me you mean the fact that we
haven't s the Smith family for setting
up the couch in the dead center of the
room and obstructing possible traffic
flow I know right or maybe we have you
know what we've literally sent every
episode of this show so I don't even
know anymore I don't know that it's a
sin but I just I just want to know more
about the booby doodle okay raises many
questions both about this therapist and
the writers who put it there that we
just never get answered release the Bole
cut why is toast the bad guy on
breakfast Planet Forks literally slice
your egg faces open and let your yolki
innards pour out and you're hanging them
on buildings like Rees at Christmas you
dicks the council said I could pick my
own Bridge crew having free rain on your
Bridge crew and not even stopping to
consider Patrick Stewart for a single
solitary second Oh Me Oh My can it be a
giant piece of I see creating a Badd
takes effort and time so sometimes you
settle for a legum that can rhyme of
course sinning such things can be
equally taxing but alas is my job not
this poetical
waxing meme chasing whatever food this
is Rick will now walk in on a dead piss
Master who's taken his own life because
this show has handled tough subject
matter so well in the past why wouldn't
they try it again Dad Mom told me you
weren't responding to her calls and this
will be the Turning Point leading Rick
into the pism rehabilitation project is
the show Trojan horsing a rick
Rehabilitation project into an episode
about a
Jerry's mother that going on a date with
Jerry's father is in no one's best
interest oh don't act like he's above
doing that and just acquiring a Morty
from a different Universe thinking
there's more to this world than news
entertainment Life and video now I'm
going to make a giant bomb plant it in a
city and then have the suit autopilot
the bomb into space boom everyone will
think piss Master sacrificed himself as
powerful as the Arts of theatricality
and deception are to the uninitiated
it's still a bad idea to model your
convoluted plans on disappointing comic
book movie climaxes I'm tempted to
second guess a lot of that but I think
you might be nailing it wait what the
man just told you he's going to plant a
bomb and hope the suit can save the day
and your response is therapy
FTW but he's piss Master people change
Jerry thinking that because it's
possible for people to change then it
means we're required to let them back
into our lives I can't stress enough I'm
8 years old I have no idea what I'm
doing and yet you somehow have a
perfectly fitted explosive ordinance
disposal suit in some sort of Orphan
infrastructure established look I know
the show's aware of this but setting up
your own jokes like this is asking me to
suspend my disbelief as if it were a
small family of elephants dangling 5,000
ft in the air from nothing more than a
particularly overused elastic band and a
crossed finger also does orphan Island
not realize you can be orphaned at all
sorts of Ages and not just as children
in fact more elderly people are orphans
than kids chew on that the internet you
were piss Master the whole time
obviously not Jerry I put the suit on
once piss Master killed Rick will now
very obvious ly backpedal and claim that
he was piss Master the whole time and
everyone will buy it despite it being
utter and not making any of the
sense I guess they just really trust
Rick Andor they know they're only two
minutes left and we need to wrap this sh
up why would Rick even prop me up like
that Jesus Jerry Rick did something nice
for once okay he's obviously trying to
change you mean obviously the show is
trying some sort of redemption story arc
that has never worked in the past and
isn't working now a man discards people
in Worlds like toilet paper uses them to
clean up his own sh and then casually
eliminate them I bet he doesn't even
look at them before he flushes what
that's what people do how are you
supposed to know if you're clean if you
don't wait Morty you have to promise not
to tell anyone but your dad made piss
Master kill
himself what the hell he killed himself
kids wait you kept the suicide note
Morty would be excellent at what the is
this episode even trying to tell us
about Rick psychosis sins I have a pitch
we're not going to add Scarlet Johansson
not adding Scarlet Johansson why are we
waiting in line for food Rick asked this
instead of the very obvious why are
waiting in this wildly inefficient line
for food look any good business should
have a grasp of basic Q Management
systems and in a space this can find
your basic hardly structured queue just
isn't going to cut it at the very least
this asteroid should have barriers in
snake formation to maximize the lateral
space but really this calls for an e
ticketing system where an order is
placed the customer returns to their
vehicle and is called up once their food
is ready ideally considering everyone is
driving here anyway a multi- window
drive-through situation would be the
dream but come on guys it's just a
cartoon I'm not that nitpicky Rick
you're going to spoil your appetite
that's a weird way to say I'm going to
stop being hungry by eating food right
out of the gate Rick would be a season 2
episode of Rick and Morty at tvin what a
wonderful thing to say I was merely
inspired by the wonderful thing you said
the comment section of every TV s video
somehow makes it into the episode now
for those of you who haven't paused I
know you're the ones that have been
leaving the comments and I see what you
write and I would just like to say thank
you your adoration for my brilliantly
executed WID and expertly craft comedy
stylings is obviously expected but still
appreciated nonetheless so the sin as
always is me being excellent at TV sins
well at least the mystery of the long
line has been solved what kind of
go to a food truck to order
this many um burrito sub witches how
nice it will be for you to eat what you
are willing to stand in line for so much
sooner trying to incept the idea into
someone's head that they should be happy
about the way you've treated them
because of how you feel about it I'm not
sure which vehicle warning light this is
but I'm sure it's one of them dear
fellow littering the ground with your
unwrapped lettuce filled um Hot Pockets
good day chain mail that is this
ineffective against a
sword whoa whoa wait a minute rewind
that without a word of warning sir David
of Mitchell is either teleported out of
the blue by an external Force causing
him to drop the food or he deliberately
drops the food and teleports them back
to the sun either way what the was the
point of this trip if all the food has
been left behind why did Rick put this
portal on the floor we've seen portals
appear out of thin air many times so
it's not like they require a physical
surface like portal portals if he' used
it normally then he and Morty could have
run through it without stopping six
seasons six seasons this has been
bugging me our lives are never ending
but not even in the dumb vampire way
where after a while you hate it well
that's a pretty bold statement to make
are you speaking on behalf of everyone
even what looks like peasants who don't
get fancy armor and swords and how can
this be something you truly know when
until you've lived for millions of years
and are endlessly suffocating through
the heat death of the universe H it is
the home of the solar scepter around
which all worlds revolve The Men Who
keep it safe are admired by all and live
as Gods admired by all then how the is
Morty only just hearing about them we'll
learn that there are people living on
all the planets of the solar system all
of whom are aware of the sun Knights yet
the most populated planet in the solar
system hasn't got a clue it's a terrific
and painful sacrifice we all make for
the most important and powerful job in
the universe careful how you're throwing
the word Universe around sir you're not
even the best drummer in the Beatles
wait I may have my star star punch lines
confused no no no the sword has already
seen blade and loved it you'll be fine
introducing us to a larger blade
doesn't make it any less of a recycled
concept I'm a drunk I'm a psychopath I'm
a murderer rejected lines from Meredith
Brook's 1997 hit song somehow make their
way into this
episode the show's acting like Morty's
more upset by the singing of these
nights than he is by the fact that they
only have honey to put on their pancakes
Jerry Beth and summer all appear to be
chewing and swallowing despite having a
plate of intact pancakes why is
breakfast such a challenge for this show
yeah so there you have it Traditions
suck ass and your most foundational
beliefs are total Morty's
lecture though strikingly similar to the
experience of taking a college level
history course for some reason includes
a diagram that presents all of the
planets on the same orbital ellips and a
room full of space Travelers lets him
get away with this I just Ed your
computer phone to search despair
you did this phone is clearly
on the history of New York podcast and
even if the rim prices there are bad
enough to have this pop up when you
search despair it's certainly not the
first hit or even above the site with
the demotivational posters so if Rick
and Morty need space suits on the moon
are we saying that the asteroid at the
start of the show had a atmosphere
haven't you seen like all of the
universes exactly so why would I hang
out on Pluto that's some Jerry
leag you take that back Pluto has had a
rough time enough as it is without that
sort of of slander do the Knights of the
sun plan to protect Mercury from this
chaos the mercurian choose to
ceremonially cut off their right breast
instead of their and I don't know if
this was a low-key way to raise
awareness for breast cancer in both
women and men but that's certainly the
reason I'm pointing it out so I'm
removing a sin because the animators
gave me the opportunity to do so but
also the animators let this scar migrate
from the left in this shot to the right
in this shot so I have to Addis in again
because they gave me the opportunity to
do
so it's all you pal this fireworks don't
I have like authority over this Suns of
the Moon meeting looks like Morty went
to the King vasera School of asserting
your Authority Santa what the hell is
that I'm the Earl of Earth godamn it the
Earl of Earth has no idea who Santa is
how can you be the Earl of Earth and not
understand the true meaning of Christmas
Venus questions the legitimacy of this
king's Authority I've been trying to put
my finger on why this episode isn't
quite Landing for me and then this line
suddenly hit me like an unannounced
10-year time Jump I think the episode so
shot for Game of Thrones but
accidentally landed in House of the
Dragon now there's a chance that they
sabotage their own episode as a meta way
to have a pop at how boring the thron's
concept is in and of itself but that
would be like me publishing this video
without any of the punch lines and I get
accused of doing that enough as it is
for grabs get it writers realized there
was no British noble title that began
with the letter N so they just gave
Neptune a silly voice and called it a
day we won't dare Play the song out of
fear of angering some pink guy but
Goodbye Blue Sky is currently
soundtracking the solar War so the sin
as always is Ruby Tuesday is Ye Old
neutral zone on the moon if so why are
the Suns and the moon okay with this and
if it's because the Suns of the Moon
moved all their operations to the sun
why haven't we started referring to them
as the sons of the sun Santa Claus is
not looking on the bright side of life
in this
scene technos plaining your types
position type no plaining your war
crimes position what is this vat of acid
again we weren't thinking it was vat of
acid again till you brought it up then
we did think it was VAV acid again
because you brought it up then we
thought it was less about doing vat of
acid again and more about doing
self-referential callbacks because you
think we love that sh then we thought
maybe we'd like it if you did do vat of
acid again because as it turns out we
might love that sh then we thought maybe
vat of acid again was just a metaphor
for trying to love again after being
burned one too many times then we
thought what's vat of acid again got to
do with it who needs a vat when a vat
can be broken Morty this family's got
enough clones and robots in it I'm not
sure if Rick is using in it as an
American way to confirm that one or more
of their family members are robots or if
he's using the British thinging in it as
a bit of filler to elicit agreement from
Morty but what I do know is that this
episode has far too many not funny jokes
in it living on the sun has turned our
veins into triple bonded carbon so try
this tail on for size Mor tanel we can't
OD well sure triple plotted veins will
do the trick but didn't you guys say you
were mortal and only died when you chose
to wouldn't that be a pretty solid
defense as well also who while on a sun
adulterated heroin binge stops for any
amount of time to confirm the
composition of their veins oh I'll give
you a fake with three layers of fail
safes yeah but if two of those fail
safes start rubbing against each other
it could really undermine the whole
Endeavor also why not just let Morty cut
his dick off and then grow it back for
him later not that I want to see this
I'm just saying we've seen Rick grow
parts of bodies clone entire bodies and
change the entire genetic makeup of a
species multiple times growing back one
penis should be a cakewalk we're going
to make your so fake buddy is a Thing
Rick said to his grandson in this
episode the signal sir the Knights of
the sun are once more everyone starts
destroying their weapons as soon as the
sun signal starts without confirming
that all of their enemies are doing the
same or that peace is actually at hand
this is like ending your crime spree in
Gotham after seeing the bat signal
without confirming that Batman isn't
just tied up with the joker or some okay
it's not exactly like that but at some
point the criminals of Gotham should
realize that theing bat signal doesn't
mean for them and if Batman is chasing
after Petty thieves then he should look
at where he's dedicating his resources I
mean why does he even attend bank
robberies in progress all theing money
is insured anyway the does the bank care
yeah yeah I know the money will get used
for drugs and weapons and stuff but is a
glorified NightLight really inspiring
that much fear and hardened criminals
what was I sting
again did your cover disguiser really
need that very visual notification that
it's been turned off also why can this
hologram be deactivated at the touch of
a button but not reactivated at the
touch of a button after Morty goes
through the dick scanner who a sunspot
what something something something
Morty's pixelated clone slinkies down
the stairs improv the rest is how I
imagine the scene was written okay well
go on through and of course by
prosthetic we mean witchcraft a little
witch is funny and all but this was
clearly designed for a humorous reveal
and not to actually fool anyone I'm not
even sure why Morty's pretending this
one was going to work we even checked
with a royal label to ensure it was real
Sun not just them hiding beneath an aat
of fake Sun show thinks it's funny that
it was VAV acid again this entire time
showing favoritism coming right up three
Lums how about 10 years in jail well sh
if you were about to arrest him for
trafficking these creatures did you have
to open with ordering some to be eaten
they get their poor little heads
punctured all so that you can have your
big gotcha moment you selfish bastard
this is like fing Batman deciding to
disappear on Jim Gordon mids just so hey
don't you ding me off I've got things to
say
skipping your cold open and intro how
dare they change the format of their own
show I see the lights Jerry hung around
the roof of the house in rattle star
ractica are no longer part of the
arrangement so here's a sin for pissing
all over Christmas traditions and here's
another sin for pissing all over
continuity and here's a third sin for
well just pissing in general Rick santz
here with gifts from across the
Multiverse come on people St rickolus
was right there although I would have
also accepted the Dutch variant C CLA
also pandering to the misguided idea
that your captive audience will
appreciate you traveling the vast
Multiverse to acquire gifts that they
think they'll love while failing to
realize the hollow that often comes with
obtaining things you once thought were
unobtainable or more simply pulling a
Multiverse of Madness for Jerry and
extradimensional version of Miracle on
34th Street I love the idea that in the
entire Multiverse the best gift Rick
could find for Jerry was aing movie it
brings me comfort knowing that there
just isn't the technology out there to
give him a tolerable personality or a
few extra brains cells also is that a
VHS tape and for the people young enough
to ask what the is a VHS tape watch your
language and get the off my lawn Morty's
only going to use this very honorable
weapon in designated Jedi zones hearing
this caused the meaty object between my
ears that Jerry is missing to wonder how
did this lightsaber make it into the
very not Jedi not Disney designated zone
of Rick and Morty wait does Disney own
Rick and Morty all right I got let me
see here okay we've got Justin royland
and Dan Harmon hi guys thanks for
watching ing uh Cartoon Network Warner
oh no oh no damn you Discovery here I'll
I'll do it myself no I know that for the
most part Rick and Morty fly by the seat
of their AI controlled pants but on this
occasion I really think there should
have been some firm ground rules in
place before laser sword Play Time
simple things like no running in the
house or no arguing over who gets to use
it next or no leaning on one of the
greatest weapons in pop culture history
to make your finale more entertaining
have Hazard Le storing the able to slice
through metal laser Death Stick right
next to your death defitely not stronger
than metal taint adjacent intangibles
okay we overshot it good problem to have
still doing the E roll I told you we
should have gone to 10 no Morty not 10
Rick is right on the money here and how
does Morty not see that obviously
there's a very important story based
reason for Morty to go to floor 10 but
labeling the button with a sign that
says Morty should definitely not go here
at any point during the finale would
have felt less contrived than making
Morty a total dumbass Rick you dumb
robot you had one job a job that you you
dumb human could have made made a whole
lot easier by not putting an unsecured
stop to your secret lab in the elevator
why does this lab even have an entrance
to stumble upon we're expected to
believe that Rick would rely on a
rickbot to keep people away instead of
just putting this lab somewhere
completely void of life like the moon an
asteroid or Jerry skull you gave him a
lightsaber for Christmas it's almost
like someone designed me to be 22% more
thoughtful than you he lightsaber is his
definition of 22% more thoughtful how is
gifting one of the coolest pieces of
Technology ever created equate to 22%
more thoughtful than putting your
grandchild at risk on a near daily basis
move aside Morty I'll put up with living
in the anus of a space lizard if it
means I get a lightsaber the
presidential Blackhawk is landing on the
lawn who dropped a lightsaber perfectly
vertical how close do the Smiths live to
the damn White House I can buy that the
president is somehow monitoring their
house for shenanigans but he managed to
get here within minutes of going
sideways I mean going perfectly vertical
you know what's in the hilt of that
thing kyber crystals okay nerd I mean
right plus it's not kyber crystals the
lightsabers power source is clearly the
incoherent ramblings of a man who 20
years after didn't realize he'd made the
greatest movie ever and decided he
needed to keep tampering with it like a
little kid and make Hing solo not be the
kind of guy who shoots first whatever it
is when it hits the core it's going to
cause a chain reaction that destroys the
Earth how the do they know what effect a
fictional gadget's going to have on the
planet's core and how does this thing
even exist its presence presumes that
somewhere in the Multiverse there either
exists a universe that exactly emulates
the LSD induced fever dream of a man in
this universe or a universe where
inspired by said fever dream someone
created a lightsaber for commercial use
or their own enjoyment both are possible
but either way how the does the
president of this Earth know what a
kyber crystal would do to the planet's
core George Lucas doesn't even know how
they work fans turned on him and started
giving any knucklehead with nerd cred a
shop and churned out these irredeemable
able cash grabs half pretend to be
satisfied half the president's little
diet tribe here makes me realize that
half the internet would be excellent at
Star Wars sins but I'm not telling you
which half it's the worst Christmas ever
well one positive Morty is that your
feet haven't fallen off of your body
from frostbite after standing outside
barefoot for the last couple of minutes
if I wanted the government in my house
I'd buy an Alexa right what kind of an
idiot would be dumb enough to do that
hey uh Google is uh the government
listening to
me I'm singing
I'm singing a song I'm your assistant
and I'm singing la la la la la la la
la that's so cool what was I saying I'm
no expert but it seems we got a a
certain amount of time to build a big
drill ship saying this when there's a
literal time remaining counter behind
you good luck finding a good scientist
on Christmas I mean Christmas doesn't
take away a good scientist's ability to
be good does it and yes I'm sure he
meant to say good luck finding a good
scientist come down here on Christmas
but he didn't say that and I'm the type
of Grinchy to make sure that
gets pointed out all right genius I give
you permission to make our drill
fast calling someone a genius who's
adorned in nothing more than a lab code
and boxer shorts while playing with a
yo-yo then you say but Mr narrator yoyos
are fun and then I say watch your
language and get the off my lawn ver
saer State your prime directive to stay
vertical and yet verto saer will almost
immediately not be vertical progress
report
ver saber do you copy do I have to
respond every time I know this is
leading to a joke about the dangers of
AI technology becoming too clever to
follow our orders but is Rick really
dumb enough to instigate this he's
looking directly at a visual update of
verta saber's progress and yet he's
still pestering it every few seconds as
if he's Jerry wondering why his grilled
cheese sandwiches keep breaking the
toaster let's play a Christmas game
Christmas games that's what happens when
you let people in and they stop
respecting you skip sorry was that
disrespectful approaching the lightsaber
in t
now T-minus now sorry and this apology
continuing for several more seconds
means that there actually was a T-minus
amount of time he could have shared but
didn't stop making a mockery of the
T-minus system movie tension isn't going
to falsify itself this franchise raised
me I own Star Wars not you I earn this
not you once again Rick and Morty hold a
mirror up to the dangers of toxic fandom
by showing us how easy it is to feel
like you own a franchise because you
watched it first or you liked it before
it was cool I applaud them for shining a
light on gatekeeping culture and the
tendency to turn fandom into a
competition instead of a celebration of
course you might have missed that if
you're new to the show and haven't
bothered to watch every episode and
purchased all the comics video games and
other ancillary media like me a true fan
I would be honored if you would carve
the ham this year I would be less sin
happy if someone in this family would
acknowledge that they have zero clue
where Morty has been for the last few
hours and maybe if one of them was
concerned about that fact also putting
fruit on meat stop it you're not my
grandpa you're a robot I'm not sure if I
should sin Jerry for just going ahead
and cutting into Rick even though Jerry
couldn't be 100% positive Morty was
telling the truth or if I should remove
a sin for Jerry taking the initiative
for once I'm pretty sure there's no God
that would forgive me for removing a sin
for Jerry so I'm going to go ahead and
play those just in case there's an
afterlife odds I'm just glad I'm not the
one that ruined Christmas I mean you did
make your family aware that Rick was an
imposter bot and they were perfectly
happy and content with not knowing that
so you didn't not not ruin Christmas
people of Earth that's never good I'm
not here to play the president who is on
TV pauses so that Beth can get her line
in will we launch the White House into
space well I'm busted but other than
comedic timing there's really no reason
you should be was the lack of gravity in
space a surprise did the genius Minds
who managed to turn the White House into
a spaceship also forget to tell the
president that making this broadcast at
the exact moment they lose gravity was
not a good
idea scream all you want Rick but this
Unholy monitor monstrosity is totally
within your power to change why is this
map been spread across multiple monitors
look at all the gaps he must be missing
if they're zoomed in to compensate for
any gaps between monitors that's even
worse because then the whole thing isn't
to a consistent scale oh so now there's
gravity on the White
House you look at him lightsaber hand
which means the president already had
access to the lightsaber technology so
why didn't he just have one made for
himself instead of going through all the
of stealing Morty you think I
want 30 low run TV series with bad CGI
they film everything on that one big
green screen says the cartoon a robot
with lightsabers for eyes God damn it he
can't see so this dryed wasn't tested
like at all some just sent the
first draft to print without thinking hm
I wonder if we should beta test this
first as if they're working on Pokémon
scarlet and violet yeah shove that
topical joke in your will immediately
date this video pipe as and smoke it
Star Wars rules say you have to forgive
me actually the Star Wars rules say that
Jerry has to swoop in and throw the
president into a bottomless void where
we miss the next 30 to 35 years of
Morty's life and instead of seeing any
of the cool he does just skip straight
to his green milk addicted retirement
years no no also you could probably have
a portal X mckinness in in just about
every episode but this one seems more
insane the most so here's one sin plus
the other 50 we should have already
given in previous episodes I should have
included you in my so we're here no one
should ever be included in your that's
your Shir it's personal and also
biodegradable I think oh we what a
season huh Mr Poopy but hole callbacks
aside here's one more reminder that Rick
and Morty would be excellent at TV
s my eyes you're a very nosy fellow
kitty cat huh you know what happens to
nosy fell
you want me to buy a subscription to the
Saturday evening post no not a word not
a word not a word now I went into a
future Dimension with such Advanced
medicine that they had broken leg Serum
at every corner drugstore I'm sure that
in 1985 plutonium is available in every
corner drugstore but in 1955 it's a
little hard to come by he's got some
kind of disability or something is that
what you want us to say I do implausible
I know but I like to imagine that he had
sex the night before and now a little
bit of residue is blocking his rra oh
jeez dad you know that's a lot to drop
on a kid all at
[Music]
once good
girl I love
you oh my God he's trying to tell us
something that is so
awesome sexual Hang-Ups in the pleasure
chamber are punishable by death what
their heads you will walk when it is
time time to walk you got that you
maggot we'll come back
tomorrow maybe they'll be gone by then
you better get out of here before
somebody sees us introducing smart dogs
the first dogs trained to train humans
Mr Spicoli you're on Dangerous Ground
here you're causing a major disturbance
on my time are you saying there's
something wrong with my gear get to the
digestive tract he's coughing I'm
possessed Dum Christmas drums sing it
here
come the drums oh my God it looks like a
huge pecker oh yeah wait that's not a
wood Peck looks like someone
private there's always a bigger fish
zerian scammers Morty the Galaxy's most
ambitious least successful con artist
that doesn't make sense we're going
streaking look at that old lady she's
she's walking a cat on a
leash yes see you in 10 minutes I'm
going to go home and sleep with my
wife and those words on your AR going to
go away let you start using topical
cream every day I'm a white boy but my
neck is red I put Miracle Whip on my
Wonder Bread well we're back to Our
Roots driving the same streets my
grandfather started on oh but time are
simpler back then weren't they because
people had Integrity I looked at the
Trap r you're out of order you're out of
order the whole trial is out of order
I've dreamt of freeing oap for 10 years
and every year it just looked too big
you've come to fight as free man and
free man you are what will you do
without Freedom buckle up your your
driver is a snail hey Jessica hello
Peter what's happening I throw balls far
I'm going to b y you know son you're not
a kid anymore oh no I go to health class
dad I already know all this stuff but
what people call love is just a chemical
reaction that compels animals to breed
biochemically no different than eating
large quantities of chocolate there's
something special about you Morty you
reach
down and you touch the brother heart rip
my clothes off and meet with me for life
it's really important in this pose that
you arch your back and keep it flat at
the same time you you're you're you're
you're you're just a little creepy creep
person you're just this Penny stealing
wannabe criminal
man so we're just going to pretend this
isn't happening I'm not saying that's a
bad idea just asking I drive a Dodge
Stratus H I think I hit
puberty should I cut the court I think
it's Linguini can't take this anymore I
learned it by watching you I came here
to do two things eat eggs and nothing
and I'm not out of either will you
please not marry me I choose Veronica
but imagine if he came back with
something actually useful for the girl
and then he came back 2 minutes later
with some self-respect and some dignity
but one of us is dead corn a no the corn
Paul Newman's going to have my legs
broke this is delicious you eat pieces
of for breakfast it says you can't eat
anymore smug smiling definitely tell you
what friends if nobody comes down and
buys a car for me in the next hour I'm
going to Club this baby seal that's
right I'm going to Club of seal to make
a better deal you know I'll do it too go
cuz I'm crazy man woman and now trunk
men man you must be out of your mind if
you think I'm going to get in this dirty
ass trunk hi I'm a trunk person I am not
an animal I am a
human what is my purpose I brought you
into this
world a machine that can think and
feel we are
laughing I want an apology nay nay I
demand Penance you're watching right
side of the bed I'm grayon chis take him
to pluton O Bay you can't handle the
truth Homer I told you this morning no
guns at the dinner table you no no no no
no
me you bring up the
[Music]
Holograms and I hate to get all Andy
Rooney about it but when did bright
colored plastic cows pigs and rabbits
get to be art coffee
time like to hear you wake up it's time
for coffee advertising wow so people
need help figuring out what to buy and
then you help them cheese it's milk that
you chew you know Jerry I'm not going to
tell you that these will increase in
value or even hold their current value
the truth is you bought them because you
like them they have value to you that's
what
matters
I don't want them to gain another yard
you Blitz all
night speaking of disasters Dad we are
leaving you in charge ooh someone has a
serious face on it smells like Thai food
in here have you guys beening every
weekend Jacks and Roses have their
Titanic experience in this car and I
have to mob it up oh that's not
right oh I'm still alive but I'm very
badly injured the beacon was activated
and Rohan will
answer you okay yeah that's you so what
we'll do is we'll rig a bus so that when
it goes below 50 m hour it blows up what
the is that oh God now there's three of
them there too many of them what are we
going to do how misguided are you I feed
you a couple of B legal precedents and
there you go you jump on it like a
in eat how's it going Bill Ted Ted it's
us again so that's how it's going to be
y'all want to play okay then I've got my
eye on you jwen that's right Mrs Smith
give in to your anger Let the hate flow
through you they take their balls and
they dip them in cocaine I want to dip
my balls in
it are you krombopulous Michael's Target
very good J Man the world can be one
together Cosmos without
hatred stars like diamonds in your
[Music]
eyes you know what those guys do in in
in their fancy boardrooms I take Quay
ludes 10 to 15 times a day for my back
pain ater all to stay focused anex to
take the edge off pot to Mellow Me Out
cocaine wake me back up again you do
understand I'm telepathic right pick a
color blue pick a number 17 all right
I'll call the two grand I'll gamble
Don't splash the pot and in my club I
will Splash the pot whenever the f I
please what is that that's what we're
going to find out balloon summer balloon
Morty I don't like chicken and I hate
hate clowns oh yeah no gy clarson we are
the Borg blow your Shields and surrender
your ships but Uncle Steve taught me how
to ride a bike Steve buttons don't work
better if you hit them harder and foam
fists don't make you strong what was my
father ever done that's so great school
superintendent big whoop there's only
like 800 kids in the entire County now I
believe someone has a final exam to
attend Wesley marmalade is served
marmade l king of R that's Rock ler but
you still can't be in our band but they
helping Punky win TV
contest
Lan shut up hamurai shut up Amish cyborg
what is this '90s
Conan face a final froner a giant head
has entered Earth's gravity triggering
climate change and natural disasters we
thought were impossible for at least
another eight years look at the size of
that boys heed time to go Morty uh where
the
[Applause]
Pentagon you can't fight in here this is
the War Room you're going to want to put
them on that giant speaker system at
your Sonic testing facility at Area 51
guess you'd like to see the big tamale
huh when God deals you an 11 you don't
fold when you always double a and what's
your plan General we still have the
nuclear option on my word we can launch
a missile at every one of those heads in
the sky hey you better find yourself
someplace to hide and keep praying
nobody ever finds
you now you're thinking with
portals in this universe there's only
one absolute everything free us ice tea
what with these people man lemonade
redesign lemonade the best ice cream in
the Multiverse
I and eat it no stop don't kill him I
thought about our dilemma and I came up
with a solution that I honestly think
works out best for one of both of us
that just sounds like slavery with extra
steps we live in a society where honor
the distant memory Ooh La La o la la ooh
la la ooh la la now slap on these
antenna these people need to think we're
aliens right right somebody said alien
she thought they said illegal alien and
signed up nothing you do matters Your
Existence is a lie yeah you
too the incredible turbo
team I think it's okay to dream Morty
I'm going to go make some wooden
staks
[Music]
what's that a very unpleasant little
creature what's his problem he's got a
cold hunting a vampire with my grandkids
now this is not going to be pretty we're
talking violence strong language adult
content
surprise motherucker all right everybody
this next one's coming straight from the
heart making the lyrics up right off the
top of my head let me out what you see
is not the same person as me my life's a
lie I'm not who
you my children may Feast on MAR and
flesh my home planet is far away and
long since gone please excuse his lack
of
decorum his enthusiasm outweighs his
disra ression that's right take
my penis but they'll never take oh
freedom I didn't know that there were
bugs out in space you mean bugs I hate
bugs boy you want to give me one good
reason why you would steal a snippers
bar the nougat why don't you have some
candy bars as well shut up I like candy
also if you tell your mom about this
I'll Purge you are you threatening me my
bung hole will not wait I see sh like
that for breakfast Morty but if you
don't do it I say it's because you're
afraid of your own Primal instincts you
eat pieces of sh for breakfast no I
squant my family what I do I squanch my
family Frank you disgust me you disgust
everyone you know you're not being very
supportive a bird person on his big day
I'm about this shut your mouth or I'll
kick your teeth down your throat and
I'll shut it for you squat this mofo not
using it right Joe ah sounds like you
and my dad have a long history together
wish I could say the same with all due
respect
What the fu are you talking
about oh that's not right you know when
I first met bird person he was listen
I'm not the nicest guy in the universe
and for the record my name's not Ted
Peterson it's Han Solo named after the
man who made the Kastle Run in less than
12 parex and I am a burger like my
father before me also I want to tell
everyone here that I've got a pretty
huge New Kids on the Block tattoo on my
back the heads are worked but you guys
it's funny scor this leg how it feels to
chew five
gum stimulate your
senses Welcome To Earth he may have
manifested some sort of butt allow me to
share with you a motto I believed in
throughout my life nobody who is an
assman can be all bad maybe I just want
you to care if I run away yelling it was
just like Sunny said it would be nobody
cares so if you're really want your
grandpa back grab a shovel the one that
won't let you down is buried in your
backyard a hole take a hole take a hole
take a hole welcome to McDonald's can I
take your order I'll have two number
nines a number nine large a number six
with extra dip a number seven two number
45s one with cheese and a large soap
it's a trap apples apples apples it's my
vagina
then the universe exploded into
existence and the remnants of these
systems were forged into concentrated
ingots infinity
stone it's because losers look stuff up
while the rest of us are carpon all them
DMS belief like fear or love is a force
to be understood as we understand the
theory of relativity and principles of
uncertainty kill me please I won't kill
you but I don't have to save you how
come you guys dress like you're in a
theme park stun show but these guys were
khakis and hockey jerseys this is the
way after the boom boom some adapted to
the new truth you speak the true truth
and he wants more and the hster giving
him exactly what they want I'll be right
back death stalkers bring me his flesh
lettera witness sorry my grandpa stole
your God and ruined your car you don't
turn your back on family
even when they
do I am summer summer State your deal
you already know my name and you can see
that I'm a machine I don't know why I'm
crying why you crying that's no crying
you know is this the first part of some
kind of magic trick illusion Michael
trick is something a does for
money God damn it I love myself cuz I
love me me
dad I would like you to tell me what's
in the syringe around and give her the
shot come on I'm a pickle when I feel
like it so you asked well actually
nobody on those planet ever really
chooses each other I mean it's all a
question of quantum physics molecular
attraction and timing it's Maximus
Renegade star Soldier Batman is playing
Galaga thought we wouldn't notice but we
did there's a classic case of guy on the
ground obviously I came here last night
during a blackout oh man so this is what
The Zone feels like oh Analyze This
Vance stay calm wake up you made a deal
with a force that's bigger than you when
the time comes they're going to ask you
to pay what they feel you owe them it's
for the greater
good surprise I want to lay
my head gently on your shoulder maybe we
can cry and hug and maybe even slow
dance don't patronize me Dean dangerous
rck Sanchez you son of a motherless goat
fin anure a we thin me off I'm full the
device before you is one of sacrifice a
sacrifice of blood mean would be
shooting you Jerry this is saving a
bullet do you comprehend the value of
the bullet in your Barrel I tell you
fellas this is the
life let's go in and out 20 minutes
Adventure 4 to 6 days later hey uh you
might if I put on some music not at all
Bird's
yourd bird is your word hey Morty
remember yesterday when I couldn't play
the trombone we check this
out not not quite my temple what a
knockout like you doing in a computer
generated gin joint like this woohoo I'm
out of my awkward State John one thing I
can promise you even in this market is
that I never ask my clients to judge me
on my winners I ask them to judge me on
my loses because I have so few uh yeah I
think we actually have the audio for his
speech here I just got a free churo
because my mom died the election's got
these yellow shirts more riled up than a
picture day Jessica if you're going to
get nasty I'm going to leave yes slow RI
tall Morty I said reading is good can we
start the story now see all you fresh
face kidlets sitting there in your neat
little rows and you're all just pods
pods waiting for your instructions from
the Ricks and mores that believe in this
Citadel to the Ricks and Morty that
don't you're screwed thank you bye
what's
this the
manage they say for your wish to come
true you have to give up something
really important yeah but you know
what this one this one right here this
was my dream my wish and it didn't come
true this this is the story of a boy
with scissors for hands return the truth
toris you have no power over me what the
hell is this a center for
ants you want thing of The Bobs I got
20 holy but I do have a thing at
six oh God do I have to keep looking
them Grand boys don't kill him I will
who wants a smoothie what are you
talking about a smooth like a drink or
something listen I've been given you a p
because I'm Charmed that life finds a
way but there's one thing the history of
evolution has taught us it's that life
will not be contained life breaks free
it expands to new territories and it
crashes through barriers painfully maybe
even dangerously but uh well there It Is
Well here's the problem right here a
mutated P36 immunosuppression Gene that
renders them immune to all
poisons what is that smell it's poo poo
with a dashy COA I suppose you're
wondering how do I sustain myself I am
evil therefore I am
lonely well that didn't go as planned I
respect your right to believe I pushed
you when you marooned me on that God
forsaken spit of land you forgot one
very important thing mate I'm Captain
Jack Sparrow I roared and I rampaged and
I got bloody satisfaction
ction no tell him Rick and Morty just
blew off America hey phrasing yes yes
yes yes you save the world now and then
and America returns that favor by not
holding the two of you accountable to
its laws diplomatic
Community wouldn't go
well can you elaborate because of the
implication
what a rush do you even know how to take
out this kind of threat you don't like
my plan that's good give me another plan
but don't tell me we're backing out
Doctor Who in this I have
the power of a thousand Cowboys running
through my veins right now Morty would
you please accompany me to forbo jilon
Prime for death crystals you don't want
to sell me that sticks Master good idea
Mor it'll get us through these asteroids
sooner sir the possibility of
successfully navigating an asteroid
field is approximately 3,720 to what he
wants to give all of our martinis to a
family of immigrants you don't know how
to drink your whole generation you drink
for the wrong reasons that's not an
integer F you science all that's left
are these Kirkland brand me
boxes kenet Kirkland what's with the
strut you think you own this school nope
no matter what you got t
stop those were my husband's last words
he says tell her she's wearing a shirt
that I spilled the margarita on and the
earrings I gave her for Christmas I
guess I got to learn how to live in the
moment a little more and that's why you
always leave a note allow me to
introduce myself my name is C I'm kind
of like the leader in here rule number
one in app development son never follow
the rule what you just said is one of
the most insanely idiotic things I have
ever heard I created The Event Horizon
to reach the stars but she's gone much
much farther than that tell them what
you told me this can't be happening you
can't be here it doesn't make sense for
you to be here I ref believe that you
are here ounces are thousand AB ball 200
grounds 80 is all pre bag and I tell you
like I tell all my boys if you C it any
more than it already is you can say
goodbye to repeat goost time to be
free what the sh Adventures of Jerry and
Morty huh put her there at no point in
your rambling incoherent response were
you even close to anything that could be
considered IR rational thought I started
today disgusted and embarrassed to be
your son and then later I thought we
were going to die because you're a
loser no
notes 10,000 years will give you such a
prick in the neck you forgot the power
glov today still wanted by the
government they survive as Soldiers of
Fortune if you have a problem if no one
else can help and if you can find them
maybe you can hire the 18 respect the
heistotron state your prime directive
the Draymond are not a subject for
philosophical debate they are a people
your life as it has been is over from
this time forward you will service us
well let's hear about this Heist movie
this is your basic mortgage Bond all
right The Originals were simple they
were just thousands of AAA mortgages
bundled together guaranteed by the US
government you would indulge in volcanic
fumes devil leer it makes you behave
like the village drunkard in some early
Irish novel we'll reach the boundaries
of Fantasia do you know where they are I
have no idea I summon thee come from the
farest space through wind and darkness I
summon thee Stone monster stick that up
your ass see that's your problem Jason
you are never serious about the craft y
sh your sh your up power of 12 ft oh I
take it all back and ever since that day
I have hated magic and all those who
practice it Shadow Jacker you haven't
come out of your masturbation cave and
Eon let me show you how to break your
three ways it's a cat that is not a cat
but what do I know I wasn't born into
the god business I am God I'm dying Rick
I think I'm dying here man my Mom and
Dad going to be
so can you recognize the sound of a
man's pants filling up with rain I find
your lack of faith disturbing Merry
Christmas
I'm in a glass case of
emotion what the hell put that thing
away now I don't want to tell you again
snakes time travel I'm
starving I couldn't hear you over my own
screaming we've talked about this can
you photoshop your life with better
decisions Jerry I have created things
that will change the world for the
better for instance here is a monkey
with four
asses oh that's funny you're going to
look funnier sucking my with no teeth so
why did you date Rick Sanchez anything
you'd like to eat Turkish delight why is
there a dead man in the sky if it's any
constellation he had very few loved ones
maybe what matters is to love yourself
first and
sore child of air and land with wings
and hands yes you're a bird and a person
guess who's got two penises and all the
agency did you make a penis dude release
the Ken glory to gloro totally welcome
to Costco I love you give a little yeeh
yipp motherucker nicey give a little
ye-haw if you want they always do a
little ye-haw like a cowboy yo oh that's
a mouse come on louder I don't sequel
It's called Integrity sequel suck by
definition alone they inferior films
ready to form Voltron activate interlock
no no no this is like torture no I I I I
hate being in my car I drive a DOD
Stratus what is this face you're making
that's my face sir you know who I am
don't you even know who my father is G
you are a snob and a half
and then Little Tommy flip flams running
down the hyperloop his ass is on fire
from Xenon fluid I got a rash so bad on
my ass I can't even sit down you know me
I can't complain great story boss really
detailed whole story in the end freeze
mother I'm a God you're God I'm
a God I'm not the
guy
King way I'm going to start beating the
out of you in the next 5 seconds and
you're going to swallow a lot of blood
for aing billfall but father I have
dreams and courage and the name of an
excellent cosmetic surgeon fear not
someday word will reach you about the
success of me Jennifer love huitt the
girl has just went wild they jumped all
over his body and threw him around like
a rag doll to get to those blueberries
let me talk to him will you would you
live for me you want me to to read I'm
reading text what's the difference I am
I am I
[Music]
am first you take the gram you stick the
chocolate on the gr then you roast the
Malo when the malo's Flaming you stick
it on the chocolate then you cover it
with the other end then you scarf we're
not worthy we're not worthy we're not
wor it's a house no house I'm playing
I'm you houses Gamu I've come to bargain
Elsa your other hand honey I can't hold
you to catch a predator what the hell
I'm Chris Hansen I want my molecules
back sources tell us these aliens who
call themselves the new Galactic
Federation will blow up the planet and I
for one welcome our new insect overlords
Jerry do you agree that the use of
Puppets makes you seem dumb and crazy I
don't think crazy is a responsible word
to you I said I want you you're not a
clone and who is that John toast
why would you make a clone of me just to
send the Clone into space stop saying
Hawaii in there father of the year piss
off ghost stop it stop it please I beg
you hey over here look at me maybe you
should put some shorts on or something
if you want to keep fighting evil today
I like standing next to you Sean makes
me look so tough I'm I'm scared Morty I
can see the end cold I'm cold I'm so
cold actually your father and I have
been very sex positive lately we've been
watching pornography hey man got a big
box of porn for
[Music]
you is that Mr nimus Nimbus I hear you
can talk to fish right there sugar hoof
I'm moving a little slow tonight I had a
Hot Pocket for dinner you will be the
one to end our pain to the
pain decoy family you made more clones
you're clones you're copies of people
out here in the world what clones what
copies what are you talking about my
spinach PFF saved them that's great good
job very good job watch it they're still
hot what the you think you're doing down
there you're making decoys you make a
copy of a copy it's not quite as sharp
as well the original we can work this
out just stop trying to kill each other
the mistake you made was you killed my
friend so I'm going to kill each and
every one of you and the only
disappointment in it for me is that I
only get to do it once you ever make a
copy of a copy I like pizza I like
[Music]
it nice Bieber Wait who the is that
I am the Borg they're heading for Vegas
Vegas baby Vegas where's your costume
this is my costume I'm a homicidal
maniac we got a baby a science
baby what a cute little pink bunny
rabbit the langers don't don't even
exist you just made them up storming
Your Castle on my steeve my
[Music]
lady stop talking like that I can't
understand you everybody look at the mo
everybody seeing the Moon the Moon is
white he's milky white everybody look at
the
Moon
by your powers
combined I am Captain
Planet this gay sex with my dad is
terrific the line must be drawn here
this far no father how are you doing
that with your mouth collect the whole
set last chance to pee on me if I had to
I'd pee on any one of you I'd like to
ask you a few questions we're touching
Rick's stuff summer he said said no n
uh-uh nuh-uh uh please God damn it hate
this hacker crap low life butt based
misg grant buttface misg Grant what if
Sydney killed Casey and Steve why would
she do that maybe she had the hots for
Steve you were just Moody you got stuck
with a
Marlin F nerds
nerds I can't gages this place is worse
than omashu locate the president's chip
Roger Roger what's our Victor Victor I'm
here today at the uh un because the
Earth has been attacked my military
advisers at the pentagram have managed
to do the impossible I need your clothes
your boots and your motorcycle we're
three across the bed not a stitch of
clothes on I made it to Shell City and I
beat the Cyclops and I rolled the
Hasselhoff and I brought the C round
back wa I think my life is like flashing
in front of my
eyes since when does this house care
about alien lives we don't even watch
British television you sound like from
London you're going to the center of a
volcano I immediately regret this
[Music]
decision
sometimes enough is enough all right hun
enough is enough we're offering to help
each of your families complete their
full goat Trum in exchange for some
concession why do you have to talk to me
like that all the time like I got to
know something meow meow meow meow meow
meow remember that time in Puerto Rico
when we picked up those two
uh I guess they were prostitutes but I
don't remember paying oh Fu you a wise
man's life is based around you the
United States of America is based on F
you I'm King my ass de mind oh not all
at once and not instantly to be sure are
you sure you don't want to come with us
oh I wish I could but I don't want to
excuse me did I pick that name I have so
many names I am indeed down to clown I
can make things out of clay and lay by
the bay I just made why was my ninth
birthday party in a pine tree what you
are looking at are memories in this case
pertaining to one individual hello hi
good afternoon what I want you to think
about what you've done Kent and from now
on stop playing with yourself it is God
I need your clothes your boots and your
motorcycle lost Germany lost BR if we
lose today we won't get to fight enough
I know the pressure on you as an nor 2
minutes to drop candy citizens we are
going to war I have crossed the Horizon
to find
you that that's how we lost our cable
guy well maybe I shouldn't have come at
all jerk off stop those portal boys
that's what they'll call us go go gadget
arms wait are you my father no but I
stole your egg and mutated your brain
wow somebody's been busy I I did it cuz
you hurt my feelings I learned it by
watching you what yes SW all kids love
log yeah Starlight Mission active what
we can do is break his age in two places
remove the middle and CFT its ends back
together that that sounds really violent
Jerome never questioned my commitment
again I took my mind off the Pain by
reminding myself that when I eventually
did stand up I'd be exactly 2 in closer
to the the Stars hey you were supposed
to be my lift home how will I get out of
here you know certain times like these I
think it's important for me to say my
tiny little nipples went to France four
stones four crates zero Stones zero
crates it's just as well I lied that
second seat's a toilet I'll see you in
hell my brains are going into my
feet
everything that you
know and
love gone forever why do I have a
reality of or because I'm green isn't
it watch yourself it's the
claw ooh the claw's coming at you you
stabbed me with a potato peeler I got it
sorry shoot him you
dumb hey Mr Goldman Bach majoran still
alive huh what's up now my Story begins
in 19 dickity to we had to say dickity
cuz the Kaiser had stolen I weigh 20
Rick was always right humans need more
animal blood it keeps the spine straight
you know never thought I'd say this but
if we put a tax on soda I mean what's
next income can't we just go back and
fix it if you can't fix what's broken
you'll um you'll go insane maybe let me
kiss you finally I'm fine I just uh
threw up in my mouth a little bit
correction what you don't have is a head
I'm not entirely sure what you're
suggesting I'm entirely sure you're
entirely sure what I'm suggesting I'm a
14-year-old boy in a video
[Music]
game can't guess you guys aren't ready
for that yet but your kids are going to
love it yeah look he's not the massage
he's a very nauy boy oh oh walkie talkie
I'm walkie and talkie are you walkie and
talkie instead of sing me an unloaded
gun she'll hand me out get the kayak
other the buckets let's just put our
guns down and let's settle this the F
conversation to boldly go where no man
has gone before Gail strikes me as a
very beautiful woman but you know
there's a little tension in a voice
could be one of two things either Gail
is nervous or unsatisfied I find this is
usually the biggest
help why are you so into Pino I mean
it's like a thing with you we get to say
anything to each other things we'd never
say to anyone else even ourselves could
Houston be misinterpreting the data tell
no secrets are great for instance I was
doing the bloody disco 100 years before
any
other seriously you two Barkley's been
running some unusual
programs well that was unexpected I
agree for the record we made a mistake
you've never been to a breakfast stor G
they didn't have churches in your
time been having him do crunches while I
sleep I
out speak English who wants
cake I'm sorry Dave I'm afraid I can't
do that
bra so anyway get back to my story I
have like two of those seven layer
burritos let's just say they didn't
schedule any bathroom breaks in the
middle of my niece's chring why are you
wearing that suit why are you you
wearing that stupid man suit that's fair
hit the sheets D
noid night person three darts is too
much you know fortune cookies only come
true if you eat the cookie first you
sure that doesn't sound right you're
going to be eaten by a big greasy
monster have a nice day why are you
dressed like Morty that guy a little
cold that guy in a little cold these are
two shoe boxes what's in the box pain
can I just tell you which box I would
put my penis in boys have a penis girls
have a vagina ship favorites playlist
track one I'm going to do a terrific
show today and I'm going to help people
because I'm good enough Mr Spicoli
you're on Dangerous Ground here you're
causing a major disturbance on my
time dinosaurs are back l two Bara Nick
toe hello I'm Dr Sheldon Cooper Welcome
to Sheldon Cooper presents Fun With
Flags you're dinosaurs thought you were
dead no you pay attention old ruter the
great circle of life has begun but you
see not all of us arrive together I do
think it's kind of funny that you're all
basically Jerry now you take that back
you think I'm going to side with you
over hyper intelligent creatures
operating Way Beyond your comprehension
I have more in common with them than you
we don't need so-called superheroes what
Empire City needs is more cops and a
Hooters it ought to
be here but it isn't gravity is pulling
all the stars in the area towards this
spot now please welcome your host an old
science guy who got rid of the dinosaurs
Rick
senters you'll be pleased to know this
is the last time I'm hosting these
Awards thanks for solving that murder
guys not many people know I love swamp
[Music]
B oh yeah no you don't want to wear
those over here things that could have
been brought to my attention yesterday
his name is story Lord what kind of
stupid name is that I'm your worst
nightmare the prime time if I
sucker your blood I'll
be what is my purpose to chew bubblegum
and kick ass no more a prick than you
friend well I'd like to take a moment to
review the several ways in which you're
douchebag I can't hold them off Rick
there's too many game over man it's game
over happy you're only supposed to blow
the bloody doors off it is I cookie
Magneto don't yourself if you fight
this guy I'm either an for not
helping or an for helping what
do you say we cut the chitchat a-hole
bew my power Green Lantern's light Oh Me
Oh My can it be a giant piece of I
[Music]
wait who are you I'm Batman well Thor's
taking on a squadron down on Sixth and
he didn't invite me orphan Island a city
populated entirely by orphans now sits
on the brink of
Doom us I found him dead and I I put on
his suit but look at this he literally
blames your dad wow the plot thickens
didn't even know you had a plot now just
cut off your penises and throw them into
the
Sun not not quite my temple this guy's
the king of the sun wait we are now the
night to
say what is this fat of acid again I
understood that reference come on Morty
stop asking what you're asking and let's
just get back to our crisis by all means
Dr Seldon speak I admit I wanted what
you once had Brotherhood tradition
stability purpose I just didn't want to
cut Myck off for it he's beginning to
believe that walkway needs those Knights
those Knights need a king and that King
needs no dick but you're not ping yeah
go tell everybody your rewards going to
be cutting off your
own okay well then I changeed my answer
to just ignoring the question Rick santz
here with gifts from across the
Multiverse my God presents are the best
way to show someone how much you
care
wow here I'll I'll do it myself no no
wait we live over a Cool Sushi Spot domo
domo not now though and I lost my
lightsaber and now it might destroy
Earth and you're unloading all this Gen
X hatred on me for even wanting one and
it's the worst Christmas ever Jesus
Joseph and doggy style Mary that is a
pile of
dog okay that could have been
worse
oh that's not right way to show us how
it's done Rick no notes now I have
sh
[Music]
ho worst crossover ever